THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES TODAY WE WILL
BE DISCUSSING THE ISSUES
REGARDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATIONAS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
READ SOME DIRECTIONS REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP INSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL ACCESS TO
THE DISCUSSION. PANELISTS TODAY
WILL BE HAVING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING IN THE
STATE CAPITOL ROOM FOUR FOUR
FOUR. THE PANELISTS ON THE
AGENDA ARE APPEARING REMOTELY
USING ONLINE TECHNOLOGY. WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THE HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET.
THE NUMBER IS. 1-877-692-8957
WITH THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE OF.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2090 NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN PERSON MAY
DO SO BUT MUST WEAR A MASK AT
ALL TIMES AND FOLLOW ALL OTHER
POSTED GUIDANCE. WE WILL BEGIN
PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER ALL MEMBERS
HAVE CONCLUDED THEIR QUESTIONS
FOR THE PANEL. THERE WILL BE NO
VOTES TAKEN IN TODAY'S HEARING
AS THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING TO DISCUSS THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSALS. I WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
FEEDBACK THROUGH THE SUB ONE
EMAIL ACCOUNT. AND THE ADDRESS
IS BUDGET SOMEONE AT ASM DOT CA
DOT GOV. BEFORE WE INVITE OUR
FIRST PANEL BEGAN I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A FEW INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS
AND OPEN IT UP TO MY COLLEAGUES
IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO DO THE
SAME. OUR FOCUS IN SOMEONE THIS
YEAR IS TWO FOLD FIRST. TO
ELEVATE THE PRIORITY ISSUES IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ASKING
QUESTIONS AND GATHERING
INFORMATION THAT WILL GUIDE OUR
DECISION MAKING PROCESS AS WE
HEAD TOWARDS JUNE FIFTEENTH TO
PASS A BALANCED BUDGET. TWO
GIVEN THE MILLION MANY
MEANINGFUL INVESTMENTS
RESTORATIONS AND EXPANSIONS
WE'VE MADE IN RECENT BUDGET IT
IS CRITICAL THAT WE EXERCISE OUR
OVERSIGHT ROLE. THIS MEANS THAT
WE SEEK TRANSPARENCY AND
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT HOW
IMPLEMENTATION IS WORKING. WHAT
OUTCOMES WERE SEEING AND
DIFFICULTIES THAT WE MAY BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS NOW TO ENSURE THAT
PRACTICE MATCHES INTENT FOR
APPROPRIATED PUBLIC DOLLARS. I
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIES FOR TODAY REGARDING
THE DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
AND DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. WITH
THAT WE WILL BEGIN TODAY'S
HEARING WITH PANEL ONE ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
REVIEW OF SERVICES FOR THE BLIND
AND VISUALLY IMPAIRED. FOR THOSE
PANELISTS WHO ARE PRISONERS
PLEASE PRESENT IN THE ORDER THAT
YOUR NAME APPEARS ON THE AGENDA.
WE WILL HAVE SIX PRESENTERS ON
THIS PANEL INCLUDING JOE XAVIER
DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION. AND THE MODERATE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION. DELIAL BAKER
BUDGET ANALYST FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SONYA
PADDOCK PRINCIPAL ANALYST FOR
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
JEFF TOM DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR THE BLIND. AND SARAH
HARRIS THE FIRST VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
THE BLIND AND DIRECTOR OF
PROGRAMS RESOURCES AND
INDEPENDENCE CENTRAL VALLEY. WE
WILL HOLD ON MEMBERS QUESTIONS
ON THE PANELS UNTIL AFTER THE
PRESENTERS HAVE CONCLUDED. LET
US BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR XAVIER.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND GOOD
AFTERNOON TO MEMBERS AND TO
EVERYONE- JONES IF YOU'RE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY MY COLLEAGUE ENDING THE
DRUG CAN AND GREETINGS TO MY
FELLOWPANELISTS- YEAH JANET
DOES A GOOD JOB OF DESCRIBING
THE ISSUE I JUST WANTED TO
PROVIDE A QUICK OVERVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENTS PROGRAMS. AND
SERVICES AND A COUPLE OF KEY
MENTIONS- FROM TO GET JAMMED UP
FIRST OF ALL- THE MISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
JUST PROVIDE THE EMPLOYMENTS OF
PROGRAMMING AND SERVICE AS- FOR
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AS WELL AS
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY IN THE COMMUNITY
OF CHOICE WHAT PURPOSE AND
DIGNITY. WE HAVE ABOUT A. FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET.
TWENTY ONE. OF THAT IS GENERAL
FUND OF THE BALANCE OF THAT
COMES FROM. OUR FEDERAL.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WITH THE
POLITICIANS ARE BUSINESS AGENCY.
AND SO ESSENTIALLY FOR EVERY ONE
DOLLAR OF GENERAL FUND THAT
WE'VE CONTRIBUTED CALIFORNIA WE
BRING IN FOR FEDERAL DOLLARS.
HOW ABOUT. A THOUSAND. EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED PLUS POSITIONS HERE AT
THE DEPARTMENT. AND THE NUMBER
OF SPECIAL FUNDS. SO THAT THE
VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION
PROGRAM SERVES ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS ANNUALLY
AND THERE WOULD PROVIDE
ESSENTIALLY ANY SERVICE THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL WOULD REQUIRE. TO BE.
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED- AS SUCH AS
MYSELF OR SOMEBODY WHO'S BLIND.
IT COULD BE ORGANIZATION. AS
WITH THE TECHNOLOGY TRAINING AND
THE LIKE. D. END UP IN LIVING
SIR PROGRAM- PROVIDE SERVICES TO
OF THIRTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUAL
INVOLVED A LITTLE BIT ON THE OF
THOSE PER. AND A THE SERVICES.
IN THAT. PROGRAMS ARE
ESSENTIALLY- A FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES- TO BE ABLE TO
WHAT ON IN THE COMMUNITY I'M
BACK IN FLORIDA COUNSELING IT
COULD INCLUDE OREGON FISH
MARBELLA AS- I'M IN THE CENTRAL
AND IN THE- OF THE NUMBER OF BUT
OF COURSE SERVICES. THAT ARE
PROVIDED SOUL START WITH THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING- CENTERS.
THERE ARE TWENTY EIGHT AND ABOUT
FORTY NINE LOCATIONS THE WHAT
THIS OF CALIFORNIA- THEY SERVE
UP WITH OF THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS.
WE HAVE A TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY
PROGRAM- AND BY THE WAY THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING SERVICES OR A
CROSS OF DISABILITY SERVICE
PROVIDER NETWORK. WE HAVE A
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY- PROGRAM
THAT FOCUSES ON SERVICES
SPECIALIZING FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
OUR- FOR MEDIC BRAIN INJURY. AND
THEN WE HAVE OUR- ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
DEVICE WHEN BEING A DEVICE
DEMONSTRATIONS IN SOME TWENTY
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THIS WOULD GIVE
THE INDIVIDUAL AND OPPORTUNITY.
TO SEE WHAT ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGIES MIGHT BE USEFUL TO
THEM- AND EVEN TO USE THOSE ON
TO SEE HOW HE ACTUALLY
FUNCTIONED- FOR THE INDIVIDUAL.
WE HAVE OUR OLDER INDIVIDUALS
WERE BLIND PROGRAM AND I'LL SKIP
AT THE MOMENT BECAUSE MY CALL
THE BOOK SUCH A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL ON THAT. THE OTHER THING
THAT I WOULD MENTION IN MY BOOK
VIEW HERE AS THAT WHEN IT COMES
TO ORDER OF SELECTION AND
WAITING LISTS I'M ORDER
SELECTION APPLIES TO THE
VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION
PROGRAM YOUNG. WOMAN SERVICE
ASIDE. AND WE HAVE ALL UP A
WAITING AND IN TAKEN EVERYBODY
THAT WOULD. A NUMBER OF TIMES
OVER THE LAST- AB DE YEARS
THERE'S- IT NOBEL. OF TWENTY
TWENTY WE FORMALLY ACCEPTED
YOUR- SELECTION. BUT RESPECTED
THE INDEPENDENT LIVING PROGRAMS
THAT I MENTIONED WE DID NOT HAVE
A WAITING LIST FOR THE PROVIDERS
NOT NECESSARILY HAPPY WITH HIM
THIS. FOR ANY OF THOSE PROGRAMS-
I WILL TURN IT OVER WITH A
CHURCH PERMISSION TO MY
COLLEAGUES TO SPEAK MORE
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT OUR PROGRAMS.
AND. SERVICES FOR THE BLIND AND
VISUALLY IMPAIRED. CONDUCTING
AND I MEAN THE MUSIC AND THAT
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR HERE AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
USHERED US SPEAK WITH YOU- WE AT
THE DEPARTMENT HAS SEVERAL
PROGRAMS. GEARED SPECIFICALLY
FOR- CONSUMERS FOR BLIND AND
VISUALLY IMPAIRED- IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO- THE LEGISLATURE IS
STYLISH UNDER SB ONE OH FIVE-
THAT THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
PROVIDE SPECIALIZED SERVICES TO-
SPECIALIZED. WE ARE SERVICES
THAT OCCASIONAL REHABILITATION
SERVICES THE PEOPLE. WHO ARE
BLIND AND VISUALLY IMPAIRED- SO
IT'S A PARALLEL PROGRAM TO R. B.
R. PROGRAM THAT- MISTER DAVE
HERE- SPOKE OUT BUT IT'S GEARED
TOWARD AGAIN- FIND A VISUALLY
IMPAIRED CONSUMERS IT'S COLOR
BLIND FIELD SERVICES PROGRAM-
AND- IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- WE SERVE. UPWARDS OF
A FORTY SEVEN HUNDRED-
CONSUMERS- IN ADDITION TO BUYING
FIELD SERVICES WE ALSO AS-
STRIPS BAKER MENTIONED WE HAVE
THE ORIENTATION CENTER FOR THE
BLIND- THAT WHICH IS OUR- OUR
FACILITY- IN THE BAY AREA THAT
PROVIDES. ORIENTATION TRAINING
TO OUR PEOPLE ARE BLIND
INCLUDING ARE PROVIDING
INDEPENDENT LIVING SKILLS
TRAINING OUR TRAINING CAN
INCLUDE COOKING INDEPENDENT
TRAVEL. RAILING COMMUNICATION
ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY. AND WORK
READINESS SKILLS NECESSARY FOR
OCCASIONAL SUCCESS- ARE
CONSUMERS THAT OCP ORIENTATION
CENTER FOR THE BLIND- ARE I'LL
HAVE- LOCATIONAL GOALS- WE ALSO
OPERATE THE BUSINESS. ENTERPRISE
PROGRAM. WHICH IS- I GUESS FOR
BLIND OF VISUALLY AND CAN. I'M
TRYING THEM AND TO BECOME
BUSINESS OWNERS THE FOOD SERVICE
IN- AND IN FACILITIES ARE
LOCATED IN PUBLIC BUILDINGS- AND
I AND THEN WE HAVE THE OLDER
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE BLIND WHICH
IS- AN INDEPENDENT LIVING SKILLS
PROGRAM FOR FOLKS WHO ARE FIFTY
FIVE AN OLDER- AND- I DO NOT
SEEK EMPLOYMENT DID NOT INTEND
TO SEEK EMPLOYMENT. OF BUT WHO
WISH TO REMAIN INDEPENDENT IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND THIS IS A
PROGRAM FOR WHICH WE ARE PROVIDE
FEDERAL GRANT DOLLARS TO-
ORGANIZATIONS THAT THAT PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES- WE ALSO- AS WAS
MENTIONED I HAVE AN INDEPENDENT
LIVING- PROGRAM- WHICH- IS.
FUNDED THROUGH FEDERAL DOLLARS
AND ALSO- FAST PASSED TO. THE
TWENTY INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
ALL OF WERE ALSO SERVED
FINANCIALLY IMPAIRED CONSUMERS
AND THEN IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
HAVE I'M A VERY SMALL- STATE
FIND A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR- JUST SIR I
HAVE FOLKS WHO. ARE BLIND OR
VISUALLY IMPAIRED BUT HE DID NOT
HAVE A VOCATIONAL FALL AND OTHER
SERVICES ARE VERY LIMITED THERE
FOR PERSONAL SERVICES GOLD. AND
OUR READERS READERS. SERVICES
YOU. I AM HAPPY TO I QUESTIONS
TO TURN IT OVER TO THE NEXT
ANNALS THANK YOU DIRECTOR AND
CHIEF STEP TO ONE HERE JULY JULY
BAKER WITH APART OF FINANCE.
HELLO THANK YOU CHAIR- WE JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS THAT WE HAVE
RECEIVED NO PROPOSALS FOR
AUGMENTATIONS OF SERVICES FOR.
THE BLIND OR VISION VISION
IMPAIRED FOLKS- THAT ARE
TRANSITIONING INTO JOB READY
SERVICES AND THAT THERE HAS NOT
BEEN A WAIT LIST- INDICATED NEED
UP- ANY ACCESS FUNDING WE'RE
AUGMENTATION FOR THESE PROGRAMS
AND THAT'S IT FOR ME HAPPY DAY
AND- THREE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM SONYA
PADDOCK WITH THE L. L. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- CINEMATIC LA- WE
DON'T HAVE ANY- SPECIFIC
COMMENTS ON THIS INFORMATIONAL
ITEM. OUR LAST TWO PRESENTERS
ARE FROM THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
FOR THE BLIND WE WILL BEGIN WITH
JEFF TOM THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS. YEAH. IN A
DIRECT TOM IT APPEARS THAT
YOU'RE ON MUTE. MISTER CHAIR IF
I COULD HELP JEFF UP CONTROL M.
WELL ON YOUR CHEEK. WE'RE STILL
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU DIRECT MY
ADMITTED ARE THERE YOU ARE YES
OKAY SO I'M GONNA HAVE TO. WELL
THE SPACEBAR DOWN BECAUSE I
CAN'T GET THE COMMAND TO WORK.
BUT I WILL DO THE BEST I CAN
WITH ONE HAND. FIVE RIGHT. BOB
SO MY NAME IS JEFF TOM I AM
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
THE BLIND. I AM TESTIFYING TODAY
TO IMPART TO YOU ONE IMPORTANT
FACT AND THAT IS TO EDUCATE YOU
CONCERNING THE NEED FOR SERVICES
TO THEIR ADULTS AND ALL ADULTS
WHO ARE BLIND OR VISUALLY
IMPAIRED. ALTHOUGH I'M GOING TO
CONCENTRATE ON DATA FOR OLDER
ADULTS ONE THING IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL THAT SHOULD BE
REMEMBERED THAT IS IF YOU ARE
UNDER FIFTY FIVE AND DO NOT HAVE
AN EMPLOYMENT GOAL MOST ADULTS
ABOUT WHEN THEY LOSE THEIR
VISION DO NOT. YOU ARE
INELIGIBLE FOR ALL OF THE
SERVICES THAT. WE'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT LATER. BOTH INSTANCES
DATA PAINT A PICTURE OF
CALIFORNIA'S OLDER ADULTS WITH
VISION LOSS THERE ARE CLOSE TO
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND OLDER
ADULTS ONLY AND CALIFORNIA RURAL
COUNTIES HAVE HIGHER PERCENTAGES
OFTENTIMES THAN URBAN ONES. THE
MAJORITY ARE WOMEN AND DUE TO
VARIOUS FACTORS THERE ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH RATES OF
. THE VISION LOSS AMONG AFRICAN
AMERICANS LATIN ACTS AND THE
NORDBY POPULATIONS NEARLY ONE
THIRD OF OLDER ADULTS WITH
VISION LOSS DO NOT HAVE A HIGH
SCHOOL EDUCATION AND 40% HAVE
INCOMES OF TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR LESS. ESTIMATES
INDICATE THAT UP TO HALF OF
OLDER ADULTS WITH VISION LOSS-
OUR IN- STAR ESTIMATES INDICATE
THAT HALF OF NURSING FACILITY
RESIDENTS AB VISION IMPAIRMENT
AND OLDER ADULTS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO SUFFER FALLS AND HAVE CHRONIC
MEDICAL CONDITIONS. FINALLY WHEN
ADULTS LOSE MOST OR ALL OF THEIR
VISION IT IS MORE COMMON THAN
NOT THAT THEY VIEW THEIR LIVES
AS ESSENTIALLY OVER IN A
DOWNHILL SPIRAL FROM WHICH THEY
WILL NOT RECOVER. THIS VIEW
CREATE AND NOW OF SYRIA MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES SUCH AS
SOCIAL. ISOLATION AND DEPRESSION
. GOOD NEWS HOWEVER IS THAT WITH
THE APPROPRIATE SERVICES. THE
PICTURE FOR THESE PEOPLE CAN BE
ONE IN WHICH THEY RETURNED TO AN
INDEPENDENT AND REWARDING
LIFESTYLE SO WHAT ARE THESE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED. BECAUSE
THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT THE
FUNDING FOR THESE SERVICES IS
WOEFULLY LACKING. THEY NEED
ORIENTATION AND MOBILITY
SERVICES WHICH ALLOW THEM TO
NAVIGATE IN THEIR HOME COMMUNITY
OR NEIGHBORHOOD IT IS AMAZING
HOW USING A CANE OR GUIDE DOG
CAN. HAVE AN IMPACT ON ONE'S
SELF CONFIDENCE THEY OF COURSE
NEED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
THEY NEED AS YOU MIGHT EXPECT
TECHNOLOGY TRAINING SO THEY CAN
USE SMARTPHONES AND COMPUTERS.
TO HELP ALL ASPECTS OF THEIR
DAILY LIFE. BUT AS I HAVE SAID
THE BIG ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM IS
FUNDING AS YOU HEARD THERE IS
FEDERAL FUNDING OF LITTLE MORE
THAN THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE WHOLE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THIS AMOUNT HAS NOT
INCREASED IN MANY YEARS. IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT THIS FUNDING
NEEDS 3% OF THE NEED ON OF
COURSE AS I HAVE SAID UNLESS YOU
HAVE AN EMPLOYMENT GOAL. YOU
ARE- IF YOU'RE UNDER FIFTY FIVE
YOU'RE NOT EVEN GOING TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THESE SERVICES. AS
LIMITED AS THEY ARE. SO I URGE
YOU TO CONSIDER EXPANDING THE
OLDER INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE BLIND
PROGRAM AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
MORE AND MORE INDIVIDUALS WITH
VISION LOSS ARE SERVE. TO EXPAND
SERVICES UNDER THE MEDICARE
EIGHT CBS PROGRAM TO INCLUDE THE
SERVICES DESCRIBED ABOVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR TOM NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM SERRA HARASSED
FIRST VICE PRESIDENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF THE BLIND. READING OF EVERYONE AND GOOD
AFTERNOON I AM SO HONORED TO BE
WITH YOU TODAY- MY NAME IS TERRA
PARENTS. AND AB JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE BUT YOU CAN HEAR ME. COMING
THROUGH LOUD AND CLEAR AWESOME
YOU KNOW THE THING THAT SAID
TELL US THAT WE'RE NOT CONNECTED
WELL WE'LL FIGURE SO I AM THE
FIRST VICE PRESIDENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL THE BLIND AS
WELL AS DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMS FOR
RESOURCES FOR INDEPENDENCE
CENTRAL VALLEY. AND I'M HERE
TODAY AND IF HE A DIFFERENT
PICTURE HELLO- SO IMAGINE THAT
YOU ARE JUST DRIVING HOME FROM
THE GROCERY STORE TYPICAL SUNDAY
AFTERNOON DRIVING HOME LOOKING
AT UNIFIL SENSE THAT ONE OF
THOSE CUTS THAT LOOKING LIKE
RAINBOW SHERBERT ORANGE AND
GREEN AND PURPLE AND RED AND
BEAUTIFUL AND THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN SOMEBODY RUNS A RED
LIGHT. AND HIT YOUR CAR AND YOUR
LIFE IS PUT INTO DARKNESS AND
CHANGE FOREVER. THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED TO ME I KNOW. THIRD AT
THOUSAND TWO. I LOST MY VISION
I'M TOTALLY BLINDS AND I HAVE
BEEN MARRIED FOR ONE YEAR- AND-
HAD TO LEARN TO LIVE IT WILL BE
DIFFERENT NINE. AT THAT TIME-
DEPARTMENT REHABILITATION HAD A
PROGRAM THAT- HANDED FORTUNE
NAME OF THE HOMEMAKER TRACK- ARE
PEOPLE WHO DID NOT HAVE AN
EMPLOYMENT OR EDUCATION GOAL
WERE ABLE TO RECEIVE INDEPENDENT
LIVING SKILLS TRAINING. THAT IS
SO IMPORTANT AND OF COURSE AT
THE TIME IT WAS SENT- HE'S BIG
ON TECHNOLOGY AS IT SHOULD BE
NOW BECAUSE TECHNOLOGY WASN'T.
AS AT. COPULAR OR OR REAL AND
AVAIL FOR US THE TIME. I WAS
ABLE TO LEARN SOME BROWN'S
SCALES I WAS ABLE TO LEARN HOW
TO USE A CANE SO HOW TO COOK AND
CLEAN AGAIN AND THAT WAS ABOUT
THE EXTENT OF THE TRAINING THAT
I RECEIVED AT THAT TIME. AND NOW
THOUGH IF THAT WERE TO HAPPEN IN
THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND. TWENTY
EIGHT TO SOMEONE. THEY WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO RECEIVE THOSE SAME
SERVICES. THE CEREMONY AND THEY
DID NOT HAVE AN EMPLOYMENT OR
EDUCATION GOAL MOST PEOPLE WHO
USE THEIR STATE LIKE MYSELF
TRAGICALLY- IN AN ACCIDENT ARE
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO GO AND
WAKE UP A WEEK LATER GO ALL
RIGHT SO NOW I KNOW I WANT TO DO
THAT SO I WANT TO BE A TEACHER
AND ONE OF THE AMERICAN FAMILY
THERAPIST. WHATEVER IT MAY BE
THAT'S NOT GOING TO JUMP OUT OF
THEIR BRAIN ALL THEY'RE GOING TO
WANT TO DO IS TO LEARN HOW TO
LIVE AGAIN. AND I HAVE FOUND
THAT THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE BLIND OR HAVE LOW
VISION. WHO ARE UNDER THE AGE OF
FIFTY FIVE. AND OVER THE AGE OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN SCHOOL THAT
ARE. NOT RECEIVING SERVICES
BECAUSE THE BEST BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT THE FUNDING ANYMORE. TO
SUPPORT PEOPLE RECEIVING
SERVICES THAT ARE SO NEEDED. AND
IT IS A VERY TRAGIC THING WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE A TON OF PEOPLE OUT THERE
THE BETTER I'M HAPPY. HERE TO
PROTEST THE NOT RECEIVING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES EITHER BECAUSE
IT'S JUST THE FUNDING ISN'T.
THERE I. RANG THE SPORTS YOU AND
- OPEN TO ANY. THAT ANYONE MAY
HAVE. AND REALLY HOPE THAT WE
CAN LOOK AT A WAY THAT WE CAN
BRIDGE THIS GAP AND FIVE
SERVICES AND FIND FUNDING FOR
PEOPLE. WHO THAT SCARE SITE. AND
HAVE TO LEARN HOW TO LIVE AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- BEFORE WE RETURN TO
MEMBERS QUESTIONS SOMEONE ASKED
THAT WE TAKE ROLE. DR ARAMBULA
HERE MATHIS HERE PATTERSON RAMOS
RUBIO DR WOULD QUORUM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WILL NOW TURN TO SEE
IF ANY MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS ON
THIS ISSUE- I WILL BRING IT
BACK. TO THE CHAIR AND WOULD
LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO FOLLOW UP
WITH DIRECTOR XAVIER AFTERWARDS.
BUT LATER IN THE AGENDA WE WILL-
SEE ON PAGE EIGHTEEN. HOW THERE
IS A RISK OF EXPOSURE TO THE
STATE OF FOR NOT. ACCOMMODATING
AND SUPPORTING AND ENGAGING OUR-
DEAF COMMUNITY IN. RESULTING IN
ISOLATION AND LACK OF MEANINGFUL
COMMUNICATION. AND HEARING WHAT
WE HAVE TODAY FROM- DIRECTOR TOM
AND FROM SARAH HARRIS I BELIEVE
THERE'S A RESPONSIBILITY FOR US
TO MAKE SURE WE ARE. ADDRESSING
THE SOCIAL ISOLATION AND HOW WE
CAN ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
CONNECTED TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT THEY WERE SPEAKING
ABOUT TODAY AND SO WOULD. LIKE
TO HAVE FOLLOW UP CONVERSATIONS
TO ENSURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION IS DOING ALL IT
CAN TO SUPPORT. BLIND
CALIFORNIANS AND JUST WANTED TO.
MAKE SURE TO BRING THAT UP- AT.
THE END I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
SURE TO HAVE A REQUEST FROM THE
CHAIR WHICH IS TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION ON PROJECTED NEEDS
AND CAPACITY FOR THE EXPANSION
OF THE SERVICES. OF THE BLIND
POPULATIONS THAT ARE NOT SCHOOL
AGED FOUR WHO ARE OVER THE AGE
OF FIFTY FIVE. I BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT HAVING HEARD THE
TESTIMONY TODAY TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE LOOKING AT THAT POPULATION-
BETWEEN THOSE SCHOOL AGES AND
OVER FIFTY FIVE TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE CONNECTING THEM TO THE
APPROPRIATE SERVICES IN REAL
TIME AS WELL. I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU BRING THAT INFORMATION BACK
TO THE SUB COMMITTEE ON MY STAFF
BY FRIDAY- FRIDAY APRIL EIGHTH
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. I'M
LOOKING TO SEE IF THAT'S
AMENABLE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION. SURE WE
APPRECIATE THE REQUEST WAS
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE ASK
WERE WERE CONCERNED THAT THE
WINDOW OF TIME. TO CONDUCT
ANALYSIS IS BEING ASKED FOR-
MIGHT MIGHT NOT PROVIDE US WITH
THAT OPPORTUNITY- I KNOW MISTER
TOM SHARE SOME INFORMATION.
ABOUT SOME BROAD PROBABLY SOME
OF THE NUMBERS THAT EXISTS. BUT
IT IT WOULD REQUIRE BE ENABLED
SHOULD NOT ONLY IDENTIFY THE
INDIVIDUALS. BUT WHICH OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHAT WANT TO GET
JUST SET UP THE SERVICE SAYS- IF
THEY WERE ELIGIBLE. FOR THE
SERVICE I THINK THERE'S JUST A
NUMBER OF. ACTORS TOOK. I MAY
ASSESSMENT OF THAT. I WONDER
WHAT TIME MAY NOT ALLOW US TO-
DIRECTORS AB HAPPY TO WITH YOU
AND OUT HOW TO HAVE THE TIMELINE
WORK FOR US ALL AND- APPRECIATE
THE ABILITY TO ENGAGE WITH YOUR
OFFICE GOING FORWARD. MISTER
ROGER. YEAH LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT DRUM I WOULD I WOULD
ONLY SAY THAT. PRIOR TO THE TIME
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PRECLUDED CALIFORNIA FROM
SURVEYING THIS POPULATION WHEN
THEY DID NOT HAVE AN EMPLOYMENT
GOAL- THAT THERE WAS A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE BEING SERVED. THAT DID NOT
HAVE SUCH A GOAL AND I KNOW THAT
THE DEPARTMENT IS WELL AWARE
THAT CAN PROVIDE THE STATISTICS.
THAT WERE AFFECTED BY THAT POINT
IN TIME. YES JEFF THAT IS
CORRECT DATA THAT WOULD BE
SPECIFIC CHAIR WHEN AND IF THE
CHAIR WISHES I CAN PROVIDE A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL ON WHAT A
HOMEMAKER. THIS WILL LOOK LIKE
BUT DATA THAT WOULD BE SPECIFIC
TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WERE
ENOUGH HOMEMAKER STATUS THAT WE
CERTAINLY WOULD HAVE. MORE
ACCESS TO. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS AND
I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TO WHICH IS THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES ISSUES
WE WILL HEAR ABOUT THREE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS AND FIVE
ISSUES UNDER IMPLEMENTATION AND
OVERSIGHT. WE WILL HAVE FIVE
PRESENTERS ON ISSUE TOO WE WILL
BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR NANCY
BARTMAN THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AS WELL
AS MULTI CHRIS UPON DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF FEDERAL PROGRAMS IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. MR FOR BOB NEILL FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SONYA
PADDOCK THE PRINCIPAL ANALYST
WITH THE L. A. L. AND LORENA
GONZALEZ EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE ALTA CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
CENTER. LET'S BEGIN WITH
DIRECTOR APARTMENT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TO
YOU OUR PROPOSALS FOR GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- AND LOOK FORWARD TO BE
ABLE TO RESPOND TO THE QUESTIONS
THAT ARE- INCLUDED IN THE AGENDA
TODAY I DO WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF FOR- PROVIDING A
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF THE
PROPOSALS AND BACKGROUND
INFORMATION- IT IS A REAL
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE TO YOU A
COUPLE THAT PROPOSAL SENATE. AND
WE'RE DOING- ON THIS ISSUE- THIS
IS A PARTICULAR ISSUE THAT IS A
VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART
BECAUSE I STARTED MY CAREER
WITHIN. THEIR REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM- WITH EARLY INTERVENTION
AND WORKING WITH CHILDREN FROM
BIRTH THROUGH FIVE- SO AS WE
TAKE A LOOK AT OUR SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WE ARE
GROWING DEPARTMENT- THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE SERVING
CONTINUES TO GROW EACH YEAR SO
BY CONTEXT RIGHT NOW. WE'RE
ANTICIPATED APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE WOULD BE
SURVEYED IN THIS NEXT YEAR
THAT'S APPROXIMATELY AT AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS FROM WHAT IS
ESTIMATED IN CURRENT YEAR- DDS
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR SERVICES
UNDER THE LANHAM AND
DEVELPMENTAL DISABILITIES
SERVICES ACT BUT ALSO- FOR THE
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES ACT-
FOR ENSURING THAT MORE THAN-
THE- OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
CHILDREN- IN EARLY START ARE
RECEIVING SERVICES AND SUPPORTS-
SAME WITH THE INDIVIDUALS UNDER
THE LETTERMAN ACT TO BE ABLE TO
REALLY MAKE THOSE CHOICES THAT
LEAD- INDEPENDENT AND- AND LIFE
THAT THEY CHOOSE TO LEAVE- WE
WORK. IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
CONSUMERS FAMILIES- SERVICE
PROVIDERS REGIONAL CENTERS OTHER
STATE DEPARTMENTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON INTENT AND
TO HAVE A VISION FOR WHAT THAT
LIFETIME OF PREFERRED CHOICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE. ON ISSUE
TO TODAY. I'M MORE FOCUSED IN-
START PARTY TO BE IT ALSO- EXT-
FROM AGE TO UP AGE. AND THE- THE
TO. ISSUESTHAT WE'RE GOING TO
REVIEW- HAS QUESTIONS THAT ARE
OUTLINED IN YOUR AGENDA SO JUST
FOR WE'RE TRACKING I'M GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND PROVIDE- RESPONSES
TO YOUR QUESTIONS- A. B. AND D.
AND THEN MY COLLEAGUE WILL GO
AHEAD AND- FINISH UP OUR PANEL-
ON C. E. AND AT. SO THE PRO THAT
WE HAVE FORWARD IS REDUCING
CASELOAD RATIOS FOR CHILDREN
FROM BIRTH THROUGH AGE FIVE-
REDUCING THOSE CASELOAD RATIOS
ONE TO FORTY AND THE QUESTION IS
ASKED AS TO HOW DID WE COME UP
WITH. KIND OF THAT ESTIMATE OF
ONE TO FORTY WE HAD ORIGINALLY
AND THAT- PROPOSED SPENDING PLAN
HAD AN ESTIMATE OF ONE TO FORTY
FIVE. HOWEVER IF THERE'S SOME
INFORMATION THAT CAME FORWARD TO
US- THROUGH SOME OF THE WORK IN
THE TARGETED- REDUCE CASELOAD
RATIOS OF AN INITIATIVE- THAT
WAS INTRODUCED IN- LAST BUDGET
CYCLE THAT'S A LOW TO NO POS.
I'M E. LARK- SOEASTERN LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL CENTER- HAD-
SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT- AS
PART OF THEIR DISPARITY GRANT
AND- TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. FOR
APPROVAL TO BE ABLE TO HAVE LOW
TO NO POS FOR CHILDREN- WHO HAD
PRIMARY LANGUAGE THAT WAS NOT
ENGLISH. AND THEY HAD- REALLY
STRUGGLE TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
SERVICES AND EXPENDITURES- FOR
THOSE SERVICES ARE CONNECTING TO
OTHER- GENERIC RESOURCES. AND
THROUGH THIS PROPOSAL THEY
REALLY DID EMONSTRATES THAT
HAVING A ONE TO FORTY CASELOAD
RATIO REALLY PRODUCE POSITIVE
OUTCOMES IT ONLY PRODUCED
OUTCOMES AS FAR AS- THE
EXPENDITURES THAT WERE REALIZED
BY- THE FAMILIES BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS SERVICES. BUT ALSO REALLY
DEMONSTRATING THEIR ABILITY TO
NAVIGATE- THE SYSTEMS TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS THE REGIONAL
CENTER WHAT IS EDUCATION.
SUPPORT THEY REALLY NOT ONLY
LIKE I SAID BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS AS TO
ACCESSING SERVICES BUT REALLY
CREATING. A LIFELONG ADVOCACY OR
UNDERSTANDING OF SERVICES THAT
WOULD BENEFIT THEM- ALSO WHEN WE
TAKE A LOOK AT HOW DO WE IMPROVE
SOME OF THE WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE TO TRANSITION CHILDREN FROM
PARK CITY WHICH IS OUR EARLY
START PROGRAM. UNDER THE
EDUCATION THAT WE ARE ABLE TO-
PROVIDE THOSE SUPPORTS TO
TRANSITION WHEN THEIR- AT TWO
YEARS NINE MONTHS TO THREE YEARS
OLD. TO EDUCATION THIS IS BEEN
PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT AND
CHALLENGING FOR MANY FAMILIES AS
SO IN MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
BEING RESPONSIVE NOT ONLY TO THE
FAMILIES BUT THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE UNDER SB EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE. WHICH IS OUTLINED
IN YOUR AGENDA TODAY THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
WORKGROUP HAD- MADE SEVERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS SO CERTAINLY THE
CASELOAD RATIOS AS RIGHT AS
RESPONSE TO THAT. BUT ALSO
TAKING A LOOK AT HOW DO WE GET
INCLUSION FOR PRESCHOOL- WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
CVP THEY'VE BEEN A REALLY GREAT
PARTNER THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
SB SEVENTY FIVE. BUT ALSO TAKING
A LOOK AT HOW CAN WE TAKE- ALL
OF THE WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING THAT
CAN COMPLEMENT EACH OTHER. SO
WITH THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS-
PROPOSING- FOR INCLUSIVE
PRESCHOOL OPPORTUNITIES IT
REALLY IS NOT. IN CONFLICT WITH
THE PROPOSALS THAT CD IS BEEN
WORKING ON IN PRESCHOO WE
REALLY SEE IT AS A COMPLIMENT
AND BEING ABLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
HOW CAN WE ACCESS MORE THE
PRIVATE PRESCHOOLS. GROUP
PARTICULARLY IN THOSE AREAS
WHERE FAMILIES ARE HAVING A
STRUGGLE IN IDENTIFYING AND
FINDING THOSE INCLUSIVE OPTIONS-
AND AGAIN A LOT OF THIS IS UNDER
THOSE- WITH THOSE FAMILIES WHO-
I HAD. DIFFICULTY SERVICES. SO-
AND WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT THE- AT
THE ENDS BUT FOR NOW I'LL GO
AHEAD AND- HANDED OFF TO MY
COLLEAGUE. REPORTS AND-
HAPPENING WHERE MEMBERS OF THE
SECOND PART OF MICHAEL SERVICES
- TO PICK BACK ON WHAT OF WATCH
SAID UNDER THE INTENDS TO AT THE
PER MIX OF STAKEHOLDER AND
CONDUCT OUTREACH TO PREPAY
PRIVATE PRESCHOOL DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WERE A TIME- YOUR SOUND
IS THERE IN CHANCE WE CAN TRY TO
MAKE AN IMPROVING. IS IT. IS SO
HARD REACH OUT THAT HERE- MISTER
CHAIR. THE MAN ARE HAVING A HARD
TIME IS WHAT THEY'RE TELLING ME
RIGHT NOW. IT IT JUST SOUNDS A
LITTLE MORE WEEK BARELY YOU. AB
I'LL TRY TO MOVE CLOSER THE-
DOES THAT HELP OR IT A STILL
HERE MUCH IF YOU'RE TO THE MIKE
A WE CAN HEAR OU CLEARLY NOW-
MISTER. THINGS THANKS FOR THE ME
KNOW- SO- LIKE I AND AT BUT
DIRECT PARCHMAN HIM. HAS SHARED
- WHAT WE INTO TO DO IT- THIS
PROPOSAL PRESCHOOL INCLUSION IS-
ENACT IS THAT WE- ENGAGE IN THE
- MIX OF STATE. AND CONDUCT OUT
THE COMMUNITY BASIN PRESCHOOLS
SPECIFICALLY THOSE THE COOPER.
AND BELIEVE. INCLUSIVE ALL-
RITUALS CONSUME. THIS IS THE
COLORING. WEDDING GROUP
IDENTIFIED MEANINGFUL OUTCOME
AND GUARDRAILS. SO WE CAN
PREVENT AND CONSEQUENCES. ARBACO
FOLK ON THREE FOUR YEAR OLD TO
WHO ARE. AND YOU SEE REGIONAL.
SERVICES THAT'S LAID IN THE- I
SPOKE WHEN. EVERY OUR PROPOSAL
IS THAT WE ASSIST THAT ARE
EXPERTS THE EDGE OF. LAW THAT IN
BECAUSE- ANSWERED. OR AS WE IN.
BUDGET CHANGED THAT I A SPECIAL
THIS. FIRST OF ALL THE- WILL NOT
CASE. THE IB EXPRESS IS THE EACH
CENTER WILL PROVIDE TECHNICAL
THIS. AND SUPPORT SIR FOR THE-
AND EDGE. EIGHT AND FAMILIES
THROUGH THE TRI. AS DIRECTOR
PARCHMENT- THAT THAT WHEN- ARE.
TO SO YOU'RE- TWO YEARS OF MY
OLD- ARTSY KIDS HOW THE CHANCE
TO PART B. RESPECT THAT YOU. AND
THIS. WILL ALSO SUPPORT-
REGIONAL CENTERS IN L. EIGHTIES
AND FED REQUIRED AND- JOB PER.
SUCH AS THE VOTE COULD NOT THE
ONLY TIME WE BUT HI QUALITY IN
THE- FAMILY SERVICE PLANS. ARE
IS THAT IN SERVICE. IN BY THE I
SPECIALISTS. WILL INCREASE
FAMILY AWARENESS OF THEIR RIGHTS
AS THE FOR A CHILD SCHEDULE.
SUPPORT AND- WITH THAT HAPPY TO
THE PASSAGE BACK TO MR. THANK
YOU NEXT WILL HEAR FROM THE OF
FINE. KRISTER O'NEILL. THANK YOU
MISS CHAIR- CHRISTOPHER- O'NEILL
FINE- NO FURTHER INFER TO SHARE
THIS TIME THANK YOU. NEXT WE
WILL FROM SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE
L. A. THANK YOU AND GO AND
MEMBERS SO YOU PAY FROM THE L.
A. I WOULD HAVE A FEW COME TO
MAKE ABOUT THIS- SOME OF THE CAN
. OF THIS PER SO FIRST WHEN IT
COMES TO CASE RATIO WE KNOW THAT
- CAL DOES. STRUGGLE CERTAIN
STAR MEASURES THAT ARE TO THE
FED GOVERNMENT SUCH AS TIMELY IN
THE WAY THE SERVICES AS WELL
TIMELY IN SETTING UP PLANNING
PRIOR TO THE TRIAL THIRD
BIRTHDAY. SO ARMY. TO THE- WAS
ABOUT WHETHER A ONE TO HAVE.
CASELOAD RATIOS THE RIGHT REYES
. AND IN LIGHT OF WHAT YOU KNOW
DDS- TESTIFIED TO AT THIS
HEARING AS WELL AS SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THEY
PROVIDED OUR OFFICE YESTERDAY WE
THINK THE JUSTIFICATION FOR ONE
TO FORTY DOES SEEM REASONABLE.
HOWEVER THERE ARE TWO ISSUES
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO RAISE THAT
ARE UP IN. THAT ARE IN THE-
PROPOSED ASSOCIATED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. SO THE FIRST IS THAT
THE ONE TO FORTY CASELOAD RATIO
WOULD NOT BE IN STATUTE INSTEAD
SIGNIFICANT DISCRETION WOULD BE
GIVEN TO YOU AT THAT APARTMENT
TO WORK IT OUT IN REGIONAL
CENTER CONTRACTS- IN ADDITION WE
KNOW THAT ONLY ONE. NEW AS FAR
AS WE CAN TELL ONLY ONE NEW
REQUIREMENT IS INCLUDED FOR
SERVICE COORDINATORS IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND THAT
IS. QUARTERLY REVIEWS OF THE
CHILD'S INDIVIDUALIZED FAMILY
SERVICE PLAN. WE WERE WONDERING
IF ANY OF THE OTHER- THE SORT OF
ACTIVITIES THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS HOPING THAT SERVICE
COORDINATORS WILL BE ABLE TO DO
SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN THIS
LANGUAGE INCLUDING- FOR EXAMPLE.
ACCOMPANYING THE FAMILY TO THE
CHILD IN THE BOOK INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PLAN MEETING AT THE
SCHOOL IF THE FAMILY. WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE THAT TYPE OF SUPPORT. ON
THE ISSUE OF REGIONAL CENTER
IDEA'S SPECIALISTS- WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
SPECIALISTS WOULD NOT BE- HAVING
CASELOAD OF THEIR OWN BUT WOULD
INSTEAD BE PROVIDING SUPPORT TO
THE SERVICE COORDINATORS THAT
SERVE THESE CHILDREN AS WELL AS-
BEING SORT OF. A SPECIALIST OR
TECHNICAL- OR OR SOMEBODY WHO'S
ABLE TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WHEN IT COMES TO
WORKING WITH THE DIFFERENT
SCHOOLS IN THE AREA. AND OUR
QUESTION I GUESS IS REALLY
WHETHER SOME OF THE REGIONAL
CENTERS. THAT HAVE- A LOT MORE
CHILDREN IN THIS AGE AS WELL AS
A LOT MORE SCHOOLS IN THEIR
CATCHMENT AREA. IF IF ONE A
SPECIALIST IS REALLY SUFFICIENT
TO SORT OF PROVIDE THE SUPPORT
TO THE SERVICE COORDINATORS AND
WORK WITH THE SCHOOLS IN THAT
AREA. WE'RE JUST NOT NOT SURE
THAT THAT ONE. WHY IT'S
NECESSARILY ONE SPECIALIST PER
REGIONAL CENTER. IN THEN WHEN IT
COMES. THE PRESCHOOL INCLUSION
PROPOSAL WE THINK THE INTENT OF
THIS PROPOSAL MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE BUT RIGHT NOW THE PROPOSAL
IS JUST NOT VERY REFINED. SO FOR
EXAMPLE- APART FROM THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED TODAY AT
THE HEARING ABOUT USING A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THERE ARE
THERE ARE NOT A LOT OF DETAILS
ABOUT HOW THIS WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED- WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY HOW THE PARTICULAR
PRESCHOOLS WOULD BE IDENTIFIED
OR WHAT TYPES OF SUPPORT. THEY
WOULD NEED SO FOR EXAMPLE THERE
STAFF MIGHT NEED MORE TRAINING
THEY MIGHT NEED MORE ADAPTIVE
EQUIPMENT OR THEIR BUILDINGS WE
NEED TO CHANGES TO MAKE THEM
MORE ACCESSIBLE- WE DON'T KNOW
IF THEY WOULD ACTUALLY NEED
EXTRA STAFFING OR IF IT WOULD
SIMPLY- IF THEY'D SIMPLY NEED TO
ALLOW CHILDREN TO BRING. IN
THEIR PERSONAL AIDES OR
PERSONAL- SUPPORTS. I HAVEN'T IN
ADDITION WE KNOW THAT LOT OF
PRESCHOOLS. A RUN FOR THE SAME
NUMBER OF HOURS AS DAYCARES SO
WERE IT'S UNCLEAR TO US WHETHER-
GETTING MORE CHILDREN IN TO
PRESCHOOL WILL- PROVIDED
COVERAGE FOR FAMILIES WHO ARE
WORKING- AND THEN FINALLY WE
JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IS BASED ON AND
WHAT WHAT THIS WILL ACTUALLY-
GET THE STATE IN TERMS OF HOW
MANY PRESCHOOLS WILL BE SERVED
AND- YOU KNOW WHAT IT. SUPPORT
THE KINDS OF CHANGES THAT THESE
PRESCHOOLS NEED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM GLORIA GONZALEZ THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ALTA
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL CENTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LAURIE BEEN
ALL THIS AND AS YOU MENTIONED I
AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT ALL
TO CALIFORNIA REGIONAL CENTER I
WORKED AT THE REGIONAL CENTER
FOR THE PAST TWENTY SIX YEARS OF
SERVING IN MULTIPLE CAPACITIES
AND ROLES- EARLY START CHILDREN
SERVICES IS AN AREA OF GREAT
INTEREST AND FOCUS FOR ME AND
FOR OUR REGIONAL CENTER- ON
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES
INCLUDING CASE MANAGEMENT. ARE
CRITICAL AND PROMOTE DEVELOPMENT
IN SUPPORT I'VE FOR FUTURE
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR OUR YOUNGEST
CLIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES. IT'S
MY PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY TO
SHARE HOW THESE INVESTMENTS THAT
DOCTOR DIRECTOR BIRDS BECAUSE
RIGHT INDICATED THAT HERE ARE
INCLUDED IN THE- PROPOSAL FROM
THE BUDGET- SERVE CHILDREN-
REALLY WELL AND I AM PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GREAT
OUTCOMES- I WAS ASKED TO ADDRESS
TWO QUESTIONS. ARE THE FIRST TO
DESCRIBE HOW THESE PROPOSALS
WOULD CHANGE OR IMPACT REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICES FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS. I AT THE TRANSITION TO
PRESCHOOL. THE FIRST IS THE
REDUCTION OF CASELOAD SIZE AND
IT'S BEEN- COMPETENT COMMENTED
ON THEM. IN TESTIMONY PREPARED
PRIVATE PRIOR TO MINE BUT I DO
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT BEING
ABLE TO HAVE A REDUCTION IN CASE
SITES UP FOR EACH SERVICE
COORDINATOR SUPPORTING CHILDREN
UNDER THE AGE OF SIX TO A
CASELOAD OF FORTY. WILL ALLOW
SERVICE COORDINATORS THE TIME TO
ASSIST SUPPORT FAMILIES MORE
INTENSIVELY. HAVING A CHILD WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS OR DIAGNOSE
DISABILITY CAN BE VERY STRESSFUL
FOR FAMILIES. FAMILIES ARE
GRIEVING AND EACH FAMILY
PRESENTS DIFFERENTLY THEY NEED
TIME AND ATTENTION TO WALK THEM
THROUGH THE SYSTEM. AND TO
DISCOVER. WHAT THE SERVICES. AND
SUPPORTS ARE THAT ARE AVAILABLE
TO THEM. AT LEAST NEEDS OF ALSO
NOW BIG THE MOLD SAYS. OF THAT
WILL BE A WORK WITH ARE THERE
NOW THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM-
MEDICAL. AND THE MEDICAL
ENTITIES- AS WELL AS- EDUCATION
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS. AND THE
COME FROM REGIONAL CENTER AS
WELL AS THROUGH THE MEDICAL
INSURANCE. REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICE COORDINATORS CAN BE ONE
OF THE BIGGEST SUPPORTERS ON
THIS JOURNEY AND PROVIDING
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT TO
FAMILIES. ON THEIR HOME BASE FOR
MANY MANY FAMILIES THE SERVICE
COORDINATOR COORDINATES EDUCATES
ASSESSES AND PROVIDES SUPPORT TO
THE FAMILY. IT'S PROPOSAL
SERVICE. MORE TIME. WITH THESE
INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE LEVEL SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEED FOR THEIR CHILD TO
HAVE THE BEST OUTCOMES INCLUDING
THE CRITICAL POINT OF
TRANSITIONING FROM EARLY START
SERVICES TO SPECIAL EDUCATION.
I'M CHILDREN EXIT THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM AT THIS POINT AND
A SOFT HAND OFF TO EDUCATION IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. FOR OTHER
CHILDREN AT AGE THREE THEY'LL
TRANSITION TO THE LAN URBAN
SERVICES TO A CHILDREN'S UNIT AT
THE REGIONAL CENTER. LOWER CASE
LOADS WILL ALLOW FOR THE
SPECIALIZED SUPPORT TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE THAT EDUCATION IN
ADVOCACY AND SUPPORTING FAMILIES
TO BETTER SERVE OTHER CHILDREN
TO BOTH SYSTEMS. ARE ALSO
ASSESSING AND PROVIDING NEEDED
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES. THE
SECOND INVESTMENT THAT WAS
MENTIONED WAS THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION SPECIALIST. TWENTY
EIGHT REGIONAL CENTER- WITHIN
IDEA'S SPECIALISTS TO TRAIN AND
SUPPORT SERVICE COORDINATORS AS
WELL AS TO GUIDE FAMILIES
THROUGH THE TRANSITION PROCESS
FROM PARTS FEE TO PART B. IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. IT WOULD
BE WONDERFUL TO HAVE THIS
POSITION I HAVE WITHIN REGIONAL
CENTERS TO CRIED THIS INCREASED
AWARENESS FOR FAMILIES TO
PROVIDE TRAINING AND SUPPORT NOT
ONLY TO OUR STAFF THE TWO
FAMILIES I TO BE A LIAISON
THROUGH EDUCATION AND THE
REGIONAL CENTER- AND TO REALLY
HELP TO PROMOTE- YOU KNOW THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM IN THE REGIONAL
SYSTEM COLLABORATING AND
COORDINATING IN THE BEST
INTEREST. OF CHILDREN SERVED THE
THIRTY BEST MAN IS THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE INCLUSIVENESS
ASSESSABLE PRESCHOOL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CHILDREN AGES. THREE AND FIVE THREE FIVE. THE
INCLUSION IS THE- INCLUDING
MAKES DE LOW DIFFERENT WHEN SHE
LEARN SIDE BY. THIS SUPPORTS
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT. I'M TO BE
INCLUDED IS A REALLY POWERFUL
THING I IN THE BENEFITS OF
INCLUSION AREN'T JUST LIMITED TO
THE CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES-
BUT ALSO TO THEIR NON DISABLED
PEERS WILL BENEFIT AS WELL.
ADDITIONALLY THIS A PROPOSAL
SUPPORTS FAMILY CHOICE IN HAVING
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS OF
POLLUTION OF PRIVATE PRESCHOOL
OR PUBLIC PRESCHOOL. A SECOND
QUESTION THAT WAS PROMOTED UNDER
MY TESTIMONY SECTION WAS WHAT
ARE THE AREAS WHERE SPECIAL
ATTENTION AS THE STATE LOOKS TO
INCREASE APPROVED SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN AN EARLY START. WELL
REGIONAL CENTERS CONTINUE TO
WORK REALLY DILIGENTLY ARE
FOCUSING ON INCREASING. ACCESS
WITH SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY-
MAKING SURE THAT EARLY START IS
ASSESSABLE TO EACH CLIENT AND
THEIR FAMILY. ENSURING THAT
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS ARE IN
LINE WITH THE CULTURE AND THE
LANGUAGE OF PREFERENCES A
FAMILY. A BUILDING THAT
REPERTOIRE AND THAT ABILITY TO
HAVE A NETWORK OF SERVICE
PROVIDERS THAT CAN SUSTAIN THIS
I NEED- GIVEN THE COMPLIMENTS
AND- COMPLEXITIES AND EACH
COMMUNITY  VER
DIFFERENCE- IN WHAT THE DATA
SUPPORTS AS WELL WHAT THE NEEDS
ARE. CALIFORNIA REGIONAL CENTER
FOR THE SURFACED COUNTY IN EACH
COUNTY I A DIFFERENT NEED INTO.
OF WHY IS A NEW TO SUPPORT
FAMILIES WITH PREFERENCE
CULTURAL- SUPPORT. SO NEED TO
LOOK AT THAT DAY AND WE NEED TO
GO OUT AND I HAVE THE SUPPORT
AND ABILITY TO ENGAGE WITH
STARTUPS PROVIDERS UNDER THE R.
F. P. AND GET FOLKS IN PLACE TO
SUPPORT THE FAMILIES.
ADDITIONALLY WE WANT TO YOU KNOW
WILL ROLL OUT WHAT IS IN CURRENT
BUDGET AND THAT'S THE IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING I TO ALL OF OUR
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF INCLUDING-
YOU KNOW CONTRACTORS THAT
PROVIDE INTAKE PROCESS SUPPORT.
AND LASTLY- IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
YOU KNOW I MENTIONED ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE FLEXIBILITY AND
ASSESSMENT AND SERVICE
PROVISION. THAT'S BEEN AFFORDED
A THROUGHOUT THIS PANDEMIC HAS
SERVED FAMILIES WHILE HAVING THE
ABILITY TO RECEIVE REMOTE
SERVICES HAS PROVIDED
CONTINUITY. FOR OUR CLIENTS
SERVED AND IT'S ALSO INCREASE
THE ABILITY OF OUR SERVICE
PROVIDERS. TO SEE MORE CLIENTS
WHEN YOU CUT OUT OF THE TRAVEL
TIME. GOING FORWARD TO BE REALLY
WONDERFUL IF THESE OPTIONS COULD
CONTINUE AT LEAST TO SOME DEGREE
IN CAPACITY. ENCLOSING ARCA ARE
ASSOCIATION APPRECIATES THE
GOVERNOR'S INCLUSION OF THESE
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS IN HIS
PROPOSED BUDGET. AND WE SUPPORT
THEIR APPROVAL AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE TODAY. THANK YOU EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR BUT KNOWLES'S WITH THAT
I WILL RETURN UP THE DICE TO SEE
IF ANY MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS ON
THIS ITEM. C. NINE NINE IWILL
FOLLOW UP ON TWO OF THE
QUESTIONS FROM THE L. A. L. TO
DIRECTOR BARGE MAN IF I CAN- I.
ENJOYED YOUR RESPONSE AND
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE- ONE TO
FORTY RATIO. AND IT I WOULD
AGREE IT DOES SEEM REASONABLE
BASED ON WHAT YOU'RE PRESENTING
BUT WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP ON
THE- EAST LA REGIONAL CENTER
DATA THAT YOU. PRESENTED BUT
WOULD LIKE TO QUESTION AS THE
ELLIE- STATED WHY WE'RE NOT.
PLACING THIS IN STATUTE WHY WERE
NOT CODIFYING THE RATIO AT ONE
TO FORTY IF WE- BELIEVE THAT
ULTIMATELY- SHOWS BETTER RESULTS
AND HOPING. YOU COULD COMMENT ON
THAT. THANK MISTER SO I THE-
CARE RATIOS AND THEN ALL WITH
THE BECAUSE- WE HAVE BEEN. A OF
THE POSITIONS- AS WE HAD NOTED
AND I THINK YOU'LL SEE OUTLINED
IN THE SUMMARY OF DIFFERENT
INITIATIVES OVER- THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS THAT HAVE BEEN
TARGETED FOR SPECIALIZED-
ATTENTION. ON SOME EXAMPLES
INCLUDE THE CULTURAL SPECIALIST-
INCLUDE- THE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS- ALSO OUR
EMPLOYMENT SPECIALIST EACH OF
THOSE WE HAVE TAKEN THE APPROACH
. NINETY ONE PER REGIONAL
CENTER- AND THEN EACH TIME WE'VE
BEEN HAVING THE- CHANGES IN
CASELOAD RATIOS AND THEN ALSO
WITH THEY ADDED POSITIONS- WE
FOUND THAT THE- INCLUSION IN THE
CONTRACT REALLY PROVIDED US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THAT
ADDITIONAL CLARITY- THAT WAS
ALSO NOTED BY MISS PETTICOAT
WHAT ARE THOSE I'M
RESPONSIBILITY SO M. INCREASED
PARTICIPATION AND I. E. P.
MEETING- WE ALSO HAVE NOTED IN
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
REGARDING- INCREASING PARENTS
ABILITY TO UNDERSTAND AND BE
ABLE TO NAVIGATE TRANSITION- SO
WE CAN GET THAT. MUCH WE CAN
HAVE A MORE INTEREST PROCESS IN
THE CONTRACT WHERE WE CAN BUILD
ON IT AND THAT'S- HOW WE WERE
APPROACHING I'M NOT ONLY THE
CASE LOAD RATIO BUT INTENTIONAL-
REQUIREMENTS- I AGREE IT'S A
GOOD BASE FOR US TO BEGIN WITH
ONES HER REGIONAL CENTER BUT
WOULD LIKE TO FOLLOW UP IF THERE
ARE SPECIFIC REGIONAL CENTERS
WITH- LARGE POPULATIONS THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AND WHETHER
OR NOT. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE TO
BE PROVIDING MORE. ID A
SPECIALIST TO THOSE AREAS IF
NECESSARY AND WOULD LIKE TO
FOLLOW UP. BUT DO YOU BELIEVE IT
SEEMS THAT YOUR NON ANSWER ON
WHY PLACING IT INTO STATUTE IS
TO GIVE SOME OF THE
FLEXIBILITIES TO THE REGIONAL
CENTERS TO IMPLEMENT AS THEY-
SEE FIT OF FOR NOT GOING TO
PLACE IT AND TO STATUTES AND SO
JUST WANT TO. MAKE SURE IS THIS
AN ASPIRATIONAL GOAL OR IS THIS
ONE WE'RE GOING TO REQUIRE OF
THE REGIONAL CENTERS TO COMPLETE
. YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THAT- THE CONTRACT CAN GET VERY
SPECIFIC AS FAR AS THE
EXPECTATION OF THE RATIOS. WE'RE
ALSO GOING TO BE MONITORING NOT
ONLY CASELOAD RATIOS I'M WE DO
KNOW THE REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE A
FAIRLY HEAVY LIFT AND- BRING IN
ON A NUMBER OF SERVICE
COORDINATORS IN THIS NEXT YEAR-
ARE PROPOSAL REFLECTS NINE
MONTHS WORTH. OF FUNDING THAT'S
NOT SO MUCH TO SAY WE WANT THEM
TO WAIT BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THERE WAS INVESTMENT AND- BUDGET
ACT TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR
REGIONAL CENTERS TO HAVE REDUCE
CASELOADS- IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION IF THEY'D BEEN THE
REST OF THAT THE CASELOAD- SO WE
WILL GET SPECIFIC IN THE
CONTRACT AS FAR AS WHAT THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE HOW WE'RE GOING
TO TRACK IT. AND THEN WE DO
HAVE- REPORTING OUT OF WHAT
CASELOAD RATIOS ARE IN ALL OF
THE REQUIREMENTS- THE ADDITIONAL
PIECE THAT I THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE REALLY VALUABLE AS OUR
PERFORMANCE CONTRACT. THAT WE'RE
ALSO GOING TO BE ABLE TO
INCLUDE- ELEMENTS SUCH AS THIS
AS TO HOW OUR REGIONAL CENTERS
PERFORMING IN A TIMELY WAY IN
FILLING THE POSITIONS TO GET THE
BENEFIT OF WHAT'S INTENDED. BY
REDUCING THESE CASELOAD RATIOS.
AND THE OUTCOMES WE EXPECT. I
WAS IN. BY WHAT YOU ARE AGAIN
ABOUT THE LARK AND- HOW THE NODE
TO LOW POS AS WELL AS- THE
POSITIVE OUTCOMES AND THE
ABILITY FOR MANY OF OUR
MONOLINGUALS TO NAVIGATE THE
SYSTEMS. AS THAT IS A WAY WE CAN
LEAN IN AND HAVE A LENDS TOWARDS
EQUITY LOOKING FORWARD. AND
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE WERE-
PLACING THAT JUSTIFICATION AND
TO. INTO LAW IF POSSIBLE AS I
BELIEVE THAT IS HOW WE WILL NEED
TO GO FORWARD WHICH IS TO MAKE
SURE WERE ADDRESSING OUR
COMMUNITY AND ENSURING THEY
HAVE. THE RIGHT STAFF AROUND TO
SUPPORT. WITH THAT I WILL HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN FOR NOW BUT WOULD
LIKE AGAIN AS I DID DURING THE
FIRST ITEM TO FOLLOW UP DIRECTOR
BARGE MAN BY APRIL EIGHTH IF
POSSIBLE WITH MANY OF THE
WRITTEN RESPONSES TO THE
QUESTIONS WE HAD HERE TODAY. AS
WELL AS A CHANCE TO WORK WITH
THE L. F. AND L. A- GOING
FORWARD FOR ANY QUESTIONS WE
HAVE AS THIS MAY- NEED TO ADJUST
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BEFORE
. COMPLETED I JUST WANT TO SEE
IF THAT'S AMENABLE TO YOUR
DIRECTOR. YEAH WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WITH- WITH THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITH THAT WE WILL- MOVE ON TO
ISSUE THREE WE WILL HAVE SIX
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL OF SUB
MINIMUM WAGE PHASE OUT. AND THE
WORK ACTIVITY PROGRAM WE WILL
BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR PARCHMAN
FOLLOWED BY CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR BRIAN WINFIELD. THEN WE
WILL HAVE CHRISTOPHER A DEAL
AGAIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE
L. A. O. ERIC ZIGMAN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE GOLDEN. GATE
REGIONAL CENTER AND ERIN
CARRUTHERS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE STATE COUNCIL OF
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
DIRECTOR BARGE MAN CAN YOU
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR YEAH SO WE'VE BEEN- A
NUMBER OF FRIENDS BEEN LOOKING
AT HOWARD PROVIDING SERVICES IN
WHAT SETTING TYPES FOR
INDIVIDUALS- AND MUCH OF THIS IS
ALSO DRIVEN BASED ON THE- H. C.
B. S. THE HOMING COMMUNITY BASED
ON SERVICES THE FEDERAL DOLLARS.
OUR COMPLIANCE- WE'VE BEEN
FOCUSING ON- LARGER SETTING
TYPES NOT ONLY FOR A DAY
SERVICES BUT ALSO FOR
RESIDENTIAL OR ONE OF THOSE
SETTINGS THAT MAY NOT BE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE NEW FEDERAL
RULE FOR COMMUNITY INCLUSION AND
CHOICE AND OTHER ELEMENTS THAT.
ARE UNDER THE- THEY REQUIREMENTS
WHICH ARE REALLY REALLY GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE- WE
WILL PRIORITIZE THERE'S FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND
EIGHT CBS FUNDING- THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE TO BE ABLE TO HELP
SUPPORT- PROVIDERS IN COMING
INTO COMPLIANCE- WE HAVE SEEN A
NUMBER OF WORK ACTIVITY PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE TRANSITION TO
ALTERNATIVE TYPES OF SERVICES-
WE'VE ALSO SEEN. BY USING SOME
OF THE FUNDS AND ALSO SOME OF
THEIR OWN INITIATIVES- BUT WE'VE
ALSO SEEN THAT WE HAVE QUITE A
FEW- WORKING TOO MANY PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE STILL- HAVE NOT
DEVELOPED THEIR PLANS OR IT'S
NOT REALLY CLEAR HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO BE TRANSITIONING I'M
INTO COMPLIANCE AND THAT IS THE
REASON I'M KIND OF GOING INTO
THAT IS BECAUSE MOST OF THE
SETTINGS. THAT REALLY ARE WITH
SUB MINIMUM WAGE- WE'RE WE PUT
THIS FORWARD TO FOLD ONE IS TO
REALLY TAKE A LOOK AT HOW CAN WE
BUILD A PILOT. THAT CAN BE AN
ALTERNATIVE WAY TO LOOK AT
PROVIDING- SERVICES AS A
TRANSITION KIND OF NAVIGATING
FROM HIGH SCHOOL OR FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN- WORK
ACTIVITY PROGRAMS BUT ALSO BE
RESPECTFUL TO THE FACT THAT MANY
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN THAT WORK
ACTIVITY PROGRAMS. HAVE DONE SO
FOR TWENTY THIRTY YEARS IN SOME
INSTANCES SO WHAT IS THAT PERSON
CENTERED APPROACH THAT CAN
REALLY. WORK WITH THE INDIVIDUAL
AND THEN LOOK AT HOW WE CAN-
THINK THROUGH. WHAT IS THE BEST-
AND WE LOOK. TO A BEING I A
BREATH. OF THE WORK I STATE
COUNCIL- THEIR WORK IS A HEAVY
LIFT AND WE ARE GOING TO BE
THERE- WITH THEM AS FAR AS
WHATEVER- DATA OR INFORMATION
THAT THAT THEY'RE WORKING ON. I
DON'T SEE THIS AS SOMETHING THAT
IS GOING TO- BE A CONFLICT AT
ALL WITH THE WORK WE'RE REALLY
HOPING THAT IT WILL BE A
COMPLIMENT OR MAYBE ONE OF THE
SERVICES. THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED AS- PART OF THE
FUTURE THINKING OF THOSE NEXT
STEPS- SO WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES TO-
FOCUSED ON THE QUESTIONS THAT
ARE ON IN THE AGENDA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- BRIAN WIND CHILL
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES- THE
PILOT PROGRAM. WILL BE
ESTABLISHED WITH A FRAMEWORK AND
REPORTING AND MONITORING OF
OUTCOMES IN MIND. WE WILL BE
ENGAGING STAKEHOLDERS AND THEY
STAKEHOLDER GROUP WOULDN'T
INCLUDE INDIVIDUALS. WHO RECEIVE
FOR CAPTIVITY PROGRAM SERVICES
AS WELL AS- FAMILY MEMBERS TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND. THE
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR NEEDS AND
WE ANTICIPATE THAT BY SPRING OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE REGIONAL
CENTERS THAT ARE PART OF THE
PILOT. WILL BEGIN TO DEVELOP ONE
OR MORE SERVICE MODELS AND
RECRUITING QUALIFY SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND IDENTIFY
INTERESTED. CONSUMERS TO THE
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM PLAN PROCESS-
DDS WILL MONITOR IMPLEMENTATION
REPORT. AN ENCORE ONGOING
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND
EVALUATION OF THE SERVICE MODEL
. I'M HOW WE PLAN TO WORK WITH
THIS COUNCIL ON THE BOTTOM
DOESN'T. REALLY THERE'S THAT
THREE TO THAT FIRST WE FIND THE
TVS PLAZA CRITICAL ROLE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE SB SIX THIRTY NINE SOME
MINIMUM WAGE MULTI YEAR PHASE
OUT PLAN. THE PILOT PROGRAM WILL
BE TO CAN COUNSEL. WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AS I PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED AND- ONE OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS AT THE TABLE WILL
OF COURSE BE THE STATE COUNCIL
ON DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND THEN THIRDLY JUST KEEPING IN
MIND THAT THE STATE COUNCIL
UNDER NORMAL DISABILITIES HAS A
VERY UNIQUE A ROLE IN THIS
PROCESS AND DDS HAS ON A
DIFFERENT ROLE IN THAT- ANOTHER
QUESTION WAS POSED AS TO WHETHER
OR NOT THESE SERVICES WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO INDIVIDUALS AND
OTHER TYPES OF PROGRAMS- THE
PILOT PROGRAM WILL BE DEVELOPED.
WITH THE NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS
AND WORK ACTIVITY PROGRAMS IN
MIND AND ALSO FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE EXITING HIGH SCHOOL-
HOWEVER AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE
WILL CONTINUE TO AND FINALLY
REEVALUATE AND IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT A SERVICES COULD BE.
EXPANDED TO OTHER INDIVIDUALS. I
WITH REGARDS TO THE- CHANGES TO
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS OPEN TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSION. OF THE
PROPOSED TVL AGAIN FIGHTS THE
WORKGROUP AND TIMELINE AND HAS A
TO PILE IT MAY BE MANAGED
THROUGH- DIRECTIVES. OUTCOMES
WILL BE IDENTIFIED THROUGH
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT BUT WILL
INCLUDE TRACKING INDIVIDUALS
PATHWAYS A POST PARTICIPATION TO
INCLUDE THE NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS AND HOW MANY HAVE
ACHIEVED COMPETITIVE EMPLOYMENT.
AND TO ATTEND HOW MANY HAVE
ATTENDED COLLEGE. AND LASTLY A
QUESTION ABOUT- IF THE PLAN FROM
RATE SAID CREATING A INVEST FOR
CREATE CREATING COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT
EMPLOYMENT- THE PROVIDER RATE
INCREASES WILL ASSIST US SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN THE CAPACITY TO
CREATE JOBS FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE SERVE. IT'S A NEED FOR
MEANS FOR IDENTIFYING AND
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS IN
SECURING EMPLOYMENT- THE WORK
WE'RE CURRENTLY ENGAGED IN WITH
THE EMPLOYMENT GRANTS THAT'S THE
TEN MILLION DOLLARS- FORD
CREATING PATHWAYS TO EMPLOYMENT-
WHICH IS A COLLABORATIVE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION- AND THEN. ON TOP
OF THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS- NEW
INITIATIVES THIS YEAR FOR
EXAMPLE THAT THE INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS THAT GO TO SERVICE
PROVIDERS FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE SUCCESSFUL IN COMPETITIVE
EMPLOYMENT FOR THIRTY DAYS. AND
SIX MONTHS AND THEN TWELVE
MONTHS THOSE INCENTIVE PAYMENTS
HAVE BEEN TEMPORARILY INCREASED-
THEY'VE BEEN DOUBLED TO A. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED AND
THREE THOUSAND. AND IN ADDITION-
ARE. INTERNSHIP PROGRAM WHERE
INDIVIDUALS- EARNS WAGES THROUGH
REGIONAL CENTER PURCHASE OF
SERVICE- WE ALSO HAVE INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS FOR THOSE PROVIDERS TO
DEVELOP THOSE PAID INTERNSHIPS-
WHERE THEY CAN RECEIVE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS AFTER
THIRTY DAYS AND A THOUSAND
DOLLARS AFTER SIXTY DAYS. SO THE
DEPARTMENT IS VERY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING OUR WORK TO INCREASE
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
WE SERVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR CHRISTOPHER
O'NEILL'S PERMANENT FINANCE A NO
FURTHER INFORMATION TO SHARE ON
THIS PRESENTATION. NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM SENATE PADDOCK WITH
THE L. A. THANK YOU- DOCTOR IN
SENATE WITH THE L. A. O. I'M.
UNDERSCORED THIS PROPOSAL DOES A
LOT OF MERIT IN THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS CURRENTLY SERVED IN
WORK ACTIVITY PROGRAMS WE ONLY
GOOD ALTERNATIVES I AND REALLY
ARE AT RISK OF LOSING EMPLOYMENT
ALTOGETHER IF GOOD ALTERNATIVES
AREN'T SET UP- YOU KNOW WE WILL
POINT OUT THAT IN TERMS OF
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT- RECENT DATA SHOW
THAT ONLY ABOUT THIRTEEN POINT
FIVE PERCENT. OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES-
HAVE COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT OR OR MAKE WAGES- AT
MY ACTUALLY NOT SURE IF THAT
FIGURE INCLUDES- SUB MINIMUM
WAGE OR NOT- SO IT'S YOU KNOW
THIS IS A CHALLENGING AREA FOR
THE DEPARTMENT- AND FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND WE RECOGNIZE
THAT GOOD ALTERNATIVES RE
NEEDED. I'M ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
WE HAD WAS HOW WELL ALIGNED THIS
PROPOSAL WAS WITH- THE EFFORTS
OF THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AS IT
DEVELOPS ITS PLAN- ACCORDING TO
SB SIX THIRTY NINE IT SOUNDS
LIKE FROM WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
JUST SAID- THAT- THE STATE
COUNCIL IS INVOLVED IN THE DDS-
PROPOSAL TO DEVELOP A PILOT SO
THAT'S GOOD WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THOSE EFFORTS ARE COMPLEMENTARY
AND NOT DUPLICATIVE. WE'D ALSO
POINT OUT THAT BOTH- THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
ALSO PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE
SORT OF JOB TRAINING IN AND- JOB
PREPARATION SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES TO ENTER
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED JOB
PLACEMENTS- SO WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT DDS ISN'T SORT OF
DUPLICATING- THE SERVICES THAT
MIGHT BE PROVIDED TO THESE SAME
INDIVIDUALS- THROUGH. THROUGH
SERVICES PROVIDED BY THESE OTHER
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT TO HEAR FROM ERIC
ZIGMAN THINKS TO FOR THE GOLDEN
GATE REGIONAL. THANK YOU FOR
GOOD AFTER HUGS EXECUTIVE GOLDEN
GATE REGIONAL CENTER MANY THANKS
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY
. SO THIRTY THREE YEARS AGO I
BEGAN MY SERVICE TO PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES BY
ANSWERING AN AD IN A LOCAL PAPER
ADVERTISING A POSITION FOR A
DIRECT SERVICE STAFF. IN A
SHELTERED WORKSHOP. I DID NOT
KNOW WHAT A SHELTERED WORKSHOP
WAS AND I BELIEVE I DIDN'T HAD
NEVER HEARD THE TERM
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. BUT
I FOUND A HOME THERE AND IT
LAUNCHED ME ON THIS CAREER BUT
HAS CREATED SO MUCH MEANING AND
PURPOSE IN MY LIFE. SO I STARTED
WORKING AS A STAFF MEMBER IN THE
WORKSHOP SERVING A HUNDRED AND
TEN INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. AND
EACH OF THEM TAUGHT ME SO VRY
MUCH. THE AGENCY I WORK FOR WAS
ALSO VERY EARLY ADOPTER OF
SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT SERVICES.
SO WE SUPPORT ABOUT TWENTY
INDIVIDUALS AT THE TIME AND WHAT
IS NOW CALLED. COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT IN REGULAR
JOBS IN THE COMMUNITY. OVER THE
NEXT FIFTEEN YEARS A LOT
HAPPENED. OUR AGENCY EVENTUALLY
SUPPORTED THE TRANSITION OF OVER
A HUNDRED OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
FROM THE WORKSHOP INTO COMMUNITY
EMPLOYMENT. AND WE ENDED UP
CLOSING THE WORKSHOP. MUCH OF
THE EXPERIENCE INFORMS MY
TESTIMONY TODAY. IN TERMS OF
SUCCESSFUL WORKSHOP THE
COMMUNITY EMPLOYMENT TRANSITION
HERE IS A FEW THINGS THAT WE
LEARNED. WHAT WE LEARNED WAS
THAT SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT WORKS
VERY WELL AS LONG AS YOU CAN
FIND A WAY TO FUND IT AT THAT
TIME I LOST A LOT OF MONEY IN
THOSE HERE'S- WHAT WE LEARNED IS
THAT YOU HAVE TO INVEST IN JOB
DEVELOPMENT EXPERTISE BUT A
STARKLY AGAIN THAT. HAS NOT BEEN
A STRONG ENOUGH FUNDING SOURCE-
AS MUCH AS INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES AND SCHOOLS AND OTHERS
CAN HELP DEVELOP JOBS BUT
ACTUALLY MOVES THE NEEDLE MOVES
THE NEEDLE AND MAKES A
DIFFERENCE. IS PAID JOB
DEVELOPERS WHO CAN BOTH
UNDERSTAND THE PEOPLE WE SERVE.
AND ALSO SPEAK TO THE BUSINESS
INTERESTS OF EMPLOYERS. WHAT WE
LEARNED IS THAT JOB COACHES HAVE
TO BE WELL TRAINED THEY HAVE TO
BE PERSON CENTERED AND ABLE TO
WORK VERY INDEPENDENTLY. AND
WHAT WE LEARNED IS THAT PERSON
CENTERED- PROCESS OF DISCOVERY.
OF REALLY UNDERSTANDING EACH
INDIVIDUAL'S SKILLS CHALLENGES
AND CAREER ASPIRATIONS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. THIS WHOLE
TRANSITION PROCESS HAS TO BE
PERSON BY PERSON- WHICH MATCHES
WELL WITH A LOT OF OUR PERSON
CENTRED FCUS OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. I KNOW THAT WE
WANT THIS TRANSFORMATION FROM
SEGREGATED EMPLOYMENT A
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT TO HAPPEN IN A COUPLE
OF YEARS BUT WHAT WE LEARNED IN
MY EXPERIENCE IS THAT IT TAKES
MUCH LONGER. FIVE YEARS WOLD BE
AMBITIOUS IN TERMS OF A STATE
WIDE TRANSITION SEVEN YEARS WAS
MORE REALISTIC I BELIEVE. STATES
LIKE OREGON AND MASSACHUSETTS
MASSACHUSETTS HOW. MAY HAVE MUCH
TO TEACH US ABOUT THE SYSTEMIC
TRANSITION AND HOW MUCH TIME IT
TAKES. IN TERMS OF THE BUDGET-
PROPOSALS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WHICH WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT HERE ARE MY
RECOMMENDATIONS FIRST- CHECK THE
NUMBERS THE PROPOSAL TARGETS
FOUR THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS IN
WORKSHOPS AND THOSE LEAVING
SCHOOLS. BUT THE PILOT SHOULD
COVER THOSE IN- OTHER PROGRAMS
AS WELL IF THEY ARE EARNING SUB
MINIMUM WAGE. SECOND WE NEED TO
DEMONSTRATE WHAT LEVEL OF JOB
DEVELOPER FUNDING IS NEEDED TO
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE
MOVEMENT OF INDIVIDUALS AND A
COMMUNITY EMPLOYMENT. THIRD MAKE
SURE THAT THE PILOTS PROVIDE THE
FUNDING AND TRAINING NEEDED FOR
REALLY EFFECTIVE JOB COACHING.
THAT COACHING FADES OVER TIME SO
IT'S A GREAT INVESTMENT OF STATE
RESOURCES. AND FOURTH I SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL TO ADD STAFF A DDS
FOR THE PURPOSE OF DEVELOPING
AND MONITORING THE PILOT BUT WE
SHOULD BE REALISTIC. IN TERMS OF
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WE SHOULD FIND
RESOURCES WITHIN THE STATE AND
WITHIN THE NATION. THAT ARE- ARE
ENTITIES THAT HAVE A TRACK
RECORD IN DEVELOPING THESE KIND
OF CAREER PATH PROGRAMS AND HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN TRANSITION
FROM SHELTER TO COMMUNITY
EMPLOYMENT. ONE OF THE FIRST AND
MOST POWERFUL THINGS THAT THOSE
HUNDRED AND TEN INDIVIDUALS
TAUGHT ME IN THE WORKSHOP LONG
AGO WAS THIS. TO SAY YOU HAVE A
JOB. AND TO SEE A PAYCHECK COME
WITH YOUR NAME ON IT IS A VERY
BIG DEAL IN OUR SOCIETY. THEY
TAUGHT ME A NEW WAY TO SEE THE
IMPACT OF THE DIGNITY OF WORK
BOTH IN THEIR WORKSHOP
EMPLOYMENT AND LATER. EVEN MORE
POWERFULLY WHEN THEY GOT INTO
JOBS ON THE OUTSIDE THEY USED TO
CALL IT JOBS ON THE OUTSIDE IN
THE COMMUNITY. WITH COMPANIES
LIKE SAFEWAY ALLSTATE INSURANCE
UC SANTA CRUZ AND MANY OTHER
EMPLOYERS. AS WE CHAMPION THIS
FINAL TRANSITION TO COMMUNITY
EMPLOYMENT LET'S TRY TO LISTEN
MORE EFFECTIVELY AND MORE DEEPLY
TO THOSE WE SERVE. AND IF MORE
PEOPLE THAT. EXPERIENCE OF THE
DIGNITY OF WORK. ALL HAPPY TO
TAKE. AND HOPES. A MORE ROBUST-
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
ERIN CARRUTHERS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE STATE COUNCIL
OF DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THANK YOU DR RAMBLING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AMERICA CARRUTHERS
EXECUTRIX TOOK THE STATE COUNCIL
ON DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES-
PAST THE GOVERNOR SIGNED LAST
YEAR'S IN A GARAGE WAS SB SIX
THREE NINE- THANK YOU YOU SENT
OUT A PROPER ENDING WHAT REALLY
ISN'T EXPLOITATIVE PROCESS START
OFF WITH SOMETHING THAT WAS SEEN
AS BEST PRACTICE- IT GIVEN
PROGRESSIVE PRACTICE BUT AS
WE'VE INVOLVED AND- GROWN AND
WHAT WE KNOW IS THE BEST WAY TO.
PEOPLE TO SUCCEED I HOPE WE CAN
REALIZE IT WAS TIME FOR THIS
PROGRAM OF PAYING PEOPLE LESS
THAN MINIMUM WAGE FOR THEIR
WORK- DIGNITY IN THEIR EFFORT TO
END THANK YOU FOR PASSING THAT
BILL THE BILL ALSO REQUIRED THE
STATE COUNCIL'S MEMBERS. OTHERS
SPEAKERS OF TALK ABOUT TO
CONVENE STAKEHOLDERS TO CREATE
AN IMPLEMENTATION PLAN- LOOKING
AT BEST PRACTICES A POLICY HOW
TURNED ITS- OUT OPTIONS MAKING
SURE THAT EACH INDIVIDUAL IS
ABLE TO TRANSITION- INTO THEIR
NEXT BEST PRACTICE WHAT THEY
WANT. THAT REPORT IS DUE TO YOU. JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY. WE'RE
BEGINNING NEXT PROCESS NOW. THIS
DDS REQUEST FOR IT AS REALLY
WELL FROM. IT WOULD COME AN OP-
AS PEOPLE LEAVE. THE SHELTER
WORKS- TRANSITIONING KEEP OUT
IT'S GOING TO BE ALL HIGH ON
CROSS. ONE THAT THIS COUNCIL TO
EXPERIENCE. AND APPLAUD THE
MINISTER CONQUER COMMITTEE TO.
BUILDING AN ALTAR. SB SIX THOUGH
I'D SAY THAT'S A CLEAR NAY. OF
WHAT THE PROPOSED IS AND IT CAN
. THE WORK BEING. UNDER SIX SB
SIX THREE AND BE DEVELOPED TO
INCLUDE IT. I'D ALSO SUGGEST
CLARIFYING THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS- IF THIS PROPOSAL IS
ADOPTED THERE WOULD BE TO
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS SEASON
LIKELY WITH MANY OF THE SAME
ACTUAL INDIVIDUALS BOTH WORKING
TO PHASE OUT SEVEN WAGE IN
DIFFERENT WAYS. TO BREAK IT OUT
THE STATE COUNCIL SIX THIRTY
NINE PROCESSES BROUGHT. IT LOOKS
GOOD MANY ASPECTS- AND MANY
PROGRAMS AND MANY OPTIONS THAT'S
A CASE OF SOMETHING WHICH FIFTY
S. PROCESS DEVELOPS- ONE
IMPORTANT AND. ONE VERY NEEDED
OPTION. THIS COUNCIL SIX THIRTY
NINE STATE PROCESS READS IN
EMPLOYMENT PLAN IT EDS PROCESS
RESULTS IN DEVELOPING A NEW
PROGRAM- SOMEBODY'S ASKED ME
HEARING DO YOU THINK THIS THE-
PROPOSAL SORT OF PUTS THE CART
BEFORE THE HORSE. I DON'T- ONE
PROCESS. DOESN'T NEED TO WAIT
FOR THE OTHER BOTH CAN HAPPEN
CONCURRENTLY. BUT WITH GOOD
CONNECTIONS SO I'D RECOMMEND
THAT THE STATE COUNCIL BE
IDENTIFIED AS CO LEAD IN THE
THIRTY S. PROCESS UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL I'M AS A WAY TO ENSURE
MAXIMUM COORDINATION. AND OF
COURSE WE WOULD ENSURE THAT THE
PROCESS INCLUDES PEOPLE WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE- THAT HAVE BEEN
PAID. SUB MINIMUM WAGE FOR THEIR
WORK. LASTLY THE STATE COUNCIL
RECOMMENDS THAT WHAT'S DEVELOPED
UNDER THIS PROGRAM- BE BUILT ON
EVIDENCE BASED BEST PRACTICES.
FROM OTHER STATES TRANSACTION
PEOPLE OUT OF SUB MINIMUM WAGE I
WE CAN LEARN A LOT FROM OTHERS
WHO LED THE WAY. SO IN CLOSING
THE STATE COUNCIL WAS COMMITTED.
I TO THE SHARED POLICY CALLED
THE LEGISLATURE THE- TO PHASE
OUT SEVEN WAGE FOR MEMBERS. FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND PEOPLE
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES SMOOTHLY. AND WITH
ESTABLISH CONTACTS WITH PEOPLE.
SIR THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY I
WILL NOW BRING UP TO THE TO SEE
IF ANY. HAVE QUESTION WE WILL
BEGIN THE SAME MATHIS. THANK YOU
. MISTER AND I THINK IT'S GREAT
THAT WE'RE TARGETING. FOUR
THOUSAND- NEAR STUDENTS WITH ID
THEY THAT AS THEY'RE GETTING OUT
LOOKING AT THAT AS A TARGET BUT
REALLY MY QUESTION IS WHAT YOU
KNOW WHAT IS THE PERCENTAGE OF
OUR IT D. POPULATION THAT. WAS
WORKING. ON THAT THIS IS
AFFECTING TO HAVE A NUMBER ON
THAT BECAUSE OUT WHAT WHAT I'M
HEARING BACK IS THAT IT'S ABOUT
FOURTEEN PERCENT. ON SO WHAT IS
THAT NUMBER DO WE HAVE THAT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT- AND WHAT IS THAT
LOOK LIKE AND I'LL START THERE.
THE CORRECT APARTMENT YES THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS- WHEN
WE HAVE THE NUMBER AND I DON'T
APOLOGIZE I DON'T HAVE- ALL THAT
THAT THE DATA IN FRONT OF ME BUT
WE CAN- PROVIDE IT- HE ESTIMATE
WAS BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ACTIVE IN WORKING TIVITY
PROGRAMS- AND THEN ALSO AN
ASSUMPTION OF SOME INDIVIDUALS
WHO WOULD BE LEAVING- HIGH
SCHOOL AND OPTING FOR THIS AS AN
OPTION. AS COMPARED TO OTHER
SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE- SO
WITH THE PILOT IT REALLY HAS
BEEN FOCUSED ON A SPECIFIED-
GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE-
PARTICIPATING IN WORK ACTIVITY
PROGRAMS. SO IT IS A SMALL
PERCENTAGE- WE HAVE SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT RIGHT AND WORK
ACTIVITY PROGRAM PARTICIPATION
OVER THE YEARS- SO THAT NUMBER.
WHERE'S MAYBE THREE FOUR FIVE
YEARS AGO WOULD HAVE BEEN
DOUBLED- IT HAS DEFINITELY.
DECREASED OVER TIME. SO THERE'S
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT WILL
BE HELPFUL WERE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
IT. OKAY BECAUSE THE THOSE ARE
NUMBERS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT AND ALSO YOU KNOW WITH
THE DECREASE WE ALL KNOW THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS THERE'S BEEN A
HUGE DECREASE IN EMPLOYMENT
PERIOD DUE TO THE- EPIDEMIC- BUT
WE'RE DEFINITELY GONNA NEED THAT
BREAK DOWN WITHIN THE
POPULATION. NO BECAUSE WE WILL
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT. THE
FEDERAL OUR STANDARDS ARE FOR
SUB PAY VERSUS WHAT WE JUST
PASSED RECENTLY. IN THE OVERLAPS
THERE IT'S VERY CONCERNING- TO
HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
WORKING WHO HAD THE DIGNITY OF
BEING ABLE TO MAKE A PAYCHECK.
IN NOW- ARE NO LONGER ABLE TO DO
THAT. SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT LETTING ANYBODY SLIDE
IN ANY GAPS IN IN CREATING- THE
A PLACE WHERE SOMEBODY DID HAVE
THE ABILITY TO WORK. IN NOW DUE
TO SOMETHING WE CHANGES
LEGISLATURE ERRORS. ARE FALLING
THROUGH THE CRACKS AND LOOSE
THAT THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO. THANK YOU I'M WHEN THIS
BILL CAME US- ON THE FLOOR LST
YEAR ONE OF MY CONCERNS THAT WE
ARE EXPERT OR AT LEAST I EXPRESS
WAS THEM THE ABILITY FOR SOME OF
THESE ORGANIZATIONS TO MAINTAIN
THE LEVEL OF EMPLOYMENT AND TO
MISTER MATHIS IS- QUESTION DO WE
HAVE AN IDEA OF HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE EMPLOYED CURRENTLY- OR WHAT
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS FOR
THAT POPULATION SO THAT'S ONE
AND NUMBER TWO- MY FEAR WAS AND
I DON'T KNOW THIS AND THIS IS A
QUESTION. MY FEAR WAS THAT A LOT
OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS WERE
GOING TO PAY THE MINIMUM WAGE
BUT THEN THE HOURS AGO THEY ARE
GOING TO BE CUT WHICH EALLY
DOESN'T MAKE A DIFFERENCE- IN
TERMS OF MORE INCOME FOR THAT
INDIVIDUAL- TWO COULD WE HAVE
DATA ON THAT AS WELL AS THE HOW
MANY PEOPLE HAVE TRANSITIONED.
INTO MORE PAY BUT LESS WORK. OR
HOURS OF WORK. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO- I HATE IT
IS. VERY CONCERNING AS- YOUR
HEARING AND OTHERS HAVESHARED
ABOUT THE DECREASE AND
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT WITH PAID JOBS. I'M
IT HAS DEFINITELY DECREASED- AS
A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC IN
ADDITION TO THE- COMPETITIVE
WAGES WE ALSO SAW A SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE AND PART OF THIS IS
THAT A TOTAL WEEK WE STILL HAVE
TO KIND OF DRILL INTO SOME OF
THE DATA. IS THAT WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT OUR DATA FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE- INCOME
PAID- PAID JOBS. THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS HAS GONE DOWN. BUT
THE AVERAGE WAGE HAS GONE UP.
AND WHILE WITHOUT KIND OF
DRILLING INTO IT SOME OF THAT
ASSUMPTION IS THAT. THOSE THAT
WERE WITHIN EVEN SUB MINIMUM
WAGE OVER THE PANDEMIC LIKE
LIKELY HAD LOST SOME OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. SO WE DO WALDRON
INCIDENTS THAT WERE WORKING ON
AT DDS THAT I'VE I'M CERTAINLY
NOT GOING TO SPEAK FOR- MR
CROWTHER SON ON THE STATE
COUNCIL BUT- THE INITIAL DOES
THAT. REALLY DO A LIFE TOGETHER
ARE IMPORTANT YOU KNOW AS WE'RE
DEVELOPING RESOURCES FOR AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT CAN BE
ALTERNATIVES AND STILL USE IN
OUR FIFTEEN MILLION TO SUPPORT
PROVIDERS TO TRANSITION. LOOKING
AT OUR EMPLOYMENT INITIATIVES
THAT WERE INTRODUCED LAST YEAR
AND IS SUPPORTING STATE COUNCIL
ON THEIR EFFORT. TO REALLY DRILL
INTO MORE OF THE- THE ISSUES AND
HOW WE CAN ADDRESS THE CONCERNS.
AND LIKE I SAID A LOT OF
INDIVIDUALS IN WORK ACTIVITY
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN PARTICIPATING
FOR SO MANY YEARS- AND WE DO
NEED TO BE CAREFUL AND
THOUGHTFUL. AS WE APPROACH THIS
. THANK YOU- I A COUPLE OF-
AGENCIES IN IN MY DAY AND I WENT
TO VISIT SEVERAL OF THEM ABILITY TO- FOR
SOME OF THOSE FOLKS TO BE ABLE
TO JUST GO TO A JOB THEY WERE SO
PROUD AND SO EXCITED TO HAVE
THIS JOB UNTIL MY CONCERN AGAIN.
ADDRESSED ON TO THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL WAS THAT YOU KNOW IF
WE'RE GOING TO TRANSITION AND
YES WE'RE GOING TO SUPPORT THESE
ORGANIZATIONS WITHOUT MONEY NOW
BUT THEN WHAT HAPPENS
AFTERWARDS. IN ARE WE GOING TO
YOU KNOW PRETEND THAT IT DOESN'T
EXIST AND YOU KNOW A LOT OF
THOSE FOLKS. YES THEY NEED
OBVIOUSLY THEY WANTED TO WORK
BUT THE PRIDE THAT I SAW IN
THEIR FACES JUST THE FACT THAT
THEY WERE AT WORK EVERY DAY THAT
HELPS WITH SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL-
WELL BEING BECAUSE NOW THEY HAVE
AN A PURPOSE RIGHT. TO WEAR
WHERE THEY'RE GETTING UP EVERY
MORNING TO GO SO I'M REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT YOU KNOW ANY.
NEGATIVE EFFECTS TO THIS GOAL I
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THAT YOU
KEEP US APPRAISED AND REALLY
FOLLOW THOSE NUMBERS AND GIVE US
THE DATA YOU KNOW AS QUICKLY AS
YOU HAVE THEM AND AS ACCURATELY
AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE- IF WE NEED
TO CHANGE SOMETHING I THINK. YOU
KNOW THE SOONER THE BETTER AGAIN
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH WE'RE NOT BUILDING
CARS WERE WORD THESE ARE ACTUAL
LIVES THAT WERE AFFECTING AND IF
WE NEED TO CHANGE SOMETHING
IMMEDIATELY THEN. THAT NEEDS TO
BE TOLD TO US SO THAT WE CAN DO
YOU KNOW REMEDY THE SITUATION
AND IF IT'S WORKING THAT WOULD
BE GEAT AS WELL IF IT'S WORKING
THEN THAT WOULD BE AMAZING. SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE ON THE PATH
BUT EITHER WAY WE I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT YOU
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO
OUTSIDE YOU HATE TO SEE MY
PEOPLE IT'S THE ROLE IN. A GROUP
IN MY AREA THEY WERE JUST SO
PROUD AND SO AMAZING YOU KNOW TO
GO AND VISIT AND THEN THEY
WANTED TO SHOW ME EVERYTHING
AND- I DON'T WANT TO LOSE THAT.
AND REALLY OVER SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN FIX AB IF WE KNOW WHAT
IS- WHAT WE'RE FIXING RIGHT AND
SO PLEASE KEEP US IN THE LOOP
MAKE SURE THAT THE DATA IS
ACCURATE AND KEEP US- I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE BUT- EXPECTATIONS
YOU. AS FAR AS DAY. IS IF YOU
CAN GET IT AS A AS- OFTEN AS- I
THINK THAT WOULD HELP US SO THAT
WE CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT- AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU.
WILL HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS AYE
AYE MEMBER MENTIONED FOR THE
MEMBERS ON THE BOARD PAGE
SIXTEEN OF THE AGENDA FROM THE
L. A. I'LL- SHOW SOME OF. THE
FIGURES FOR EMPLOYMENT FOR THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS. BUT AGREED
THE NEED FOR DATA IS IMPORTANT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENEFITS THAT
THE DATA IS NOT QUITE EXACT-
BACK TO YOU KNOW YOU'RE WE'RE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION I
REMEMBER A FEW YEARS AGO EVEN
GOING WITH THE DIRECT WE WENT ON
A GREAT TORE DOWN THE COSTA
MESA. WITH THROUGH A LOT OF
THESE PROGRAM SAW A LOT OF
REALLY GOOD THINGS ARE
HAPPENING- BEFORE THE RECENT
LEGISLATION. AND YOU KNOW I I'VE
GOT TO ASK YOU KNOW WE CANNOT
IMPROVE THESE NUMBERS. WHAT IS
THE FALLBACK PLAN. WHAT ARE WE
DOING TO ENSURE THAT THIS
POPULATION IS VERY VERY FRAGILE
POPULATION AGAIN IS NOT GOING TO
FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS. BECAUSE
SOMETIMES LEGISLATION IS NOT THE
BEST. SOMETIMES YOU KNOW WE MOVE
FORWARD AND THEN WE GOT TO TAKE
TWO STEPS BACK SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE IT IS WE'RE GOING THROUGH
THIS- ALL THINGS ARE BEING
CONSIDERED BECAUSE WE CAN'T RUSH
INTO THIS AND EXPECT THE
ECONOMIC SECTOR YOU KNOW THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO SOCIAL COVERS
POSSIBILITIES YES BOY THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC THROUGH EVERYTHING
ELSE WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS POPULATION ISN'T BEING. IT
IS IN A LOSE OUT. BECAUSE OF
GOOD INTENTIONS. I'D LIKE TO ADD
ON TO THE QUESTION IF I MAY BOTH
FOR- THE DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS
FOR THE STATE COUNCIL. I BELIEVE
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT FOR US THAT
FAIL SAFE PLANS TO ENSURE THAT.
THOSE WHO CURRENTLY ARE EMPLOYED
THROUGH THE WORK ACTIVITY
PROGRAMS OR OTHER SETTINGS. YOU
WILL NOT LOSE EMPLOYMENT
ALTOGETHER THROUGH THE PENDING
CHANGE I SHARE THE CONCERN THAT
THE L. A. O. HAS AND WOULD LIKE
TO HEAR WHAT THE PLANNING IS
AROUND THIS AND WHAT CAN BE DONE
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE POSITIVE
OUTCOMES. FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO MIGHT BE ADVERSELY IMPACTED. YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS- WE
WERE HAPPY TO WORK ON AND-
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION BUT ALSO
AT THE SAME TIME MAKING SURE
THAT- OUR STAKE HOLDERS ARE-
PROVIDING THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS.
AS WELL AS FAR AS WHAT ARE THE
OTHER ALTERNATIVES THAT A PLAN
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO HELP
SUPPORT STATE COUNCIL WITH. IS
LIKELY GOING TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY WHAT ARE THOSE BARRIERS
TO ADDRESS EMPLOYMENT YOU KNOW
THE WORK THAT- MISTER WHEN
FILLED IS DOING WITH HIS
WORKGROUP UNEMPLOYMENT IS ALSO
REALLY. ADDRESSING THIS THIS IS
A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE IT'S A
PRIORITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT- TO
LOOK AT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EMPLOYMENT- AND I SHARE CONCERNS
ABOUT WHENEVER WE ARE
TRANSITIONING OUT OF. A SERVICE
A DELIVERY THAT IS CHANGING WE
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL- THIS IS NOT
I'M I'M NOT GONNA SAY IT'S GOING
TO BE EASY AT ALL BUT WE ARE
HIGHLY SENSITIVE WE CLOSE
DEVELOPMENTAL SECTORS THAT WAS A
VERY SENSITIVE- TRANSITION FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE HAD TO BE
VERY. MINDFUL AND LISTEN TO
THOSE SELF ADVOCATES AND- REALLY
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT IS THAT
SAFETY NET TO MAKE SURE THAT-
WE'RE NOT. YOU KNOW. PUTTING
PEOPLE ONLY AT RISK BUT MAYBE
NOT HAVING THE CHOICES IN OUR
LIFE SO APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS
ABOUT FORWARD TO HAVING FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS. I WAS HOPING TO
BRING IN ERRANT. WITH THE STATE
COUNCIL- FOR ANY COMMON YOU MAY
HAVE THIS QUESTION AS WELL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
ECHOING DEPARTMENTS COMMENTS
REGARDING CHOICE- I'D INVITE-
EXPANDING THE VIEW OF WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN BECAUSE PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN IN- ONE PROGRAM. AT A
SHELTERED WORKSHOP- WE CALL IT
JOB BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE GETTING
PAID IT BUT SOMETIMES IT'S TWO
DOLLARS AN HOUR- IS THAT REALLY
A JOB. WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN NEXT
IS AS- MR SIEGMAN POINTED OUT
THAT THERE IS IN THE PROCESS
WE'RE WORKING WITH. EACH PERSON
PERSON BY PERSON FIFTY NOT WHAT
IS IT MAY WANT TO HAPPEN NEXT
WHAT THEY WANT FOR THEIR LIVES.
AND THEN FINDING THE BEST MATCH
FOR. FOR WHAT THEY WANT SIR
COULD BE VOLUNTEER COULD BE
EDUCATION ACT COULD BE ANOTHER
JOB- IT COULD BE A VARIETY OF
THINGS. AND THAT'S PART OF OUR
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS IS TO
IDENTIFY ALL THOSE. PUSH THOSE
OUT IN MAKE SURE THEY'RE
STREAMLINED EFFICIENT SUPPORTED
WEIGHTS- TO CERTAIN PEOPLE. AND
TEN THEIR NEXT BEST DAY. I
BELIEVE WOULD HEARING FROM MOST
OF US ON THE DÍAS IS- IN AND-
WITH THE DIRECTION THAT BOTH A
C. D. D. THE DEPARTMENT RE
MOVING BUT SIMPLY THAT WE WANNA.
MEASURE TWICE AND CUT ONCE THAT
WE WANT TO GET THIS DONE RIGHT
WITHOUT ADVERSELY IMPACTING
PEOPLE AND WOOD- LOOK FORWARD.
TO HOPEFULLY LEARNING SOME
LESSONS FROM OTHER STATES WHO
HAVE MADE THIS TRANSITION AND
LOOK TOWARDS SOME OF THEIR TIME
LINES TO INFORM US ON- HOW
QUICKLY WE CAN MAKE AND-
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THESE
TRANSITIONS AND SO- WITH THAT WE
WILL. I THANK VERY MUCH ALL THE
PANELISTS FOR ISSUE THREE AND WE
WILL MOVE NOW ON TO ISSUE FOR.
WHICH IS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
COMMUNICATION ASSESSMENTS FOR
CONSUMERS WHO ARE TOUGH. WE WILL
HAVE FIVE PRESENTERS ON THIS
PANEL NANCY BARGE MAN THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. BRIAN
WINFIELD CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
CHRISTOPHER ARE NEIL WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SONYA
PADDOCK WITH THE L. A. L. AND
LISA KLEIN BOB EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE REGIONAL CENTER
AT THE EAST BAY. LET US BEGIN
WITH DIRECTOR PARCHMENT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- SOLD AS
BRIEFLY SHARE WITH YOU- THE
PROPOSAL- THAT WE HAVE WORDS
CORRECTLY OUTLINED ON PAGE
SEVENTEEN AND THE AGENDA TODAY-
THAT WE ARE REQUESTING- FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS THE FUNDING FOR
ASSESSMENTS THIS BUILDS UPON THE
INITIATIVES THAT WE HAVE PUT
FORWARD. ON- BUILDING HOW TO RE
GOING TO BE ADDRESSING SUPPORTS
THEN- SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE THAT AND OUR REGIONAL
CENTER CONSUMERS. REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE HIRING THEY'RE JUST
SERVICES SPECIALIST ON DDS ISN'T
THE LAST KIND OF PHASE SAID
HIRING ARTISTS SERVICES
SPECIALIST- AND SO BUILDING ON
ADDITIONAL INITIATIVES- WE ARE-
MAKE IT A REQUEST TO ADD TO-
WHAT WE ALREADY HAD FOR- AND
PRIOR INITIATIVES BUT FUNDING
FOR THESE ASSESSMENTS AND MR
WINFIELD GOING TO WALK YOU
THROUGH THE PROPOSAL THE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. THE PROPOSAL
ON DEAN AFTER THE FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS WILL BE USED TO
SECURE THE SERVICES OF
ASSESSORS. TO DEVELOP OR
IDENTIFY ASSESSMENT TOOLS CAN
PERFORM COMMUNICATIONS
ASSESSMENTS FOR INDIVIDUALS
SERVED BY REGIONAL CENTERS WHO
ARE DEAF. OF THE COMMUNICATION
ASSESSMENTS WILL INFORM BOX
LANDING TEAM TO DETERMINE THE
TYPES OF SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
TO BE INCLUDED IN THE
INDIVIDUAL. PROGRAM PLAN AND
OBTAINED THROUGH EITHER REGIONAL
CENTER FUNDING FOR A FEW OTHER
AGENCIES. OF THE FUNDING AMOUNT
REFLECTS THE APPROXIMATE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS. WHO WILL REQUIRE
AND SHE'S TO HAVE A
COMMUNICATION ASSESSMENT- AND
THAT'S MULTIPLE AND BY AN
AVERAGE OF ABOUT A THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER ASSESSMENT. AND THEN
THERE'S ALSO FUNDING FOR
SECURITY ASSESSORS AND
DEVELOPING OR ADAPTING THE
ASSESSMENT TOOLS. A DDS- IS
CREATING A STEERING COMMITTEE
AND THE STEERING COMMITTEE WILL
BE COMPRISED OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE DEAF. OF FAMILY MEMBERS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DEAF. AT
SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO SPECIALIZE
IN PROVIDING SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DEAF.
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL.
SERVICES AMONG OTHERS. OF THE-
PLAN AND TIMELINE AS OF OUR MAN
POINTED OUT OF CENTERS THE
DEPARTMENT ARE WELL UNDER WAY
WITH REGARDS TO- RECRUITING THAT
DEAF SERVICES SPECIALIST AND
WITH THAT WILL CREATE MORE OF A
COORDINATED STATEWIDE EFFORT-
WERE ALSO IN THE MIDDLE OF
VERIFYING CONSUMER DATA TO.
ENSURE THAT E HAVE GOOD- DATA
INTEGRITY WITH REGARDS TO THE
NUMBERS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO WHO
ARE DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING.
AND WE ALSO HAVE BEEN
RESEARCHING ASSESSORS AND
ASSESSMENT TOOLS AND OTHER WORK
TO ACCOMPLISH OUR ULTIMATE GOAL.
WE ANTICIPATE ASSESSMENTS WILL
BEGIN IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- AND REGIONAL CENTERS
ALSO ENGAGED IN DEVELOPING
NEEDED RESOURCES WHICH IS A
CRITICAL PIECE TO THAT MEETING
THE NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DEATH- AND THE WORK PROCESS IS
WILL EVOLVE AS WE CONTINUE TO
LEARN AND GAIN ADDITIONAL
EXPERIENCE IN THIS AREA. OTHER
QUESTION IS ASKED WHY THIS
FUNDING IS A ONE TIME AND NOW
WHAT WILL HAPPEN WITH
INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED
ASSESSMENTS. AFTER THE ONE TIME
FUNDING- SO THE ONE TIME FUNDING
WILL ASSIST US IN THE- THIS
INITIAL WORK OF OBTAINING
ASSESSMENTS FOR- EVERYONE WHO.
IS DEAF AND ONCE THE ASSESSMENT
THAT WILL BE PART OF THE
PLANNING TEAM PROCESS- BUT IN
THE OUT YEARS REGIONAL CENTERS
WILL USE THEIR PURCHASE A
SERVICE FUNDING TO UPDATE THOSE
INITIAL ASSESSMENTS. AND FOR
ASSESSMENT OF NEW INDIVIDUALS
WHO COME INTO THE REGIONAL
CENTER WHERE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO REGION AGENT NEEDED A
COMMUNICATION ASSESSMENT.
FOLLOWING THE- COMPLETION OF THE
ASSESSMENT ALREADY MENTIONED
THIS INFORMATION WILL THEN BE
USED BY EACH CONSUMERS PLANNING
TEAM- TO DETERMINE- THE TYPES
AND AMOUNTS OF SERVICES THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS. OF THE TYPES
OF SUPPORTS THAT THE PERSON
NEEDS TO ACCESS THOSE SERVICES-
THIS COULD RESULT IN
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES IT COULD BE
ALTERATIONS AND SERVICES OR THE
WAY IN WHICH AND TO RECEIVE
THOSE SERVICES. OR IT COULD ALSO
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL SERVICES
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL. THE QUESTION
WAS ASKED ABOUT COM. THE
ADMINISTRATION BEING MEAN BEING
AMENABLE TO CHANGES TO THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- THE
ADMINISTRATION IS OPEN TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSION ABOUT TRIPLE
LANGUAGE HOWEVER NO STATUTORY
AMENDMENTS WERE IDENTIFIED AS
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- CHRISTOPHER
O'NEILL DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
HAVE NO FURTHER INFORMATION TO
SHARE ON THIS ITEM. NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE
L. L. THANK YOU SONYA PEDIGREE-
FROM THE L. A- THIS PROPOSAL IS
ANOTHER ONE THAT MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE AND THE PROPOSAL AS IT WAS
WRITTEN LACKED A LOT OF DETAIL
BUT SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
WE HAD ABOUT IT- MISTER MISTER
WINFIELD- JUST WAS ABLE TO
ADDRESS SUCH AS- HOW THE FUNDING
AMOUNT WAS DETERMINED- WHAT THE
TIME LINE WOULD BE. HOW PEOPLE
IN THE FUTURE WOULD BE SERVED
GIVEN THAT THIS IS ONE TIME
FUNDING- WHETHER THE DEPARTMENT
IS CONSIDERING THE TYPES OF
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES THAT MIGHT
BE NEEDED GOING FORWARD TO
BETTER SERVE INDIVIDUALS SO I
WITH THAT I- I DON'T HAVE ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
LISA KLEINBERG EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE REGIONAL CENTER
OF THE EAST BAY. THANK YOU CHAIR
AROUND BLOODY COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
MY NAME IS LISA CLIMB UP AND ON
THE SECOND DIRECTOR I REGIONAL
CENTER OF THE EAST BAY WE
CURRENTLY SERVE OVER SIX HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS WHO IDENTIFY AS
STAFF ARE BORED OF HEARING. IT'S
A DIVERSE POPULATION INCLUDES
MANY WHO USE AMERICAN SIGN
LANGUAGE BUT ALSO OTHER METHODS
OF COMMUNICATION. MOST
COMMUNICATION STRATEGIES FOR
THIS GROUP OF ADULTS WERE
SAVAGED FOR THEM. DURING EITHER
THEIR YEARS IN EDUCATION AND
THEN THEY ARE READ OVER TO THEIR
ADULT LIVES OR REGIONAL CENTER
HAS HAD A LONG COMMITMENT HAVING
CASE MANAGERS WHO ARE FLUENT IN
ASL AS WELL AS WHO HAVE LIVED
EXPERIENCES IN THE DEAF
COMMUNITY. WE'RE ALSO GLAD TO
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PROMOTED STAFF
TO THE RECENTLY FUNDED DEBT
SPECIALIST POSITION WILL BE
INVALUABLE IN ASSURING THAT WE
CAN CONNECT PEOPLE TO RESOURCES
AS- WELL AS DEVELOPING THAT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT WILL
BE IDENTIFIED THROUGH THESE TYPE
OF ASSESSMENT. DISINVESTMENT
WILL PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
A COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT OF
EACH PERSON SOME OF WHO MAY
NEVER HAVE HAD SUCH AN
ASSESSMENT OR HAVEN'T HAD SUCH
AN ASSESSMENT AND- DEFINE WHAT
THE REGION IS RICH IN RESOURCES
AND HAS A LARGE DEAF COMMUNITY.
THERE IS A NETWORK OF
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE FAMILIAR
WITH AN EXPERT AT SERVING I'M
DEFINITELY VIGILS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. OF MOST IMPORTANT
WILL BE OF MOST IMPORTANCE WILL
BE IDENTIFYING HE ESSENTIAL
COMPONENTS OF AN ASSESSMENT
INCLUDING THE ASSESSMENT TOOLS
AND THE QUALIFICATIONS AND
EXPERTISE. THAT ARE REQUIRED TO
ASSESS INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DEAF
PLUS INDIVIDUALS MAY ALSO HAVE
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES INCLUDING
PHYSICAL DISABILITIES VISUAL
IMPAIRMENTS AND OTHER CO
OCCURRING. UNCONCERNED WE. ALSO
HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY NOT
YOU. AS BUT RATHER ANOTHER SONG
LINK OR CAN YOU. STRATEGY WHAT
FUNDING. THE TO IS. FOR ALL
THESE INDIVIDUALS BEING SERVED
AND TO DEVELOP THE RESOURCES FOR
SUCH ASSESSMENT IN THE OUT YEARS
WE WILL CONTINUE TO COMPLETE
ASSESSMENT. AS NEW PEOPLE
ENTERED SERVICES AS WELL AS WHEN
CHANGES AND NEEDS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES NECESSITATED THAT
CONDUCTING THESE ASSESSMENTS IN
A ONE TIME WAY WILL HAVE THE
ADVANTAGE OF A LARGE SCALE
IDENTIFICATION OF WHERE THERE
ARE SYSTEM GAPS IN SERVICE
AVAILABILITY. FOR THIS COMMUNITY
IN OUR AREA WHILE WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF PROVIDERS WHO SERVE
THIS COMMUNITY WE MUST EXPECTED
THIS INVESTMENT WILL IDENTIFY
ADDITIONAL NEEDS FOR SERVICES
THAT WE MAY NOT CURRENTLY KNOW
ABOUT. OUR. HAVE CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE. SOME AREAS THE MAY
NEED TO BE DEVELOPED INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL TRAINING FOR SUPPORT
STAFF- THAT WILL NEED TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE THROUGHOUT
THE DAY. THERE MAY ALSO BE A
NEED TO IDENTIFY WHAT IS
IMPORTANT TO INDIVIDUALS IN
TERMS OF THEIR INCLUSION IN THE
DEAF COMMUNITY AS WELL AS IN
OTHER ARENAS INCLUDING
EMPLOYMENT. ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
STAFF WHO ARE FLUENT IN ASL AND
OTHER COMMUNICATION METHODS MAY
NEED TO BE RECRUITED THE DEFAULT
OF A STIPEND FOR BILINGUAL STAFF
WHICH IS- OCCURRING AS PART OF
THE RATE IMPLEMENTATION. AND
SOME OTHER INITIATIVES WILL BE
HELPFUL TO THIS EFFORT I EXPECT
THAT WE WILL ALSO NEED TO
CONNECT WITH AND HAVE EXPERTISE
IN TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN BE USED
TO SUPPORT INCLUSION. AND
INDEPENDENCE THE PLANNING FOR
AND FUNDING OF COMMUNICATION
ASSESSMENT IS A GREAT BEGINNING
THERE WILL ALSO NEED TO BE AN
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO SUPPORTING
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE RIGHT
SERVICES. ARE IDENTIFIED THROUGH
THIS PROCESS- THANK YOU FOR ON
LISTENING AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WILL BRING IT UP TO THE
DENTIST TO SEE IF ANY MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS. SOON NONDA I
WILL KEEP IT WITH THE CHAIR AND
MAKE A COMMENT- I REALLY
APPRECIATED- EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
KLEINBURG TALKING ABOUT THE
SYSTEMS GAPS FOR THE COMMUNITY
THAT CAN BE IDENTIFIED THROUGH
THIS ASSESSMENT AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO RECEIVING THAT
INFORMATION. AND MAKE
APPROPRIATE BUDGET DECISIONS IN
THE FUTURE. BUT AS I DID UNDER
ISSUE ONE I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE TO DRAW A PARALLEL HERE
WITH OUR BLIND COMMUNITY AND THE
NEED FOR US TO DO. SIMILAR
ASSESSMENTS TO IDENTIFY ANY
SYSTEMS GAPS THAT MAY EXIST
WITHIN THAT COMMUNITY. AS I
BELIEVE WE SHOULD. HAVE PARITY
AND TO BELIEVE BUT IN FOR US TO
COMPLETE THESE US- SOON AS WE
CAN AND SO I- THANKS VERY MUCH
ALL THE PANELISTS ON THIS AND-
LOOK FORWARD TO. A CONTINUED
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE FIVE WHERE
WE WILL HAVE TEN PRESENTERS THIS
IS ON THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
WORK FORCE AND RATE STUDY
IMPLEMENTATION. INCLUDING
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVES WE WILL
BEGIN WITH BRIAN WINFIELD CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. SERVING CAR
WHO'S THE CHIEF DATA ANALYTICS
AND STRATEGY FOR DDS JIM KNIGHT
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR DDS.
CHRISTOPHER I'D KNEEL WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SONYA
PADDOCK WITH THE L. A. O. JORDAN
LINDSAY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE ARC AND YOU SEE P.
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION. JUDY
MARC PRESIDENT FOR DISABILITY
VOICES UNITED. BBM HAN SENIOR
ATTORNEY WITH ID DE PRACTICE
DISABILITIES RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
MARK MELANSON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LIVING
THAT WORK MARC CLAUS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. FOR THE SAN DIEGO
REGIONAL CENTER. IF WE BEGIN I'D
LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO EXPRESS
MY INTEREST AS TO WHETHER
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE RATE STUDY
CAN. OR SHOULD BE ACCELERATED.
THE BURN RATE STUDY WHICH WAS
COMPLETED IN TWENTY WAS
COMPLETED IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
SINCE THEN THE KOPET NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO OUR LIVES INCLUDED
INCREASING INCREASES TO OUR COST
OF LIVING. TO THIS END I WILL BE
REQUESTING AN ADDENDUM TO THE
RATE STUDY TO EXAMINE WHETHER
THE PROPOSED IMPLEMENTATION
TIMELINE IS SUFFICIENT TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS IN A POST
KOPET NINETEEN WORLD. LET US
PLEASE BEGIN WITH MR WINFIELD
WHEN YOU ARE READY ALL. HI
MISTER CHAIR OF THE JIM MY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND HOPE YOU DON'T MIND
UP ALL WILL BE TOUGH FOR THE
DEPARTMENT ON THE ISSUE. SO
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZED THE NOT
ONLY THE MAGNITUDE BUT ALSO THE
SIGNIFICANT IMPORTANCE OF THE
INVESTMENT. IN RATE REFORM AND-
OTHER WORK FOR THE STATED GOAL
OF THE ENHANCING CONSUMER
EXPERIENCE. EQUITY QUALITY AND
OUTCOMES AND WITH THE MEDICATION
THE BILL. REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE ENOUGH
STAKE THANK. THE AGENDA OUTLINES
THAT PHASED APPROACH TO
IMPLEMENTING THE RATE MODELS
PROPOSED IN A RATE STUDY IN THE
FIRST. IS RATE ADJUSTMENTS THAT
ARE WILL BE EFFECTIVE APRIL
FIRST AT. WE DISCUSSED BEFORE
THEIR SIGNIFICAN VARIATION IN
THE WAY THAT RATES ARE
ESTABLISHED TODAY AND ALSO IN
HEALTH SERVICES ARE PROVIDED AND
SO WE- GET TO DO THIS FIRST
THAT. WE REALLY NEED TO OBTAIN A
LOT OF INFORMATION FROM ONLY
REGIONAL ARTS BUT ALSO SERVICE
PROVIDERS. SO WE CAN DO THAT THE
DOES THE JUDGMENT FOR APRIL
FIRST. THE TO HELP FOR THIS
PROCESS AND CAN MAKE FOLKS
AWARE- BERMAN AND SUMMIT
THEORIES OF PUBLIC MEETINGS WE
STARTED THOSE BACK IN NOVEMBER.
INDOS MEANS RECORDED BACKGROUND
ON THE RATE STUDY ALTHOUGH THE
CURRENT RATE REFORM EFFORTS AND
THE PROCESS OF WORKING USED TO
MAKE THOSE RATE CHANGES. NOW.
THERE IS A HUGE UNDERTAKING
GATHERING THIS TYPE OF
INFORMATION LIKE I SAID IT'S
ABOUT- INDIVIDUAL PROVIDING
SERVICES WHERE THE SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED IN SOME CASES THE
PACKING SERVICE AND WE'RE DOING
THIS IN MAKING HIS REQUEST- WELL
YOU KNOW DURING THE LATEST
SURGING INCUMBENT NINETEEN G. SO
WE WANT TO REALLY EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR ALL THE HARD
WORK THAT'S GONE ON AND INSPIRED
OF THE CHALLENGES. WE'VE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS EVEN IN
SPITE OF THE CHALLENGES AND TO
LATER THIS MONTH WE EXPECT TO
BEGIN SENDING- UPDATED PROVIDER
RATE CUTS OUT TO A REGIONAL
CENTER THE KNOWLEDGE OF
PROVIDERS WILL ACT ON A FLOW
BASIS AND WE HOPE TO GET THE
MAJORITY. COMPLETED BY THE END
OF MARCH. SO IT'S LIKE THAT WE
WON'T HAVE EVERYTHING TO BY END
OF MARCH BUT WILL STILL BE. TO
THE NUMBER AND GET UPDATED RATES
OUT FOR PROVIDERS. AND EVEN
THOUGH IT WILL HAPPEN FOR SAMPLE
- THAT CALCULATION WILL BE AFTER
MARCH THOSE RATES WILL STILL BE
A FACTOR- APRIL FIRST.
REGARDLESS OF WHEN YOU GET THE
INFORMATION NEEDED. COUPLE OTHER
THINGS TO KNOW. OUR ARE YOU KNOW
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. THAT WE GET
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR THESE RATE
CHANGES AND IN OUR APPLICATION
FOR THAT. THAT CHANGE WAS
SUBMITTED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN DECEMBER AND SO
HOPEFULLY WILL RECEIVE
INFORMATION ON FINAL APPROVAL.
AT SOME POINT NEXT MONTH. AND
THEN YOU KNOW THE RATE STUDY AS
YOU MENTIONED- WEST WEST
PUBLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THERE WAS AN UPDATE IN
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY. SO PART
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING TO IS THAT
WE NEED TO UPDATE THE RATES. ARE
BASED ON THE BRAKE MODELS THAT
WORK PUBLISHED OR UPDATED BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY SO
UTILIZING MORE CURRENT
INFORMATION ON WAGES AND THE
OTHER COST COMPONENTS THE MODEL.
DOES THOSE RATES WILL BE
AVAILABLE SOON AND SO WE'LL USE
THOSE UPDATED RATES TO DO A
COMPARISON TO THE PROVIDERS
CURRENT RATE MAKE DOES THAT THE
CALCULATIONS OF THE CHANGES. AND
THEN. REGARDING YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT IF THERE ARE ANY STATUTORY
OR OTHER CHANGES NOW- WE WOULD
EXPECT THAT ON THE EXISTING
DIRECTIVE AUTHORITY THAT THAT
ALREADY THAT IS IN THE STATUTE
THAT MIGHT ALONG WITH THE RATE
REFORM WOULD BE SUFFICIENT TO
ADDRESS ANY OPERATIONAL ISSUES
THAT WE KNOW NOW- YOU KNOW AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. THERE'S GOING TO
BE A LOT OF CHANGES THAT ARE
GOING TO NEED TO BE MADE BETTER
ENVISIONED BY THE RATE STUDY SO
THERE WILL BE A REGULATORY
PROCESS THAT- TO FULLY
IMPLEMENT- THE RATE STUDY AND TO
IMPLEMENT THE STRUCTURE THAT'S A
PROPOSED IN THE RATE SETTING.
AND LEADS TO. UNIQUE OTHER.
ABOUT I DO. ADDRESS ANY REFINED
IN RATE SETTING. SO WE'RE
WORKING WITH AN INTEL THE NUMBER
OF TARGETED MEETINGS WITH GROUPS
THAT DIFFERENCE SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE EARLY START
TRANSPORTATION SUPPORTED AND
INDEPENDENT LIVING SERVICES
AMONGST OTHERS AND THEY'VE
EXPRESSED SOME CONCERNS OR HAVE
SOME SUGGESTIONS ABOUT SOME OF
THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT WERE MADE
IN ESTABLISHING THE RATE MODELS.
INFO AT WE CONTINUE THIS WORK
WE'D EXPECT THERE MAY BE
REFINEMENTS THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED ARMED TO THE
REGULATORY BUDGET PROCESS. IT
WITH THAT HISTORIC INVESTMENTS-
THAT RATE REFORM BRINGS THE
ONGOING COLLABORATIVE ASSESSMENT
AND MONITORING. OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION IS GOING TO BE
CRITICAL. IN I ALSO WANT TO
ADDRESS THE SERVICE STAFF
RECOMMENDED YET GENDER AND WE
HAVE BEEN ON AND WILL PROVIDE AN
ESTIMATED COST IN TIME ENOUGH
FEDERAL APPROVAL FOR
ACCELERATING THE RATE INCREASE.
IN AND WE CAN ROVIDE THAT BY
MARCH FOURTH THAT SUGGEST. SO
WITH THAT I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER
TO MR SERVING GOTTA TALK ABOUT
THE INCENTIVES. THANKS JIM.
BURST AT THE TRIBECA WITH THE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT THANKS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY- I'M HERE TODAY
TO TALK ABOUT- THE SECOND SOME
PART OF THIS ITEM. I WHICH IS
THE QUALITY INCENTIVE PROGRAMWE
WERE ASKED TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE PLAN FOR THAT PROGRAM
IN A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE OF HOW THE
PROGRAM. MIGHT WORK WHEN IT'S
IMPLEMENTED. I'M THEIR THEIR ARE
THE CALL AND CENTER PROGRAMS IS
WHY OF THOSE IN. RECENTLY THAT
IS ANTI TO MOVE THE- SERVICES
SYSTEM OF FURTHER FOCUS ON
OUTCOMES. I WOULD THE RANGE.
THIS THIS PROGRAM- WILL PROVIDE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TO MEET OR
EXCEED BENCHMARKS ON QUALITY
MEASURES THAT ARE BEING
DEVELOPED THIS YEAR. AND THAT WE
EXPECT WILL EVOLVE IN FUTURE
YEARS. THE PROGRAM IS REQUIRED
TO BE FULLY IMPLEMENTED IN THE
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX FISCAL
YEAR. THE FINAL PERSON. QUALITY
OUTCOME MEASURES. AT THE END.
LEVEL AS MR MYNACH KNOWLEDGE-
THIS IS ANOTHER GROUP THAT HAS
BEEN CAN I MEETING- MONTHLY
SINCE NOVEMBER THAT TO DEVELOP
THE PROGRAM THERE AND IN
ADDITION TO THE FORTY ONE
MEMBERS OF THE GROUP THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN THOSE MEETINGS
AS WELL. WELL LIKE MANY OF THE
MEETINGS ON THE SUBJECT ARE THEY
ARE RECORDED AND- ALL THE
MATERIALS AND RECORDING YOU
POSTED ON THE WEBSITE AND INPUT
IS AVAILABLE THROUGH A DEDICATED
MAILBOX THERE BETWEEN MEETINGS
AS WELL SO WE'RE REALLY
INTERESTED IN THIS TOPIC. AND
APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT AND
WE'VE HAD SO FAR. OF FOR
EVERYONE INVOLVED. AFTER SOME
LEVEL SAID ACROSS DIVERSE
MEMBERSHIP OF THE GROUP- WORKER
. AS CONTINUE TO WORK TO DEFINE
THE QUALITY OUTCOME MEASURES
THAT WOULD LIKE TO ACHIEVE IN
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX. ARE YOU
CAN THINK OF THIS IS DEFINING
WHERE WE WANT TO BE AT THE END
OF THE ROAD AND I WILL BE
WORKING WITH THAT GROUP ON AN
ONGOING BASIS TO DEFINE THAT THE
PASTOR CHIEF THOSE THOSE.
QUALITY OUTCOME MEASURES. ONE IT
IS AN ABSOLUTE RESULT WE EXPECT
THAT- IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THOSE
OUTCOMES MEASURES ANGLES HERE
THIS AN EXAMPLE IN A MOMENT-
THERE MAY BE SOME INTERIM
MEASURES IN THE YEARS OF THE
TWENTY ONE ON OUR WAY TO GET TO
THOSE EVENTUAL GOALS. WELL IN
TERMS OF PROCESS THE WORKING
GROUP'S RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
STATURE WERE POORLY REQUIRED. TO
BE PROVIDED TO THE DEPARTMENT IN
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. IN
APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUIRED TO POST
POTENTIAL MEASURES FOR FURTHER
PUBLIC INPUT ARE ON THE INTERNET
. ARE THE WORK GROUP IN THE
DEPARTMENT WILL CONTINUE TO OF
ALL OF THE- INTERIM AND LONG
TERM MEASURES AND THEIR
ASSOCIATED BENCHMARKS AND
METHODOLOGIES. I SEE HOW THOSE
MEASURES ARE CALCULATED BUT ALSO
WHERE WE EXPECT PEOPLE TO BE.
FOR AN INITIAL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PROGRAM IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE ABOUT
THE UPCOMING YEAR. ALTHOUGH THE
LONG TERM MEASURES ARE UNDER
DEVELOPMENT HERE'S A POSSIBLE
EXAMPLE OF HOW SPECIFIC MEASURE
MIGHT WORK. WORKFORCE CAPACITY
AND STABILITY AS WE'VE HEARD
ALREADY TODAY ARE LARGE PROBLEMS
FACING THE SYSTEM TODAY. BECAUSE
HOWEVER THE STATE IS NOT THE
DIRECT EMPLOYER OF PEOPLE
PROVIDING SERVICES THE STATE
DOES NOT HAVE INSIGHT INTO THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING SERVICES FOR THEIR
COMPENSATION TRAINING AND TURN
OF THE- IF WE PRESUME FOR A
MOMENT THE QUALITY OUTCOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS. CAN BE SUPPORTED BY
A QUALITY WORKFORCE THAT IS
PROVIDING SERVICES TO THEM. THEN
PERHAPS HAVING A QUALITY
WORKFORCE IS A MEASURE THAT
SUPPORTS QUALITY OUTCOMES. WE
COULD NOT FIND A QUALITY
WORKFORCE AS AN ADEQUATE AND
STABLE SUPPLY OF PEOPLE
APPROPRIATELY TRAINED TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY.
YOU'RE NOT ALONE KRISPYKREME
CULTURALLY COMPETENT MANNER THAT
RESPECTS INDIVIDUAL CHOICES AND
IS GEARED TO ACHIEVE. OUR
DESIRED PERSON CENTERED OUTCOMES
SO THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
MOUTHFUL BUT IT'S A TASTE OF HOW
COMPLEX THE DEFINITION MIGHT BE
. ARM AND THEN. A QUALITY WORK
NONE COULD AN EXAM OF A LONG
TERM QUALITY OUTCOME MEASURE. TO
KNOW WHETHER WE'RE SUSTAINING A
QUALITY WORKFORCE REQUIRES MUCH
MORE INFORMATION THAN WE HAVE
TODAY AND THEN TRACKING THAT
INFORMATION OVER. FOR EXAMPLE IN
YEAR ONE WE MIGHT SURVEYS
SERVICE PROVIDERS FOR THE FIRST
TIME TO COLLECT SOME BASELINE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES THAT THEY HAVE
PROVIDING SERVICES. THEIR
COMPENSATION BILL LANGUAGE
COMPETENCIES AND OUR AVERAGE
TENURE OR TURNOVER RATES. NEAR
TO DO WE MIGHT BUILD ON NOT BY
COLLECTING THE SAME INFORMATION
AND THEN ANALYZING WHETHER
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE MAKING
AND WORKFORCE TRAINING AND RATE
ADJUSTMENTS ARE HAVING THEIR
INTENDED IN. WE MIGHT ALSO BEGIN
TO COLLECT THIRD PARTY
INFORMATION SUCH AS SURVEYS OF
INDIVIDUALS. ABOUT THEIR SERVICE
PROVIDER EXPERIENCE IN TERMS OF
THE TRAINING AND CULTURAL
COMPETENCY THAT THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING. IN YEAR THREE WE
MIGHT CONTINUE THOSE SURVEYS AND
ALSO BEGIN TO INCREASE THE
WEIGHT GIVEN TO THE THIRD PARTY
INFORMATION- FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS BEING SERVED AS- THE
GOAL ULTIMATELY IS INDIVIDUAL
PERSON CENTRED QUALITY OUTCOME
MEASURES. THE PROGRAM ALONG THE
WAY WOULD PROVIDE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES WELL PERHAPS SIMPLY
INITIALLY JUST FOR PROVIDING
THAT DATA THAT FOUNDATIONAL DATA
WE WOULD NEED TO BE CONSTRUCTED
MEASURE AND KNOW WHERE WE ARE.
AND THEN INCREASINGLY FOR
PERFORMING AT OR ABOVE BENCHMARK
LEVELS ON THE MEASURE FOR MAKING
MEANINGFUL PROGRESS TOWARD THE
BENCHMARK. WHICH COULD BE FOR
EXAMPLE AND IN THIS CASE REDUCE
TURNOVER CERTAIN LEVELS OF
TRAINING AND CERTAIN TOPICS THAT
ARE VALIDATED AS PRACTICED. AND
OUR WORKFORCE COMPOSITION
DEMOGRAPHICS THAT ARE MORE
CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH THE
COMMUNITY BEING SERVED. SO I'M
GONNA WORK KNOWLEDGE BECAUSE
THESE MEASURES ARE STILL BEING
DEVELOPED EVEN THIS EXAMPLES AND
IN PERFECT AND HYPOTHETICAL
EXAMPLE BUT STILL LACKS SOME
DETAILS- WE'RE REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE ENGAGEMENT
THAT TIME AND THE EXPERTISE OF
OUR SYSTEMS INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES
AND- STICK TO STAKEHOLDERS AND
REGIONAL CENTERS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS. AND WE EXPECT THAT IN
GAUGE MEANT TO CONTINUE WELL
INTO THE FUTURE AS THIS PROGRAM
CONTINUES TO BE- INTO TO INVOLVE
. WE WANT TO REMIND THAT ANY
MEASURES THAT WE ULTIMATELY
DECIDE UPON THAT THEIR
MEANINGFUL BUT THERE ARE VALID
AND RELIABLE. THAT THERE
FEASIBLE TO COLLECT. ON THE DAY
WE'RE NOT CREATING PERVERSE ARE
CONTRADICTORY IMPACTS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT. YOU HEARD IN THIS
EXAMPLE THERE MAY BE AREAS OF
WHICH TODAY WE LACK THE DATA OR
PROCESS INFRASTRUCTURE TO
CALCULATE A MEASURE ON DAY ONE
AND THAT'S REALLY WHERE THE
SYNERGIES WITH OTHER INITIATIVES
FROM REGIONAL CENTER PERFORMANCE
MEASURES TO THE NEW CASE
MANAGEMENT OR OR THE NEW HAND OR
THE NEW FISCAL SYSTEM. OR THE
WORKFORCE INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT ALL COME
TOGETHER TO ACHIEVE AND THAT
MEASURE QUALITY PERSON CENTRED
OUTCOMES AT THE INDIVIDUAL LEVEL
AT THE ULTIMATE ON. I'M STILL A
LITTLE OF A MOUTHFUL BUT
HOPEFULLY FOR EXAMPLE. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH WE WILL NEXT HEAR FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- CHRISTOPHER
O'NEILL DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD TO THE
PRESENTATION. NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE L.
L. THANK YOU DOCTOR AND IT WAS
WHEN YOU PICK WITH THE L. A. O.
AND- SO THE FIRST THING WE WOULD
SAY IS- THE RATE. RATE STEADY
IMPROVEMENT TO THE RATE REFORM
QUALITY INCENTIVE PROGRAM
REPRESENTS SUCH A HUGE CHANGE IN
THE SYSTEM IT'S A- POSITIVE STEP
TOWARD A MORE RATIONAL AND
TRANSPARENT SYSTEM FOR PAYING.
THE MANY PROVIDERS SERVING
INDIVIDUALS IN THE SYSTEM AND WE
REALLY HAD TO BIG- QUESTIONS
ABOUT THIS PROCESS- GOING GOING
INTO THIS- BUDGET CYCLE. SO THE
FIRST WAS HELL WILL BE HAS MAKE
IT HEARD OF IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
SYSTEM. AND OUR OUR
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT- REALLY STARTED TO
ADDRESS THIS TODAY WHICH WAS WAS
GREAT TO HEAR- AND I WOULD JUST
UNDERSCORE THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING A TRANSPARENT SORT OF
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT PROCESS I
MEAN IT'S BETTER TO SORT OF. IF
THERE'S ISSUES THAT WE CAN
IDENTIFY NOW THAT NEED TO BE
FIXED IT'S BETTER TO FIX THEM
NOW AND THEN TO YOU KNOW
IMPLEMENTED- A RATE SETTING
PROCESS THAT- MAY BE WITH US FOR
SOME TIME- SO JUST TO GIVE AN
EXAMPLE- THE AGREEMENT THAT WAS
REACHED LAST YEAR INCLUDED THE-
THE PLAN TO PHASE IN RATE
INCREASES OVER FIVE YEARS. AND
THESE RATE INCREASES ARE BASED
ON WHAT THE RATE MODEL SAY RATES
SHOULD BE AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO MISTER NIGHT- INDICATED THAT
THOSE THE ACTUAL. AMOUNTS WILL
BE AVAILABLE SOON. SO THIS THAT
IN FIVE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX- THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO LEVEL RATES WILL BE
FULLY PHASED IN- MEANING THEY'RE
SORT OF. RT DATE- SO ONE BENEFIT
OF THE RATE MODELS IS THAT THEY
CAN BE UPDATED WITH- REGULARITY
AND WITH SOME AMOUNT AND HE'S
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT THE INPUTS
ARE INTO THOSE THREE MODELS. SO
YOU KNOW QUESTION IN OUR OF MY
INTO THEN IS HOW DOES THE
DEPARTMENT INTENDS TO APPROACH
UPDATING RATES AFTER TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX- ANOTHER. WHICH
MISTER KNIGHT ALSO ALLUDED TO
IT'S JUST THAT RATE MODELS WERE
DEVELOPED PRIOR TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND THERE MAY
BE SOME LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE
PANDEMIC EXPERIENCE THAT SHOULD
BE INCORPORATED. INTO THE RATE
SETTING PROCESS SO AGAIN WE JUST
UNDERSCORE THAT IT WOULD BE SORT
OF BETTER TO YOU- FREE VISIT YOU
KNOW IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT GO
INTO THE RATE MODELS OR ABOUT
SERVICE DESIGN ANSWERED. BETTER
TO ADDRESS THOSE NOW- YOU KNOW
BEFORE BEFORE THE REMOTE OR
SOMETHING. IN PLACE AND OFTEN
READING. I'M BILL THE OTHER MAIN
QUESTION THAT WE HAD AND MISTER
TO BANK TRINCA- ALLUDED TO THIS
A MOMENT AGO CONCERNS- DDS IS
BIG I. T. SYSTEMS AND- BUSINESS
SORT OF THE PERENNIAL COMMENT
THAT THE L. A- MAKES IT BUDGET
HEARINGS ABOUT DDS IS I. T.
SYSTEMS- BUT WE WOULD SAY AT.
THIS YEAR THAT DDS IS RECEIVING
PLANNING DOLLARS FROM THE
FEDERAL EACH CBS FUNDS TO
OVERHAUL TWO OF IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT DATA SYSTEMS THE
CONSUMER RECORDS MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM. AS WELL AS THE UNIFORM
FISCAL SYSTEM WHICH SUPPORTS-
THE INVOICING AND PAYMENT OF
SERVICE PROVIDERS- I KNOW THIS
ISSUE- I THINK IT'S GOING TO
COME UP LATER IN THE HEARING IN
ON ISSUE NINE BUT THE REASON I
WANTED TO BRING. IT UP HERE IS
THAT- J. TO POINT OUT HOW BY
THESE. SYSTEMS WILL BE TO.
PERFORM BASED PROGRAMS THE
QUALITY INCENTIVE PROGRAM AS
WELL AS THE REGIONAL CENTER
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE. PROGRAM
THEY'RE ALSO JUST VITAL TO
UNDERSTANDING SYSTEM TRENDS BE
IT CONSUMER OUTCOMES CONSUMER
CONSUMER SERVICE NEEDS. SERVICE
GAPS GAPS IN SERVICE PROVIDER
AVAILABILITY- PERFORMANCE OF
REGIONAL CENTERS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS EQUITY IN THE PURCHASE
OF SERVICE AND- OTHER SPENDING
TRENDS. SO- ONE OF OUR CONCERNS
IS THAT THERE WERE NO DETAILS
ABOUT THE PLANNING THE I. T.
PLANNING PROCESS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SO WE HAVE A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT- HOW DDS
IS GOING TO APPROACH THIS
PROCESS. AND HOW DDS WILL
IMPLEMENT THESE PERFORMANCE
SPACE PROGRAMS IN THE ABSENCE
OF- BEFORE THESE SYSTEMS REALLY
ARE IN PLACE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM JORDAN LINDSAY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ARC IN UCPE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION ALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
SHORTLANDS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
YOUR CAN YOU SEE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION SPEAKING ON BEHALFOF R. TWENTY TO R. CHAPTERS
ACROSS THE STATE TEN. OF THE
IT'S ON OUR THIRTY SEVEN BOARD
MEMBERS WHO ARE ALL PARENTS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS INDIVIDUALS WITH
IDEAS WELL AS INDIVIDUALS AB DE
UM I ALSO SPEAK TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE LAND IN QUESTION. ALSO
BEGIN TO ANSWER THE QUESTION ON
THE AGENDA I WANT TO GIVE BRIEF. CONTEXT FOR HOW WE GOT HERE.
APOLOGY IF YOU CAN HEAR SIRENS
IN THE BACK. FIFTY YEARS AGO
CALIFORNIA PASOLINI'S ACT AND
THE ACT WAS UPHELD AND STRENGTH
IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
COURT CASE THE ARK VERSE DDS
WHEN THE COURT RULED THAT. THE
ACT DEFINES A BASIC RIGHTS IN
THE CORRESPONDING BASIC
OBLIGATION THE RIGHTS WHICH
GRANTS TO THE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED PERSONS TO BE PROVIDED
WITH SERVICES THAT ENABLE HIM TO
LIVE A MORE INDEPENDENT AND
PRODUCTIVE LIVES IN THE
COMMUNITY. THE OBLIGATION WHICH
IMPOSES ON THE STATE IS TO
PROVIDE SUCH SERVICES. PERSON
HAS THE RIGHT TO BE PROVIDED
WITH SERVICES IN THE STATE HOUSE
OF OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES. THAT'S FORTY TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND FOR MANY
YEARS THOSE SERVICES WEREN'T
BEING ADEQUATELY PROVIDED IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AT THAT TIME
REQUIRED TO REPEAT THIS STEP
RIGHT STUDY TO BE DONE AND AS WE
KNOW IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IT
IDENTIFIED THAT SERVICES WERE
BEING UNDERFUNDED. BY ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION. LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE LEANED INTO OUR
COMMUNITY AND WE'RE SO GRATEFUL
AND THREW A ROCK EFFORTS
INCLUDING OF COURSE THE EFFORTS
OF THIS COMMITTEE. AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ADVOCACY
COMMUNITY- YOU WERE ABLE TO PASS
THE FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
RATE STUDY STARTING WITH 25% THE
ST PAUL- IT REALLY WILL CREATE
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED. I'M IN
FUTURE ABOUT PERSON CENTERED IN
ALKEM BASED SYSTEM. IN THERE IS
GREAT HOPE AND OPTIMISM IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR THE FUTURE. BUT I
DO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO TALK
ABOUT THE PRESENT. AS IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED UNDER THE FUNDING HAS
ACTUALLY YET AND ALLOCATED IN
THE COMMUNITY. AS UNDERGONE
EXTREME STRESS DURING THE
PANDEMIC LSO MOST URGENTLY
THERE IS AN ACUTE STAFFING
SHORTAGE AS IT'S ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED ACROSS THE STATE.
WHICH IS CAUSING RATIONING OF
SERVICES AND INADEQUATE ACCESS
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO TALK ABOUT ON
THE IMPACT ON PROVIDERS IN AN
INFORMAL SURVEY OF. NINETY
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS WHICH
IS COMPLETED LAST WEEK AND OUT
OF THE NINETY PROVIDERS THERE
WERE 200-060-0404 CURRENT JOB
OPENINGS. AND I MEAN IN 19%
FEWER EMPLOYEES THAN PREPRINT
ADVOCATE MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
THAT MEANS ONE OUT OF. EVERY
FIVE STAFF IS GONE AND WE CAN'T
GET THEM BACK RIGHT NOW. IF YOU
EXTRAPOLATE THAT TO CASELOAD AT
730-005-0020 TWO PEOPLE NOT
BEING SERVED ON CURRENT
CASELOADS. OR BOARD OR LIKELY
WHAT IS HAPPENING THAT WE'RE
HEARING. IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
BEING SERVED AT A MUCH
DIMIISHED SERVICES- BECAUSE WE
JUST CANNOT FIND THE BODIES IN
THE PEOPLE. TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE
STAFFING. IT'S THE SAME THING
I'M IMPACTING ALL SECTORS ACROSS
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY. EXCEPT THAT
WE CAN'T COMPENSATE BY RAISING
WAGES WHICH IS WHY WE NEED
INCREASED RATES NOW BECAUSE THE
MONEY WILL GO STRAIGHT TO WAGES
TO THE WORKFORCE. MOST
CRITICALLY I WANT TO ALSO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPACT AND THE
BURDEN THAT'S BEEN SHOULDERED BY
INDIVIDUALS WITH IT AND- HE'S-
AS A SNAPSHOT. BOTH ARE
CALIFORNIA'S BOARD PRESIDENT IN
PAST PRESENT. AND THEIR ADULT
CHILDREN MOVING OUT OF
INDEPENDENT LIVING AND PACKING
WITH THEIR PARENTS. BECAUSE
THERE ARE NO STAFF TO SUPPORT
THEM. IT TRAGICALLY ALSO LOSING
SECTION EIGHT HOUSING UNITS
RESULT. OF WE CANNOT WAIT FOR
THE WAIT RIGHT STUDY
IMPLEMENTATION TO TRICKLE OUT
THE NEXT FOUR YEARS THE NEED IS
URGENT. WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGE THIS TREMENDOUSLY
CHALLENGING TIME. AT THE SAME
TIME THE AVERAGE MINUTES BUDGET
SURPLUS. WE BELIEVE THAT BY
ACCELERATING THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE RIGHT STUDY BY ONE YEAR
AS A ONE TIME INVESTMENT. AND
ALSO ACCELERATING THE QUALITY
AND OUTCOMES BASED REQUIREMENTS
THAT WE CAN BEGIN TO
AGGRESSIVELY COMPETE ONCE AGAIN. FOR WORKERS. AND WE HAVE SOME
IT IS. PROPOSAL TO YOUR- WE ALSO
DO WANT TO IN UP IN THE SIX. AND
SAY SITUATION JUST A FEW YEARS
TIME WHICH IS WE ALL SEE THAT.
FOR A REGULAR UPDATES OF THE
RATE MODELS WE- I MISS PETTICOAT
. ALREADY MENTIONED I'M WE SEE
EVERYTHING YEARS. TO UPDATE THE
RIGHT MODELS SUBSEQUENTLY THE
RATES. FINALLY WE HAVE CHANGED
AS A COMMUNITY AS YOU HAVE
MENTIONED MISTER CHAIR SINCE THE
PANDEMIC BEGAN TWO YEARS AGO.
AND THE RATE STUDY ANALYZED A
PRE PANDEMIC SYSTEM OF SUPPORTS
AND SERVICES WE BELIEVE THERE IS
A NEED FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
REQUEST AN ADDENDUM TO THE RIGHT
STUDY AND WE THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR FOR JUST DOING CELL AND-
WE HOPE THAT IT WILL YOU GIVE US
A CHANCE TO EVALUATE NEEDED
UPDATES TO MODELS ELIGIBLE
SERVICES BILLING METHODS. I'M IN
THIS TO WE HAVE SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM JUDY MARC PRESIDENT.
FOR DISABILITY VOICES UNITED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MY NAME IS
JUDY MARC BOB I AM THE PRESIDENT
OF DISABILITY VOICES UNITED AN
ORGANIZATION LED AND STAFFED.
EXCLUSIVELY BY PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
OTHER DISABILITIES AND THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS. I AM ALSO THE
PARENT OF A TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD
SON WITH AUTISM WHO SERVED BY
REGIONAL CENTER. I AM HERE TO
PRESENT THE SOUTH AFRICAN FAMILY
PERSPECTIVE ON THE SUBJECT. TO
BE HONEST MOST PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES LIVE DAY TO DAY.
AND NEVER EVEN HEARD OF THE RATE
SETTING. WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT
MANY OF US HAVE TO FIGHT TO
RECEIVE SERVICES AND GOOD
PROVIDERS SO THE IDEA OF RATES
IS NOT EVEN ON OUR RADAR. HERE'S
WHAT WE DO CARE ACT WE WANT TO
HAVE SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO ARE
RESPECTFUL RELIABLE AND RESTORES
FULL IN HELPING US MEET OUR
PERSONAL GOALS. THERE ARE MANY
AMAZING PROVIDERS OUT THERE WHO
HAVE THOSE QUALITIES. WHEN I
SPEAK TO OUR COMMUNITY ABOUT
THIS ISSUE THEY ARE OFTEN
SURPRISED TO HEAR THAT RATES ARE
NOT TIED TO OUTCOMES. DOESN'T IT
JUST MAKES SENSE TO PAY HIGHER
RATES TO THE PROVIDERS TO DO
BETTER FOR THEIR CLIENTS. THE
REGIONAL CENTER THE SAME RETOOL
PROVIDER THAT TREAT US WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT AS THE YEAR
TO A PROVIDER THAT ABUSE. WHY IS
THE RATE THE SAME FOR PROVIDER
THAT HELPS US ACHIEVE OUR PERSON
CENTRED INCLUSIVE OUTCOMES. AS
IT IS FOR ONE THAT KEEPS A
SEGREGATED AREN'T SITTING IN A
MEANINGFUL OUTCOMES THAT MATTER
TO PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THIS IS WHERE THE
CONVERSATION NEEDS TO BE TODAY.
WE DEEPLY APPRECIATE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO CHOOSE TO WORK
WITH US AND OUR FAMILY MEMBERS.
BUT WE ARE NOT A REGIONAL CENTER
OR PROVIDER CENTERED SYSTEM WE
ARE A PERSON CENTRED SYSTEM AND
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ISSUE WITH
THIS LANDS YOU MIGHT COME AWAY
WITH A VERY DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE. LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
ESTABLISHED A MULTI YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TWENTY
NINETEEN RIGHT STUDY FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE APPROACH AND SCHEDULE. THAT
TIES THE PHASE IN OF RATE
INCREASES TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF A QUALITY INCENTIVE PROGRAM
TO IMPROVE CONSUMER OUTCOMES
SERVICE PROVIDER PERFORMANCE AND
QUALITY OF SERVICE. WE HAVE
HEARD REQUESTED A TO ACCELERATE
THE SCHEDULE THIS ACCELERATION
SHOULD ONLY BE CONSIDERED IF WE
ALSO SPEED UP THE QUALITY
INSPECTOR PROGRAM. WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES COULD LEAD TO QUALITY
SERVICES AND IMPROVED OUTCOMES
FIRST RATE INCREASES SHOULD BE
DIRECTLY LINKED TO AN INCREASE
IN THE WAGES OF DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS OUR DS PEAS. SINCE
THE GOAL MANY TODAY'S TO
STABILIZE THE DSP WORKFORCE
BANKING WAGES THAT CAN ATTRACT
AND RETAIN QUALIFIED RESPONSIBLE
STAFF WHY DON'T WE NOT REQUIRING
THAT THE READING CRISPY USED TO
RAISE WAGES FOR DSPS. SECOND
CONGREGATE SERVICE PROVIDER
SHOULD HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE
MEANINGFUL EFFORTS TOWARD
COMPLIANCE WITH THE H. T. V. S.
FINAL RULE BEFORE RECEIVING RATE
INCREASES. WE ARE ONE SHORT YEAR
AWAY FROM LOSING FEDERAL FUNDING
FOR LACK OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE
H. TVS ROLE. YET MANY OF OUR
CONGREGATE SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE
NOWHERE CLOSE TO BE THEIR
SERVICES TOWARDS COMPLIANCE. THE
READING CREASES OFFERED
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE A
SIGNIFICANT INCENTIVE TO PUSH
THOSE CONGREGATE PROVIDERS
TOWARD DEVELOPING FEDERALLY
REQUIRED INTEGRATED SETTINGS AND
PERSON CENTERED SERVICE. THIRD
QUALITY PERFORMANCE MEASURES
BEING DEVELOPED BY DDS SHOULD
FOCUS ON THE PERSON CENTERED
OUTCOMES OF PEOPLE WITH IDG I'M
NOT A SERVICE PROVIDER
COMPLIANCE. FOR EXAMPLE A
QUALITY PERFORMANCE MEASURE
COULD BE THE PERSON FEEL THEY
HAVE CONTROL OVER THEIR DAY TO
DAY LIFE. AN INTERIM ASSESSMENT
TO WORK TOWARD THAT MEASURE
COULD BE STAFF HAVE BEEN TRAINED
IN PERSON CENTERED THINKING. BUT
THE QUALITY OUTCOME WE ARE
ULTIMATELY SEEKING TO ACHIEVE IS
ABOUT THE PERSON NOT THE
PROVIDER DV YOU ALONG WITH OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WILL BE PRESENTING
TO DDS IN THE LEGISLATURE MORE
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
COMING WEEKS FOR CALLING FOR
QUALITY PERFORMANCE MEASURES
BASED ON INDIVIDUALIZED
OUTCOMES. FINALLY THE
MODERNIZATION OF OUR OUTDATED
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGIES
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM MUST BE
PRIORITIZED IN ORDER TO TRACK
OUTCOMES AND TIED UP TO PROVIDER
RATE. ALL OF THIS DISCUSSION
ABOUT HOW COMES IS PURELY
ACADEMIC BECAUSE- INCREDIBLY
OBSOLETE I. T. SYSTEM CAN'T
POSSIBLY TRACK THE- WE ARE
SPENDING HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS INCREASING PROVIDER
RATES WITHOUT HAVING ANY IDEA
HOW TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
INVESTMENT WAS WORTH IT. WE CALL
THE LEGISLATURE TO PUT ASIDE
MONIES NOW FOR THIS
TRANSFORMATIONAL SYSTEMS
OVERHAUL THAT INCLUDES AN
OUTWARD FACING COMPONENT THAT
ALLOWS REGIONAL CENTER CLIENTS
TO ACCESS THE RECORDS VERIFYING
PROVIDER INVOICES AND REPORTS
AND PROVIDE REAL TIME FEEDBACK
ABOUT THEIR SERVICE. THANK YOU
FOR GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM BABY ON HAN WHO IS THE
SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH THE-
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES PRACTICE GROUP
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY MY
NAME IS THAT THE AND CURRENT I
AM WITH THIS ABILITY RIGHT
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS THE STATE'S
PROTECTION AND ADVOCACY AGENCY.
THERE'S NO QUESTION WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A FURIOUS WORK.
PROVIDE OVER THE LAST YEAR I'M
SORRY RIGHT CAL EVERYDAY PEOPLE
WHO ARE STRUGGLING FROM SOMEONE
WHO NEEDS TWENTY FOUR SEVEN CARE
THAT CAN'T FIND ENOUGH. MEETING
HELD AT HOME ALONE FOR HOURS AT
A TIME FROM A MARKET OUT OF THE
HIGH DESERT YOU CAN'T FIND
ANYONE IN HER AREA YOU CAN
SUPPORT HER CHILD IN THE
LANGUAGE THEY SPEAK. STORIES
LIKE THESE OUT EVERY DAY AND
MAKE IT CLEAR WE HAVE TO ACT
URGENTLY TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
MORE DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS. QUALITY JOBS AND
QUALITY SERVICES ARE IN EXTRA
COMPLETELY. WHAT IS OUR
COMPETITIVE WAGES AND THOSE WHO
EXCEL TO BE VALUED AND PAID
ACCORDINGLY. FOR THAT TO HAPPEN
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO FIND WHAT
QUALITY SUPPORT LOOKS LIKE IN
THE LIFE OF A PERSON WITH IT.
YOU STRONGLY THAT IF WE WANT TO
ACCELERATE THE TIME FRAME FOR
BREAKING. ACT RATE BY HALF TO BE
TIED TO A FEW CRITICAL. FIRST
LET'S MAKE SURE THOSE INCREASES
DOWN TO WHERE THEY NEED. TO
RAISE OUR WAGES FOR FRONTLINE
STAFF. LET'S ALSO ACCELERATOR
TIME FRAME FOR IDENTIFYING WHAT
QUALITY OUTCOMES RIGHT AND FOR
FIGURING OUT HOW PROVIDERS CAN
GET HOLD MORE FOR THOSE THAT
COME. IF THE RATE INCREASES MOVE
UP A YEAR THE SCHEDULE FOR
HAVING QUALITY INCENTIVES AND
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL OUTCOME
MEASURES SHOULD MOVE UP A YEAR
IN. ANOTHER THE TWENTY NINETEEN
RICK STUDY THAT HELLO THIS WAS
BASED ON. AS WE'VE JUST BEEN
DISCUSSING THERE IS A LOT THAT
IT DOESN'T TRACK. TWENTY
NINETEEN WAS BEFORE CODED BEFORE
EIGHT PROGRAMS ARE DISTRESSED
AND REMOTE SERVICES BEGIN PAYING
BEFORE SOCIAL RECREATION CAMPING
SERVICES PROFESSOR ACTED BEFORE
WE NEED A MINIMUM WAGE SETTING
WOULD BE. OUT WE ALL MESSED
TWENTY NINETEEN BUT IF WE HAVE
LIVE IN THIS. RATE STEADY HOW TO
BE DRY HERE TO. BUT A BREAK THAT
TO REFLECT OF THE- CHANGES THAT
SEEN. INTO IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
. THAT BRINGS US THE MOST
IMPORTANT EIGHT WE CAN ALL.
RIGHT STUDY WAS BASED ON THE
ASSUMPTION THAT PROVIDERS
CONTINUE TO BE CALLED ON TO BE
RESTORED. FOR BOB CHANGING OUT
TO. WHEN THE RATE INCREASE ARE
DONE WE NEED AND BRAKES AND ONE
THAT'S REAL AND THEN PARADIGM WE
MOVING TOWARD A ONE FINDER TO
PEYTON JUST FOR THE RIGHT NOW
BUT CERTAIN THEY PROVIDE BUT
ALSO THE QUALITY AND THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE WORK THAT THEY
DO. IN THAT SENSE. YOU GET WHAT
YOU PAY. WHAT IT LOOK LIKE WHEN
WE START PAYING PROVIDERS BRIDGE
COMES MOST IMPORTANT TO PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. I
DON'T HAVE CHOICE AND CONTROL
OVER THEIR LIVES. FOR THEM TO BE
PART OF COMMUNITIES RECORD
CONDUCTED READING A LONG FOR
THEM TO HAVE A WAYS TO
CONTRIBUTE TO BE LAWFULLY
EMPLOYED. FOR MAKING SURE THE
MOST HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND PEOPLE OF
THE MOST INTENSE TO SUPPORT ME.
EQUAL ACCESS FOR ALL OF THESE
THINGS. CHANGING WHAT WOULD PAY
PROVIDERS FOR HAS SO MUCH POWER
AND POTENTIAL TO DRIVE REAL
CHANGE TO SHIP THE PRACTICES
NORMS AND EXPECTATIONS. JUST
LEAVE MANDATES TOP DOWN
DIRECTIVES ALLOWED FROM START
FOR THE KINDS OF OUTCOMES WANT
TO SEE. IT'S ONE OF WOULD BE
EASIER FOR PROVIDERS TO
PRIORITIZE THOSE OUTCOMES THAT'S
WHEN WE'LL HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT THIS HAPPENED AND
THAT IS WHEN WE'LL FINALLY START
BEING. QUALITY OUTCOMES
HAPPENING MORE AND MORE IN THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME FALL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WILL HURT
HERE FROM MARK MELANSON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LIVING
NETWORK. THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARK LANSING
EXECUTRIX OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LIVING NETWORK CC ON
THE STATEWIDE TRADE ORGANIZATION
WITH OVER ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
AGENCY PROVIDER MEMBERS LARGE
AND SMALL. ROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
SUPPORTED LIVING INDEPENDENT
LIVING EMPLOYMENT SO LET'S
DISTANCE AND RESPITE. THE IN
PERSON SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
PROVIDED IN THE COMMUNITY FACE
TO FACE THROUGHOUT THIS. ONGOING
PANDEMIC OCCURRED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC- WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO
RESPOND TO THE QUESTION HOW
COULD THE QUALITY INCENTIVE
PROGRAM FUNDED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET BE OPTIMIZED FOR SHORT
TRANSPARENCY IMPROVEMENT. WRITER
ACTOR AND GREATER EQUITY IN
SERVICE PROVISION. WE BELIEVE
THAT THE INCENTIVES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES WILL BE
TRANSFORMATIONAL IN DELIVERING
LANDMARK DATA DRIVEN. QUALITY
OUTCOME BASED SYSTEM FOR PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES CCL
AND NUMBER THREE HUNDRED PAGES
OF RESEARCH THAT SUPPORTS THE
WORK THAT WE HAVE BEEN FOCUSING
ON TO DEVELOP THIS PROJECT OVER
THE LAST THREE TO FIVE YEARS.
THE NATIONAL QUALITY FORUM IN
CUBA HAS INDICATED INTEREST AND
INTENT TO TRACK SUPPORT AND
POTENTIALLY WORK ALONGSIDE CCL
AND ON THE EVALUATION PROJECT.
AND U. S. AS INDICATED POSSIBLE
NATIONAL. IMPACTS ABOUT WORK
IT'S PRESENTED TO THEM. WE WERE
SO EXCITED TO SEE A ONE ONE FIVE
BY THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
THAT SPECIFICALLY NAMES YOU SEE
ALLEN AS THE CONTRACTOR THAT
WILL NOW ALLOW US TO BEGIN WORK
AHEAD OF US. CCOO AND IT'S
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY BUT SELF
ADVOCATES INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING
SERVICES AND THEIR FAMILIES. DDS
REGIONAL CENTERS STAKEHOLDER
WORKGROUPS AND PROVIDERS TO
ENSURE AN INTEGRATED AND
SEAMLESS APPROACH SIXTY
ARLINGTON IN DBS CAN NOW ENGAGE
OUR TEAMS OF SELF ADVOCATES
LEADING INNOVATORS. RESEARCHERS
AND INTERNATIONAL IDT EXPERTS TO
DEVELOP MANAGE AND OVERSEE. THE
AIDS PROJECT ROLLOUT. SO WHAT IS
THE PAY PROJECT A PROJECT INDICATORS OF QUALITY
AND MEASURABLE OUTCOMES.
DEVELOPED BY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LIVING NETWORK CAVE
PERSON CENTERED ADVOCACY VISION
AND EDUCATION WILL. DEVELOP A
CREDIBLE SYSTEM FOR MEASURING
SOCIAL SERVICE OUTCOMES THAT
DOES NOT CURRENTLY EXIST.
DEVELOP A SYSTEM DESIGNED TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF SERVICES
FOR PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES BY
MORE EFFICIENTLY USING STATE
RESOURCES. DEMONSTRATE THE FIRST
SET OF COMPREHENSIVE OUTCOME
DATA THIS SERVICE IS PROVIDED BY
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL CENTER
VENDORS. DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A
GROUNDBREAKING SERVICE QUALITY
INDICATOR SYSTEM THAT PRECISELY
MEASURES INDIVIDUAL OUTCOMES. IN
TRADE ALL STAKEHOLDERS ONE
PERSON CENTRED ACTIVE SUPPORTS
ANY CORRESPONDING INDICATOR OUT
COMPASSIONATE. IDENTIFY UNMET
SERVICE NEEDS FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR SUPPORT THE FIRST CULTURAL
PREFERENCES AND INDIVIDUALIZED
SUPPORT SERVICES. IMPROVE
ACCOUNTABILITY EQUITY AND
TRANSPARENCY AND SERVICE
OUTCOMES AND- UP CALIFORNIA
POLICYMAKERS BETTER EVALUATE
EXISTING AND FUTURE SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. THIS
PROJECT WILL BEGIN SELECT
REGIONAL CENTERS AND OF THE
BIRTH DETAILED PLAN TO SCALE
SYSTEM Y. Y. K. E. A PERSON
CENTRED. FOUNDATION FOR
IDENTIFYING WHAT IS QUALITY FOR
PERSONAL IBM THEIR FAMILIES WERE
RECEIVING SERVICES. EIGHT FOR
ADVOCACY ENSURING THAT ALWAYS
HAS A PEOPLE RECEIVING SERVICES
AND THEIR. FAMILIES ARE HEARD
AND RESPECTED. THE THIRD VISION
CALIFORNIA'S FOR THE- TELL WILL
BE THE NEXT PAYS A PROGRAM THAT
WILL TO THE COUNTRY'S. NATIONAL
ACT RECOGNIZE IN GLOW BIGGEST
OUT BASED MEASUREMENTS FOR IDPS
. AND HE FOR EDUCATION. WE'RE TO
QUALITY INDICATORS MEATPACKER.
IT OCCURS IN THE VERY POINT OF
INTERACTION BETWEEN A DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL WHEN THE
PERSON RECEIVING A SERVICE
THAT'S WITH THE JOURNEY OF
PERSONS OR QUALITY MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES BEGINS. DSP TRAINING IS
AN ESSENTIAL COMPONENT SUCCESS
OF A PROJECT ONE OPTIMIZER WORK
WE ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE NTDS TO
ALLOCATE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THE TRAINING DSP WORK FORCIBLE
PROVIDERS WHO PERSON CENTRED
ACTIVE SUPPORTS. EVERY MOMENT AS
POTENTIAL. WE WILL JUST TO
STRUGGLE TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUAL
WITH TEACH WHICH THEIR CHIU MY
LIFE AND- OUTCOMES WITHOUT
RECOGNIZING THE CHRONIC NEGLECT
OF THE WORKERS. AND TAKING
IMMEDIATE STEPS TO ATTRACT AND
RETAIN A WELL TRAINED AND
ADEQUATELY COMPENSATED
WORKFORCE. DSPS HAVE BEEN SO
CRITICAL IN KEEPING PEOPLE
HEALTHY SAFE AND IT HAS BEEN.
WELL WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE.
NINETY ONE TO FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR CARE TO BE. TO THE IN
HOME SUPPORT SERVICE WORKERS I
HSS IS THERE AN ELECTRICAL PART
OF THE NETWORK OF CARE FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU KEY. WORD
OF THE CHARACTER ANY PAYMENTS
FOR ONLY I. HSS WORKERS HAS
SPREAD AMONG THE DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL WORKFORCE NOW TO
KEEP UNITY. IT HAS LET THESE
CARE CLINIC WORKERS WONDERING
WHAT'S MY WORK IN WHERE'S MY
THANK YOU. WE STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO IMMEDIATELY RECOGNIZE THESE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WITH THE SAME
GRATITUDE. CECIL IS IN SUPPORT
OF THE ACCELERATION OF THE RATE
STUDY IMPLEMENTATION BUT THERE
MUST. BE WHICH AND STATUTES BUT
IN SHORT IS THAT THE FUNDING
ACTUALLY RESULTS IN AN INCREASE
TO BE THE CENTRAL WORKERS WAGES
AND BENEFITS AS OUTLINED IN THE
STUDIES ONLINE. NIGHTS HELLO
ACCOUNTABILITY- OUR CURRENT WORK
FORCE TO. DEPENDS ON IT WE ALSO
MUST NOT END IN THE WORK TOWARDS
. NOW AND NEW IN BUT SERVICE
GREAT MODEL MUST FIXED. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH GDS ON
THE RATE STUDY IMPLEMENTATION
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROJECT AS
WELL AS THE INITIATIVES THAT
WERE IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
BILINGUAL EIGHT DSP TRAINING AND
CAREER PATHS AND THE DEFINITION.
THESE WILL ALL BE CRITICAL STEPS
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO
BOLSTER THE WORKFORCE. THE
CEILING IS GRATEFUL WE LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
COLLABORATION WITH CBS AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY OUR
COMMUNITY- COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF. WITH HIM FOR C.
C. ONTAP PATCH THAT TESTIMONY ON
TODAY'S PANEL OF THE CAPITA
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. BUT STE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM MARK CLOUSE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF. THE SAN
DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER. THANK YOU
CHAIR A COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT. SOME INFORMATION THIS
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS MARK CLASS
I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER.
SENATOR REGIONAL CENTER SUPPORTS
AND SERVES OVER THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS. LIVING IN
SAN DIEGO AND IMPERIAL COUNTY X.
THE QUESTIONS THAT THAT WERE.
THAT I WAS ASKED TO ADDRESS OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES AND WORK
FORCE IN PURCHASE OF SERVICES
FOR INDIVIDUALS SERVE OUR FIRE
REGIONAL CENTER. THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE IS A LACK OF A
WORKFORCE THAT THAT IS THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE
FACING. OUR VENDORS ARE
PROVIDERS ARE FACING STAFFING
SHORTAGES AT THIS CRITICAL LEVEL
ARE LIMITING INDIVIDUALS
ABILITY. TO ACCESS MUCH NEEDED
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES. AN
EARLIER TEST AMERICA A COUPLE OF
THE PANELISTS MENTIONED- THAT
THIS WAS CAUSING SOME DISRUPTION
IN SERVICES OR OR AVAILABILITY
OF SERVICES I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE. IN MANY CASES THERE
ARE NOT DISRUPTIONS THERE ARE NO
SERVICES BEING PROVIDED BE
OPTIONS FOR FAMILIES DUE TO
PROVIDERS NOT HAVING ADEQUATE
STAFF. RESULTS IN NO SERVICES
BEING PROVIDED. YOU DON'T HAVE
EMPLOYEES YOU CAN'T PROVIDE
SERVICES YOU CAN'T PURCHASE
SERVICES. IT TOO MANY YEARS A
LOT OF THE DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS HAVE BEEN ROCKED
RELEGATED TO MINIMUM WAGE
EARNERS. ONLY SEEING INCREASES
WHEN THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE AND
PERCHED ATOP THE ADOPTION OF THE
WAKE MODELS WILL GO A LONG WAY.
IN MAKING. UP HOW DOES THE REEF
MODEL IMPLEMENTATION FIT AND
WHAT. CAN YOU RESPOND TO THE
NEEDS. EXPLORING THE RIGHT MODEL
IMPLEMENTATION BY A YEAR AS
YOU'VE HEARD FROM MOST PANELISTS
IS WRONG THE ONLY OPTION AT THIS
TIME THAT I SEE FROM FROM A
STAFFING PERSPECTIVE THE PRICES
IN OUR SYSTEM. AND WE REALLY
WANT TO HAVE CHOICE IN PERSON
CENTERED SERVICES WE NEED TO
INVEST IN THE WORK FORCE. A
REVIEW OR FIX AND NOT. EARLY
START RATES IOS RATE SAYS THIS
MISTER MELANSON MENTIONED. AND
OTHERS- NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED IT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED QUICKLY.
IF WE'RE TRULY GOING TO MAKE AN
IMPACT. IN FRONT LOADER
RESOURCES. WE REALLY NEED TO
START WITH PROBABLY EARLY START
SERVICE THIS HAS TO BE A
PRIORITY ON THE TO DO LIST.
WITHOUT THIS INVESTMENT THE
ACCELERATION OF THE GREAT MODEL
IMPLEMENTATION. MY FEAR IS THAT
PEOPLE'S DREAMS PEOPLE'S HOPES
THEIR BALLS AND CHOICES WILL NOT
HAPPEN. CHANGING THE RATE MODELS
IS CRITICAL AS I SAY WE NEED TO
DOUBLE UP OUR EFFORTS AND MOVE
BACK THAT REPORT. IN TERMS OF
QUALITY AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES. THE WORK
FINALLY BEING DONE BY DDS
QUALITY INCENTIVES WORKGROUP.
THANKS MISTER SURVISCOR AND
OTHERS THERE ARE OVER FORTY.
MEMBERS THE FIRST MEMBERS ON
THAT COMMITTEE- MR SAREK
ASSEMBLY MET WE MET ONCE A MONTH
WE ACTUALLY HAVE FIVE MEETINGS
AT FOUR MONTHS WE'VE DOUBLED UP
ON JANUARY THIRD WE SPENT A FULL
DAY TOGETHER- HAVING THESE
DIFFICULT DISCUSSIONS- WE NEED
TO REALIZE THAT THERE ARE REALLY
NO EASY FIX. MOST OUTCOMES- THIS
PATRICK MENTIONED DATA- THAT
THAT WAS NOT EASILY AVAILABLE
I'D SAY IN MANY CASES IT'S NOT A
IT'S NOT JUST USED TO IT IT'S
NOT EASILY AVAILABLE JUST NOT.
YEAH IN GETTING TO. DATA
COLLECTION. LOOKING AT BASED
LIGHTING DATA IS REALLY
ESSENTIAL OF REMEMBER TRULY
DEFINE WHAT QUALITY LOOKS LIKE.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE PARTNERSHIP- WHAT THE
PROVIDER COMMUNITY WHAT FAMILIES
WERE ADVOCATES WITH EDS THE
DEFINING WHAT OUR SERVICES LOOK
LIKE IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE SB ON. BEHALF OF
THE ANSWERED QUESTIONS THAT THE
- THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
WE WILL BEGIN WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO. YES THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THE INFORMATION
ON THE RITZ- THE INFORMATION I'M
SORRY THE IMPLEMENTATION BUT-
WHAT IS THE AMOUNT IT WOULD TAKE
TO ACCELERATE THESE- THESE
RATES- THE- THAT'S ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS. YES HI JIM KNIGHT
WITH THE DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES THAT MAY
INDICATE ENHANCE ITS REQUESTED
IN THE AGENDA WILL BE PROVIDING
THAT INFORMATION BY MARCH FOURTH
THE ESTIMATE NOT ONLY ACOSTA-
TIME FOR FEDERAL APPROVAL AS
WELL. DO YOU HAVE ANY BALLPARK
IDEA. I KNOW I'LL WAIT FOR THE
MARCH FOURTH BUT DO YOU HAVE ANY
BALLPARK I'M SURE YOU'VE BEEN
DOING SOME WORK ALREADY. I DON'T
HAVE THAT RIGHT NOW. BUT WE WILL
CERTAINLY PROVIDED BY MARCH
FOURTH AT THE LATEST. ASSEMBLY
WOMAN IF IT'S POSSIBLE I CAN
POSSIBLY PROVIDE A BALLPARK- I
THINK IT WAS A PART OF THE MUCH
MORE DESCRIPTIVE IN MUCH MORE
DETAIL- FOR JUST A ONE YEAR-
ACCELERATION PROJECT JULY
TWENTY. TWENTY THREE TO JULY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE ESTIMATE
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS AT ONE TIME
INVESTMENT. THANK YOU. I WILL
BRING AMOUNT TO THE CHAIR AND-
BEGIN MY QUESTIONS BY UPLIFTING
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT I'VE
HEARD TODAY THAT FOR US TO
ACHIEVE QUALITY OUTCOMES WE NEED
A QUALITY WORKFORCE WHICH
REQUIRES US TO HAVE AN ADEQUATE
SUPPLY TO MEET THE NEEDS IN A
CULTURAL AND LINGUISTICALLY
COMPETENT PERSON CENTERED WAY
INSIDE LIKE TO DIG IN A LITTLE
BIT TO SOME OF THESE OUTCOMES
AND THE IT SYSTEMS THAT WILL
NEED TO BE DEVELOPED AND- WOOD
LOCKED LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON THE
QUESTION FROM THE L. A. O. ABOUT
THE PROCESS OF ENGAGEMENT ON.
THE THIS I. T. SYSTEM AS WELL AS
TO HEAR FROM- BOTH SERVING GO
AND MARK MELANSON. ABOUT HOW DO
WE HOW DO WE- HOW CAN WE
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THIS PRIOR TO
COLLECTION OF. DATA AND BASED ON
DATA AND- START UP OF THIS IT
SYSTEM AND START TO HAPPEN THERE. HI THIS IS MARK WILL INSTANTLY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LOOKING AT
WORK I DON'T WANT TO JUMP IN
FRONT OF PEOPLE- YOU KNOW I GO
BACK TO THE FIRST STAKEHOLDER
MEETING THAT WE HAD WITH TVS ON
QUALITY INCENTIVES HANDS ON
MARCO ONE OF THE FIRST MEETING
SAMMARCO FROM CHS JOINED AND
SAID YOU KNOW HOW- ON WE'VE GOT
TO START SOMEWHERE. YOU KNOW OUR
X. WE EXPECT TO COURSE CORRECT
ALONG THE WAY- AS DEVELOPED AS
AS OUTCOMES AND MEASURES ARE
DEVELOPED- AND I'M I'M NOT GONNA
SPEAK TO THE TECHNOLOGY AND DATA
SYSTEM THAT'S NOT MY WHEELHOUSE-
BUT- WE'VE GOT TO START
SOMEWHERE- AND I JUST I'VE HEARD
THAT ECHOED- IN THE CAPITAL AS
WELL SO THAT THAT WOULD BE MY
COMMENTS. TO THAT QUESTION
COMMONWEALTH'S IF KEEP WANTS. TO
FOLLOW UP. THERE ARE SO YOU KNOW
I MEAN FIRST ATTY COMBO. OF IS
THAT THE OTHER DAY. THAT I GAVE
YOU A SITE THAT THE- WE ACTUALLY
HAVE MEASURES LIKE A- TO
DEPARTMENT OR- A COUPLE OF
STRANGE. HAVING JUST SAID THAT-
I THINK. IT'S A FAIRLY LONG-
EXPECTATION THAT SOMETHING
AROUND WORKFORCE THE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY DELIVERING THE SERVICE.
WOULD CONTRIBUTE TO THE QUALITY
OF. THAT OUTCOME FOR THE AT THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL BUT WE'RE ALL
SEEKING TO ACHIEVE SO. I THINK
SUBJECT MATTER WISE IT'S
CERTAINLY GOING TO BE INCLUDED-
I THINK YOU WOULD BE HAPPY TO BE
HERE PERHAPS THAT. COLLECTION OF
DATA ABOUT THE WORK FORCE CAN BE
SOMEWHAT SEPARATED FROM THE I.
T. SYSTEM. OF THE STATE OR
NATIONALLY. OUR THE DEPARTMENT
IS- ENGAGED AT MOMENT WITH-
VARIETY OF. COLLECTING INPUT
REGARD A S. OF STOPS THE BILL-
WERE. THE OPERA. THAT EXISTS TO
USE- THE NATIONAL CORE
INDICATORS YOUR MODEL FOR THIS
PURPOSE- IT'S- THAT MATCH CORN
WE ARGUES FOR THEIR SURVEYS IN
CALIFORNIA SERVING INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES ARE DARK GUARDIANS- AND
ADULTS. AND THEY HAVE A MODEL
AVAILABLE THAT'S USED BY MANY
OTHER STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY-
TO LOOK AT STAFF STABILITY SO
THIS IS KIND OF WHAT YOU WOULD
EXPECT RIGHT TURN OVER RATES
COMPENSATION LEVELS. ON THE BACK
BENEFIT AMOUNTS AVERAGE TENURE
OF THOSE KINDS OF THINGS- SO WE
ARE HOPEFUL AND EXPECTING TO BE
ABLE TO LAUNCH THAT IN THE
SPRING THIS YEAR- THE NATIONAL
SURVEY CLOSURE DATE IS AT THE
END OF JUNE- I'M SO WE WOULD BE
WE WOULD BE COLLECTING NOT NOT
NOT THROUGH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I G. SYSTEM AND
PROJECT BUT RATHER THROUGH THE
NATIONAL SURVEYING- INSTRUMENT-
THAT WAY THAT'S A SURVEY THIS
COMPLETED BY. ARE THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND VENDORS- THAT-
EMPLOYEE DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS SO IT'S ALSO ONLY
A SLICE OF THE WORK FORCE BUT
THE VERY IMPORTANT SLICE THAT
DIRECTLY- ENGAGES WITH
CONSUMERS- AND SO WE ARE NOT BE
THE FIRST TIME THAT CALIFORNIA
WOULD DO THAT SURVEY- IT'S- AT
LEAST CURRENTLY ENVISIONED AS A
VOLUNTARY SURVEY- AND- AS SUCH
YOU KNOW WE REALLY WANT FOLKS
TO. HELP US SEE THE VALUE. IN IN
PROVIDING THIS INFORMATION- YOU
KNOWAND ASSURANCES THAT YOU
KNOW IT WOULDN'T BE PUBLICLY
RELEASED AT THE INDIVIDUAL
PROVIDER LEVEL MAY HELP THE
RESPONSE RATE FOR THIS IS REALLY
CRITICAL WE THANK- THE SURVEY
AND THAT THAT'S DONE NATIONALLY
OF COURSES AFTER THE YEAR- IS
CLOSED OF THIS SURVEY THAT WE
WOULD BE DURING THE SPRING WOULD
BE FOR CALENDAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. WE THINK IT'S ALSO TIMELY
FOR THE VERY REASON THAT AS WE
IMPLEMENT RATE ADJUSTMENTS
CALENDAR TWENTY TWO WILL HAVE
SOME BASELINE DATA ABOUT THAT EX
AND SOME WAGES IN IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND SO YOU CAN GO BY
TOPIC AND SEE THAT THAT WOULD BE
REALLY VALUABLE. I THINK THEY'RE
VERY SHORT. THAT MR CHARTER
YOU'RE- IS. THE I G. SYSTEM
NECESSARILY. HAVE TO GET IN THE
WAY OF COLLECTING SOME DATA
TODAY- AND THAT THIRD PARTY
PERSPECTIVE THAT I MENTIONED TO
OF FINDING OUT YOU KNOW THE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE. CONSUMER
EXPERIENCE THE INDIVIDUAL A
FAMILY EXPERIENCE. WHAT WITH THE
DIRECTOR PROFESSIONALS AND
SERVICE COORDINATORS AND SO
FORTH- IS ALSO SUBJECT TO- THOSE
OTHER AND SEE OUR MODULES THAT I
REFERRED TO EARLIER- A COUPLE
MINUTES AGO SO. THERE ARE THINGS
THAT CAN BE DONE OUTSIDE OF THE
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM ITSELF.
BUT I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS FIRMLY COMMITTED
TO TAKING A WHAT I'LL CALL A
WHOLE PERSON VIEW. OUR ENTER THE
EXTENT OF THE PEOPLE ENGAGING
WHERE FOR MANAGING THE CASE OF
ARE THE PEOPLE THAT WERE
PROVIDING SERVICES TO- IT'S
REALLY NICE OF ALL OF THIS COULD
BE THOUGHTFULLY WHILE TIED
TOGETHER. SO EVEN THE SURVEY
DATA AND INDIVIDUAL SURVEY DATA
YOU CAN SEE THAT THIS WILL BEGIN
TO ITERATE AND AFTER COULD BE
CAPTURED IN A CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM AND WE WOULD ACTUALLY
KNOW HOW PEOPLE ARE FEELING.
ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE GETTING. YOU
COULD SEE IMMEDIATELY WHETHER
WOULD BE BENEFIT TO THAT SO
SHORT TERM OPPORTUNITIES LONG
TERM GOAL. AND LOTS OF WORK IN
THE MIDDLE AND REALLY AGAIN
GRATEFUL FOR THE PARTNERSHIPS.
THAT ARE GOING TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN. I THANK I THINK ALONG
THOSE LINES WITH FROM WHEN THAT
THE GREAT AND OP. AND I AND I
WILL SHARE AN APPRECIATION WITH
THIS ADMINISTRATION TO FULLY
FUNDING THE RATE STUDY. IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET BUT HIS COMMENT IS
THAT HE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT THE
PRESENT. AND I THINK WE HEARD
FROM A NUMBER OF- FRONTLINE.
PARENTS AND- EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS
OF REGIONAL CENTERS ABOUT WHAT
TODAY LOOKS LIKE- JUDY MARKS
WORDS WERE THAT SHE HAS TO FIGHT
TO GET SERVICES. FROM MARC CLAUS
WE HEARD THAT THERE ARE NOT
DISRUPTIONS THAT THERE ARE NOT
SERVICES. AND I'M CONCERNED THAT
WHILE WE ALL ARE APPRECIATIVE OF
WHERE WE WELL AS AS YOU SAID. NO
WE'RE WE'RE GETTING TO AT THE
END OF THE ROAD FOR SOME OF OUR
FAMILIES WE CAN'T GET THERE FAST
ENOUGH. AND WE'RE NOT GETTING
THE SERVICES TODAY AND I BELIEVE
THAT'S THE REAL- IMPETUS FOR US
TO LOOK TOWARDS ADVANCING THIS
RATE STUDY AND FIGURING OUT WHAT
IS POSSIBLE AND SO I WILL COME
BACK TO MY INITIAL COMMENTS BUT
WOULD LOVE TO- FIGURE OUT IF
THIS CAN BE ACCELERATED AND THEN
FOR US TO EVALUATE WHETHER IT
SHOULD BE XCELERATED IS THE
SECOND QUESTION BUT BUT I DO
WANT TO COME BACK TO ONE FINAL
QUESTION BEFORE WE MOVE ON WHICH
IS- THIS WAS A POINT IN TIME FOR
THE RATE STUDY AND WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THE ADMINISTRATION WHETHER
THEY THINK OF FUTURE RATE STUDY
WILL BE WARRANTED AFTER THE
COMPLETION. OF THE INCREASE THAT
WE'RE SPEAKING ABOUT AND WHETHER
OF REGULAR- RETURN TO THIS IS
ALSO SOMETHING THAT- THEY
BELIEVE IS NECESSARY FOR US TO
KEEP UP TO DATE- WITH THOSE
PROVIDER RATE. YEAH YOU CHAIR
JIM KNIGHT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
DEPRECIATE THE QUESTION AND YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE COMMENTS ABOUT
LOOKING AT THE SERVICES THAT MAY
BE CHANGED AND CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH THAT- DURING DURING COVERT
NINETEEN AND THAT WE MAY WANT TO
LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE CHANGES
CARING FOR WORK SO TO THAT
EXTENT AND WHEN WE DID JUST TAKE
A STEP BACK THE RATE STUDY
LOOKED AT SERVICES IN THE
REQUIREMENT FOR SERVICES AS THEY
EXISTED AT THAT POINT. IN AND
MADE SOME COST ASSUMPTIONS THE
BUILT MODELS BASED ON THOSE-
THOSE REQUIREMENTS. WE WOULD OF
LOOK AT IF WE'RE GOING TO DO
SOMETHING NEW LOOK AT WHAT IS
THE NEW REQUIREMENTS OR NEW
SERVICE STRUCTURE THAT WE WANT
TO BUILD A MODEL FOR IF YOU
WILL. AND IN THAT WE CAN WORK
FROM THERE. AS FAR AS REGULAR
REVIEW- CERTAINLY OPENS UP THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT MAKES
SENSE WHETHER IT BE A RATE
STUDY. A REVIEW OF THE
AVAILABILITY OF PROVIDERS ACCESS
AND THOSE TYPES OF THINGS THAT
ARE REQUIRED ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. TO THEN SEE WHAT WOULD BE
NECESSARY AND WHAT. ACTIONS WE
SHOULD TAKE. ON A REGULAR BASIS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. I APPRECIATE
THE I AYE- I WILL REPEAT AGAIN
WHAT JORDAN LINDSAY HAD SAID
ABOUT THE CUTE STAFFING SHORTAGE
TODAY THAT THERE ARE CURRENTLY
TWO THOUSAND JOB OPENINGS AND A
TWENTY PERCENT. DECREASE FROM
PRE PANDEMIC TIMES IT'S THOSE
TYPES OF FIGURES THAT REALLY-
SHOULD ALLOW US TO LEAN IN. AND
FIGURE OUT HOW TO. ADVANCE THIS
RATE STUDY- AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
AGAIN WILL. APPRECIATE THE
WILLINGNESS TO. ENTER INTO THESE
CONVERSATIONS. WITH THAT WE
WILL. MOVE ON I WILL THANK ALL
OF THE PANELISTS ON CHANNEL FIVE
AND WE WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUES
SIX. WHICH IS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION REVIEW AND
OVERSIGHT OF DISPARITIES WITHIN
THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
SYSTEMS. AND STRATEGIES TOWARD
EQUITY. WE WILL HAVE SEVEN
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL WE WILL
BEGIN WITH CARLA CAST. INTO
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR DDS.
WE WILL THEN HAVE BRIAN WINFIELD
FOLLOWED BY CHRISTOPHER ODD NEIL
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SONYA
PADDOCK WITH THE L. A. HELLO.
BILL THE GEAR ON THE DIRECTOR OF
OUTREACH AND LEADERSHIP TRAINING
WITH DISABILITY VOICES UNITED.
FOLLOWED BY ANDY AND PARRADO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
AND MICI A GATE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CURRENT
REGIONAL CENTER. LET US PLEASE
BEGIN. WITH MISS CASTANEDA WITH
THE DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IN JUST TO DOUBLE CHECK-
HAVE YOU MOVED TO ISSUE SEVEN.
SIX HUNDRED HOLDERS AND MOST.
THIS. I WILL USE THE CORRECT
GUIDE HERE- ISSUE SIX INSTRUCTOR
BARGE MAN LYING ON THE WALTER-
DOCTOR VICKY LOVELL- CHRISTOPHER
AUDIO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
THE PADDOCK WITH DELEO LIZABETH
GOMEZ DIRECTOR OF THE INTEGRATED
COMMUNITY COLLABORATIVE AND AMY
WEST PLAYING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR ARCA. LIST PLEASE BEGIN WITH
DRUG DEPARTMENT. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NANCY PARCHMENT
DIRECTOR DDS- WE HAD AS A
DEPARTMENT AND WORKING WITH- OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS OUR FAMILIES-
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICE
PROVIDERS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS. TO ADDRESS THE
DISPARITIES AND SERVICE ACCESS
AND- QUITY AND OUR SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM- I AM EXTREMELY
PROUD OF THE PARTNERSHIP THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO FORM- TO
REALLY THINK THROUGH WHAT ARE
THE ISSUES THE BARRIERS WHAT'S
THAT. THAT DRIVERS TO-
CHALLENGES THAT FAMILIES- ARE
FACING THOSE WHO. MAY NOT SPEAK
ENGLISH OR THOSE FROM
COMMUNITIES THAT- ARE NOT AS
COMFORTABLE- FOR VARIOUS REASONS
OF ACCESSING SERVICES OR HAVE
HELPING THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND
OTHERS UNDERSTAND HOW TO BEST.
I'M REALLY MEET PEOPLE WHERE
THEY ARE TO ENSURE THAT WERE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES-
WE HAVE BEEN BUILDING ON-
DIFFERENT INITIATIVES OVER A
NUMBER OF YEARS- TO REALLY
EXPLORE WHAT ARE THOSE.
STRATEGIES INTERVENTIONS AND
CURRENT ADDRESSING THE BARRIERS
AND REALLY INTERRUPTING- SOME OF
THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES THAT WERE
SEEN WE STILL HAVE A WAYS TO GO-
AND THAT'S WHY YOU'LL SEE THAT
IT'S- WE HAVE CONTINUED
PROPOSALS. AND ARE. DESPITE TO
BILL ON I KNOW OF THE INITIAL
THE WE PUT FORWARD- LAST YEAR
THAT- WE'RE FINDING IS THERE
FOR- FROM BUDGET OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- ON PAGE THIRTY NINE
I BELIEVE IT IS ON PAGE THIRTY
NINE THE SUMMARY OF THE
DIFFERENT INITIATIVES I'LL JUST
POINT OUT NINE OF THOSE
INITIATIVES- JUSTIN IN THIS LAST
YEAR REALLY WERE CENTERED AROUND
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM THE COMMUNITY TO THINK
THROUGH HOW DO WE REACH INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND STARTED DRESSING-
THE CONTINUED ISSUES THAT WE'RE
FACING-SO MANY INEQUITIES AND-
BUT THAT WE'RE FACING IN OUR
SYSTEM OUR OUR MULTI PRONGED-
WE'RE- WE'RE FACING SOME
INEQUITIES TO THOSE WHO ARE
ACCESSING SERVICES. I'M STILL
COMING IN THROUGH THE FRONT DOOR
FOR ASSESSMENT AND SERVICES- AND
SOME OF THE INITIATIVES TO
ADDRESS- THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE
BURKE THE PROFESSIONAL
ELIGIBILITY THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
PUT FORWARD FOR THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS- BEING ABLE TO-
SUPPORT THE LOW TO NO PURCHASE A
SERVICE AND OUR CURRENT PROPOSAL
IS AN EXAMPLE OF- THAT WE TALKED
ON ISSUE TOO WITH REDUCING
CASELOAD RATIOS- NOT TO MENTION
SOME OF THE NAVIGATOR AND OTHER
INITIATIVES- WE ALSO ARE SEEING
AN EQUITY OF SPENDING AND ACCESS. OF UTILIZATION OF SERVICES. I
SO WE HAVE NO OF A PROPOSED FROM
FOR- END OF. HER LIVING IN THE
HOME SO WE HAVE PER. THAT ARE-
UNFAIR MARC- RIGHT NOW TO
SUPPORT- THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND
SO LAST YEAR WE HAD- THIRTY TO
BE ABLE TO START DEVELOPING A
PILOT PROJECT. THAT IS SIMILAR
TO SUPPORTIVE LIVING SERVICES TO
BE ABLE TO- IT STARTED DRESSING
THOSE ISSUES- AND THEN JUST
LASTLY I'LL JUST NOTE THAT YOU
KNOW WE JUST HAD A REALLY GOOD
DISCUSSION. ON THE RATE
IMPLEMENTATION AND- REALLY
STANDARDIZING THOSE RATES WAS
ADDRESSING SEVEN EQUITY- RATES
BETWEEN DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS THAT WE HAVE. PARTICULARLY
IN COMPARISON OF NEIGHBORING
REGIONAL CENTERS- SO WEAK WE DO
LOOK FORWARD FOR THAT CONTINUED
WORK- I WAS ASKED- IN ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS HERE IS THAT- IT. YES
SEEKING ADVICE FROM OTHER
STATES- WHO CAN SUCCESSFUL IN
THIS AREA. YOU KNOW WE ARE
ALWAYS OPEN AND MY COUNTERPARTS
IN OTHER STATES WE DO MEET AND
DISCUSS IMPORTANT ISSUES AND
SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY AS
ONE. CALIFORNIA'S ENTERED INTO A
COMMUNITY OF PRACTICE WITH
GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY ABOUT FIVE
YEARS AGO TO ADDRESS. CULTURAL
LINGUISTIC COMPETENCY. WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO REALLY THE MANY OF
THE PROPOSED IN A- AROUND THAT.
OF THAT SAD I WILL SAY THAT- DUE
TO THE SUPPORTED- THE
LEGISLATURE OUR COMMUNITY AND-
THE INITIATIVES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BEEN ABLE TO
PUT FORWARD. I'M WE ARE OFTEN
SOUGHT BY OTHER STATES TO
UNDERSTAND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE DOING AS- IN THIS
AREA- WE ARE WE ARE VIEWED. AS A
LEADER- IN ADDRESSING AND
PUTTING FORWARD IDEAS WE'RE ONE
OF THE FIRST STATES TO PUT
FORWARD- MAKING SURE THAT WE HAD
A SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY TALK
AND- BRANCH AT THE DEPARTMENT AS
WELL AS- PUSHING DOWN SUPPORTS
OF THE REGIONAL CENTER LEVEL-
BUT THEN THE COMMUNITY- BUT
AGAIN WE ALWAYS HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LESSONS
LEARNED THERE'S PEARLS OUT THERE
THAT OTHER STATES ARE DOING THAT
WE CONTINUE TO REMAIN OPEN. AND
WANT TO LEARN FROM THOSE BEST
PRACTICES AS WELL AS CHERRY NOSE
WITH OUR COMMUNITY SO I'LL PAUSE
THERE AND- TURN TO MY COLLEAGUES
TO. ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL I'M QUESTIONS AND I
BELIEVE WE HAVE PLAYED NINETY
WALTER ASSISTANT DEPUTY WHO'S
GOING TO DO THAT. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOT A WALTER
ASSISTANT DEPUTY OF SERVICE
ACCESS AND EQUITY. I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO SHARE
WITH YOU SOME OF THE
DISBURSEMENTS. STRATEGIES. AND
INITIATIVES TOWARDS EQUITY. DO
IS TAKEN A MORE PRONGED APPROACH
TO REDUCE DISK. BY FIRST BILL.
AND CONTINUING TO BUILD TRUST
WITH DIVERSE COMMUNITIES. SERVED
IN OUR SYSTEM AND LOOKING AT AT
THE HEART OF OUR INITIATIVES
HAVE BEEN THAT ENGAGEMENT. IN
ADDITION TO THE ELEVEN MILLION
ANNUALLY IN OUR SERVICE ACCESS
pIMPLEMENTED SOME KEY STRATEGIES
TO REDUCE THESE DISPARITIES.
FIRST EXPANDING COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT WITHIN THE LAST TWO
YEARS. WE HAVE FOCUSED ON
EFFORTS OF DEEP LISTENING TO
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES ESTABLISHING THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN FOCUS GROUP. IN
RECOGNITION THAT WE HAD LACK OF
REPRESENTATION HONORED YES TASK
FORCE THIS MONTH WE CAN GAUGE
MEANT HAS INVOLVES HAS INVOLVED
INTO MEANINGFUL CONVERSATIONS
WITH AFRICAN AMERICAN PARENT
LEADERS FAMILY MEMBERS CDOS AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS. IT'S BEEN AN
INVALUABLE OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
HEAR DIRECTLY FROM COMMUNITY.
CREATING NEW PARTNERSHIPS
STATEWIDE WITH THEIR NATIVE
AMERICAN LEADERS WITH INVESTMENT
IN PRIVATE COMMUNITIES TO
ESTABLISH MEANINGFUL CONNECTIONS
WITHIN THE REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM TO PRODUCE CULTURALLY
RELEVANT PROGRAMMING JARRIEL'S
WITH A FOCUS ON EARLY START TO
RETURN TRAVEL COMMUNITIES. AND
THIRD HOSTING CBO MEETINGS IT
BEGAN A FEW YEARS AGO WITH MAYBE
TWENTY EIGHT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. MEETING ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS THAT HAS GROWN
OUT TO OVER SIXTY COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS MEETING MONTHLY
SHARING STRATEGIES THEIR
STRATEGIES. PROVING EQUITY IN
OUR SYSTEM. LISTENING GOES BOTH
WAYS THESE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO CHEER AND ALSO
TO LEARN. R. CBO'S REFLECT
CALIFORNIA'S RICH DIVERSITY WITH
A FOCUS OF OVER EIGHTEEN
ETHNICITIES REPRESENTED WITH A
FOCUS OF LANGUAGES FOURTEEN PLUS
LANGUAGES ARE REPRESENTED ON
THIS MONTHLY CALL. ANOTHER
STRATEGY THE DEPARTMENT IS
FOCUSED ON IS DEVELOPING
CULTURALLY COMPETENT AND
FLEXIBLE SERVICE MODELS. THIS IS
AN EXAMPLE WOULD BE COORDINATED
FAMILY SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE IN MULTI
GENERATIONAL HOMES AND PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL SERVICES BEYOND
BREAST THERE. OF COURSE A LOT
HAS BEEN SPOKEN ABOUT- WORKFORCE
EXPANDING OUR WORK FORCE WITH AN
EXAMPLE WOULD BE PILING A
BILINGUAL KEY DIFFERENTIALS. BUT
THIS ALSO EXPERIENCE INDIVIDUAL
CHOICE SO NOT ONLY ARE WE
EXPANDING THE WORKFORCE BUT
WE'RE ALSO ENSURING THAT
FAMILIES HAVE MORE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMUNICATE AND WORK WITH THE
SERVICE PROVIDER THAT MEETS
THEIR BOTH CULTURAL AND LANGUAGE
NEEDS. THIRD STRAIGHTENING
TRUSTED PARTNERSHIPS
IMPLEMENTING PROJECTS BACK ON
NOW NEW PROGRAMS LIKE THE
COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR PROGRAM
PARTNERING WITH FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTERS TO IMPLEMENT A PROJECT
STATEWIDE. IS AN IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF OUR SYSTEM ENHANCE
SERVICE COORDINATION ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO TAKE WHAT
OCCURRED OR HAS BEEN DEVELOPED
IN OUR SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY
GRANT PROGRAM TO BE AFFECTIVE
STATEWIDE MODEL. AND FOR
EXPANDING LANGUAGE ACCESS POINTS
MULTI LINGUAL POLICY BUDGET AND
GRANT BRIEFINGS AB HELPED TO
RAISE UP DIVERSE VOICES IN OUR
SYSTEM TO ALSO RAISE AWARENESS
IN NATIVE LANGUAGE. MOST
RECENTLY IN THE DEPARTMENT HAD
HOSTED BOTH A VIRTUAL POLICY
BRIEFING AS WELL AS A BIGGER
CONFERENCE CENTER GRANT PROGRAM
. ENTIRELY IN SPANISH THIS WAS
THE FIRST TIME THAT OCCURRED IN
OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ATTENDEES ATTENDED BACK
CONFERENCE ALONG. WE'VE SEEN A
SHIFT IN THE PAST FEW YEARS
TOWARDS A HEIGHTENED AWARENESS
OF SYSTEMIC RACISM AND
STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES IN OUR
SOCIETY ALONG WITH A STARK
ADVANCEMENTS IN STATE AT THE
STATE LEVEL TO ADDRESS
UNDERLYING INEQUITIES. EDS IS
INVESTED IN SUSTAIN FOCUS ON
CLOSING THE GAPS AND BECOMING A
MORE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY COMPETENT SYSTEM.
BUTIT DOESN'T AND IN ONE MOMENT
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
AN ONGOING PROCESS THAT REQUIRES
LISTENING CLOSELY TO OUR DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES AND CONSISTENTLY AND
CONSTANTLY RE CALIBRATING AS WE
MOVE OUR SYSTEM TOWARDS. BEING A
MORE EQUITABLE SYSTEM FOR
EVERYONE WE SERVE. ANECDOTALLY
SOME OF THE FACTORS THAT MAY BE
CONTRIBUTING TO INEQUITIES ARE
BIASED BETTER BUILT INTO OUR
SYSTEM TOOLS AND PROCEDURES FOR
INTAKE INELIGIBILITY. AND EVEN
AT LINGUISTIC VARIATIONS IN
TRANSLATIONS RATHER THAN HOLDING
MEETINGS AND DISCUSSIONS AND
PRIMARY LANGUAGE. CONSISTENT
WITH THE AGENCY'S FOCUS OUTLINED
IN RECENT BUDGET RELEASED. THE
NEW OPPORTUNITIES PROVIDED IN
OUR BUDGET OUR INVESTMENTS IN
PROGRAMS AND EFFORTS THAT DEEP
AND ARE FOCUSED ON THE WHOLE
PERSON WITH THE HOPE OF
ADDRESSING INEQUITIES LAID BARE
BY THE PANDEMIC. IN OUR UPCOMING
EVALUATION THE DISPARITY GRANTS
OUR HOPE IS THAT WORKING WITH
GEORGETOWN WE WILL BE ABLE TO DO
A FEW THINGS. REFINE AND DEVELOP
OUR SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY
GRANT PROGRAM. WITHOUT HOPE OF
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE PROJECT
STATEWIDE THAT HAVE AFFECTED
OUTCOMES. THAT ARE HELP US TO
PRIORITIES PRIORITIZE WHAT SOME
OF THE POPULATIONS ACTIVITIES
ARE PROJECTS MAY BE INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION WILL ANALYZE THE
EXISTING GRANT PROGRAM BUT ALSO
HELP WITH RECOMMENDATIONS ON
QUANTITATIVE AND QUALITATIVE
MEASURES. INCLUDING METRICS AND
OTHER CONSIDERATIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT PRIORITIZE ACTIVITIES
AND POPULATIONS THAT GRANTEES
SHOULD FOCUS ON. EDS IS LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
GEORGETOWN NATIONAL CENTER OF
CULTURAL LINGUISTIC COMPETENCE
AND THE EXPERTISE THAT THEY
BRING TO THIS IMPORTANT WORK.
IMPROVING EQUITY IN OUR SYSTEM
REQUIRES ONGOING EFFORTS THAT
ARE PURPOSEFUL COLLABORATIVE
COMPREHENSIVE. AND FLEXIBLE DDS
IS COMMITTED TO BUILDING A MORE
EQUITABLE SYSTEM TO DEVELOP
POLICY THAT'S RESPONSIVE TO THE
DIVERSE NEEDS OF ALL OF THE
FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE. THANK
YOU NOT BE HAPPY TO TAKE FURTHER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM DOCTOR LOVELL. THANK
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR
ARAMBULA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
AM VICKY LOVELL CHIEF OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S RESEARCH EVALUATION
OF PRODUCTS BRANCH I WOULD TRUST
TO ACHIEVE IN THE AGENDA
REGARDING DISPARITIES. YES THE
CASHIER REGULAR TRACKING OF
BASIC MEASURES OF SERVICE EQUITY
WITH FIFTEEN SIXTEEN DATA. DATA
OR THE YEAR BEFORE THE SERVICE
ACCESS AND EQUITY GRANT PROGRAM
BEGAN. THIS ALLOWS US TO
IDENTIFY AREAS OF THE GREATEST
CHALLENGE IN ACCESSING SERVICES.
CAN BE REDUCED AND TO SEE THE
IMPACT OVER TIME OF ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENTS EQUITY PROJECTS.
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN
PERSON SURVEYS FOR THE NATIONAL
CORE INDICATORS PROJECT WE'RE
NOW COLLECTING DATA ON
INDIVIDUAL LOOKS VERY HANDSOME
SATISFACTION INDICATORS THAT CAN
BE ANALYZED BY ETHNICITY FOR
EACH REGIONAL CENTER. THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO TRYING TO
DISCREET ANALYSES TO INFORM
SANDERS STANDING OF DISPARITIES
IN SPECIFIC AREAS OVER TIME SUCH. AS ACCESS TO RESPITE SERVICES
. OR THE EXPERIENCE AS AMENDED
WHO ARE DEAF. REGISTER SERVICE
OR LAST ED CHAU PROGRESS TOWARD
EQUITY FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
ASIANS AND HISPANICS FROM
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FOR MOST AGE GROUPS
CONSUMERS FROM ASIAN COMMUNITIES
AGE THREE TO TWENTY ONE LIVING%
AT HOME ARE NOTABLE EXCEPTIONS
IN PROGRESS. AND DESPITE THIS
PROGRESS AVERAGE POS FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANINFANTS LAGGED BEHIND
BUT WHITES RECEIVE AN AVERAGE
PEOPLE ASK FOR HISPANIC ADULTS
LIING AT HOME IS APPROXIMATELY
10% LOWER THAN FOR WHITE. KING
OF THIS TREND WAS THE INCIDENTS
THE COORDINATED FAMILY SUPPORT
SERVICES PROJECT THE PROGRAM
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT DIRECTOR
BARGE AND MENTIONED. GAPS ALSO
NARROWED FROM FIFTEEN SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR MOST
STATEWIDE DISPARITY MEASURES
INCLUDING SERVICE FUNDING FOR
SUPPORTED INDEPENDENT LIVING AND
PARTICIPATION AND SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAMS. SOME
MEASURES THAT NOT SHOW
IMPROVEMENT ADAPTIVE SKILLS
TRAINING REMAINS A CHALLENGE.
AND EVEN REFUSED MEASURES
INDICATE PROGRESS TOWARD EQUITY
EQUALITY OF FUNDING WE ARE AWARE
THAT WE MAY STILL NEED TO
ENHANCE SERVICES THAT ARE
PREFERRED BY SOME ETHNIC
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- CHRISTOPHER
O'NEILL WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD
TO THE PRESENTATION. NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM SUNDAY PADDOCK
WITH THE L. L. AND THANK YOU
DOCTOR ARAMBULA I'M SEND YOU
PICK FROM THE L. A. O. YOU DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF COMMENTS TO ADD ON
THIS ISSUE THE- DEPARTMENT-
PROVIDED A LOT OF GREAT
INFORMATION JUST NOW- IN THEIR
TESTIMONY. I THINK ONE- POINTS
WE WOULD WANT TO MAKE LOOKING
AHEAD IS- WE AGREE WITH DR- I'M
SORRY WITH DIRECTOR BARGE MEANT
THAT A LOT OF NEW INITIATIVES
HAVE BEEN STARTED UP- REAL THAT
ARE SORT OF TARGETED TOWARD THIS
ISSUE OF EQUITY AND REDUCING
DISPARITIES IN THE SYSTEM
PARTICULARLY IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. I'M INCLUDING EVERYTHING
FROM COMMUNITY NAVIGATORS TO
REGIONAL CENTER IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAINING- SO- WE WOULD SUGGEST
AT MINIMUM CONSIDERATION OF
EVALUATING THE EFFECT OF THESE
RECENT EFFORTS ALONG WITH THE-
EVALUATION THAT DDS IS ALREADY
DOING. ON ITS- DISPARITIES
GRANTS- TO SORT OF SEE WHICH OF
THESE DIFFERENT EFFORTS-
ACTUALLY HAS AN EFFECT NOW A
CAUTIONARY NOTE IS THAT IT MAY
BE HARD BECAUSE- BECAUSE A LOT
IS BEING THROWN AT THE ISSUE- IT
MAYBE IT SORT OF DIFFICULT TO
DISCERN- YOU KNOW WHICH WHICH
EFFORTS ARE HAVING. THE DESIRED
EFFECT ON WHICH INDIVIDUALS AND
WHICH REGIONAL CENTERS BUT TO
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION CAN BE DISCERNED
IT'LL BE HELPFUL IN TARGETING
RESOURCES. TO THE EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT- POLICY INTERVENTIONS
AND- AS THE DEPARTMENT-
REPRESENTATIVES WERE TALKING ONE
QUESTION THAT CAME TO MY MIND IS
WHETHER THE STUDY THEY'RE DOING
WITH. GEORGETOWN ON THE
DISPARITY GRANTS COULD
POTENTIALLY BE EXPANDED TO
CONSIDER SOME OF THESE NEW
POLICY INTERVENTIONS THAT WERE.
INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM ELIZABETH
GOMEZ DIRECTOR OF THE INTEGRATED
COMMUNITY COLLABORATIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
TESTIMONY TODAY. MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH GOMEZ AND I AM THE
MOTHER OF TWO BOYS SERVE BY THE
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES. MY SON
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD HAS DOWN
SYNDROME I AM ALSO THE DIRECTOR
OF THE INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE. YEAH I C. C.
COMMUNITY IMPACT OTHER ORDERS
HER PARENTS AND SELF ADVOCATES
WHO HELP THEIR PEERS SPECIALLY
IN THE LATINO COMMUNITY. WE HELP
NAVIGATE THE COMPLEX REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM. WE USE ORGANIC
RELATIONSHIP BASED COMMUNITY
OUTREACH REALLY WORK OF
CULTIVATING TRUST. TRUST PLACED
IN US BY OUR COMMUNITY MY
TESTIMONY TODAY REFLECTS THAT
TRUST THAT TRUST OF OUR
COMMUNITY WHO IS SEEKING RESPECT
VALIDATION AND A FAIR
OPPORTUNITY TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. I FIRST WOULD LIKE TO
THANK. CORRECT APARTMENT FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THE GOOD
ALLOWING THE GUIDELINES THAT
COULD BE OPEN FOR PARENTS LIKE I
WON THE POINT TO GET OTHER
ORDERS TO BECOME PART OF THE
SOLUTION WE ARE REALLY GRATEFUL
FOR HER LEADERSHIP. OUR
ORGANIZATION IS ONE OF THE CBO
SCORE RECEIVED A GRANT FROM THE
S. TO HELP REDUCE RACIAL AND
ETHNIC DISPARITIES. WE HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT. IN HELPING
FAMILIES WITHIN THE ALLOCATED
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT WE HAVE
WORKED WITH IN THE LAST FOUR
YEARS. OUR EFFORTS ARE
MEASURABLE. CAPABLE AND CAN BE
REPLICATED YOU FOR ABLE TO
CONTINUE. RECENT DATA SHOWS THAT
IN ALL EXCEPT FOR OF THE
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT THE NOSE
RECEIVED AS THAN HALF THE AMOUNT
OF SERVICES THAT WHAT FAMILIES
GET. DISPARITIES EXIST EVEN WHEN
I KNOW THE SYSTEM COMPARES WHITE
AND LATINO ADULTS LIVING AT HOME
. AT THE ICC DISPARITIES ARE
JUST THAT THE SIX WE ARE IN C.
HUMAN FACES BEHIND THOSE NUMBERS
. IN THE PAST WE HAVE COME TO
THESE HEARINGS YEAR AFTER YEAR
WITH THE STORIES OF PEOPLE WHO
IN ADDITION TO DISPARITIES IN
ACCESSING SERVICES ALSO FACE
INTIMIDATION RETALIATION FOR
JUST SHOWING HERE AND TESTIFYING
. I'M HERE TODAY. TO SHARE WITH
YOU PERSPECTIVE AND LIVED
EXPERIENCE OF PARENTS. LEADING
ORGANIZATION THAT IS FROM THE
COMMUNITY THAT FACES DISPARITIES
EVERYDAY. HERE ARE VERY SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW THE
STATE SHOULD RESPOND IN A
CONCRETE WAY TO REDUCE RACIAL
AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES.
RECOMMENDED AN EQUITY PLAN OF
ACTION WE WOULD LIKE TO SUGGEST
THAT ANY PLANS THAT ARE
DEVELOPED MUST THINK YOU FROM
THE BEGINNING AND AT EVERY LEVEL
. EVERY STEP OF THE WAY COMPLETE
INVOLVEMENT OF THE PEOPLE
AFFECTED BY THIS DISPARITIES.
PLEASE DO NOT MAKE ALL THE
DECISIONS AND THEN ASK US FOR A
POINT OF VIEW. WE NEED TO
CONNECT THE SYSTEM TO THE
COMMUNITY IT SERVES. WITH
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE SYSTEM LACKS EMPATHY. AND IS
SET ON COMPLIANCE IS SUPPOSED TO
PERSON CENTER OUTCOMES. WHEN THE
FAMILY COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE WAY
THEY ARE TREATED BY A REGIONAL
CENTER STAFF IT NEEDS TO BE
TAKEN SERIOUSLY. IF THE PARENTS
SAID THAT THEY WERE INTIMIDATED
OR RETALIATED AGAINST SOMETHING
MUST BE DONE INSTEAD OF BLAMING.
THE PARENTS WERE SPEAKING UP FOR
THEMSELVES OR MAKING IT THEIR
FAULT. THERE NEEDS TO BE
ACKNOWLEDGED MEMBER THE REGIONAL
CENTERS THAT DISPARITIES STILL
EXIST INSTEAD OF MAKING EXCUSES
WE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER TO
BRING ABOUT RESOLUTIONS.
REGIONAL CENTERS. SHOULDN'T SEE
GROUPS LIKE OURS AS PARTNERS NOT
ENEMIES. ARE YOU ARE VOICE AND
TELL US WHAT WE SHOULD NOT SAY
WORK WITH US AS EQUALS. WE NEED
TO ENGAGE IN CONTINUE TO FIND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE THE
TRUST OF THE COMMUNITY AND NOT
RELY ON HIRING SOME MORE
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF THAT
QUICKLY BECOME PART OF THE
EXISTING CULTURE. AND RE
PERCEIVED AS THE EXTENSION OF
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM.
EVALUATION SHOULD BE DONE OF ALL
FUNDED PROGRAMS INCLUDING
REGIONAL CENTER PROGRAMS NOT
JUST THE PARENT TO PARENT YOUR
PROGRAMS TO SEE WHETHER THE
DISPARITY FUNDS ARE BEING WELL
SPENT. PLEASE REFORM BE UNFAIR
HIRE LAWYERS IN HEARING
SPECIALIST. ON TAXPAYER DOLLARS
TO FIGHT US. WHEN ALL WE'RE
ASKING FOR SERVICES FOR A
DISABLED CHILD. AND WE HAD NO
13% LAST. DON'T COUNT ON
IMPLICIT BIAS AND CULTURAL
COMPETENCY TRAINING TO MAKE THE
DENTON DISPARITIES. IN BALANCE
OF POWER BETWEEN THE REGIONAL
CENTER SOME FAMILIES MUST BE
CORRECTED FIRST. WE ARE SAD OUR
COMMUNITY IS THIS SUPPORT
ROBERTS AT THE SUFFERING FROM IT
AND THEN MAKE. AND WE APPRECIATE
THE DIRECTIVES. HOWEVER THEY
ONLY GAVE MORE POWER TO REGIONAL
CENTERS AND MAKE FAMILIES SHOW
UP MONTH AFTER MONTH TO BEG FOR
SERVICES. SOME OF THE SERVICES
CAME VERY LATE. TODAY FAMILIES
ARE TOLD THAT THERE IS NO MORE
NEED FOR THE SERVICE OR FOR THIS
HELP SINCE THEN IT HAS GONE IN
CHILDREN ARE BACK IN SCHOOL. YET
THIS IS NOT TRUE. BUT WE ARE
STILL VERY MUCH INDEPENDENT
AGAIN FACING DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES. BUT WE DO NOT GIVE
UP IN FACT WE ARE INSPIRED WE'RE
EMPOWERING AND UNITING OUR
COMMUNITY TO STAND UP FOR THE
RIGHTS BECAUSE IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE. FOR THIS TO
CONTINUE WELL WE KNOW THERE'S
HELP AND WELL INTENTIONED PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO BRING BALANCE. WE
HOPE YOU CAN HELP US. SEPTEMBER
ARAMBULA YOU COME FROM OUR OUR
COMMUNITY AND I KNOW THE
COMPLETE THE COMMITTEE
UNDERSTANDS OUR CONCERNS WE'RE
HAPPY TO MEET WITH YOU AND
DISCUSS THIS AND MANY MORE IDEAS
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO THAT.
PROCESS ME OUT I AM ABLE SALAS
THEY'LL PUT TWENTY THAT. CRISIS
NECK WE'LL HEAR FROM ME WHY WING
A- DIRECTOR OF ARC. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMY
WESTLING AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER EIGHTEEN ALSO
KNOWN AS ARCA ARCA WORKS WITH
ALL OF THE STATE TWENTY ONE
RESULTS. I WANT START BY
THANKING. TEREBRA AND THE OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR TYPE
TODAY AS WELL AS COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR A COMPREHENSIVE AND FOUGHT
FOR GENDER. I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY TO
DISCUSS THIS CRITICAL TOPIC. I
APPRECIATE THAT THE AGENDA
INCLUDED NOTATIONS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE NOT
ONLY RELATED TO THE HIGH LEVEL
DATA IN THE AREA OF DISPARITIES
BUT ALSO THE COMPLEXITY OF IT.
FOR THE SECOND TIME I WOULD LIKE
TO DIVE A LITTLE BIT DEEPER INTO
THE DATA FOR THOSE FOR QUITE AND
THOSE WHO ARE LIKE YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT PUBLIC THEIR FAMILY.
YOUR TWENTY WE KNOW THAT
CHILDREN ZERO TO THREE BUT HOME
WITH THEIR FAMILIES READ ALSO
CENTER SPENT APPROXIMATELY 4%
MORE FROM LATINO CHILDREN THEN
ON WHITE CHILDREN. FOR CHILDREN
AND SCHOOL AGED YOUNG ADULTS
FROM THREE TO TWENTY ONE
REGIONAL CENTER SPENT 18% LESS
ON WHICH YOU KNOW SPENT ON MY
CHILDREN. AND FOR THOSE LIVING
IN MOBILE OVER THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE REGIONAL CENTER SPENT
APPROXIMATELY 18% LESS ON WHICH
EMAILS BUT ON THE PHOTOS WERE
WHITE. I WAS NOW TO MEET A THIS
. OF THE OR TO NIGHT WITH THIS
VERY SIX. BUT RATHER TO
HIGHLIGHT. THERE ARE IN OF OUR
SYSTEM WORLD SPRING. AND THE
STRANGER IN THE AREAS OF RESPITE
AND EARLY SO. AND I WOULD QUORUM
ALL TO LOOK AT WHY ARE THOSE
AREAS. AND HOW CAN WE BUILD ON
EXPECTS IT MEANS VERY OF
SERVICES ARE DELIVERED BY VOTERS
IN THE FAMILY HELLO. IT'S
SERVICES THE FAMILY IS THAT
FAMILY IS SPECIFICALLY FOR
RESPITE AND PERSONAL ASSISTANCE
CAN SELECT CARE GIVERS BEFORE
APPROVAL BUT THEY ARE KNOWN TO
THE FAMILY THAT PERHAPS. OUR
EXTENDED FAMILY. WHAT THANK THAT
WE CAN. AND GROW UP. FROM
BELIEVE AREAS WHERE WE ARE
SEEING. EQUITY CONSTRAINTS. I
WAS ASKED TODAY TO DISCUSS WHAT
ARE THE REGIONAL CENTERS
PRIORITIES FOR DISPARITY
REDUCTION AND HELPING THE STATE
RESPOND IN A CONCRETE CONCRETE
WAY TO ADVANCE THE- OUR
PRIORITIES ARE VERY SIMPLE WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO ENSURING
THAT EACH PERSON HAS THE SERVICE
SALES. TO MEET THEIR UNIQUE
NEEDS. THANK YOU FOR ACCESS TO
INDIVIDUALIZED SERVICES THIS IS
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL SERVICE
MODEL. BUT- SERVICES THAT MEET
ONE PERSON STATES MAY NOT MEET
ANOTHER GROUPS AND ART OF THE
SECRET. IS THE ADVANCEMENT AND
DEVELOPMENT OF SERVICES THAT
MEET. A VARIETY OF PEOPLE THREE.
IN ORDER TO DEVELOP- SERVICES WE
NEED TO BE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE AND
WE BELIEVE THAT INVESTMENTS IN
THINGS SUCH AS BILINGUAL
STIPENDS HELP A MAN FLEE WITH
THE BALLOT. BROADER AND MORE
ROBUST SERVICE PROVIDER NETWORK
THAT WILL MEET THE FLAG. IN
TERMS OF ACTIONABLE STEPS
SEVERAL STEPS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
ALREADY. WHICH PARKER PREVIOUSLY
ADVOCATED FOR THESE INCLUDE THE
REDUCTION OF CASELOAD RATIOS.
THE EXPANSION OF WHAT WORKS IN
THE DISPARITY GRANT PROGRAM
THROUGH THE STATE WIDE EXPANSION
OF THE ENHANCE ITS LOAD RATIO
PROJECT THE RESTORATION OF
SOCIAL RECREATIONAL YEAH.
ADDITIONALLY DIRECTOR BURGEONING
NOTED OTHER INVESTMENTS THAT
BEGAN IN THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR
SUCH IS THE COMMITTEE NAVIGATOR
PROGRAM IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING
AND PROVISIONAL ELIGIBILITY TO
NAME A FEW. OTHER THAN THAT WE
CAN- AGREE. ON WHAT MEASURES
WERE GOING TO USE TO EVALUATE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF TWENTY
PROJECTS TO A VALUE FOR YOUR
SYSTEM FROM AN EQUITY
PERSPECTIVE. AND THIS IS A COP
OUT THIS IS REALLY AN INTEREST
IN IDENTIFYING HOW ARE WE GOING
TO MEASURE WHETHER WE'RE MEETING
THE MARK. WHEN IT COMES TO
PURCHASE OF SERVICE AND SERVICE
ACCESS ROUTE INTO EIGHT. AND
OTHER FACTORS THAT GO BEYOND
SPENDING BECAUSE ONCE WE
IDENTIFY THOSE MEASURES THOSE
INTERVENTIONS TO IMPROVE IN ALL
OF THOSE AREAS WILL BECOME MORE
. AND FINALLY WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE STATE AS THE LOOKS TO
PERFORMANCE THROUGH WITH THIS
GRANTSBURG. FOCUSING ATTENTION
ON PROJECT. BROUGH THE PROGRAM
AS THEY WENT THEMSELVES TO YOU
IF I. MEDICAL OF DISK IMPACTS
AND LATER REPLICATION THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE FOR
THE SOUTH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WILL BRING THAT BACK TO THE
CHAIR FOR COMMENTS AND- FIRST I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT AND
APPRECIATE ELIZABETH GOMEZ AND-
I AM GRATEFUL THAT DIRECTOR
PARCHMAN IS INCLUSIVE AND-
INTENTIONAL ABOUT INCLUDING
VOICES WHO. DON'T NORMALLY GET
INCLUDED INTO NECESSARY
CONVERSATIONS THAT MATTER FOR-
ALL OF THE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
INTERACTING WITH OUR SYSTEMS.
AND I BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE WERE
IDENTIFYING AND CALLING OUT THE
GLARING NATURE OF THE
DISPARITIES THAT WE SEE. AND
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN A SERIES OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT HOW WE GET
TO A DISABILITY EQUITY PLAN OF
ACTION. AND WOULD LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CREATE THAT STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP
INITIATIVE AS WELL AS HELP TO
DEFINE WHAT SOME OF THESE. BASIC
METRICS THAT WE CAN AGREE UPON
TO MEASURE OUR PROGRESS AS WE GO
FORWARD AS WELL AS CREATING A
TIMETABLE FOR THOSE MILESTONES.
TO ACHIEVE THE GREATER EQUITY
THAT WE ARE REACHING FOR AND MY
HOPE IS THAT TOGETHER WE CAN
DEVELOP THIS ROBUST. AND
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
YOU THE ADMINISTRATION AND
AGENCY AND GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SO
THAT WE ALTERNATELY WILL BE
ADVANCING EQUITY WITHIN OUR- DD
SYSTEM AND- AM QUITE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE MULTIPLE
INVESTMENTS WE'VE BEEN MAKING
TO- ADDRESS THIS AND WOULD LIKE
TO FOLLOW UP ON THE ALEJO'S
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE STUDY AND
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
GEORGETOWN. SO- WHILE WE LOOK TO
FOLLOW UP WITH CONVERSATIONS ON
THE DISABILITY EQUITY PLAN OF
ACTION- WOULD ALSO. LIKE TO ASK
TODAY ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP
WITH GEORGETOWN AND WHETHER THEY
COULD HELP TO PLAY A ROLE- IN-LOOKING FORWARD TOWARDS. ACTION. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NANCY
BIRDS MEN- I WE CAN CERTAINLY
HAVE- CONVERSATIONS WITH
GEORGETOWN- BUT I THINK WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IS UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE SCOPE OF- FURTHERING THE
STUDY AND THE EXPANSION OF WORK
WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE- I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE IMPORTANT
FOR US TO SEE WHAT GEORGETOWN IS
PRODUCING UNDER REVIEW THAT THEY
HAVE CURRENTLY- AND BUT HAPPY TO
HAVE FURTHER CONVERSATIONS. WITH
GEORGETOWN AND- AT I UNDERSTAND
KIND OF ARTICLE IN WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO ACHIEVE. I LOOK
FORWARD TO THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND AGAIN JUST THANK YOU FOR-
WORKING WITH OUR OFFICE. WITH
THAT I WILL THANK VERY MUCH-
THESE PANELISTS WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE SEVEN. WE WILL HAVE SEVEN
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL KARLA
CASTANEDA CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
BRIAN WINFIELD CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH DDS. FOLLOWED BY
CHRISTOPHER I DEAL WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THE
PADDOCK WITH POLIO- GILDO GARON
DIRECTOR OF OUTREACH AND
LEADERSHIP TRAINING FOR
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED. ANDY
IMPARATO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
MICI A GATES EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR KERN REGIONAL CENTER LET'S
PLEASE BEGIN WITH MISS CASTANEDA
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR CARLA BECAUSE
THEN THE OTHER DEPARTMENT FELT
LITTLE SERVICES- WE'LL START
WITH ADDRESSING THEQUESTIONS IN
THE AGENDA- THE AGENDA ALREADY
INCLUDES A SUMMARY OF THE
EXPENDITURES FOR COPELAND.
NINETEEN SO I'LL KIND OF EXPLAIN
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW WE CAME
UP WITH THOSE PROJECTIONS ARE
YOU FOR A LITTLE BIT EARLY YOUR
COP COMMENTS ABOUT OUR DATA
SYSTEM RESTRICTIONS. ON WHAT WE
DID WAS WE LOOKED AT THE
EXPENDITURE TRENDS UP TO
BEGINNING FOR THE PANDEMIC LOOK
FOR JUST SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE
DIFFERENCES INCREASES OR
DECREASES. IN EXPENSE AS OF
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY AND
TRACKED THAT TRACK FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS- WITHOUT WE DID
SEE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN SOME
OF THE- CATEGORIES OF
EXPENDITURES THAT YOU SEE IN THE
AGENDA- USING THAT METHODOLOGY
WE'RE PROJECTING APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION. IN COMPANY MAKES
MANAGERS IN THE CURRENT YEAR IN
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX LANE
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. FOR PURCHASE
OF SERVICES. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE SEE AND
PROTECTING WHICH CAN. THAT LINK
ENERGY. RELATED TO THE LACK IN
THE DATA. WHICH WHICH SEE BUT
DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. FLAG THAT THAT
INFORMATION IS SERVICE- AND EACH
CYCLE WE DELIVER THE MOST RECENT
CLAIM STATUS THEN ADJUST
ACCORDINGLY. TO DATE WE HAVE NOT
SEEN ANY SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN
THE TOTAL BUDGET- RATHER
SHIFTING CATEGORIES OF
EXPENDITURES. ON THE STATE UP
CRICKET SIDE OF THE CURRENT YEAR
HAS FIFTEEN MILLION IF THERE
WERE NEED FOR SEARCH ACTIVITY.
TO DATE WE HAVE NOT HAD TO
ACTIVATE THAT ACTIVITY- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY AN ADJUSTER FOR A
YEAR. ARE ANY OUTSTANDING IN THE
BUDGET YEAR- THE COMMITTEE HAD
ASKED ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHARACTERISTICS THAT WE HAD SEEN
IN SOME OF THE INFECTION AND
MORTALITY RATES. OF EARLY IN THE
PANDEMIC THE DEPARTMENT WITH
SOCIAL SERVICES AND OUR
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO PROVIDE PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT TO PROVIDERS AND
REGIONAL CENTERS OF ALL
FAMILIES. AND WE'RE SO PROUD OF
THE PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL OF
THOSE ACTIVITIES AS WE IDENTIFY
ISSUES EARLY AND TRY TO FIND
OPTIONS FROM FOR MAINTAINING
SERVICES AND MAINTAIN THOSE
SAFELY. THAT THE- ON PAGE ONE
THIRTY PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF
THAT CUMULATIVE DATA ON
INSPECTIONS AND UNFORTUNATELY
THE DEATH RATE. WHAT WE START
EARLY ON WAS- A LARGER
PROPORTION OF THOSE IN
CONGREGATE SETTINGS- BUT AT THE
STATE I DON'T KNOW AND- THE
WORLD ACTUALLY IDENTIFIED MORE
TOOLS TO ADDRESS THE PANDEMIC.
WE SAW THAT WHILE THEIR WORK TO
UNIT FUNCTONS THE PROPORTION OF
DEATHS FROM. DIDN'T CONTINUE TO
INCREASE- SO WHAT WE'RE HOPEFUL
IS WE FEEL MUCH MORE PREPARED IF
THERE ARE SUCH A GREAT WAVES.
AND WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS TO
ADDRESS ANY OF THOSE UNMET
NEEDS. ONE OF THE OPTIONS THAT
CAME FROM SOME OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WAS LOOKING AT A
CLOCK SPEED OF SERVICES HELLO
FREE FOR NOT PROVIDENTIAL
SERVICES. AND WHAT THAT ALLOWED
WAS GIVING PROVIDERS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO TRY TO PROVIDE
OTHER OTHER NEEDS. TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF CONSUMERS IN THE SAME
WAY IN IN DIFFERENT-
POTENTIALLY- REYES OR ACTUAL
DIFFERENT SERVICES. WHAT WE SAW
AS THE PANDEMIC BUT ON WAS
ACTUALLY KIND OF A CONFERENCE ON
A WHAT THAT ALTERNATIVES. TO
USING MORE REMOTE SERVICE. BOB
YEAH ALLOWED ME OF OUR OUR BY
AND OUR PROVIDER OR THE USE OF
THAT TECHNOLOGY WHICH WAS ONE OF
THE UP SIDES AS WELL AS THE
DOWNSIDE OF PROVIDING SERVICES
DURING THE PANDEMIC- THE
COLLABORATIVE SPIRIT OF OUR
COMMUNITY DEFINITELY HELPS TO
STAY ON TOP OF WHATEVER THOSE
CHANGING NEEDS ARE- MAKING THAT
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE AND IN THE
USE OF TECHNOLOGY IT WILL
IMPROVE THE COMMUNICATION IT
ALLOWED FOR GREATER STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT MORE FREQUENT MORE
PARTICIPATION. AND THEN IT ALSO
ABOUT FOLKS TO DEVELOP NEW
SKILLS SO WHILE SOME INDIVIDUALS
IN SOME PROVIDERS DID IDENTIFY
THAT REMOTE SERVICES IN THE USED
TO BACK TECHNOLOGY. EXPANDED
THEIR ABILITY TO ENGAGE IT
PROVIDED FLEXIBILITY IN
SCHEDULING OF ONE OF THE
EXAMPLES THERE IS FROM OUR EARLY
START SERVICE PROVIDERS. THEY
AND THE FAMILIES WERE ABLE TO
INCREASE THAT SCHEDULING
FLEXIBILITY SO MORE OFTEN THEY
WERE ABLE TO ACTUALLY CONNECT-
BUT A LOT FOR SOME OF THE
COACHING OPPORTUNITIES.
IMPLEMENTING STRATEGIES THAT
WILL HELP SUPPORT THE CHILDREN.
BUT THE DOWNSIDE OF THAT
TECHNOLOGY WAS IT HIGHLIGHTED
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE THAT
CONTINUES TO EXIST SO I'M
LOOKING AT MORE EFFORTS TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS IN THAT AREA. OUR
AND THEN OF COURSE AS WE EMERGE
FROM THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY- WHAT WE LEARNED
WHAT'S FOR SOME INDIVIDUALS THE
REMOTE SERVICES WORK WHILE.
OTHERS DEFINITELY PREFER IN
PERSON AND ARE LOOKING FORWARD
TO. THAT INCREASING TRACKING IT
WILL DISSIPATE. THERE WILL ALSO
BE A FACTOR OF THE OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT ONCE A BLANK-
FIRST WE LOOK FORWARD TO IT'S
CAN GET. AS WE ARE ADDRESSED
CHANGE NEEDS THANK YOU. NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM BRIAN ONE FIELD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AT A
MISSED CATCH IN A COVERED ALL
THE QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
CHRISTOPHER I DEAL WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- CHRIS SO NOTED
PARTNER FINDS NOTHING FURTHER TO
ADD TO THE PRESENTATION SONYA
PADDOCK- HELLO. WE DON'T HAVE-
MANY SPARROWS SPECIFIC COMMENTS
OR OR RECOMMENDATIONS THE
PRIMARY- IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
RAISE I GUESS IS JUST THAT THE
EVIDENCE SUGGESTS THAT KOBE
NINETEEN WILL REALLY BE A LONG
TERM. ISSUE EVEN IF IT'S NOT AS
EXTREME AS IT HAS BEEN- OVER
THESE PAST TWO YEARS AND SO IF
IT DOES BECOME SOMETHING MORE
AKIN TO THE FLU- ANNUAL FLU.
MANY OF THE INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WILL
BE AT HIGHER RISK OF DISEASE OR
SERIOUS ILLNESS- DUE TO
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS OR
THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF THEIR
LIVING SITUATIONS SUCH AS LIVING
IN A CONGREGATE LIVING SETTING-
SO WE WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF- DDS IN REGIONAL
CENTRES CONSIDERING HOW TO PLAN
AND PREPARE- PREVENTATIVE SPAHN
TO. TO DISEASE WHETHER IT'S-
INSURING PEOPLE DO HAVE GOOD
ACCESS TO PPP- ACCESS TO TESTING
AND BOOSTER SHOTS- INTERESTED
SUPPORT FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING
HER HAVING- ACCESS TO THE TYPES
OF COMMUNICATIONS THAT- IS-
CASTANEDA MENTIONED- IF THEY DO
NEED TO RECEIVE SERVICES IN A
REMOTE FASHION- MORE EMERGENCY
COORDINATION- SUPPORT WAS
APPROVED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
FOR- REGIONAL CENTERS AND GDS SO
WE WOULD EXPECT- THAT. THESE
GROUPS OF INDIVIDUALS WOULD BE
IT WOULD BE DOING EXACTLY THIS.
TYPE OF PLANNING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE WILL FROM THE
BUILDER. WITH THIS VOICES UNITED. HI MY NAME IS GILBERT HIT ON
AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
OUTREACH AND LEADERSHIP TRAINING
FOR DISABILITY VOICES UNITED I
AM ALSO THE MOM OF THREE YOUNG
CHILDREN TWO OF WHOM HAVE
DISABILITIES. AND IT'S BEEN A
ROUGH COUPLE OF YEARS AROUND OUR
HOME MY TWO YEAR OLD DAUGHTER
ABBY HAS SPINA BIFIDA AND
RECEIVED EARLY START SERVICES
FROM THE REGIONAL CENTER BECAUSE
OF THE PATHOGENIC OLIVER
SERVICES HOW TO BE PROVIDED FOR
ME IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
PROVIDE THERAPY TO THE BABY OVER
SALE AND THIS IS ON TOP OF
JUGGLING MY OTHER TWO CHILDRN.
WHO ARE NOT IN SCHOOL AND HAD TO
BE SUPPORTED IN VIRTUAL
LEARNING. BOTH MY HUSBAND I WORK
FULL TIME AND HAD LITTLE SUPPORT
AT THE TIME. I WAS WORKING FROM
FOR A NONPROFIT THAT PROVIDED A
COMMUNITY BASED DAY PROGRAM TO
ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES THAT
ALSO HAD AGO VIRTUAL. THAT'S
BECAUSE THE HUGE AMOUNT OF
STRESS ON OUR FAMILY. BUT I'M
NOT ALONE AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE WITH THE VIEW HAS FOUND
FROM OUR COMMUNITY ABOUT THE
OBSTACLE SPACE AND SUPPORTS THE
RECEIVED DURING THE PANDEMIC. WE
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT HURT HER
I THINK EFFORTS OF SO MANY IN
OUR SYSTEM WELL TAKING LESSONS
LEARNED AND MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
IMPROVEMENTS. FIRST I WANT TO
THINK GOVERNOR NEWSOM SECRETARY
KHALIDI AND DIRECTOR NANCY
PARCHMAN FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP IN
ENSURING THAT PEOPLE WITH ADD
WERE PRIORITIZED. FOR EARLY
ACCESS TO VACCINES AND FOR
REQUIRING VACCINES AND BOOSTERS
FOR THE STAFF TO SUPPORT THEM.
WE HOPE THAT THESE PRIORITIES
AND REQUIREMENTS WILL CONTINUE
AS ADDITIONAL VACCINATIONS.
TESTING AND OTHER NEEDS EMERGE
TO RESPOND TO KOBE TO
CHALLENGES. BUT WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT MANY SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE
UNABLE TO SUPPORT CONTRACT
WORKERS TO COMPLY WITH THESE
MANDATES WHICH MUST BE ADDRESSED
TO KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES. THE
STATE COUNCIL AND MANY SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO MEET PPL AVAILABLE
IN THE PAST YEAR. DO YOU ALONG
WITH MANY REGIONAL CENTERS AND
PROVIDERS ALSO RAN VACCINE
CLINICS AND EXTRA SUPPORT FOR
PEOPLE WITH IDT. HOWEVER DURING
THE MOST AWAY FROM. THEM DURING
THE RECENT WAVE OF THAT- MACRON
BEARING AND WE KNOW THAT IN MANY
FAMILIES SOME ARE ALL FAMILY
MEMBERS CONTRACTED COBIT. BURDEN
OF SECURING SCORES TEST
APPOINTMENTS IN TRAVELING TO
THEM BITING COLD CAST MANAGING
EFFECTIVE HOME ISOLATION. AND
UNDERSTANDABLE GUIDELINES FOR
ENDING PORTANTINO PUT AN
ENORMOUS STRAIN ON FAMILIES.
MANY DID NOT GET THE HELP THEY
NEEDED WE WILL ADDRESS THE
DEPARTMENT DEVELOPING MORE
ROBUST SYSTEM FOR REGIONAL
CENTERS TO ASSIST FAMILIES
DURING PERIODS OF CRISIS. IN
MAJOR REVELATION IN THE PAST TWO
YEARS HAS BEEN THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF FLEXIBILITY ENACT
ACCESSING RECEIVING SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES. WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE FLEXIBILITY DDS HAS PROVIDED
THROUGH ITS DIRECTIVES TO
REGIONAL CENTERS AND WE STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THAT THE DEPARTMENT.
MAKE THOSE FLEXIBLE APPROACHES
PERMANENT. YOU NOW IT'S WE TO
YEARS OF LIFE UNDER THE COUNTER
. FAMILIES CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE THE STRESS OF
DISRUPTED WORK AND SCHOOLS GET
SCHOOL SCHEDULES AND STILL NEED
TO ATTEND CRITICAL MEETINGS
REMOTELY AND TO ACCESS
ADDITIONAL IN HOME RESPITE
HOURS. WE WERE PLEASED TO SEE
THAT LAST YEAR'S TRAILER BILL
INCLUDED AMENDMENTS THAT ALLOW
EARLY START L. ENTRANT ACTED
MEETINGS ON SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS TO BE HELD REMOTELY.
WHEN REQUESTED BY CONSUMER AND
WORK FAMILY. HOWEVER THIS
FLEXIBILITY ONLY EXTENDS UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND WE'RE EXPECTING. HE GAVE ME
A PERMANENT WE ALSO RECOMMEND
THAT DDS CLEARLY ESTABLISHED AND
MAKE PERMANENT THE CONTINUED
AVAILABILITY OF ADDITIONAL
RESPITE HOURS WHEN NEEDED. WE
HAVE ALSO HEARD MANY FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS EXPRESSED
CONCERN ABOUT THE DELIVERY OF
ALTERNATIVE SERVICES. WE HAVE
HEARD STORIES OF SERVICES BEING
PROVIDED ONLY ONE ALREADY DAY
ONLINE WHEN A PERSON HAS IN
CRISIS AND NEEDS MUCH MORE. FOR
SOME HAVING NO ACCESS TO A
COMPUTER OR THE INTERNET MEANT
THAT YOU RECEIVE NO SERVICES AT
ALL THESE ISSUES. THE AFFECTED
PEOPLE IN CONGREGATE PROGRAMS
WHICH HAD TO SHUT DOWN OVERNIGHT
WITH LITTLE BIT NINETEEN STRUCK.
THE LESSON LEARNED HERE IS THAT
OUR SYSTEM RELIES TOO HEAVILY ON
CONGREGATE PROGRAMS AND WE MUST
MOVE TOWARD MORE INDIVIDUALIZED
INTEGRATED SETTINGS ESPECIALLY
SINCE THEY MUST CHANGE BY NEXT
YEAR'S MIGHT BY NEXT YEAR'S.
EACH CBS FINAL RULE DEADLINE IN
ADDITION WE WANT TO COMMEND THE
HEROES IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO
SHOWED UP IN PERSON EVERY DAY
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THE
SUPPORTED LIVING RESPITE AND
KRISTIN ALL SYSTEM PROVIDERS
CAME TO THE HOME OF PEOPLE WITH
IDT EVEN WHEN I COOK IT. WORKED
OVERTIME TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
WERE SUPPORTED BUT THESE HEROES
WHATEVER REWARDED. FOR THEIR
LIFE SAVING WORK WELL THE
LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZE FUNDING
FOR CARICOM THE PAYMENT OF FIVE
HUNDRED FOR HSS WORKERS. THAT
SEEMED BONUS WAS NOT FUNDED FOR
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS TO
DO THE SAME. WORK AND OFTEN IN
THE SAME HOME. THANKS AND- IN
THE PAST TWO YEARS WILL LIKELY
TO A TOLL ON TO MEET. EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE WE MUST ALSO PLAN FOR TERM.
OF KOBE DON'T OUR COMMUNITY
INCLUDING RICK. MENTAL HEALTH
AND BEHAVIORAL STE. WE IS FOR
THE- WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE NTDS TO
MEET THESE CHALLENGES AND
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR ALL PEOPLE
AND FAMILIES SERVED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM ANDY IMPARATO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK. COMING THROUGH LOUD
AND CLEAR. WITH SO YES I AM AND
THE IMPERATOR WHEN I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I STARTED IN
THIS ROLE A MONTH BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC SO IT'S BEEN AN
INTERESTING FIRST COUPLE OF
YEARS FOR ME. I ALSO HAVE HELPED
YOU TO SURVIVE THE COMMUNITY
BANKS IN ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ON
THE FEDERAL CODE NINETEEN HEALTH
EQUITY TASK FORCE THAT PRESIDENT
BY AND CREATED IT TO HELP.
RESPOND TO THE PANDEMIC FIRST I
JUST REALLY WANT TO LIVE COME
FROM EUROPE O HAVE MISTER CHAIR
ABOUT HAVING A DISABILITY EQUITY
PLAN OF ACTION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE I KNOW IN THIS
CONTEXT YOUR THINKING ABOUT
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. I
THINK HAVING A PLAN LIKE THAT
WOULD BENEFIT THE ENTIRE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK WE LEARNED A
LOT DURING THIS ACADEMIC WE HAVE
A LOT OF EQUITY CHALLENGES AND
THE DJ SYSTEM OUTSIDE OF THE TV
SYSTEM. AND I CAN JUST TELL YOU
WE ARE DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WOULD LOVE TO WORK
WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF ON AND
DISABILITY EQUITY PLAN OF ACTION
AND WORK WORK WITH THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AS WELL THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH. SO JUST SOME QUICK
POINTS AND TERMS OF LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE PANDEMIC FIRST
I JUST WANT TO ECHO- BUT- IS
HEROES THAT- ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE FLEXIBILITY
THAT DDS GAVE THE REGIONAL
CENTERS QUICKLY AT THE BEGINNING
OF A PANDEMIC. THAT WAS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT DDS TO FAST
AND IT MADE A HUGE DIFFERENCE SO
I JUST WANT TO LOOK THAT UP AND
I AGREE THAT THAT THAT KIND OF
FLEXIBILITY AND RAPID RESPONSE
FROM DDS IS SOMETHING THAT-
SHOULD BE SIMILAR TO TRY TO DO
IN RESPONSE TO ANY EMERGENCY NOT
JUST IN THE PANDEMIC AND SOME OF
IT. SHOULD BE BAKED INTO THEIR
REGULAR POLICIES SO I REALLY
APPRECIATED. HER COMMENT ON THAT
. NO ACROSS THE TWENTY REGIONAL
CENTERS. WE DID NOT SEE CONCERT
. AND HOW RESPOND TO THE- SOME
REGIONAL WE'RE BETTER AT THE- OF
TIME MOLD WAYS OF COMMUNICATING
. WITH THEIR CONSUMERS
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEEDED IN
ORDER TO STAY SAFE. AND TO HAVE
SERVICES DURING THE PANDEMIC
I'VE ALWAYS LOOKED UP TO AS A
POSITIVE EXAMPLE. THE VALLEY
MOUNTAIN REGIONAL CENTER WHICH
DIDN'T JUST RELY ON EMAIL
UPDATES AS AS MOST OF THE
REGIONAL CENTERS DEAD. BUT THEY
ALSO HAD IN PERSON OUTREACH
SESSIONS AND THEY HAD MULTIPLE
WAYS OF REACHING OUT TO MAKE
SURE. PEOPLE HAVE THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEEDED TO
STAY SAFE. DURING THE PANDEMIC
ANOTHER EXAMPLE WHERE THERE'S
BEEN INCONSISTENCY HAS SOME
REGIONAL CENTERS. HAVE A DATE
AND SAID WE'RE NOT GOING TO KEEP
PAYING FOR SOME OF THESE
PANDEMIC RELATED SERVICES AFTER.
YOU KNOW APRIL FIRST OR AFTER
JANUARY FIRST. NOT WITHSTANDING
THE FACT THAT THE PANDEMIC IS
STILL ON GOING AND NONE OF US
KNOW WHEN IT'S GONNA AND SO.
WE'D LIKE TO SEE MORE CONSISTENT
OVERSIGHT FROM DDS TELLING THE
REGIONAL CENTERS FLEXIBILITY IS
REALLY IMPORTANT NOW JUST LIKE
IT WAS IMPORTANT AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMICS AND
YOU SHOULD NOT SET ARBITRARY
DATES AROUND WHICH CERTAIN
SERVICES ARE GONNA AND- I ALSO
JUST WANTED TO LIFT UP. THE
RELATIVE IMPORTANCE OF THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THERE WERE MANY POINTS DURING
THE PANDEMIC. WHERE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH MADE DECISIONS THAT
TURNED OUT NOT TO BE GREAT
DECISIONS IN PART BECAUSE THEY
WEREN'T TALKING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND OTHER FOLKS TO KIND
OF HELP THEM AVOID. THOSE
DECISIONS MORE EXAMPLE WAS THE
CRISIS STANDARDS OF CARE
GUIDELINES WHEN THEY CAME OUT
WITH DRAFT GUIDELINES EARLY IN
THE PANDEMIC. THE BASICALLY SAID
IT WAS OKAY TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
ARE OLDER PEOPLE WHEN YOU'RE
DECIDING WHO'S GOING TO GET A
VENTILATOR OR OTHER- SCARE.
SERVICE IN A IN A- AND HEALTH
CARE RATIONING SUCH A- WE ABLE
TO PUSH. AND THEY'D SAY THEIR-
AND I GREW THAT TIME CAL. HAS
TURNED OUT TO BE A GREAT
LISTENER AND A ALLY TO THE-
COMMUNITIES BUT IT WAS A TRUCK
THAT. WAS NOT. ABLE TO THERE WAS
TO BEAR FOR THOSE TRAPPED
GUIDELINES FOR RELIEF. ANOTHER
EXAMPLE WAS ON BACK
PRIVATIZATION AGAIN THEY ENDED
UP IN A GOOD PLACE. BUT WE HAD
TO HAVE A FIGHT TO GET THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO PRIORITIZE. UNDER
SIXTY FIVE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO ARE HIGH RISK
INCLUDING EVERYBODY WHO'S THE
REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMER THAT'S
WHERE THEY ENDED UP. BUT IT WAS
A THERE WAS A LOT OF BACK. AND
FORTH BEFORE WE GOT TO THAT
POINT. ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS A
HOSPITAL VISITATIONS WE HAD TO
PUSH HARD. TO GET THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
MAKE CLEAR. THAT PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES OR
HAD TO GO TO A HOSPITAL SHOULD
BE ABLE TO BRING. A SAFE PERSON
WITH THEM SOME INFO CONTRA WITH
EVEN THOUGH THERE'S A POLICY
AGAINST LETTING PEOPLE BRING
VISITORS TO HOSPITAL WE SAW THAT
AS AN ACCOMMODATION. UNDER THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT
BUT AGAIN THAT WAS A FIGHT THAT
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE HAD TO HAVE. I
ALSO JUST WANT TO LET DOWN. THIS
PARADIGM HAS DESTROYED A LOT OF
SERVICE MODELS YOU HAD A WHOLE
ISSUE SESSION FOR YOU TALKED
ABOUT SOME MINIMUM WAGE
EMPLOYMENT AND SEGREGATED
EMPLOYMENT. AND I JUST ENCOURAGE
US AS WE REBUILD FROM THE
PANDEMIC. TO ASK THE QUESTION
WHEN WE LOOK AT A SERVICE MODEL.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO ADVANCE
INTEGRATION WHAT ARE YOU DOING
TO ADVANCE SELF DETERMINATION
AND WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO
ADVANCE EQUITY. AND IF THE
SERVICE MODEL IS NOT REALLY
ADVANCING THOSE CALLS THE MAYBE
WE SHOULDN'T BE BUILT ABOUT WE
SHOULD HELP THEM INNOVATE. TO
CREATE A NEW SERVICE MODEL THAT
WOULD ENHANCE THOSE CAUGHT. THE
LAST PANEL UNDER. I JUST ONE
THING I WANT TO LIFT UP TO THE
THINK IT'S EASIER GET LOST IN
DATA. IF WE'RE SPENDING TWO AND
A HALF TO THREE TIMES AS MUCH ON
WHITE INDIVIDUALS AS WE ARE ON A
LOT NEXT INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I THINK THERE ARE A
LOT OF WAYS TO EXPLAIN IT BUT
WANT TO EXPLAIN IT IS
DISCRIMINATION I DON'T THINK I
WOULD HAVE NOT LEVEL OF
DISPARITY. IF PEOPLE WHO ARE
LATIN ACTS OR AFRICAN AMERICAN
OR IN OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING DISPARITIES.
WARRANT ALSO EXPERIENCING
DISCRIMINATION SO AS WE THINK
ABOUT A RESPONSE TO DISPARITIES
ARE ENCOURAGED TO TALK ABOUT
CIVIL RIGHTS ENFORCEMENT WHAT
ARE WE DOING. TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE NOT EXPERIENCING
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION WHEN THEY
GO TO SERVICES FROM A REGIONAL
CENTER. AND FINALLY IF WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE AN EQUITY AGENDA
FOR CALIFORNIA WE NEED BETTER
DATA. ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET VACCINES
EARLIER FOR PEOPLE DEVELOPMENT
IS PLACES WE DIDN'T HAVE GOOD
DATA. ON HOW THE DISEASE WAS
AFFECTING PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES SO AS AS WE COME
OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC LIKE LET'S
MAKE A COMMITMENT THEY WERE
GONNA COLLECT MORE DATA SO THAT
WE'RE BETTER PREPARED FOR THE
NEXT PANDEMIC. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
FINAL PANELIST ON THIS PANEL IS
SMITTY GATES WOULD BE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. OF KERN REGIONAL
CENTER. THE DIRECTOR GATE. YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW.
OKAY SORRY I THINK I FORGOT TO-
YOU- THANK YOU COMMITTEE CHAIRED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MEET SHE GAVE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
KERN REGIONAL CENTER. DURING THE
PAST YEARS OF THE PANDEMIC
REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE BEEN
GUIDED AND SUPPORTED BY THE
STRONG LEADERSHIP OF EDS. THE
NUMBER OF DIRECTIVES HELD AT
TIMES BEEN HARD TO KEEP UP WITH
THAT HAS ENSURED A CONSISTENT
RAPID RESPONSE. THESE DIRECTIVES
AND ACCESS TO ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND FUNDING TO ADDRESS
PANDEMIC RELATED NEEDS. ALLOW
CURRENT REGIONAL CENTER TO
BETTER SERVE OUR INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES ALL AT THE SAME TIME
MAXIMIZING SAFETY. FOR EXAMPLE
MAKING FACE TO FACE CONTACT WITH
OUR INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
THIS IMPORTANT. DIRECTIVES
PROVIDING THE FLEXIBILITY TO
CONNECT CONDUCT MEETINGS
REMOTELY HELPED ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE COULD STAY SAFE WHILE
MAINTAINING ACCESS TO SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS. WE ALSO FOUND THAT
SOME INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
PREFERRED REMOTE VISITS AND IN
THOSE CASES HAS RESULTED IN
INCREASED PARTICIPATION IN
MEETINGS. DIRECTIVES THAT
SUPPORTED OUR INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES SUCH AS THE ADDITION OF
PERSONAL ASSISTANCE INDEPENDENT
LIVING SERVICES AND SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT CHU PARTICIPANT
DIRECTED SERVICES ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES TO HAVE
MORE CHOICE OVER HOW SERVICES
FOR PROVIDED. AND PERHAPS MOST
CRITICALLY FLIGHT HOME AND THE
PANDEMIC ENVIRONMENT. PROVISION
OF P. P. TO REGIONAL CENTERS FOR
DISTRIBUTION TO INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IN HELPING
TO CONTAIN THE SPREAD OF
INFECTION. KERN REGIONAL CENTER
CONTINUES TO DISTRIBUTE DBS
PROVIDED KEEP YOU SUPPLIES YOUR
PROVIDERS INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES WHEN NO OTHER RESOURCES
AVAILABLE. KERN REGIONAL CENTERS
ALSO SUPPORTED OUR FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER WITH PP DRIVES
WHICH PARTICULARLY TARGET ARE
HISPANIC LATINO COMMUNITY.
ALLOWING REGIONAL CENTERS TO
SUSPEND THE ANNUAL FAMILY
PROGRAM BE AND FAMILY COST
PARTICIPATION PROGRAM YEP YEAH
N. F. C. P. P. OR FAMILIES IS
ANOTHER IMPORTANT TANDEM X.
SUPPORT. RK STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE AND OTHER ADVOCACY
GROUPS SUPPORT ELIMINATING THOSE
TWO PROGRAMS PERMANENTLY. KERN
REGIONAL CENTER HOUSES BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER THIS
ACTION THESE FEES WERE
INSTITUTED DURING THE RECEPTION
RECESSION BUT ARE NOT PROVIDING
HOPE FOR COST SAVINGS TO THE
STATE. THEY ARE INSTEAD BARRIERS
TO FAMILIES UTILIZING REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICES. IN TERMS OF
CHALLENGES THE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR VENDORS
THE PEOPLE WHO DIRECTLY SUPPORT
OUR INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES DUE
TO THE NEED TO VIGILANTLY GUARD
AGAINST CROSS INFECTION A DOCTOR
HUGE CHANGES IN THE WAY SERVICES
ARE PROVIDED AN ADDRESS I'M
GOING STAFFING SHORTAGES AND
INCREASED OVER TIME NEEDS. DTS
RECORDS ALLOWING REGIONAL CENTER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS TO APPROVE
PANDEMIC RELATED HIGHER HEALTH
AND SAFETY PAYMENT RATES TO KEEP
STOP WORKING AND COMPENSATE THEM
FOR LONGER WORK HOURS SHE
ALLOWED KERN REGIONAL CENTER TO
BE RESPONSIVE TO URGENT NEEDS.
SOME DIRECTORS HAVE BEEN
DIFFICULT TO IMPLEMENT DO YOU TO
REGIONAL CENTER WORK LOAD
CAPACITY. FOR EXAMPLE
DOCUMENTING ALL COMBAT NINETEEN
THE FACT INFECTIONS OCCURRING
AMONG OUR INDIVIDUALS AND
PROVIDERS. AND SERVICE
COORDINATORS REGULARLY
CONTACTING ALL INDIVIDUALS ON
THEIR CASELOADS TO INSURE THE
UNNECESSARILY SUPPORTS
INFORMATION AND ACCESS TO
VARIOUS COMMUNITY RESOURCES
INCLUDING HOGAN NINETEEN TESTING
AND VACCINES. EARLY IN THE
CATATONIC CARE C. DIRECTED OUR
SERVICE COORDINATORS TO MAKE
MONTHLY CALLS TO ALL INDIVIDUALS
ON THEIR CASELOAD. TO CHECK ON
THEIR WELFARE ENQUIRE ABOUT
THEIR NEEDS AND TO OFFER
RESOURCES. THE CHALLENGE HAS
BEEN HOW TO MAKE TIME FOR THIS
IN AN ALREADY FULL DAY. OUR
SYSTEM THAT'S GUIDED BY THE
IMPERATIVE TO PUT THE HEALTH
SAFETY AND NEEDS OF OUR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES FIRST
ABOVE ALL OTHER INTERESTS. OVER
THE YEARS INCREASE COMPLIANCE
REQUIREMENTS AND HIGH CASELOADS
HAVE MADE IT CHALLENGING FOR
REGIONAL CENTERS TO DO OUR JOBS
. HERESY LOOKS FORWARD TO
CURRENT AND FUTURE INITIATIVES
THAT REDUCE CASELOAD SIZES
ENHANCED TECHNOLOGY. FOCUSED ON
PERSON CENTERED SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS AND MEASURE QUALITY
THROUGHOUT COMES MEANINGFUL TO
THE INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WE
SERVE. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
CHAIRED A OMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY. THE
DIRECTOR DATES AND- I WOULD LIKE
TO FOLLOW UP- AFTER THIS MEETING
ABOUT THE FAMILY PARTICIPATION
FEES THAT YOU WERE SPEAKING
ABOUT- AND- WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO SEE IF THIS IS
CONSISTENT. WITH INCREASING
ACCESS AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT.
THIS WILL LEAD TOWARDS
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS AND
REALLY APPRECIATE DIRECTOR GATES
FOR YOU BRING IT TO OUR
ATTENTION TO THAT. WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD ISSUE SEVEN OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE EIGHT
IMPLEMENTATION REVIEW AND
OVERSIGHT OF THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES H. C.
B. S. FINAL RULE COMPLIANCE. WE
WILL HAVE FOUR PRESENTERS ON
THIS PANEL BEGINNING WITH BRIAN
WINFIELD CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR CDSS JIM KNIGHT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR DDS US CHRISTOPHER
O'NEILL WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND SONYA PADDOCK WITH
L. A. L. LET US BEGIN WITH MR
WINFIELD. HI MISTER CHAIR AT THE
GYM NINETY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
AND I WILL- BRIGHTON RESPOND TO
THE QUESTIONS IN THE AGENDA ON
BEHALF OF THE DEPARTMENT. SO AS
NOTED IN THE AGENDA IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
OTHER DEPARTMENTS. WE ANTICIPATE
SUBMITTING OUR STATE WIDE
TRANSITION PLAN TO THE CENTERS
FOR MEDICARE AND MEDICAID
SERVICES. FOR THEIR FINAL
APPROVAL LATER THIS YEAR AND SO
JUST TAKING A STEP BACK THIS
PLAN IS A REQUIREMENT THAT THAT
JUST OUTLINED IS A FANTASTIC
THEY PLAN. OF WHAT WE ARE WE ARE
AT THE IN IN MEETING THESE
REQUIREMENTS AND WHAT OUR PLAN
IS FOR WORK TAINING- COMPLIANCE. THAT BY MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. SO A COUPLE OF THE THAT
ARE HIGHLY THAT ARE WE- TO BE
THIS PLANT UP WE NEED TO GET THE
FINAL APPROVAL ACTUALLY BEFORE I
GO THERE. JUST FOR COMPARISON.
YEAH THERE ARE TWO STEPS TO THE
APPROVAL PROCESS AND ON. THE
TRANSITION PLANS. THERE'S AN
INITIAL APPROVAL WHICH THAT THE
STATES THAT WE HAVE ALREADY
OBTAINED OF THE STATE. AND THEN
FINAL APPROVAL WHICH IS WHAT
WE'LL BE LOOKING TO JUST
AMERICAN THAN A CHANGE LATER
THIS YEAR. JUST SO YOU JUST FOR
AWARENESS. THERE ARE TWENTY ONE
STATES THAT HAVE RECEIVED FINAL
APPROVAL FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON THEIR PLANS. WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE INITIAL APPROVAL
AND THERE ARE STILL FOUR STATES
THAT ARE STILL WORKING TOWARDS
EVEN A TEAM IN THE INITIAL
APPROVAL AS WELL. SO THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY A WIDE VARIATION
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY OF. OF
THE STATUS OF WHERE STATES ARE.
BOB OKAY OF THE THINGS THAT NEED
TO BE INCLUDED IN THE- THE IN
THIS PLANT TO GET FINAL APROVAL
AS ONE THEY SET AN ESTIMATE OF
WHERE WE ARE AS FAR AS MEETING
THESE REQUIREMENTS INTO THAT'S
GOING TO INCLUDING THAT OF THE
NUMBER OF PROVIDERS THAT
CURRENTLY MEET THE REQUIREMENTS
AND THOSE THAT DON'T AND THEN
ALSO A PLAN OF HOW THEN WHAT
WHAT IT'S- PROCESS TRANSFER
BURKE DOES PROVIDERS TO COME
INTO COMPLIANCE. AGAIN BY MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. SO IT'S A
MULTI STEP ASSESSMENT PROCESS
THAT WE NEED TO DO TO. GET THOSE
ESTIMATES OF THOSE NUMBERS ABOUT
WHAT WHERE WE ARE SH AND SO IT
BEGAN WITH THE PROVIDERS
COMPLETING A SELF ASSESSMENT- TO
IT TOO DEAR. GERMANY BASED ON
THE BACK PROVIDERS- VIEW HOWEVER
THEY MEETING THE REQUIREMENTS IN
THAT BOOK WHATEVER. PURCHASE A
STRANGE REQUIREMENTS. THE NEXT
STEP THAT WE TO GO. IS THE
VALIDATION OF THOSE RESULTS
AGAINST THE PROVIDERS THAT
DENNIS THAT'S MATCH BUT THEN
THERE HAS TO BE A FOLLOW UP- OR
WHAT WE REFER TO AS VALIDATION
OF THOSE RESULTS. PROCESS
VALIDATION- FOLLOW UP PROCESS IS
UNDER WAY AND IT'S GOING SH IT'S
TAKING PART IN A COUPLE OF WAY.
ONE ALREADY BEEN DONE FOR A
SAMPLE OF PROVIDERS- THROUGH
ONSITE. VISITS OR ASSESSMENTS.
AND THEN FURTHER TO THE OTHERS
WE ARE WORKING THROUGH A PROCESS
THAT WILL BE- SUBMISSION OF
DOCUMENTATIONS THAT CAN BE
REVIEWED BY THE STATE REGIONAL
CENTER. AND OTHERS TO VERIFY THE
RESULTS OF THE MEET THE
ASSESSMENT THAT THE PROVIDERS OF
DOT. ALSO ASKED ABOUT WHAT WILL
OCCUR- IF CALIFORNIADOESN'T
NEED COMPLIANCE AND SO. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE WAY SAID THAT-
THAT OF THE STATE WIDE
TRANSITION PLAN NOT ONLY HAVE TO
INCLUDE A TESTAMENT TO
COMPLIANCE. BUT ALSO HAVE TO
OUTLINED WHAT IS THE ONGOING
MONITORING PROCESS. TO ENSURE
ORCHARDS AT. THE POPE THE STATE
CAN BE A AND THAT ULTIMATE. THE
CENTERS FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID SERVICES CAN BE AWARE
OF HOW THE STATE IS DOING IS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE SETTINGS
REQUIRE. SO WE'RE GONNA
DISSIPATE THAT REPORTING ON AN
ONGOING BASIS ON OUR- COMPLIANCE
AND HOW THE STATE IS DOING IS
GOING TO BE PART OF THAT ONGOING
ROUTINE REPORTING THAT WE
ALREADY DO. AND THAT INCLUDES-
MAJORS RIGHT NOW IN OTHER AREAS
NOT RELATED TO SENATE
REQUIREMENTS BUT- ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS HEALTH AND WELFARE
FINANCIAL ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OTHERS. ONCE AGAIN THAT'S A SO
THIS IS ANOTHER REQUIREMENT THAT
WE ARE EXPECTING TO. HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO REPORT ON TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND YOU KNOW
ALREADY YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT
THE STATUS OF- THE FEDERAL
COMPLIANCE NOW YOU KNOW THAT'S
GOING TO BE AFFECTED SAID WITH
THE OTHER FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
IS GONNA BE MONITORED ON A
CONTINUING BASIS WE'RE TALKING
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT- THE DEFENSE
REQUIREMENTS THE RESULTS OF THE
PROVIDER SELF ASSESSMENT- ARE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE. AS WE CONTINUE THE
VALIDATION OR FOLLOW UP
ACTIVITIES THAT I TALKED ABOUT
WILL UPDATE THAT INFORMATION
WHICH GIVES AN OUTLINE OF WHERE
WE ARE THE NUMBER OF PROVIDERS
THAT ARE. IN COMPLIANCE AND
THOSE THAT ARE NOT. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO UPDATE INFORMATION
THE STATISTICS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE
REGULARLY AS REQUIRED BY CURRENT
STATUTE. BUT THERE'S A FINAL
QUESTION ABOUT HOW TO THE WORK
ON THE SETTINGS REQUIREMENTS
INTERACT WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE RATE MODELS THANK HERE IT'S
REALLY- HELPFUL TO NOTE THAT
WHAT IS REQUIRE WHAT IS WHAT ARE
THE SETTINGS REQUIREMENTS OF
ABOUT IN AT A HIGH LEVEL YOU
KNOW THAT THE CORE OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS IS THE FOCUS ON
CHOICE. AND THE QUALITY OF
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCE THAT SO
IN SHORT IT'S ABOUT ESTABLISHING
THE COURT IN A PERSON CENTRED
WAY. THAT LEAD TO POSITIVE
OUTCOMES. YES WE ARE A LOT OF
TALK TODAY ABOUT NOT ONLY ARE
QUALITY INCENTIVE PROGRAMS BUT
THERE'S ALSO BEEN REFERENCE YOU
THE DIRECT SERVICE PROFESSIONAL
TRAINING. PROGRAM ALL THE
LOOKING AT LOSING ABOUT
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
COMPETENT SERVICES AND AN
INDIVIDUAL CAN PROVIDE DOLLARS
LOCAL BILINGUAL TYPE AND THAT
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING GENTLEMEN AS
WELL. ALL THOSE MAYOR TO GAS
WITH WELL I THE RATE MODEL
REALLY GOING TO SUPPORT- IN THE
WAKE REFORM THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER THIS YEAR TO REALLY LEAD
TO THAT PERSON THAT ARE POSITIVE
OUTCOME BASED THAT. INFO ALONG
WITH THE QUALITY INCENTIVES THAT
WORK IN PERFORMANCE AND THAT
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT EARLIER
SCHNALL WHAT WHAT CAN IN HAND
NOT JUST THE RIGHT MODEL FOR ALL
OF THESE INVESTMENT. THAT REALLY
GO TOWARDS- BUILDING AND
SUPPORTING THEM LAYING THE
GROUNDWORK SO THAT WE CAN MEET-
OVERALL THAT. THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS. THANK YOU THINK WE
ARE COVERED THE INFORMATION
QUESTIONS ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND CERTAINLY HAPPY
TO RESPOND TO QUESTIONS LATER.
THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- CHRISTOPHER
O'NEILL WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- NOTHING TO NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD TO THE
PRESENTATION. NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM SUNNY PADDOCK WITH THE L.
L. I WE ALSO DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
ADDITIONAL TO ADD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
APPRECIATED THE DEPARTMENT'S
ANSWERS AND WE'LL BE FOLLOWING
UP WIT MORE DETAILS AND WITH
THAT WE WILL BE COMPLETING PANEL%
NUMBER ISSUE EIGHT AND MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE OUR LAST
DISCUSSION OF THE DAY WHERE WE
WILL HAVE EIGHT PRISONERS ON
THIS PANEL DISCUSSING. THE
IMPLEMENTATION REVIEW AND
OVERSIGHT OF VARIOUS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE INITIATIVES AND THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM WILL
BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR BARGE MAN
FOLLOWED BY BRIAN WINFIELD KARLA
CASTANEDA CHRISTOPHER ODD MEAL
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE L. A. O.
TIM CHEN WHO'S THE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR FOR DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED BABY ON HAN SENIOR
ATTORNEY WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AN AMY WEST WING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ARCA. LET
US PLEASE BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR
PARCHMENT ALL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THE NUMBER OF INITIATIVES
THE ONE THAT I'M IN A- PROVIDE A
QUICK UPDATE ON IS- RELATED TO
ITEM C. AND THE AGENDA ON PAGE
THIRTY SEVEN AND THAT'S THE-
LANGUAGE ACCESS AND CALL
CULTURAL COMPETENCY- WE ARE
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO USING
THE FUNDS THAT WERE EARMARKED
FOR THE DEPARTMENT- FOR THE
COMMUNITY. IN LANGUAGE ACCESS
AND CULTURAL COMPETENCY- ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS AND- THE INITIAL
GUIDELINES FOR REGIONAL CENTERS
SHOULD BE OUT BY- APRIL FIRST
WE'VE BEEN MEETING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS GETTING SOME.
INFORMATION AS TO PRIORITIES ON
THIS INITIAL INVESTMENT WHY WE
WORK ON THIS NEXT YEAR ON WHAT
ARE THE PRIORITIES- I'M GOING
FORWARD AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE REALLY EXPANDING BE
COMPETENCY AND CULTURAL
RESPONSIVENESS OF OUR REGIONAL
CENTERS AND YOU SEEN. THE
INVESTMENT IN IN THE FUNDS TO
I'M EFFECT CHANGE- SOME FEEDBACK
THAT WE'VE ALREADY RECEIVED FROM
OUR COMMUNITY. THANK GOODNESS
REALLY TAKE A LOOK AT OUR THE
INTAKE PACKET OR THE INFORMATION
THAT IS PROVIDED TO- FAMILIES
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE NOT ONLY
TO OUR THAT NEXT COMMUNITY BUT
OUR AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
AND AN API SO WE'RE REALLY GOING
TO BE TAKING A LOOK AT YOU KNOW
ARE THERE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO
STATEWIDE AS WELL AS REGIONAL
CENTER SPECIFIC CAN BE
RESPONSIVE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
I'M ALSO LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN
TAILOR- ASSESSMENT SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE DIVERSE COMMUNITIES- BUT
LOOKING AT EACH REGIONAL CENTERS
TO THE COMMUNITIES THAT- THEY-
SERVIN WHERE THEY'RE PROVIDING-
THE SUPPORT. OF WE'RE
APPROACHING THIS- INITIALLY AS
HAVING BASE FUNDING THAT WOULD
BE ALLOCATED TO REGIONAL CENTERS
AND I'M REALLY LOOKING AT THOSE
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT HAVE A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF- FAMILIES
THAT ARE MONOLINGUAL- AND ALSO
LOOKING AS TO A ALLOCATION AND
THAT WOULD BE GREATER FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE GREATER DIVERSITY IN
OUR COMMUNITY. THAT WE ALREADY
KNOW HAVE- ACT ACCESS ISSUES
BASED ON CULTURE OR LANGUAGE
UNTIL WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS AND
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL UPDATES OF
SWEET FURTHER- THE DISCUSSIONS
AND- IDENTIFY OUTCOMES WITH THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE FUNDS- IN MY
COLLEAGUE- THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR BRIAN WENT BILL'S GOING
TO. ADDRESS THE NEXT SET OF
QUESTIONS. YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE COFFEE ADDRESSING SELF
DETERMINATION AND SOCIAL
RECREATION AND CAN'T SERVICES
AFTERNOON. WITH REGARDS TO THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS ASKED WAS HOW
MANY OF THE PARTICIPANTS CHOICE
SPECIALISTS HAVE BEEN RECRUITED
AND HIRED BY REGIONAL CENTERS.
AND AS OF TO DATE A REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE HIRED TWENTY SIX OF
THOSE- STAFF. THERE ARE A COUPLE
OF REGIONAL CENTERS THAT HAVE-
FILLS ALL THREE OF THEIR
POSITIONS AND THEN OTHER
REGIONAL CENTRES- EITHER ONE OR
TWO. OR ARE IN ACTIVE
RECRUITMENT AND EXPECT TO HAVE
THOSE POSITIONS FILLED- I
OFTENTIMES IN FEBRUARY OR EVEN
MARCH. THE HOME THESE PARTISAN
CHOI SPECIAL. WILL BE SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS AND REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICE OPTIONS THAT%
INCREASED CONSUMER CHOICE AND
CONTROL AND PARTICIPANT DIRECTED
SERVICES AND THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM- THEY WILL
NOT CARRY CASELOADS. THEREFORE
THEY'LL BE FULLY DEDICATED TO
SUPPORTING THE REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICE COORDINATORS AS THEY ARE
ASSISTING CONSUMERS AND FAMILIES
WITH TIMELY TRANSITIONS TO THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM. AND
BUILDING THE REGIONAL CENTER IN
TUESDAY INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE
REGARDING PARTICIPANT DIRECTED
SERVICE OPTIONS WHICH INCLUDE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM. FROM
WHAT THE QUESTIONS ASKED HAS TO
DO WITH THE GOALS AROUND EQUITY
BEING INCORPORATED INTO
ENROLLMENT DIRECTORS WITH
REGIONAL CENTERS- IN NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY ONE THE DEPARTMENT ISSUED
A DIRECTIVE TO REGIONAL CENTRES
WITH REGARDS TO. THE DUTIES OF
THE PARTICIPANT DIRECTED
SERVICES A SPECIALIST AND
REQUIRED THE REGIONAL CENTER TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A CAP
REGION TRAINING PLAN ABOUT THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAMS FOR
THEIR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES SERVED%
BY REGIONAL CENTER- INCLUDING IN
CONGREGATE SETTINGS. AND ALREADY
HE HAS PART OF A TWENTY ONE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. IN THESE
PLANS THE INFORMATION. IT SAYS
THE INFORMATION WILL BE IN PLAIN
LANGUAGE ALTERNATE FORMATS AND
OUTRIGGERS MODES OF
COMMUNICATION AND IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES AND THAT THE REGIONAL
SENSIBILITY INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING CONSUMERS
AND FAMILIES THAT REFLECT THE
ETHNIC AND LANGUAGE DIVERSITY OF
THE REGIONAL CENTERS CONSUMERS
ABOUT THE- EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
OUTREACH AND TRAINING AND OTHER
ACTIVITIES THAT MAY BE EFFECTIVE
IN REDUCING DISPARITIES IN THESE
PROGRAMS. ON THE PARTICIPANT'S
CHOICE SPECIALIST WILL EXPAND
THE AWARENESS OF PARTICIPANT
DIRECTED SERVICE OPTIONS THROUGH
THESE EFFORTS AND IDENTIFY
CONCERNS AND BARRIERS TO
ENROLLMENT- REDUCE. SHARES AND
BUY FROM AFTER TRAIN TO CONSUMER
. AND FAMILIES AND OF THE
PARTISAN DIRECT DIRECTED OPTIONS
. AS WE PREVIOUSLY AT TESTIFIED
TODAY ALL THE WORK FOR
DEPARTMENT DOES HISTORY TO THE
LENS OF SERVICE ACCESS AND
EQUITY AND WITH REGARDS TO SELF
DETERMINATION IT'S NO DIFFERENT-
IT IS OUR GOAL TO ENSURE THAT
THE PROGRAM IS AVAILABLE. TO ALL
AND REFLECTS THE DIVERSITY OF
CONSUMERS SERVED BY THE REGIONAL
CENTER AND THAT DISPARITIES IN
THE SIZE OF THE BUDGETS ARE
REDUCED- WE ARE CLOSELY
MONITORING THE S. THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM IN A
PROMISE BY REGIONAL CENTER AND
BY ETHNICITY AND WHERE NECESSARY
I'M TAKING ACTION. WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND OUR
STAKEHOLDERS. TO HELP INCREASE
EQUITY ACCESS DDS IS A WOMAN IN
A NUMBER OF ITEMS- DOING NOT
REACHING TRAINING TO THE
COMMUNITIES AS WE TALKED BEFORE
ABOUT THE ARTIST CONTRACTED
SERVICES SPECIALIST BUT- I'M
ALSO- THIS IS PART OF THAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S MISSION AS WELL. WE
WILL SOON BE ISSUING GUIDANCE TO
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT- PERTAINS
TO THE LOCAL VOLUNTEER ADVISORY
COMMITTEE FUNDING. THAT PROVIDES
A FOCUS ON USING THESE FUNDS TO
INCREASE ACCESS FOR THE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES SERVED BY THE
REGIONAL CENTER- OTHER WAYS THAT
HOW WE'RE EXPANDING INTO SUPPORT
FOR ENROLLMENT- DECIDES TO
PURCHASE NAY CHOI SPECIALISTS.
AND WE'RE ALSO DEVELOPING
ENHANCED TRANSITION SUPPORTS
WILL BE FOCUSED ON MORE
INDIVIDUALLY TAILORED SUPPORT
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES HE SUPPORTS WILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL FUNDING AND
THE SUPPORT COMPONENTS WILL BE
UNBUNDLED TO BEST MEET
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS- WE'RE ALSO
HAVE A STATEWIDE ORIENTATION
CONTRACTS THROUGH THE STATE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. ALL TRAINING
MATERIALS WILL BE IN PLAIN
LANGUAGE PROVIDED IN ENGLISH AND
SPANISH AND OTHER LANGUAGES HAS
REQUESTED BY CONSUMERS AND
FAMILIES. THE TRAINING WILL BE
DELIVERED AND MODULES. FOR
CONSUMERS AND FAMILY MEMBERS CAN
ACCESS THE SPECIFIC INFORMATION
THEY NEED. IN ADDITION TO LIVE
TRAINING SESSIONS THE TRAINING
WILL BE POSTED ON LIGHTS THAT
CAN BE EASILY ACCESSIBLE- ALSO
DEVELOPMENT OF ADDITIONAL
TRANSITION SUPPORTS PROVIDED BY
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT SERVICES
PROVIDED DURING THE TWO MONTHS
HE NEATLY PRIOR TO THE
ENROLLMENT. WE'VE HEARD THAT
THAT'S A VERY- TO INDIVIDUALS
AND ROLLING INTO SELF
DETERMINATION AS A WORKING ON A
WAY IN WHICH OUR FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT SERVICES CAN ASSIST
INDIVIDUALS. PRIOR TO THAT THAT
INITIAL. ENROLLMENT STP- SO HAS
WE MOVE FORWARD WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THE EQUITY IN ACCESS TO
THE PROGRAM- BY DEVELOPING
TARGETS AND BENCHMARKS WHICH
WILL INCLUDE AREAS SUCH AS
TIMELY ENROLLMENT. DIVERSITY OF
CONSUMER SURVEY AND REDUCTION OF
DISPARITIES IN THE PROGRAM. I
WILL BE REVIEWING INDIVIDUAL
BUDGETS EXCEEDING IDENTIFIED
THRESHOLDS TO IDENTIFY TRENDS
AND NEED FOR ADDITIONAL PROGRAM
GUIDANCE. AND A REVIEW OF
INFORMATION RECEIVED THROUGH THE
PARTICIPATORY SPECIALIST AND
THREE WITH THE ORIENTATIONS ARE
CONDUCTED BY THE STATE COUNCIL
ON DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
OUR LAST QUESTION IS- HOW HAS
TVS IN THE HOMELESS PERSON USED
TO STATEWIDE SELF DETERMINATION
ADVISORY COMMITTEE'S REPORTTO
ON BARRIERS TO IMPROVE ACCESS.
FIRST AS YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE
OF SELF DETERMINATION HAD A
THREE YEAR PHASE AND WAS OPEN TO
ALL REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMERS
EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- THE STATUTE WAS
AMENDED TO REQUIRE REGIONAL
CENTERS TO ME SELF DETERMINATION
TARGETS AS WELL AS BENCHMARKS.
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE ALL THOSE
TARGETS AND BENCHMARKS- WILL BE
DEVELOPED AND WITH THE I. OF
INCREASING ACCESS TO ALL
ETHNICITIES- WE'VE ENTERED INTO
THE INTER AGENCY AGREEMENT WITH
THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL SWEDISH FOR
ORIENTATION AS I MENTIONED. AND
THE CHARACTERISTICS. OF THAT
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED- LOS- ISSUE
FRANKLY I QUESTIONS AND IF
DIRECT AND GUIDANCE TO REGIONAL
CENTRES- SENSE THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE PASSED IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO PROVIDE MORE STRUCTURE
AND FRAMEWORK AROUND THE PROGRAM
- DDS AND REGIONAL CENTERS WILL
PROVIDE TRAINING TO ALL THE
SERVICE COORDINATORS IMPAIR
HEARING SPECIALIST. ON THE
PRINCIPLES OF SELF DETERMINATION
THE MECHANICS OF THE SELF
PROCLAIMED TERMINATION PROGRAM
AND THE RIGHTS OF CONSUMERS AND
FAMILIES ARE THESE TRAINING WILL
BE CONDUCTED IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND
THE LOCAL VOLUNTEER ADVISORY
COMMITTEES. LASTLY WE DID
ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF
OMBUDSPERSON. FOR SELF
DETERMINATION AND THAT PERSON
WAS APPOINTED BY OUR DIRECTOR ON
OCTOBER TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- JEFF THE INFORMATION IS ON
OUR WEBSITE AND WE- HOLD PUBLIC
MEETINGS TO- PUBLICIZE THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE
OMBUDSPERSON. AND WE ARE ALSO-
ESTABLISHING THE ENTIRE- OFFICE
OF THE OMBUDSMAN BUT THAT
POSITION CURRENTLY EXISTS TO.
RECEIVE INPUT FROM THE COMMUNITY
TO PROVIDE ADVOCACY AND TO
REDUCE BARRIERS TO ACCESS TO THE
PROGRAM. NEXT I'LL TALK BRIEFLY
ABOUT THE RESTORATION OF SOCIAL
RACK RECREATION A CAPTAIN
SERVICES- ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
POSED WAS HOW CAN THE STATE
CLARIFY USES SO THAT THE
RESTORATION DOES NOT NECESSARILY
RESULT INTO MANAGEMENT OTHER
SERVICES LIKE RESPITE- THE
DEPARTMENT HAS RECEIVED A FEW
INCREASE FROM FAMILIES ABOUT
SOCIAL RECREATION AT CAMP AND SO
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE
CLARIFICATION TO THE FAMILY
MEMBERS- ONE OF THE WAYS THAT WE
HAVE PROVIDED LEADERSHIP AND
CLARIFICATION IS THROUGH OTHER
REVIEW AND APPROVAL OF REGIONAL
CENTER PURCHASE OF SERVICE
POLICIES. THESE ARE POLICIES
THAT ARE USED BY REGIONAL CENTER
STAFF TO HELP GUIDE THEM ON THE
PURCHASE OF SERVICES AND SO THE
DEPARTMENT HAS A REALLY CRITICAL
ROLE IN ENSURING THAT THOSE
POLICIES COMPLY WITH UP STATUTES
AND REGULATIONS IN AND COURT
DECISIONS SO WE'VE BEEN DOING
THAT ON ON GOING BASIS. BOB WE
HAVE BEEN PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO REGIONAL CENTERS
ON THE RESTORATION OF SOCIAL
RECREATION CAMP. AT ALSO
REQUIRED EACH OF THE REGIONAL
CENTERS TO DEVELOP OUTREACH AND
TRAINING PLAN WITH A FOCUS ON
UNDERSTOOD UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR COMMUNITIES ARE. AWARE OF
THE RESTORATION AND FAMILIAR
WITH THE SERVICE OF THIS-
ANOTHER QUESTION IS WHAT IS DÍAS%
DOING OR WILL DO TO TRACK THE
IMPACT ON DISPARITIES. AGAIN THE
OUTREACH PLAN TO THE REGIONAL
CENTERS BUT THE RESULTS HAD TO
CREATE- REFLECTS THAT COMMITMENT
TO OUR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES-
WE ALSO HAVE CREATED A SOME
CODE. THAT REGIONAL CENTERS CAN
USE THAT THEY CAN IDENTIFY ALL
SERVICES THAT ARE PURCHASED FOR
SOCIAL RECREATION- SANDERS CAN
PURCHASE SOCIAL RECREATION AND A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT WAYS AND IT
ISN'T ALWAYS- OBVIOUS ON ITS
FACE THAT THAT WAS THIRTY INTO A
PURPOSE LESS SOCIAL RECREATION.
SO THROUGH THE USE OF THE SUB
CODE I WILL BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
I'M ALL OF THOSE. EXPENDITURES
LAST QUESTION WHAT IS THE
CURRENT YEAR LEVEL OF
EXPENDITURE STATEWIDE SO FAR BY
REGIONAL CENTER AND THE OUT
REACH EFFORTS- WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING. THE DATA
ON A MONTH BY MONTH BASIS IT'S A
LITTLE EARLY I'M IN THE PROCESS
TO SEE A HUGE INCREASE. REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN-
BUILDING UP THEIR PROVIDER
NETWORKS TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES- THEY HAVE BEEN USING A
VARIETY OF FORMS FOR. MAKING THE
COMMUNITY AWARE OF THEM THEY'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING THE SERVICES AND
THE CONTACT OF INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAM PLAN MEETINGS. AND
ALTHOUGH WE DO HAVE SOME
PURCHASE A SERVICE DATA THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT- IF THERE'S JUST
NOT ENOUGH YET TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION ON ON THE USAGE
YET. I'M LAST ARE CLOSE WITH
SOME OF THE AVERAGE EFFORTS BY
REGIONAL CENTERS WHICH ARE
DEVELOPMENT OF TRAINING
MATERIALS- SUCH AS NARRATED
POWER POINTS IN FACT SHEETS. A
PUBLIC MEETINGS WHICH INCLUDE
TOWN HALLS A COMMUNITY
INFORMATION SESSIONS IN VIRTUAL
MEETINGS. A REGIONAL CENTER
CULTURAL SPECIALIST PROVIDING
OUTREACH ON THE AVAILABILITY OF
THE SERVICES- USING THEIR
WEBSITES AND SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTINGS. ARE TRAINING FOR
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF.
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM PLANNED
MEETINGS HAVE A PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED. OF GENDER OUTREACH
AND DINNER MEETINGS. AND
DISCUSSIONS WITH COMMUNITY
GROUPS SUCH AS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS FROM THE TORAH'S.
TRAININGS FOR PEER MENTORS AND
FOCUS KICK MEETINGS. AND LASTLY
PROVIDING A RESOURCE LISTINGS ON
THEIR WEBSITES INTO. THEIR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE WILL HEAR FROM CAR CAST.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING ASKING
OTHER DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND I
WILL ADDRESS OUT THE QUESTIONS
IN A AND WILL. FARM REGARDING
THAT THE GENERAL QUESTIONS
RELATED TO INVESTMENTS BOB PAGE
OF THIRTY NINE AND FORTY HAVE A
LIST OF THE INVESTMENTS THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT INFORMATIONAL CENTERS
WERE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
RECRUITING AND HIRING TO FILL A
NUMBER OF THOSE POSITIONS- SOME
OF THE OTHER. M. INITIATIVES OR
- TO HAVE WILL A LONGER TERM
WRAP UP. DEVELOP BASED ON LAST
INFORMATION- WORKING SEE SOME
THE PROJECTS TO LATER IN STILL
DEPENDING ON HOW ANDTHOSE RISKS
CAN GET UP AND RUNNING BUT OUR
IS DIRECTLY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE BALL IS MAINTAINING SO- MALL
THERE WILL BE ONGOING
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND THAT
THE STOCK DISCUSSIONS- DEPENDING
ON WHEN. WE'RE FOREST THERE
THERE MAY BE SOME DELAYS.
REGARDING THE INVEST FOR THE AND
IMPROVE THAT AREN'T THE
TECHNOLOGY- WE ARE ALL IN THIS
THIS FIVE FOR OFFICE- WHERE HAVE
PRIOR TO OF STAFF TO THE PROJECT
. AND WE'RE CURRENTLY
COORDINATING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY TO. WORK WITH OUR
LARGER STAKEHOLDER BURKE SO I
THOUGHT BACK TO KIDS AND
FAMILIES LOOKING TO IDENTIFY
SOME OF THE MORE IMPORTANT
INFORMATION. FOR LISTING
COMPONENT OF THE CLIENTS.
CURRENT RECORD SYSTEM AND THEN
OF COURSE REGIONAL CENTERS WILL
BE INCLUDED IN PROVIDERS ON SOME
OF THE INFORMATION OF EXISTING
AND NEW DATA FOR SOME OF THE
FUTURE. NEEDS OF. WE'LL JUST
TELL YOUR QUESTION- WE HAVE THE
ARE WE WERE AWARE A FEW STATES
THAT HAVE. DEVELOPED FROM CHECK
SYSTEMS SO RESTART TO GET SOME
OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS TO
IDENTIFY WITH SOME OF THEIR
CHALLENGES ARE IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES WORK HOPING OF COURSE TO
LEARN FROM THAT- LEVERAGE ANY OF
THAT. EFFORT WE'RE ALSO LOOKING
TO LEVERAGE ANY OPPORTUNITIES
FROM THE CURRENT DATA EXCHANGE
FRAMEWORK THAT THEY CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
IS COORDINATING. SO ALTHOUGH THE
TYPICAL TIMELINE FOR THESE
PROJECTS CAN TAKE SEVERAL YEARS
TO COMPLETE GIVEN THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF THE PROJECT- WE WILL BE
LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO
ACCELERATE AND OF COURSE BASED
ON SOME OF THE LESSONS LEARNED
FROM OTHER ENTITIES. MAKE SOME
OF THOSE IMPROVEMENTS. I THINK
ISSUE FIVE THIS OF THE DISK
TALKED ABOUT. HOW WE MIGHT
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE
PERFORMANCE SPACE MEASURES
WITHOUT THE SYSTEMS IN PLACE.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE CLEAREST
DISTINCTIONS WAS. BROUGH BURKE
FIFTY AT THE END OF SOME OF THIS
WILL ALLOW US TO INCORPORATE
SOME OF THAT THAT DATA NEEDS IN
THE SYSTEMS TODAY- AND IN THE
MEANTIME SHORT TERM WE WOULD BE
LOOKING AT WAYS TO VENTURES THAT
WE CAN ACCOMPLISH WITH. SURVEYS
OR- WOW PROJECTIONS TO THE
EXISTING SYSTEMS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
CHRIS I'D MAIL WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- CHRIS SUTTON
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD. NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE L.
L. THANK YOU DR AMBULANCE
MEDICAL WITH THE LA- O. AND- THE
AGENDA REYES TO MANY OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE HAD HAD WHICH
THE DEPARTMENT RESPONDED TO SO
I'LL JUST KEEP IT- ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS BRIEF BUT- OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN AND I'M SURE THIS IS
EVERYBODY'S PRIMARY CONCERN IS
JUST ENSURING THAT THESE MANY
NEW INITIATIVES ARE ARE
IMPLEMENTED SUCCESSFULLY. AND TO
THE BENEFIT OF INDIVIDUALS
SERVED- AND WE ALSO HOPE THAT OF
COURSE IMPLEMENTATION WILL BE
EFFICIENT SO I THINK OUR MAIN
CONCERN WHICH WE REYES
THROUGHOUT THIS HEARING TODAY IS
JUST TO THE EXTENT THAT ISSUES
OR CHALLENGES IT'S BEGIN TO
ARISE OR THE DEPARTMENT HAS
NOTICED THAT MAYBE SOMETHING
NEEDS TO BE CHANGED OR MODIFIED
- WE'RE HOPING THAT- YOU KNOW
DDS WILL HAVE A- A PROCESS IN
PLACE FOR SORT OF FLANKING THESE
ISSUES AND SUGGESTING
MODIFICATIONS AND FOR KEEPING
THE- THE LEGISLATURE APPRISED.
OF THOSE CHALLENGES AND WHAT
THEY RECOMMEND- DOING IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS THOSE CHALLENGES AND
YOU KNOW I'LL JUST GIVE ONE
EXAMPLE FROM THE PAST I MEAN I
DO THINK THE SYSTEM IS IN A
DIFFERENT. DIFFERENT PLACE. NOW
THAN IT WAS IN SAY TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN BUT- AT THAT
TIME THE DEPARTMENT HAD BEEN
GIVEN FUNDING. FOR THE-
INCENTIVES FOR COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED. AND OVER THE COURSE
OF THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS IT
STARTED TO COME TO LIGHT THAT
THE DEPARTMENT WAS REALLY UNABLE
TO USE MUCH- HARDLY ANY OF THAT
FUNDING RELATED TO PROVIDE THOSE
INCENTIVES LIKE THERE IS
OBVIOUSLY A PROBLEM- IN. HOW
EMPLOYMENT WAS BEING APPROACHED
AND I MEAN THERE'S STILL A
PROBLEM WITH TRYING TO GET THOSE
INCENTIVES OUT THE DOOR SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT THOSE KINDS OF
PROBLEMS START TO CROP UP WITH
ANY OF THE NEW INITIATIVES WE
WOULD HOPE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD NOT LET THE LEGISLATURE NO
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER. SHOULD
THERE BE CHANGES IN POLICY THAT
WOULD HELP- IMPROVE. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE PROGRAMS
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM TIM CHEN
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WITH
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED. MY
NAME IS TIM CHEN I THINK THE
SYSTEM DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNICATIONS RIGHT SAID
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED.
YESTERDAY WAS MY BIRTHDAY SO I'M
GONZALEZ FORTY SEVEN HE ROLLED
CAREER IN AMERICAN MAN WHO HAS
CEREBRAL PALSY. I AM USING A
COMMUNICATION DEVICE AT THE BASE
OF MY WHEELCHAIR BY TYPING WITH
MY TOES. I AM HERE TO TELL YOU
HOW MUCH THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM HAS CHANGED MY LIFE AND
ASK YOU TO BREAK DOWN THE
BARRIERS SO THAT OTHER LIVES CAN
BE CHANGED AS WELL. I WAS IN THE
TRADITIONAL REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM FOR A VERY LONG TIME. I
WOULD HAVE TOLD YOU THAT I WAS
HAPPY WITH MY LIFE UNDER THE
BROKEN SYSTEM BECAUSE I DIDN'T
KNOW THAT I WAS EATING MEATLOAF
EVERY NIGHT WITH KETCHUP.I FELT
THIS WAY FOR PRETTY MUCH ALL OF
MY LIFE. THE AGENCIES THAT HIRE
THE PEOPLE TO SUPPORT ME NEVER
ASKED WHAT THEY COULD DO BETTER.
EVERYONE JUST ASSUMED THAT I WAS
DOING FINE. IF YOU SWITCH THE
LAST TWO LETTERS IN MY NAME IT
SPELLS T. M. HI. SO I'M GOING TO
BE VERY HONEST. UNDER THE
TRADITIONAL SYSTEM I SUFFER FROM
NEGLECT. BY STAFF CAME TO MY JOB
ONLY ONCE DURING THE DAY TO HELP
ME GO TO THE BATHROOM AND SHE'D
BE LUNCH. THIS LED TO MANY
TOILET ACCIDENTS BECAUSE I
DIDN'T HAVE SUPPORT WHEN I
NEEDED IT. I MISSED NUMEROUS
LAUNCHES BECAUSE THE AGENCIES
COULDN'T FIND RELIABLE PEOPLE TO
HELP ME. THE AGENCIES WHICH SAID
RANDOM STAFF WHO DIDN'T KNOW OR
RESPECT ME. IF I WANTED TO GO
OUT TO DINNER WITH FRIENDS OR
FAMILY I HAD TO BE HOME BY EIGHT
PM BECAUSE THAT IS WHEN THE
SHIFT CHANGE HAPPENED. I NEEDED
TO ASK. PERMISSION TO LIVE MY
LIFE. SINCE I STARTED IN THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM I'VE
BEEN SEEING FRIENDS THAT I
HAVEN'T SEEN IN A LONG TIME. I
NOW WORKOUT IN THE GYM FLOOR TO
SIX TIMES A WEEK FOR AT LEAST A
TWO HOUR SESSION. AND I HIRED
STAFF REALLY KNOW HOW TO COOK.
FINALLY THE BOTTOM LINE IS THERE
IS NO LONGER APPROVAL NEEDED
FROM A SUPERVISOR BECAUSE I AM
IN CHARGE NOW IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME THAT OTHERS HAVE
THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE SO MANY
BARRIERS TO PARTICIPATION THAT
FEW HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ENROLL.
THE SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM
FINALLY WENT STATEWIDE LAST
JUNE. AFTER A VERY SLOW PHASING
THE PROBLEMS AND BUREAUCRACY
HAVE ONLY INCREASED. THERE IS NO
CONSISTENCY BETWEEN REGIONAL
CENTERS WITH LONG DELAYS AND
STAFF PROVIDING HE WRONG
INFORMATION WE CONTINUE TO HEAR
OF REGIONAL CENTER STAFF
DISCOURAGING CLIENTS AND
FAMILIES FROM GOING INTO THE
PROGRAM PARTICULARLY PEOPLE OF
COLOR. THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
INITIAL DATA SHOW THAT THE
PROGRAM ACTUALLY REDUCING SOME
OF THE SERVICE DISPARITIES THAT
ACTUALLY THE TRADITIONAL SYSTEM
IF WE CONTINUE TO SEE PROFOUND
INEQUITIES IN THE ENROLLMENT OF
LATINOS INTO THE PROGRAM WHO ARE
DRASTICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED.
THE CRITICAL NATIONAL MANAGEMENT
SERVICES HAVE FACED THEIR OWN
BUREAUCRATIC BARRIERS WITH WHO
ALREADY LEAVING THE PROGRAM AND
OTHERS PAUSING ACCEPTING NEW
CLIENTS. THE WHOLE PROGRAM COULD
GO INTO CRISIS UNLESS SOMETHING
IS DONE TO MAKE SURE THEY ARE
ABLE TO DO THEIR JOB WITHOUT
UNNECESSARY OBSTACLES. M. THE
BENEFITS OF THE S. DE YOUNG
BUCKS PERSON HAS YET TO BE
REALIZED SGPS HASN'T HIRED A
PERMANENT PERSON FOR THE JOB YET. WHAT CAN BE DONE TO SAVE THIS
PROGRAM THAT HAS REALLY SAVED ME. OVER THE NEXT MONTH HE VICKY
YOU WILL BE PREPARING A SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PRESENT TO D.
D. S. SENATE THE LEGISLATURE.
THEY WILL FOCUS ON TGS PROVIDING
MORE CLEAR DIRECTION OVERSIGHT
AND TRAINING OF DIGITAL CENTERS
AS WELL AS SPECIFIC WAYS TO
BREAK DOWN THE BUREAUCRACY. WE
HOPE THAT TGS WILL TAKE THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE I WANT EVERYONE WITH A
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY LIKE ME
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS AMAZING PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU TEMPER PROVIDING A
GREAT VOICE. NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM CARIBBEAN HANSSON RETURNING
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA ALL. THANK YOU AND
GOOD EVENING AGAIN. HE FELT
PRETTY SHAPE THE COMMENT THAT
CAN JUST MADE ABOUT THE
TERMINATION AND BE HEARTEDLY
SUPPORT FROM. BUT WE'LL TURN TO
SOME OTHER IMPORTANT INITIATIVES
IN OUR REMARKS TODAY ALL. WE'RE
PLEASED TO KEEP DEDICATED
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET OR
LANGUAGE ACCENT AND CULTURAL
COMPETENCY. FIRST LANGUAGE
ACCESS IS A LEGAL RIGHT SO WE'RE
GLAD THAT REGIONAL CENTERS ARE
GETTING MORE FUNDING. AND LET'S
NOT FORGET THAT LANGUAGE ACCESS
ALSO MEANS RAIN LANGUAGE IT
MEANS OF TRINIDAD AMENDED
COMMUNICATION. IN EXILE INCLUDES
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT WAYS THAT
SELF ADVOCATE ADVOCATE. LANGUAGE
JACKSON'S IMPORTANT AND IT'S NOT
ENOUGH. THE PROBLEM ISN'T JUST
ABOUT HELPING PEOPLE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THEM. WE FIND THAT
USUALLY PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT REGIONAL ISN'T
TELLING THEM. AND ALL TOO OFTEN
WHAT THEY'RE HEARING IS NOW.
HELLO BECAUSE OF DIFFERENT AGE
YOU SHOULD BE FUNDING A SERVICE
NO BECAUSE THE REGIONAL CENTER
THANKS THE FAMILY MEMBER SHOULD
PROVIDE A SUPPORT FOR FREE. NO
BECAUSE THE REGIONAL CENTER
DECIDE IT KNOWS BETTER THAN THE
PERSON SAID ABOUT WHAT FACTORS
AND. THERE NEED TO BE MORE
INVESTMENT DESIGNED TO HELP
REGIONAL TENSIONS THAT. ONE OF
THOSE IS COORDINATED FAMILY
SUPPORT. A SUPPORTED LIVING LIKE
SERVICE WHAT ELSE WHO LIVE AT
HOME WITH THEIR FAMILY. SUPPORT
OF LIVING IS A SERVICE THAT MAKE
THAT POSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE TO READ
INDEPENDENTLY IN HER OWN HOME.
BUT A LOT MAKE FACTORS IS THAT
THE ELBOW. YOU CAN AFFORD TO
HAVE ON A- THREE. HURTS ADULTS
WHO LIVE IN MY GENERATES
HOUSEHOLDS WHO ARE INCREASE AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOWER INCOME
AND LATIN TAX COURT FROM OTHER
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. IT
CONTRIBUTES TO THE HOUSING
CRISIS AND EXACERBATE REGIONAL
CENTER. SO WE WERE THRILLED LAST
YEAR WITH THE CREATION OF A
SIMILAR SERVICE SPECIFICALLY FOR
PEOPLE LIVING WITH FAMILY. WHY
NEED ECONOMIC SUPPORT. WE HEARD
FROM SPECIALLY THOSE OF COLOR
WHO CALLED IT A POTENTIAL
CHANGER. HOWEVER TO DATE DDS NOT
PROVIDED CLARITY ABOUT THIS
SCOPE OF SERVICES THAT WILL BE
OFFERED UNDER THIS NEW MODEL.
NOR HAVE DEPARTMENT IDENTIFIED
HOW IT WILL ENSURE THAT THESE
SERVICES WILL ACTUALLY REACH
UNSERVED OR UNDERSERVED PEOPLE
WHO NEED IT MOST. THIS PILOT
PROJECT IS DESPERATELY NEEDED TO
EXPAND HOUSING OPTIONS TO KEEP
PEOPLE OUT OF CONGREGATE
RESIDENTIAL SETTING AND TO
DISRUPT PRODUCT DISPARITIES IN.
IT NEEDS TO BE A DOCTOR. THERE
ALSO NEEDS TO BE MORE OVERSIGHT
TO HELP REGIONAL CENTERS JACQUI
. LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT IN THE
CONTEXT OF CAMP ESPECIAL
RECREATION. THE RESTORATION OF
CAMPAIGN SOCIAL RECREATION
REPRESENTS A POTENTIALLY HUGE
STEP TOWARD REDUCING SOME OF THE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES IN
THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES THAT
. HOWEVER AS OF TODAY THESE
SERVICES REMAIN OUT OF REACH FOR
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. FOR THEM A
ROLLOUT HAS BEEN CONFUSING
BETTER SHOT AND FLOW. SOME
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE TURNING
DOWN REQUESTS WHILE THEY AWAIT
DIRECTION FROM DDR. OTHERS FELT
THE TIMELY CONDUCT OUTREACH AND
PUBLIC FIVE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE RESTORATION OF THE SERVICE.
SOME FAMILIES HAVE BEEN TOLD
THAT REGIONAL CENTERS ARE NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR TRANSPORTATION
TO THE SERVICE. WHAT THE COMPANY
OF THE CHILDREN AT ONE TO ONE
SUPPORT ISN'T. WHAT EVERY FAMILY
HAS A CAR AND NOT EVERY FAMILY
CAN TAKE TIME FROM WORK. AS
REGIONAL CENTERS DEVELOPED
REGIONS THE SERVICE POLICY ON
CAMPUS AND SPECIAL RECOGNITION
HE URGED THEM TO TAKE A VERY
CRITICAL. NOT JUST THAT EACH
WITH THE OUR- BUT HOW THEY ACT
THIS WHEN AND HOW SERVICE
COORDINATORS APPROVED REQUESTS
FOR THE SERVICES. OUR AND HOW
THE PRACTICES COULD POTENTIALLY
DESTROY RACIAL DISPARITIES OR
INADVERTENTLY PERPETUATE.
CHALLENGES ARE ILLUSTRATIVE OF A
LARGE. WHICH IS THAT EVERY
REGIONAL CENTER HAS THE ABILITY
TO DEVELOP ITS OWN POLICIES AND-
INTERNAL CONTROLS ABOUT WHEN AND
UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES IT WILL
APPROVE A SERVICE. SO WE END UP
WITH TWENTY ONE DIFFERENT LEVEL
POLICY. FOR SWEEPING CHANGES BE
INVOLVING THE CREATION OR
RECREATION ALL SERVICE TYPES WE
NEED A STRONGER MORE ACTIVE. H.
AND DDS WOULD BE FAR MORE
EFFECTIVE. FINALLY SOCIAL
RECREATION AND CAMPING AND
COORDINATED FAMILY SUPPORT
SERVICES WERE AMONG THE FEW
INITIATIVES IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AT WORK OKAY ON HIRING
MORE STAFFERS EDS AND REGIONAL
FACTORS OR ON BREAK FOR DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL. FOR
REPORTER ROLES IN THE SYSTEM
THAT IT'S NOT ABOUT. IT IS THE
BALLOT AND FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AND AFTER YEARS.
OF DOLLARS OF INVESTMENT
BUILDING OUT STAFF BUILDING OUT
EACH THE DISABLED PEOPLE DESERVE
MORE INVESTMENTS AND BALLOT IN
EXPENDITURES. THAT GO DIRECTLY
TO THEM. ONLY FINALLY HAVE THE
KIND OF DIRECT INVESTMENT OF THE
NATIONAL DESERVED TO BE
PRIORITIES AND TO KEEP
EMPLOYMENT OKAY AN URGENCY. THE
DOUBLE FOR THINGS LIKE SOCIAL
RECREATION AND COORDINATED
FAMILY SUPPORT SERVICES THAT
WERE LARGELY DESIGNED TO LIFT
THAT DISABLED PEOPLE OF COLOR
WHO'VE BEEN LEFT OUT AND LEFT
BEHIND FOR OUR- ONE. DRC URGES
REGIONAL CENTERS ET OCT.
MINISTRATION AND THE LEGISLATURE
TO WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
COMMUNITY THREE BILLION. THE
REPORT WHEN INCIDENTS IN THE
MANNER THAT DISABLED PEOPLE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM IN THE WEST
WING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ARC.
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- PRESENT ON THIS
PANEL AND ADDRESS SOME OF THE
SPECIFIC. IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS
THAT ARE GOING FORWARD RIGHT NOW
ON THE RADIO BUT MICHIGAN'S THAT
WORK ON INTRODUCED AND INCLUDED
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AND- BOTH
THE NATION'S QUICKLY OFF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE THE OIL
PIPES AND SERVICE DELIVERY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I WAS
ASKED TO SPEAK ON SPECIFIC
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS
AS WELL AS. TO MAKE HIM FOR
CONCRETE. EGGMAN DACIAN FOR. HOW
TO MAKE IT FROM ONE FACT. SO I
WANT TO SPEAK THIS EVENING-
REACH TOPICS AND I THINK
THURSDAY TO THE ONES THAT WE FOR
OTHERS PRESENT FROM THIS EVENING
ALREADY FIRST A SOCIAL
RECREATIONAL YEAH SECOND
SUPPLEMENTATION AND BIRD THE
PERFORMANCE AND SANTA BARBARA.
IT WORKED PRETTY RIGHT AND THE
IS A FINAL. OFFER ARGUS
ADVOCATING FOR THE- OF SOCIAL
WORKING CAMPS SINCE AT LEAST
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. BECAUSE HE
UNDERSTANDS THE EVIDENCE RESPOND
DRESSED UP JUST. NO DATE IS
REALLY IS THAT HAS THE UPPER TO
PROVIDE PEOPLE WITH SOMETHING
THEY DESPERATELY NEED VETERANS
GREATER ACCESS TO THEIR
COMMUNITY. WE KNOW THAT THESE
SERVICES FOR FORMALLY IN GREATER
QUANTITIES BY NON WHITE
COMMUNITIES THAT WHAT'S THE
BASIS OF OUR ADVOCACY ON THIS
ISSUE FROM YEARS. SO WE'RE GOING
TO SPEAK THAT WORKS. THAT
DOESN'T MEAN YOU CAN FOCUS WE
AND BACK TO CHIU IN. HOW THINGS
YOU TO BE AND SO OF THAT IS FOR
THE- BECAUSE WHAT WE USED HAPPEN
PLACE WHEN WE SOCIAL WORK READ
AND SERVICE SIX. BARTLETT'S
STATIC. I WHITE HOUSE CHIEF FOR
PEOPLE WITH THE BOX DISABILITIES
FOR. SINCE THE TIME. WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT. OF HOW MANY BASED
SERVICES FINAL. AND WE EXPECT
THESE SERVICES BE FOR IN THE
INTEREST BY NOW. AND SO THERE
ARE HUGE CHALLENGES WITH GETTING
THERE ONE OF THEM IT IS WITH
IDENTIFYING AND BUILDING UP OUR
PROVIDER NETWORK. MANY PROVIDERS
THAT PROVIDED THE SERVICE SINCE
ALSO PROVIDE OTHER SERVICES THAT
ARE STRETCHED THIN DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND WE ARE ENGAGING
WITH THEM TO CRIED BUILD THAT
NETWORK BACK UP. R. AS WELL AS
THE ART CALIFORNIA WILL BE CO
HOSTING A WEBINAR NEXT MONTH. TO
HELP PROVIDERS GET THROUGH THE
FACTORIZATION PROCESS
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE GLAD TO SEE
FINANCIAL TRACKING THAT WILL
HELP US TO ASSESS THE FULL
SPENDING PICTURE. IN ITS AREA.
IN OF STEPS BEING TO. WE ARE
LOOKING AT STUFF THE STUFF THAT
. FOR BLUE. SERVICE PROVIDERS
ARE WILLING TO ACCEPT PAYMENT IN
ARREARS AND ARE WILLING TO
PROVIDE INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
ACTIVITY LEVELS. AND AS A
POTENTIAL SOURCE FOR. THE NEW
YORKER TO PROVIDE THESE SERVICES
TO PHONE STILL IN THE
TRADITIONAL CIRCUMSPECT STOCK.
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE DOING OUT
REGIONALLY THESE DISCUSSIONS
ALSO DURING THEIR EXPENDITURE
COMMUNITY THINGS WHICH ARE
COMING UP SOON SO IN THIS ONE
THERE IS PROGRESS BEING MADE AND
IT JUST NEEDS A BIT MORE TIME TO
COME TO FULL FRUITION. IN TERMS
OF SELF DETERMINATION THANK YOU
FOR THAT EIGHT IF YOU WERE
PROGRAM IS HAVINGTODAY IT IS
IT'S HAVING GROWING. PUBLIC ****
BURLINGTON FRIEDMAN BUT. IT'S
FAR AWAY. THE BIGGEST ISSUE
RIGHT NOW. WHICH HAS BEEN A WILL
TO ALL BUSY THINK YOU THIS WAY
THE- FINANCIAL MEANT SERVICES.
INCLUDING ACCESS. AND WE OTHERS
BY THERE ARE CHEN WITH THIS. AND
APPRECIATE IT APARTMENTS IN
ALMOST ALL. AND THERE IS TO
SCHEDULE NEXT WEEK CHOI. HOW THE
MAKE THE FMS SYSTEM WORK BETTER
FOR PROVIDING. ALSO VOTERS IN
THE WHO WANT TO THE SUBJECT
NATION FOR. ANYTHING OVERALL THE
QUESTION IN THE CELL DETERMINED
FOR. THINK ABOUT EQUITY AND
ACCESS IS HOW TO MAKE THE
PROGRAM LAST FIVE INTENSIVE
OVERALL. IN TERMS OF THE BOOK
AND SECOND PROGRAM WERE BROUGHT
TO FIT WITH THE SYSTEM IS GOING
UP OF THE- OF SERVICES ON PEOPLE
LIVES. THIS IS THE RIGHT THING.
MEASURE HOW WE CAN PEOPLE'S
LIVES RATHER JUST WHAT PROVIDE
ABOUT. WE ARE. THAT PERFORMANCE
VENTURE FOR ME FOR ALL PUT ON AS
OUR- TO. MAKE SURE THAT AND
BRING. THIS IS AN ALBUM AND-
UNDER BY IT ABSOLUTELY NO RIGHT
THING TO DO. WE THAT THIS BURKE
ABOUT AND FOR NATION WHICH IS
THE DIRECT SERVICE THAT
EVERYONE'S BY A REGIONAL
RECEIVES. AN OBSCURE WEAPON. FOR
STRENGTH. THE SENATE GOING.
NUMBER WE ARE EXCITED TO SEE BE
IMPRESSED IN B. INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS WE NOTE THAT
IS BOTH SYSTEMS THE BELLHOPS
WHICH WILL OUR CAPACITY THAT
MEASURE WHO REPORTS CENTERED OUT
. AND THE SECOND IS THAT WE HAVE
A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW.
TO PREVENT THAT THE STATE OF THE
INVESTMENT IN SERVICE. PORTAL
YOU SHOULD. AND THIS TIME DONE.
AS OUR AND AS THE IDEA WHO
OPPOSE- UNDERLYING CENTER
FUNDING KNOWN AS THE STAFF AND
FOR ON THE FORM HE IS REGIONAL
ONLY PROPERTY OFF THE BACKS
FIRING EACH SERVER FOR MANY. AND
THAT'S BROKEN THE CASE WILL
RAISE APART FIND RIGHTS AND WHAT
ARE SIGNIFICANT TO THE ALWAYS
PRIVATE YEAH ARMADA FOR YEAR IN
. WITH A COMMITMENT TO KEEP
FORMULA WITH SOME PURPOSE
MILLION MISTER FOR SYSTEM FOR I
WOULD PROVIDE IT WITH THE SERVER
PART THAT THEY CAN BE TO THEM
NOW THE OF THAT SORT LEVELS THAT
COME WITH DISABILITY SERVICE
THAT'S. AT THOSE ARE GOING
STRONG ITS RECORD. BUT I CAN
MAKE AN ABOUT FIVE. RICH GAVE.
I'LL OF IMPLEMENTATION. SO AS WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS I BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE THE
RIGHT OVERSIGHT AND- I'M GLAD
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO. PROVIDE
AND- HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
HOW WE CAN MAKE IMPROVEMENTS TO
THE MULTITUDE OF PROGRAMS THAT
WERE BEGAN LAST YEAR. WITH THAT
I WILL SAVE MY QUESTIONS AND
FOLLOW UP AS I REALLY AGREED ON
THE NEED FOR US TO HAVE FOCUS
AND URGENCY TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE PROGRAMS
AS I BELIEVE THEY WILL ALLOW US
TO. WORK TOWARDS A MORE
EQUITABLE SYSTEM FOR ALL IN
RTD'S. SYSTEM WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT RE ITERATE THAT
IF THE DEPARTMENT HAS NOT
PROVIDED WRITTEN RESPONSES
PREVIOUSLY TO OUR QUESTIONS CAN
WE PLEASE WORK WITH MY STAFF SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE THAT
INFORMATION BY EARLY APRIL. THE
ONLY QUESTION I HAVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS NANCY
BERGERON- WE WILL PROVIDE THE
WRITTEN RESPONSES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS. AND AS A REMINDER WE
WELCOME PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY
ISSUE IN OUR AGENDA. WE HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND THEREFORE I WANT TO
URGE YOU TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
BRIEF SO THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM
EVERYONE. WE WILL START WITH
ANYONE IN PERSON AND SEEING NO
ONE CURRENTLY HERE WE WILL NOW
GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AS A REMINDER AT THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD
BE ON THE SCREEN OF YOUR
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. AND
THE NUMBER IS. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR FOUR. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
TWENTY NINETY INE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. OPERATOR
WE ARE READY TO BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT OVER THE PHONE TODAY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND FIRST WE WILL GO TO LINE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR MIKE IT I'M
SORRY WE LOST FIFTY FIVE AT
FIRST WE WILL GO TO LINE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY. YES I'M HERE CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK. LOUD AND CLEAR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- CARL LUNDEN A
MAP THE ALLIANCE FORTY PEOPLE
WITH TYPE II OUR ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING PROVIDERS THAT DOWN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FIRST I
WANT TO- ASSOCIATE ARE
ORGANIZATIONS WITH THE RATE
STUDY COMMENTS MADE BY JORDAN
LINDSAY TODAY BY THAT- PERHAPS
THE LAND RENT COALITION- ONE
THING I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS FROM
COMMENTS MADE EARLIER BY REPS.
FOR A DISABILITY BOYCE'S UNITED
D. R. C. THEY'RE SOMEWHAT
MISLEADING. FIRST IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR ALL REMEMBER THAT ANY RAISES
IN RATES GIVEN TO PROVIDER
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUBJECT TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CAP. OF FIFTEEN
PERCENT. THAT IS BEEN PLACE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS. SO THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF ANY
FUNDS GOING TO PROVIDERS GHOST
RECKLESSNESS SERVICES ON THE
WAGES OF STAFF BY LAW. SAKET YOU
CAN'T SIMPLY THEN IGNORE THE
FACT THAT OTHER COSTS SUCH AS
WORKERS COMP. UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE RATE GAS OTHER ITEMS.
HAVE RISEN AND MUST ALSO BE
ADDRESSED- NO PER IS INVOLVED
THE PROVIDER IN THEIR COMMUNITY
UNLESS BY CHOICE IS CONSTRUCTED
THEIR INDIVIDUALIZED PROGRAM
PLANNED. SOME MAY THINK THAT THE
SYSTEM NEEDS TO BE REINVENTED TO
ACCOMPLISH A- PERSON CENTERED
APPROACH. THE FACT IS THAT THERE
ARE YOU JUST THAT WAY- I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO BRIEFLY COMMENT ON
THE EMPLOYMENT ISSUE AND
REITERATED COMMENTS MADE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MATHIS RUBIO
AND YOURSELF. DESPITE PASSING AN
EMPLOYMENT FIRST RATE STATUTE
INTO LAW IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. OUR PRIMARY FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH IDEAS CONTINUE
TO STAY FLAT. AND EVEN DROP IN
IT'S NOT AS THE DEPARTMENT SAYS
SIMPLY DUE TO THE PANDEMIC. A
MAJOR CONCERN WE HAVE IS THAT
THE DATA ON EMPLOYMENT OF OUR
POPULATION SIMPLY INADEQUATE. AS
AN EXAMPLE YOU YOU. AND YOUR
COMMITTEES OVER TIME BOB PRICE
CLOSE TO A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT AND PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAMS. WE SHOULD
KNOW HOW WAS THE CONCERT WORKING
DEFINITIVELY BUT WE DON'T WE
DON'T HAVE THE DATA THAT SHOWS
THE QUALITATIVE QUANTITATIVE
OUTCOMES FROM THESE PROGRAMS.
THE DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSAL TO
SPEND EIGHT MILLION NOW IN A
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT. IN
EMPLOYMENT IS VAGUE AND WE URGE
YOU GET MORE DETAILS ON HOW THIS
WILL ADDRESS. THESE ISSUES
BEFORE MAKING ANY COMMITMENTS. I
ALSO URGE YOU CONSIDER OFFRAMP
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB SIX
THIRTY NINE. IF WE DON'T HAVE
GOOD DATA. ANY GAME PLAN IN
PLACE THAT WILL WORK- ALSO ONE
TO RAISE THE SOMETHING NOT IN
YOUR AGENDA AFFECTING. UP AND
DOWN STATE. WHEN THE CULPRIT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HIT IN MARCH
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. MANY
PROVIDERS WHICH ARE BUSINESSES
TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S OFFER FOR PPP
LOANS. LARGELY BECAUSE IT WAS
UNCERTAIN. AS TO HOW THEY WOULD
KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN WHEN THE
ONLY WAY THEY GET PAID IS
PROVIDING A DIRECT SERVICE. TO
CONSUMER AND THEN BILLING FOR
IT. THE DEPARTMENT DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES NOW NEARLY TWO YEARS
LATER. HAS LEFT OPEN A DIRECTIVE
THAT THEY WANT TO CLAIM FUNDS
FROM ANY PROGRAM THAT SOUGHT
SUCH ALL. THIS CANNOT BE THE
STANDARD AND WE ARE TO SEARCH
THE LEGISLATURE TO STEP IN. TO
THE SWEET THE DEPARTMENT FROM
PURSUING THAT PATH. PUBLIC FOR
DISCUSSING. THIS FURTHER WITH
YOU YOUR STAFF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SIR OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWO FORTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WELL THANK YOU AND
CHAIRMAN PERAMBALUR FOR HEARING
US AND I AM. A MEMBER OF THE
INCLUSIVE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND I AM ACTUALLY
TOTALLY BY MYSELF AS WELL I ALSO
WORKED FOR TEN YEARS AND
COUNSELING AND LATER ON JUST
COUNSELING EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AND- CRISIS
INTERVENTION AND THEN I PROVIDED
THAT SERVICE ADAM PLANETARY
CENTER LOCALLY FOR ANOTHER NINE
YEARS AND IN MY COUNSELING
EXPERIENCE. I DID EXPERIENCE
THIS WITH PEOPLE THAT GO THROUGH
VISION LOSS AND SO I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS THAT FIRST PANEL THAT
DEALT WITH CLIMATE SERVICES.
WHEN I THERE WERE SOME COMMENTS
MADE ABOUT PEOPLE WHO. THEIR
VISION THAT WE WANT SERVICES IN
ORDER TO. GET ADJUSTED TO THEIR
HOME LIFE AND BE ABLE TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY AND THEN
EVENTUALLY GO TO WORK WELL. WHEN
PEOPLE ARE ASKED IF THEY WANT TO
WORK THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
IMAGINE WORKING AND IN MY
COUNSELING EXPERIENCE WHEN YOU
FIRST LOSE YOUR VISION AND WITH
OTHER CAPABILITIES AS WELL
IMAGINING THAT WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW YOU'RE
GOING TO MATCH YOUR CLOTHES DO
YOUR LAUNDRY DO YOU BASIC
HOUSEHOLD AND GROOMING TAX. IT'S
REALLY IMPOSSIBLE I THINK WE'RE
ASKING SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE
CAN'T EMOTIONALLY DO UNTIL THEY
GET SERVICES. AND SO. A LOT WITH
MENTAL. AND OTHER SERVICES
STAYING IN THE HOME I THINK IT
WOULD PROVIDE THOSE ON THE FRONT
END WE WILL ACTUALLY SAVE MONEY
ON THE BACK END BECAUSE PEOPLE
WILL BECOME EMPLOYED. MORE OFTEN
OR BE ABLE TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY
AND NOT IN TRAINERS COM THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TO YOU TODAY. THANK YOU OPERATOR
GO TO NUMBER
GOOD EVENING A DOCTOR IN THE
LAB- THE BERRY CARE DEAL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SERVICES AND I WANT TO JUST
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUCH A PUBLIC
HEARING. ON ALL THE ISSUES
RELATED TO THE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY SERVICES SYSTEM- I
ONE OF THE- LARGE OUR SUPPORT
PORTAL ENEMY COALITION PROPOSALS
THAT WERE PRESENTED BY JORDAN
LINDSAY TODAY PRINCIPALLY TO
ACCELERATE THE RATE AT THE- TO
ADDRESS OUR WORKFORCE CRISIS
INDEPENDENT SERVICE PACK THAT'S
PREGNANT WHICH ULTIMATELY PUT
OBLIGATION. AT RISK. I THANK
WANT TO HAVE THE FACT THAT ARE
THE PROPOSAL IS. A ONE TIME CON
CANCER THE OF OUR IN PLACE TO
SCRATCH. AND AN EXHILARATION THE
JUST BE POINT FUNDING- THE FIRST
TIME IN THIS. AND I THINK
ULTIMATELY. LOOKING TO THE
FUTURE OF THE EXPLORATION OF THE
OVERALL PLAN. REALLY COVERED OUR
TRANSFORMATION OUR SYSTEM WILL
BRING INCOME OUTCOMES BASED-
FOCUS TO THE SERVICE I'M- AND
CAN REALLY GET A THAT THE FROM
THE COMARO THAT WERE THAT WERE
ALL HOPING OR- I ALSO WANT TO.
MAKE COMMENT ON- ISSUE SEVEN OF
WHICH WAS AROUND THE COLD IT-
PROVISIONS THAT HE ASKED
SPECIFICALLY WANT TO CALL OUT-
AND YOU I THANK OUR PARTNERS FOR
THEIR RAPID RESPONSE TO A LOT OF
THE CHALLENGES FACED DURING.
KOBE IN PARTICULAR ALTERNATIVE
SERVICES WHICH HAVE BEEN
CRITICAL AND PROVIDED BY THE
SERVICE DELIVERY. AND I THINK
THAT HOPEFULLY THOSE WILL INFORM
SOME OF THE- ETHNIC AND
ADJUSTMENTS THAT WE MAKE AS WE
DO TRANSFORM THAT SYSTEM- TO THE
RIGHT NOT LET THEM CATCH UP
MENTIONED EARLIER BUT THIS
TECHNIQUE FROM COALITION
PROPOSAL OPERATE. EIGHT IT'S
ALSO A VERY MUCH SUPPORTED BY
CDS. NINETY WHERE SHE QUICKLY
ISSUE. OF THE- FINDING FOR THE
TRANS FATS CAN- SEVEN WAGE- WE
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSED IN THE
WRECKAGE OF AN- FOR FUNDING AND
HEALTH ON POPULAR. AS WE
TRANSFORM THE- COUPLE WITHIN
WITH THE BIKE TO SEE BROADER
INCLUDE OF SERVE FOR WHERE I'M
CERTAINLY IS CURRENTLY OFFERED.
INCLUDING ORDER COMING AND
PROGRAM WHICH IS ALSO NOTED IN
THE GENDER BUT ALSO REALLY FOCUS
ON THE FACT THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED MORE INVESTMENT AND WHAT'S
PROPOSED HERE TO MAKE SURE WE
DON'T LOSE THE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES I SPECIFICALLY
WHAT ARE TAKEN STEPS REGIONAL
CENTER. OF GOLDEN GATE-
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT WE
DON'T JUST MOVE PEOPLE OUT INTO
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT MIGHT HELP
WITH THE CHILDREN BUT A LOT OF
THESE FOLKS NEED TO REMAIN AND
WORK NOT FOR ME TO WORK AND I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE PASSED WITH
THEIR TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN- IN
THAT FINALLY AND OFFICIALLY
REGARDING IT YES SHE DID HE
DEPARTMENTS UPDATE. I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT PROVIDERS ARE STILL
WAITING ANXIOUSLY FOR THE RESULT
OF THEIR ONSITE ASSESSMENT. AND
WE ARE ONLY THIRTEEN NOT TALKING
THE COMPLIANCE DEADLINE THE
CLOCK IS TICKING AND OUT TO
SEVERAL WAY- THE PANIC LEVEL
WILL ESCALATE IF THERE ARE NEED
A TRANSFORMATION AND
MODIFICATIONS TO SERVICES. THAT
IS GOING TO REQUIRE SOME TIME
AND WILL NEARLY OUT OF IT SO I
JUST ENCOURAGE IN PARTS
DEPARTMENT SHE WILL WORK IN THAT
CASE IT'S POSSIBLE I'M NOT I'M
IN FINAL THANK YOU JUST A CALL
BACK AS FOR THE COMPREHENSIVE
AGENDA AND FOR HER- EXISTENCE I
WANT ALLOWANCE OF THE TREATY AND
PUT ON THE- PUNISHES. SYSTEM
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK. YOU SIR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WELL NOW GO
TO SIXTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME NAME IS
TERRIBLE POP OUT THE BY AND
PUTTING. REALLY THANK YOU FOR
THE- THE WORKFORCE REAL US WE
HAVE FIVE EMPLOYEES OR PANDEMIC
WE HAVE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE NOW
CAN DO IT I'LL FOR LOVERS. OUT
WE HAVE OUR VERY DIFFICULT
HIGHER SEVENTY OPEN VERY MUCH OF
THE CONNEX THE RIGHT SET. TO GET
RESTARTED HERE QUICKER TO TRY
WITH COMPLETELY FINE WITH MY
GOING TO LINES AT WORKING TO GO
INTO FINE WITH THE OF THE
OUTCOME. VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT
- IT'S HARPER. ONE TO. SUPPORT
THE FAMILY BEEN ADDED IN OUR
SYSTEM THAT WE WANT TO- I ALSO
WANTED TO- SUPPORT SO WE MODEL A
AND EVERYTHING YOU FOR STATE
THAT- WE FOR SO THROUGH THE
PANDA TO DENY TO HAVE THAT WOULD
IT R. AS WE GO FORWARD ALIGNED
WITH EACH TO GET SENTENCE RULE
END. REALLY PUT EFFORT INTO BE
AN OUTCOME BASED SYSTEM THAT SO
MANY SPOKE WHILE OUT TODAY. A
SMALL PLUGGED AFTER AFTER THE
BILLING CAN BE ELIMINATED BY THE
LAST VESTIGES. FROM ABOUT. IN
DEMOCRATS LAID IT AND GIVES ME
TO SUCH RELATED- CUTS. ARE AND
THEN DOT. THERE WAS A LOCAL BY
LAND COALITION TO. PUT IN MY
DISPLAY THAT THE RATE MY OF A
REGULATE. SO THAT WE DON'T
FINDERS SYSTEM IN THE PLAYERS
FOR. UNABLE TO. SERVICES A LOT
WE WANT SOME PUT THAT BACK BE
FOUND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONTENT OF THE- FOUR THINKING
WHEN. YOUR YOUR COLLEGE. AND
ALLOW. I JUST WANT TO THANK DO
YOU HAVE FOR THE CLUB SPIRIT
THAT THEY SEAN THROUGHOUT PANDA
. BOB WHAT'S ALL THE WORK
TOGETHER TO GET THROUGH REALLY
DIFFICULT. YES IS DUE TO THE
PROVIDERS- YEAH JUST CENTER
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE.
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE CARD
EVENING THANK YOU SO MUCH
STAYING LATE ARAMBULA- J. S. CAL
. WORKS THE DECELERATE OF THE
GREAT TEMP BECAUSE- WE KNOW IN
TERMS OF QUALITY OF CARE THE ONE
FROM SERVICE IS I YES AND THERE
SHOULDN'T STUDIES OF THE YEARS
SO CLEARLY THAT CAUGHT OF CARE
KEEPING THE SAME PROVIDER. THE
BIGGEST DETERMINANT ABOUT
COUNTLESS. M. O. AND THAT'S
FACED ONLY ON SALARY THAT'S HOW
YOU KEEP PEOPLE THAT COULD GET
PEOPLE TO DO THE JOB SO DID THE
RATE STUDY COLORATION IS THE
FASTEST BEST EASIEST WAY TO GET
THERE AND THAT HELPS WITH
WITHOUT COMP- THE SECOND THING
IS THAT WE WILL ALSO DECIDE TO
SUPPORT. OUT THE RESULT IS
PROPOSAL BURKE UPDATES COM TO
UPDATE THE COURTS SAPPING
FORMULA BECAUSE IT HAS LED. TO
HORRENDOUS CASELOADS WHERE
PEOPLE CAN'T DO THE JOB THAT
THEY WANT TO DO. WELL WE THINK
DOING THAT LET THEM KEEPING THEM
UPDATED JUSTIMPORTANT YEAH.
THAT'S KEEPING UP TO DATE THE-
BREAKS THAT LOW THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME WE THANK THE
DEPARTMENT AND YOUR CREDIT CARD
ALL YOU'VE GOT. AND THEN. YOU'RE
TOO MANY STAFF THANK YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT ON THE LINE TWO THIRTY
THREE. HELLO THE PUBLIC CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES MA'AM YES I CAN HEAR
YOU. OKAY PERFECT HELLO I'M
CALLING AT THE MOTHER OF THE
CHILD WELL IT'S A YOUNG ADULT
WHO WILL TURN EIGHTEEN THIS
MONTH. I WANTED TO SAY THAT-
FROM WHAT I RECEIVE SERVICES FOR
WHAT I KNOW FROM REGIONAL
CENTER- HONESTLY I RECEIVED A
LOT MORE. SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE
ABA SERVICES. IF YOU TO BELIEVE
THAT I WOULD NOT THE AGES OF
PROVIDER FOR MY CHILD. I
ACTUALLY WORKED IN THE NONPROFIT
BECAUSE I WASN'T AWARE THAT I
COULD RECEIVE. THAT OPPORTUNITY
TO BE THERE ARE YOU JUST
PROVIDER FOR MY SON. SO I FIND
OUT WHO ARE YOU I THOUGHT ABOUT.
GOING THROUGH SOME MEETINGS
WITH. JUDY MARC ALL THE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WERE OUT
THERE FOR MY FAMILY. MY TELL
ONLY RECEIVE CONDEMNING HE ONLY
RECEIVED ONE SERVICE. SO I'M
HERE TO ASK. YOU TO LET US. THE
FAMILIES MAKE THAT DECISION WE
CANNOT LEARN SOMETHING THAT IS
THE SYSTEM FOCUS WELL- CHILDREN
HAVE TO MEET THEIR GUIDELINES
AND THEY HAVE TO HAVE BENCHMARK
TO WHAT THERE ARE ELIGIBLE TO DO
AND NOT. THAT I AM ASKING YOU TO
PLEASE SUPPORT. WHAT ELIZABETH
COLEMAN AND I HE- AND GETTING
MARK HAVE BEEN SAYING WE NEED TO
MOVE FORWARD INTO CALLING THE
TERMINATION WE NEED TO MOVE.
HELLO CANNIBAL REGIONAL CENTERS
AND WE NEED. ACCEPTABLE VENDORS
QUITE HONESTLY THE VENDOR THAT
YOU CAN OFTEN I HAVE I DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY LOOPS THEY HAVE
TO. JUMP OVER TO GET TO BECOME
BETTER. BUT BY THE TIME THEY
BECOME BETTER THEY HAVE SO MANY
RESTRICTIONS. IT'S NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET A DECENT
SERVICE OUT OF THAT. SO PLEASE
SUPPORT. WHAT DO YOU MARK AND-
ELIZABETH COMMITTEE HAVE SHARE
WITH YOU. I DON'T KNOW LIKE SO
MUCH JUST TO TELL YOU. HOW TO
BREAK IT DOWN I JUST KNOW THAT
I'D LISTEN TO THEM AND I WITH
THE SERVICE THAT. I AND MY
FAMILY HAS BEEN BALANCED BECAUSE
OF ALL THE STUFF THAT I LEARNED
NOT FROM REGIONAL CENTRES. BACK
BUT FOR WHAT I LEARNED FROM ICC
AND BANISH. IN BOTH MEETINGS AND
WHAT I HAVE LEARNED WHAT YOU TO
MARK SO PLEASE. IF YOU HAVE TO
LISTEN TO SOMEBODY. TO THE
FAMILIES. NOT THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE GONNA BE MAKING MILLIONS AND
BECOME MILLIONAIRES OUT OF
PROVIDING SERVICES FOR OUR
CHILDREN. AFTER WE HAVE WAITED
MONTHS AND MONTHS TO GET THE
SERVICES. HOPING VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NOW GO TO
NUMBER TWO FIFTY NINE. HI GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS PATRICIA
BEING YOUNG AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF PROJECT AND NOT REACH FOR THE
ART OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY OKAY-
AND I THINK ONE OF MY LIFE- SOME
OF THE WORK THAT WE HAVE BEEN
DOING FOR THE SPANISH SPEAKING.
I'M A GREAT TO HEAR THE MONSTER
THAT JUST SPOKE- IN REGARDS TO
LATINA. WHO INFORMATION
DELIVERED IN THEIR LANGUAGE OUR
GOAL IS TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
EDUCATION AND LEADERSHIP IN
AFRICA. THE SPANISH SPEAKING
FAMILIES WHO HAVE CHILDREN OR
FAMILY MEMBERS WITH DISABILITIES
I'M AND THIS IS WHAT WE HEAR
TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING THE
INFORMATION THAT IS SO CRUCIAL
TO THEM AND TO HAVE IT IN THEIR
LANGUAGE WE UNDERSTAND THE
COMPLEXITIES OF NAVIGATING THE
SYSTEM. THAT FAMILIES STATE
PURCHASED THE VEHICLE AND HER-
THERE ARE YOU EIGHTEEN. WE
CANNOT IMAGINE HOW MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THEM IF THEY DON'T
SPEAK THE LANGUAGE AND SO WE
HAVE BEEN PROVIDING VIRTUAL
PRESENTATION- FOR. ALL THE
FAMILY COOL- BANISHED WE NEED TO
TRAIN THEM ON ALL THE DIFFERENT
SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE. FOR
THEM AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
AND BY PROVIDE EACH TO THAT AND
THEIR NAME. AND HELP SPREAD DOWN
ANY COMPETE. NOTHING GETS LOCKED
INTO. ONLY THING ALONG WELL. OF
THE PATIENT EACH FROM THE FAMILY
. AND TYPICALLY WHEN WE HAVE TO
PRACTICE THEY ARE NOT AFRAID TO
UP AND ACT BUT- AT THE COAST TO
WHEN THEY PARKED. IN WHERE DOES
THAT. A LACK OF THE B. MONTH
FROM THEM. ADULT I'D LIKE TO
OPEN- SPEAKER ISSUE NUMBER THANK
- AND I JUST WANT OUR ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF SORT OF THING
ACCESS EQUITY GRANTS FROM YEAH.
WE HAVE BEEN PART ENOUGH TO HAVE
A SEAT FROM THE ACTIVE HELP THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE THAT CAME UP
DURING THE AND THEN MAKE. WE
HAVE NOT ONLY ABLE TO PROVIDE
MIGHT TO HELP FAMILIES THANK.
AND ACCESS TO THE VIRTUAL
PARKING. BUT WE HAVE ALSO THE
LACK OF INTERNET KIND OF FIBER
ON. ON THE INTERNET SERVER. OR
BY PROVIDING THEM WITH. AN
EATING AND WE HAVE ALSO HEARD
THAT. RIGHT HE BECAUSE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE VICE THAT DO NOT
NOT SO WE HAVE HELP AND LOT
FAMILIES TO USE THAT DEVICE THAT
YOU CAN TO WRITE IT ON HOW TO
THE VIRTUAL CARE ACT PROJECT
DOWN WILL HELP CRACK AS THE
WEATHER AND YOU NEEDING WHAT
THAN AND- WE HAVE ALSO HELPED
CREATE AND THEN THEIR OWN EMAIL
THANK WERE SOME TO COME IN THE-
IN NINETY ZERO. VERSUS HAVING TO
RE ON THEIR SON OR DAUGHTER WHY
DON'T YOU GIVE THEM. SO THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE REACHED NEED TO
HELP THEM OVER ONE POSITIVE I
JUST WANTED THANK. FOR SUPPORT
THAT THEY HAVE. I'M AN ACTOR
LIKE TO- JUST. COMMENT- BUT ONE
OF THE THANK- ADMITTING THAT
ABOUT LET HAVING TELL YOU. YOU
NEED SO YOU CAN FIND AT ONE OF
MY OF. WORK ON A. AND. ONE
EIGHTY FOUR. HI MY NAME SOME
CARL- I'M SERVICE BY NORTH LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HAVE BEEN DENTAL
CENTER AND I'VE BEEN AROUND FOR
THIRTY NINE YEAR AND IT SEEMS
LIKE WE WENT BACKWARDS HERE FOR
YOU KNOW THE LAST EIGHT YEARS.
I'M FULLY IN SUPPORT OF
ACCELERATING THAT THE RATE NOT
ONLY FOR OUR SERVICE PROVIDERS
FOR OUR REGIONAL CENTER WORKERS
PARKING MANAGER BECAUSE- MY GOD
THEY RAIDED RIDICULOUSNESS- WHEN
IT COMES TO MY PROVIDERS THAT
THEY ARE. DIE HARD PEOPLE THEY
THEY CAME THROUGH THEIR THEIR
PROVIDING AS MANY STAFF AS THEY
CAN. BUT WE HAVE A REAL SHORTAGE
AND A REAL DISPARITY IN MY
COMMUNITY. I'M IN THE ANTELOPE
VALLEY. AND WE ARE LACKING STAFF
. WHAT THE BOARD NURSES P. EIGHT
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF- ARE OUR
PROVIDERS. THEY'RE LOSING THAT
SO WE NEED YOUR ASSISTANCE LET'S
CELEBRATE THE MONEY FOR ALL OF
THE THIRTY FIFTH AND I
DEFINITELY SUPPORT ABOUT THE
TERMINATION FOR ANYBODY THAT
WANTS TO GO THERE I'M A DIE HARD
. THURMOND AT PENRITH ALIKE
DAVID REGIONAL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER TWO FIFTY SIX. HI I MADE IS GAVIN LEVENSON
ALBUM THANK YOU MY TWO BOOKS OF
THESE OTHER GIRLS ARE I SEE I
MIGHT WANT TO THERE ARE SENTENCE
MEDICAID SERVICE SELECT MANY YOU
SAID BIGGEST PARTY MAYBE WHERE.
THAT HOW TO CHANGE DON'T
RETIREES SO OF ISSUES- PLEASE
HELP US TO CHANGE THE THIS THINK
. THANK YOU FOR THE RIVER. ONLY
YOU PARTICULAR TOMORROW. DO THEY
TEACH. COUNTRY THEIR LIVES FOR
OUR KIDS. I THINK THEIR REGULAR
CENTER CRAP ON A LOT OF MONEY
YEAH FOR O. G. E. WE- WHEN. WE
CAN OBTAIN ONE SAID THIS IS FOR
OUR KIDS THEY DON'T WANT TO GIVE
ANYTHING. BUT YOU HAVE TO PUT ON
AN UPDATE BERMAN SAID. EASY
THEY'LL GIVE NOTHING ONLY THEY
WANT TO BE NAMED FOR OUR
CHILDREN OF THEIR- EIGHT
ENVELOPE PUT. ANY SET OF ISSUES
- THEY SAID THEY'D BE DESPITE
THAT COMMUNITY- BLACKCOMB TO.
KNOWN HAVE FUNDED MORE AND ALL
FOR THAT FOR A VIDEO A LIFE
PARTNER I WOULD CHOOSE. AND WE
DON'T CURRENTLY. ENGLISH VERY
WELL. NO COST. FROM FOR EXAMPLE
IN THE LOCAL ACCESS FOR SAID
BECAUSE THE LOOK AT THE CUT
OPINION ON. IT PUTTING. ONE ONE
IF KEY TRACK SAID BECAUSE FOR
ONE DAY FOR TEN THOUSAND IN ALL
TWENTY TWO OF BUT POLITICAL-
WHITE PEOPLE EITHER EIGHT EIGHT
THOUSAND. EIGHT EIGHTY. SEVENTY
PEOPLE. A PLEA DON'T SAID OF
THESE ARE- DON'T KNOW WHY IT.
WHAT YOU'RE CURRENT YOU DON'T BY
THE END DEADLINE FOR HOURS HE'S
IN YOUR HOUSE ONLY YOU CAN THESE
. IT'S A VERY BIG THEY SEE. HE
PLEASE TAKE- DO YOU HAVE ONE
CHILD A FIFTY TWO WE BE PUT IN.
KINDS OF MESSAGES ONLY YOU'LL
CAR. FROM THE MALL BUT IT'S NOT
FORGET BASS WE WORKING ON WE
TUNE IT TO TAKE OUT CHILDREN IF
WE DON'T CAN. TO SEVENTY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR HELP. IN
ASSISTING ON. CALLERS NEXT WEEK
DO NOT TWO. GOOD EVENING CARE
ARAMBULA AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THIS EVENING I'M MY NAME IS
SERRA VERITY I'M REPRESENTING
ABILITY PASSED WITH THEIR
CHILDREN ADULTS AND FAMILIES
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL AND
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES IN.
CANAKKALE IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
. I AM GRATEFUL TO THE
LEGISLATURE NPO FOR THE- LAST
YEAR THE POOL OF THE PLAN TO
FILL THE FUNDING GAP FOR BT
SERVICES INVESTMENT AIMS TO SELL
WHAT WAS IDENTIFIED BY THE RATE
STEADY AS AN ANNUAL FUNDING GAP
OVER A FIVE YEAR PERIOD.
MEANWHILE THE FOLKS WHO WE SERVE
CONTINUE TO BE IMPACTED BY
DECADES OF UNDERFUNDING. WE WERE
RECENTLY CONTACTED BY MANY
SILICON VALLEY EMPLOYERS
INTERESTED IN HIRING ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES TO FILL. THEIR
HIRING NEEDS AND- WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE WE
CANNOT HIRE JOB COACHES TO
SUPPORT THOSE FOLKS OUT. THANK
GOD. HE'S ME. AND I'M ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS ARE IMPACTED BY OUR
INABILITY TO HIRE STAFF RIGHT
NOW SO I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL TO ACCELERATE
INVESTMENT TIMELINE BY A YEAR.
AND IMPORTANTLY TO MAKE CRITICAL
AT THE LOWEST RATE MODEL THE
FUNDS ARE GOING TO HELP ADDRESS
WHAT WE CAN ONLY DESCRIBE AS A
CRISIS. HELLO AGAIN I SUPPORT
THE MANAGEMENT COALITION
PROPOSALS AND- THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS IS NUMBER
TWO FIFTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
DOCTOR ARAMBULA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LISTEN TO THEIR FAMILIES MY NAME
IS CHRISTINA MARKETS AND I AM
THE MOTHER OF A YOUNG ADULT WHO
HAS AN INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY
AND IS SERVE. THE REGIONAL
CENTER I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT I SUPPORT I SEE SEE A JUDY
MARC JUST PLAY ONE OF THE
MOTHERS SAY EVERYTHING THAT I
HAVE FOR AND THE SERVICES THAT I
. THE HOBBIT ADVOCATED FOR MY
SON'S BY LEARNING FROM THEM. I
DON'T ANY STATION IS MAKING AN
AMAZING JOB TO ALL DELIGHTED
FAMILIES. THAT I'VE NOT SERVE.
BY THE REGIONAL CENTERS ALL THE
TO COMMON SEATS- WE CANNOT
CENTER YOU SAY IN THAT THEY ARE
PROVIDING- TRAINING THROUGH THE
STORM AND PROVIDED COMPUTERS TO
THE FAMILIES TO KNOW ABOUT THE
SERVICE THAT IS TRUE BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY ARE
GIVING THE SERVICES TO THE
PEOPLE THAT FAMILIES THAT THEY
ATTY MEET WE CAN LEARN HOW WE
CAN GET TRADED BUT WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN WE NEED TO GO TO THE
SERVICE COORDINATOR. AND ASKED
ABOUT THE SERVICES THEY ARE SO
THAT WE ARE GETTING HE'S ALWAYS. WE DON'T QUALIFY FOR THE
SENATE. BUT THEN GIVE YOU IS
START LEARNING ABOUT YOU RIGHT
UP A LOT TERM AND ACT. YOU SEE
THAT MANY ALL RIGHT HOW TO.
VIOLATORS SO JUST LIKE THE ALL
LATINA MOTHER. PLEASE YOU NEED
TO TAKE A CHANCE TO TALK WITH
THE ICC FAMILIES YOU NEED TO
LISTEN TO THEIR FAMILIES FROM
THE REGIONAL CENTERS BECAUSE
THAT WAY YOU WILL SEE ALL THE
NECESSITY IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LISTENING. IN ON OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANKS OF THE NUMBER TWO
FIFTY FIVE. TWENTY FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT- YOU. HI MY
NAME IS NADIA SALON NUMBER OF
MONEY A SOLANO EVEN GO UP OR
DOWN BALLOT IN YOUR ARE YOU
AVAILABLE GONZALEZ. WHAT THAT
MEANS A PERCENT DONE BY THE SEE
KAMEL MOTHER IF I MEAN. ONLY
CALL PEOPLE CONTROL PEOPLE COMO
ASSOCIATED WITH SOME OF THE BOTH
OF INTERNET ITSELF BUT THAT
MEANS YOU DON'T BELONG TO THEM
DON'T PUT THEM IN THIS YOUNG
PEOPLE NO LONGER THEY GIVE US IN
PEOPLE CONTENT OF STILL. ALIVE
MAN THANK HE SENT THE PHONE NINE
BLOCKED BY ME HOLDING PEOPLE
THANK YOU CALL OKAY SEVEN BE IN
THE COMPARISON SOMEONE GUN THIS
MESSAGE WITH OTHERS THIS BECAUSE
THEY- DEPENDENT BUT MISSES THE
SENATE I WILL BE IN. IN A SECOND
OF THE FROM I MEAN FOUR ONE
BECAUSE OF. IN THE DEVELOPED
FOOT THEM THEN LAPTOP IN WELL
ALONG THEIR- LOCAL THAT BUNDLE
STAPHYLOCOCCI IT CORDONED
COMMITTEE LOOK BAD A LITTLE WILL
PROBABLY YOU'LL BE THE FIRST
PUBLIC SO MANY. FOLLOWING OKAY
ALSO THE LOCAL UP BY THE OF BUG
AND LOOKED IN WE DID. THE
VEHICLE MOST OF THE OF ALMOST
ABOUT THE SOMEONE THAN THE TO
SPEND MY- CAN ALSO PLANET EARTH
IF YOU LOOK AT REFILL AND ONLY
ONLY IF ONLY FOR A SIMILAR AT
LEAST. LIKE THAT YES THE COLOR
SO MANY WENT FROM OPINION. YOU
IN YOUR FOR THAT GIVEN SPENT ON
A OTHER ON THANK YOU GOODNESS
THIS MEMORABLE APPROVAL.
GOOD
NIGHT MY NAME IS PRETTY NOTHING
BANNER. I'M MORE OF THEIR OKAY-
PLANTS OF SORTS OF HURRYING UP
AND THEIR- JUST- WANT TO SUPPORT
OLD. THERE EAT ARE YOU SURE- ALL
THE TEAMS ARE EIGHTY SEVEN
COMMENTS. ITALIAN YOU. AND ALL
THESE IS TRUE WE NEED- BEFORE.
AND WE NEED A- HELP FOR THE
FAMILY'S BECAUSE HONESTLY.
YOU'RE NOT UNDER A PAYING. FOR
LAWYERS AND PROFESSIONAL. OUR
GAMES ARE THE FATHERS THE FAMILY
THAT FOR THE CLIENTS THAT.
THAT'S PROBABLY BECAUSE- SO I
JUST THE POINT NEEDS AE YOU
SOME OF THE COMMENTS AND GET THE
MAX THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LEVINE TO
SEVENTY. HI AT FIRST- MY NAME IS
MARGARET PARMENION AND I'M THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER UCPE
NORTH BAY. I WANT TO START OFF
BY THANKING CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA
FOR A VERY. COMPREHENSIVE
COMMITTEE HEARING I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT AND I'M I'M
BASICALLY CALLING IN TO
EMPATHIZE- JORDAN LINDSEY'S
TESTIMONY FROM FOR THE A OR C.
UTP COLLABORATION IN THE LANDER
AND COALITION- I WANT TO REALLY
EMPHASIZE THE STAFFING CRISIS
THAT YOU'VE HEARD. SO MUCH ABOUT
FROM SO MANY PROVIDERS ON THESE
CALLS- WE HAVE HISTORICALLY AS
AN ORGANIZATION BEEN ABLE TO RUN
TWELVE PROGRAMS SERVING SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CHILDREN AND
ADULTS ANNUALLY. OUT WITH THIS
STUFF STOPPING CRISIS THAT WERE
ENCOUNTERING NOW. WE'VE HAD TO
INCREASE WAGES OVER THE LAST
NINETY DAYS BY 20% WE STILL ARE
MAINTAINING A STAFFING- PROBLEM
OF TWENTY PERCENT. UNDERSTAFFED
FOR DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS
ACROSS ALL OF OUR PROGRAM. THIS
IS REALLY- SEVENTEEN WE YOU KNOW
WE'VE IMPLEMENTED SIGNING
BONUSES AND REFERRAL BONUSES AND
EVERYTHING THANK UP. AAW TO
ATTRACT A WORK FORCE AND WE ARE
JUST REALLY STRUGGLING TO HIRE-
SO A LOT OF OUR CAPACITY AS YOU
HEARD OTHER PROVIDERS TALK ABOUT
IN TERMS OF SOCIAL ENTERPRISE
AND SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT WORK
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR FOLKS THAT
ARE. THAT ARE BETTER THAN
THEY'VE EVER BAN FRANKLY BECAUSE
OF THE STAFFING CRISIS
NATIONALLY. WE AREN'T ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE UP BECAUSE WE
CAN'T HIRE JOB COACHES TO
SUPPORT THOSE FOLKS. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE DEPARTMENT- FOR-
INSTITUTING ALTERNATIVE SERVICES
DURING THE PANDEMIC PERIOD. AND
REALLY EMPHASIZED THE PERSON
CENTERED APPROACH THAT REMOTE
PROGRAMMING HAS BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE FOR SOME OF OUR SOME OF.
THE PEOPLE WE SUPPORT IT'S
REALLY BEEN QUITE REMARKABLE AND
IT'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD LOOK
INTO IN THE FUTURE. TO EXPAND
THAT POSSIBILITY FOR FOLKS THAT
THAT- THAT YOU LIKE AND CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT KIND OF
SERVICE DELIVERY IT'S NOT FOR
EVERYONE BUT THERE ARE THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
REALLY BLOSSOMS BUT THAT AND
WE'VE PROVIDED DEVICES HOT SPOTS
AND WHATNOT AND- REALLY SEEING
PEOPLE. INCREASE THEIR SKILL
LEVEL IN THE TECHNOLOGY BROWN SO
IT'S BEEN WONDERFUL SO JUST ONCE
AGAIN I WANT TO RECORD WE
RECOMMEND THAT WERE ACCELERATING
THE INVESTMENT TIMELINE FOR THE
BIRDS AND THE THIRTIETH STREET
STUDY. AND THAT WE ALSO CONTINUE
TO UPDATE THAT STUDY- NINE THINK
EVERY TWO YEARS I'M AT THE RATE
THAT WE ARE SEEING WAGES
EXPANDING IN OUR COMMUNITY- YOU
KNOW FOLKS CAN CAN MAKE FIVE
DOLLARS. OR MORE WORKING AT AT
AT AT A BURGER JOINT AND THIS IS
JUST AN UNACCEPTABLE SO- I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND-
SAY THAT I'M VERY HOPEFUL. FOR
THE FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEKOGA LINE
OF TWO TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
LINE TO TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE YES
HELLO. OKAY GOOD EVENING THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY MY NAME
IS MARIA I'M FROM SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY I THINK THAT THE CARE
GIVER AN APPARENT I WANT TO
COMMENT ON THE LACK OF SERVICES
FOR THOSE WITH EIGHT CHILDREN
ARE NON POTENT MINIMALLY WILL
OPEN DOORS TO BE CLOSED NEED
SOMEONE TO BE OF INDIVIDUALS
WILL HAVE MORE NEEDS AND LESS
CARE ON BOTH WEB BEHAVIOR NEEDS.
THE END OF JULY CORRECT EXCEPT
IN TWO MONTHS WITH BEHAVIOR AND
IF THEY DO ACCEPT THEM ABU
TWENTY TALK TO FAMILIES OF BOB
DOES THIRTY. BETTER THINK
<c.blue>NGINES CONSUME THAT THIS</c>
HAPPENS MORE AGAINST THE PALM
BEACH OF PRODUCT IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES FIVE MINUTES WE'LL
SPEAK WITH AN ACCENT EXCEPT THAT
THOSE WOULD MEAN MADE MULTIPLE
CONSERVATIVE OF THE LADY FONG
KWOK BEING REFLECTED. IN AND BY
THE CURRENT SYSTEM. I URGE THEM
TO. DON'T NEGLECT MEET THE OF
ANY POP. CORNELIA SUPPORT AB BY
FACTORS THAT FIVE. THANK YOU FOR
IN A DISCIPLINE OF NON THE SAN.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR- AND PUBLIC
BANK THIRTEEN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. Q. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO
THE NUMBER TO A. SIX HELLO. SEE
WHERE. WHAT ARE LARA. SHE. SIX I
KNOW WHAT THE NUMBER IS GOING TO
SELL THIS PRODUCT BECAUSE DON'T
SEE POST BELOW. I MUST PICK
ANNUAL SURVEY ON OVER ABOUT. THE
MEASURE MOST ON ECONOMIC BY. I
HAVE IS FOR THEIR POLITICAL
CRITICAL- THAT EIGHTY SEVEN BOB
THIS PROMISED A VOTE INVESTORS
LIKE BETWEEN THE CHOLESTEROL
MARKS HIM. OUT YOUR MOST ME BACK
GAINESVILLE ALL AUGUST FIFTH
LAST. ENOUGH COMMERCIAL FOR ME
THAT EM- THIS STORY MORE. M.
WHAT OKAY DOESN'T EVEN START
FATAL CALIF YOU. A ARE YOU SHE'S
. IS MAY I KNOW THAT WANT THANK
I. YOUTH COMMUNITY RESULT OF
ATHEIST YOUR CAREER ARE ONLY
THREE. IT OREGON SHE'LL. OKAY
MERCHANT ACCOUNT FOR FABULOUS
OKAY ALTHOUGH MEAN WE MORE YOU
MY- ATM JUMPED BY THE TO CREATE
AN ECO NINETY FIVE THAT. SHE
INTENDS BIGGEST. IT'S FABRIC IS
BELOW. THE LAST YES IT'S
POSSIBLE WELL THE LAST COUPLE
CHOI CHU. THE PROPOSAL WHICH IS
. BUT AFTER A MOTHER CRISIS IN
YOUR NEXT. FOR THE NEXT TO GO TO
NUMBER. EIGHTY FIVE. HI HELLO.
YES YES I CAN HEAR YOU. HI DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT IS AND- OUR
TELEPHONE SYSTEM SB THIRTY TWO-
I LEAVING THE BAY AREA AND I
SUPPORT THE COMMENTS OF THE
REPUBLIC FORMER AND LAWRIE MARKS. ARE ONLY- WE THIRD TO KNOW FOR
YOU TO PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS QUICK.
I DON'T I WOULD TO LEARN FOR.
OUR AGENCIES LIKE I THINK HE
HELLO WHAT THE PARTS THE NEW
AFTER- YOU KNOW VERY YOU TO NAY
DIDN'T INTIMIDATE US R. Y. A.
ONE DE THE WI FI ABOUT YOU THINK
. THE BILL WAS PUSHED EVERY WILL
ASK FOR OUR CHILDREN AND OUR
THINK IT'S FAIR- I SUPPORT I
THINK SCHOOL WITH ARGUMENT
ALLOWS THEM ABOUT- RETURNING IN
ALMOST EVERY SENSE MY- AND-
PLEASE. BOB BECAUSE WE WERE ALL
HELLO OUR- NOT ON OUR DAILY
BASIS CALL WOULD BILLION WITH
I'M SURE AND ALL THE COMPANY
SUPPOSED HELP OUR. I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE. NEXT
NUMBER NINE ONE. HELLO IT ALONE
YOU'RE- OKAY HI NAME IS THAT WE
ON THE- FOR THE REGIONAL CENTER
IN THE NUMBER OF THE AMERICAN
QUITE COME CON EIGHTEEN YEARS-
ONE OF THE THINGS I WANT DISCUSS
TONIGHT IS- THE FORENSIC HE
WALKED AT THE FRONT DESK WORKERS
THE- I WORK WITH TWENTY PEOPLE
PEOPLE WORK WITH INCOME.
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY WITH
TWENTY SIX. IN STATE HOSPITALS
IMPROVEMENTS IN. AND MAYBE PIC
SO- BLOCKERS. AND WE HAVE A 98%
SUCCESS RATE IN OUR AGENCY WHICH
I'M VERY PROUD. WHAT VERY HARD
TO KEEP THAT SUCCESS RATE. WITH
ALL THE PROPER FUNDING WE ARE WE
NOT WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE DOING THAT GREAT WORK.
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE IF WE
CAN GET THE SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE. IT'S
REALLY IT'S REALLY SAD THAT YOU
CAN ACTUALLY DO OUTSTANDING JOBS
DO VERY GOOD WORK AND DON'T GET
THE RECOGNITION THAT YOU ARE DUE
TO. AND IT IS IT COMES TO ONE
THING IT IN THE END. THANK GOD
WE GET THE RATES STEADY BUT WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT THE DISPARITY
. IN THE COMMUNITY WITH THE
VENDORS. OUR LATINO AND FILIPINO
COMMUNITIES AFRICAN AMERICANS
BUT LIKE WE HAVE BEEN OVERLOOKED
. A LOT OF PEOPLE FEEL THAT YOU
KNOW BASICALLY IS BECAUSE OF
OUR- DIALECT. EDUCATION LEVEL
WILL GET WHAT. WE ARE THE SAME
THANK A DAKAR PAGING COUNTERPART
AND WE WANT THAT SPAIN EXACT K.
THAT WAS THE CASE MANAGER.
SUPERVISOR AT NORTH BAY REGIONAL
CENTER AND I ACT LIKE THAT WHILE
WE ONLY GETTING FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH FOR TWENTY FOUR
HOUR STAFFING. AT THIS REGIONAL
CENTER FOR TWENTY FOUR HOUR CARE
FOR SUPPORTED LIVING. IT OUR FOR
OUR- SHE SAID WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT. THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN THING IS THEY EAT THAT
UP. AND I CAN TALK TO MY
COUNTERPART IN MY COUNTERPART TO
ME LIKE BACK THEN THAT'S THE
ONLY THING THAT WE CAN YOU KNOW
THAT WE JUST GOTTA BE QUIET. AND
I LOOKED AND I THOUGHT ABOUT HOW
TO TALK TO MY COLLEAGUES THAT
EAST BAY TALK TO MY COLLEAGUES
THAT. WE ARE SEEING IT IT IS A
DISPARITY. WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT
THE RACISM AND UNDERLYING RACISM
JUST BECAUSE YOU PAY ONE BLACK
BENDER VALUE THAN. YOU PAY THE
OTHER. THAT DOESN'T MAKE YOU
RIGHT. WE ARE LOOKING FOR CHANGE. IN THE CHANGE IN THE SYSTEM
HAS TO HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY WE
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU GUYS ARE
DOING AND IF THEY'RE NOT THE
MONEY THAT'S REALLY GOOD THERE'S
A LOT OF VENDORS THAT DON'T IN
SUPPORT OF LIVING HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT THE EIGHT. ONE ONE THE- FOR
THE EMERGENCY HOUSING PRESIDENT
BUSH PUT OFFICE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR YOU HAVEN'T
SEEN A LOT OF BLACK BOB LATINO
VENDORS YOU KNOW VENDORS THAT DO
SUPPORT ELEVEN HE NEVER HEARD OF
IT BECAUSE IT'S ONLY GIVEN OUT
TO DEFLECT VENDORS. THANK YOU
WHAT. GET THAT WILL BRING THE
SAME BUSINESS THEY ARE LITERALLY
PAYING AND HELPING OUT. TO KEEP
BILL CLINTON- DEPARTMENT. ALL
THE THINGS THAT WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT BUT WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
HIM IN THE LEAD COULD LET OUR
LEGISLATORS KNOW THE TRUTH
BEHIND ALL THE- THANK YOU MISTER
LEGISLATOR FOR HELP IN ABOUT-
THANK COULD NOT WE NEED TO TELL
THE TRUTH. THERE IS DISPARITY IN
OUR COMMUNITY IN DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND WE NEED TO GET
WITHOUT BEING OUT OF TOUCH. AT
THE END OF MY TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR OPERATOR NEXT CALL
PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE TWO OH
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS- JASON THE LETTER WOULD
BE D. SANTA PRIZES FROM THE
CENTRAL COAST OF CALIFORNIA. AND
JUST WANT TO REITERATE A LOT OF
COMMON DIVERT PREVIOUSLY ABOUT.
I LOOKING TO ACCELERATE HE- THE
RATE STUDY. IMPLEMENTATION I
THINK THE WAY I LOOK AT THAT AS
WE WERE GETTING A LOT OF REALLY
FUN EXCITING INITIATIVES. COMING
OUT OF DDS IN THE GRAMMAR OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN TERMS OF NEW- NEW
OUTCOMES AND NEW PAUL AND NEW
POSSIBILITIES FOR SERVING
INDIVIDUALS. WHAT I SEE IS THE
INCREASE IN THE RATE STUDY THE
PAPER APPLICATION AND IT REALLY
BOILS DOWN TO THE ALTERNATE
SERVICE MODEL THAT WE DID OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS. WE NEED THAT
LIFELINE IN ORDER TO GET OUR
SERVICE SERVICES STABILIZER THAT
WE CAN THEN. LOOK AT TAKING ON
SOME OF THESE OTHER INITIATIVES-
FOR EXAMPLE I YOU KNOW I DO- BUT
MONTHLY CALL ABOUT EVERYBODY
THAT WE SERVE. AND IT'S REALLY-
CHALLENGING LOOK PEOPLE IN THE
AYE THIS POINT TWO MONTHS OR TWO
YEARS AND EXCUSE ME. AND SAY
THAT WE STILL ARE NOT ABLE TO
GET STAFF. HIRED TO- TO SERVE
THEIR OR THEIR MOTHER OR
DAUGHTER BROTHER SISTER. AND I
DON'T THINK WE WOULD TOLERATE
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SCHOOL
NOT BEING ABLE TO REOPEN BECAUSE
THAT BE ALL HIRE TEACHERS SO I
DON'T. I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A-
LOOK AT DOING SOMETHING BEING
ABLE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THE
RIGHT SIZE SO THAT WE COULD. YOU
KNOW GET OUR STAFF HIRED
CELEBRATE DEPRIVED THE SERVICE
THE BECAUSE THIS IS JUST.
CONFERENCE ALONG WE NEED TO GET
THE SERVICES STABILIZE AND THEN
WE CAN LOOK AT PICKING ON SOME
OF THESE NEW INITIATIVES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXTHERA LINE THREE OH
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN I
BE HEARD YES PLEASE YES EGGMAN.
GREAT HI MY NAME IS MIKE PEREIRA
I AM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SERVICE PROVIDER BERKELEY CALLED
HELICOPTER CENTERS AND THE CO
CHAIR OF THE STATE LEGISLATIVE
COALITION. FIRST I WANTED TO
EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE TO DR RABIL
AND THIRDLY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE- THAT CLEAN WATER
PEOPLE CHAT REGARDING. THE
CONTENTS OF TODAY'S SESSION
WHICH IS BLOOMING AS BECAUSE OF
ALL OF THE INVESTMENTS THAT
WERE. GIVEN TO OUR COMMUNITY AND
LONG OVERDUE LAST YEAR- WHAT I
REALLY WANT TO SHARE IT'S GOT A
FEW THINGS- FIRST BUSINESS YEAR-
ALL HEARTED. WELL CORRODED-
SUPPORT OF ACCELERATION RATES
STEADY IF THERE'S ONE THING THAT
KIND COMMON OF ALL THE
INITIATIVES THAT COME THROUGH
THIS PAST YEAR AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT WERE MENTIONED IN
TODAY'S HEARING IS THAT THEY'RE
PREDICATED ON HAVING PEOPLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICE. WITHOUT PEOPLE
TO PROVIDE SERVICE IT BECOMES
VERY CHALLENGING TO MEET ANY OF
THE- NEED FOR THE INITIATIVE
DEMOCRATS PUT FORTH. SO OUR
COMMUNITY IS IN BADLY NEEDED OF.
THAT INVESTMENT WHICH IS. GIVEN
PROVIDED TOUCH WITH IMMEDIACY
AND URGENCY I WANT TO STRESS.
THE NEED FOR THAT THE SECOND
PIECE OF THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
A FEW OF MY COLLEAGUES TODAY
HAVE MENTIONED WHICH IS. WE NEED
TO AVOID THIS SITUATION MOVING
FORWARD IT TOOK. REPAYMENTS FROM
ADVOCACY GROUPS AND CERTAINLY
PASSED FOR FROM THE LEGISLATURE
TO ACTUALLY PROMOTE THIS LONG
OVERDUE INVESTMENT. WE NEED TO
AVOID THAT MOVING FORWARD BY
HAVING A REGULAR RATE UPDATES SO
THAT WE CAN ADJUST AS THINGS
MOVE FORWARD AND ALSO AGAIN
PROVIDING AVENUE FOR OUR WORK
FORCE TO HAVE A LIVING WAGE AND
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT PEOPLE
PURSUING A CAREER PATHS THAT
THEY- ENJOY. SO INCLUDING AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND I
REALLY HOPE. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE LOOKS VERY STRONGLY
AT THE PROPOSAL TOOK FOURTH BUT
WHEN A COLLISION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANKS TO THE LINE OF
THREE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI YES HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. C.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU- HI GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
LESLIE SILVA I AM A PARENT
ADVOCATE FOR THE LATINO
COMMUNITY I HAVE A THIRTEEN YEAR
OLD SIR BY REGIONAL CENTER R.
IDG OUR COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY
LATINOS. HAVE BEEN UNDER SERVED
FOR MANY YEARS. OUR CHILDREN
NEED TO BE TREATED WITH THE
QUALITY WHEN IT COMES TO
PROVIDING THEM WITH THE SERVICES
NEEDED COMPARED TO OTHER
ETHNICITIES AND NOT HAVING
ENOUGH PARENTS. THANK YOU FOR
THE SERVICE. THEY ARE ENTITLED
TO OR SIMPLY DENYING THE
SERVICES BECAUSE IT IS THE
PARENTS RESPONSIBILITY TO CARE
FOR A PARKING CHANGES NEEDED OUR
CHILDREN DESERVE BETTER I WOULD
LIKE TWENTY FIVE. A COMMENT THAT
WAS MADE EARLIER IT IS NOT LACK
OF ENGAGEMENT FROM AS THE PARENT
IT IS SPEAKER OF THE SYSTEM AND
THEY INTIMIDATION THAT WE
EXPERIENCE ON A DAILY BASIS FROM
THE SENATE FROM COLCHESTER AND
THAT NEEDS TO BE CHANGED AND I
THINK THE PARENTS NEED TO BE
LISTENING TO. GLADLY OF COURSE I
AM IN SUPPORT OF MIS MARKED AND
MEDICAL MYTHS COMMENTS. PLEASE
BRING LIGHT AND HOPE TO OUR IT
COMMUNITY. SO PLEASE I. IMPLORE
THE COMMITTEE TO LISTEN TO THE
PARENTS NOT THE AGENCIES BEHIND
THE SERVICE DESK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT WILL BE LINE THREE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE THING
IS GIVING ME A. THREE THAT'S
FOLLOW UP OF THE NEED AT. AB
NUMBER AREA CODE YOU GET LIKE
MINDED AND- THERE'S BEEN DURING. NINETY YUP ALL YOUR LOCAL NEWS
YOU'LL HAVE A GOAL MAY. TO THE
MARCH P. AND G. HE DID NOT GET A
- WHAT ELSE OF THE MOST PEOPLE I
KNOW EVERY YOUR LOCAL THE BORDER
OF THIRTY TWO NEED. COMMUNITY
FOR A LOT. MEDIA YOUR IS. WE
DIDN'T. LOOK AT IT CIRCUIT
HEATING THE WHOLE AS THE IDEAL.
MEDICAL FONG EXPLORED. FOXBAT
DOLLARS THOUGHT PROCESS BOTH
HOSPITAL FOLLOWED FROM TELL ME
BACK IN WHICH NINETY FEET. YOU
KNOW COMO FIVE THE DEMOCRATIC
THE YEAR FINALLY OKAY KATIE THE
- IS PROBABLY NOT THE ONLY. IF
YOU'RE NOT HERE IT DIDN'T BREAK
DOWN LATE IN PER MONTH HE DID IT
DO YOU HAVE BEEN EASIER AFTER
ONE YEAR. AND. FOR FOUR EIGHT
NOT SOME GREAT ONE ABOUT THE
BUCKET LUCK WITH THE ACT FORTY
MILLION EIGHT YEARS OLD GET OF
THE VOTE FOR WAR ONE YOUR BOOK
MARKETS AT THE LIS IF YOU DON'T
OUT ON THE ONE ABOUT FIFTY BUCKS
YOUR BUSINESS TO PAY YOU DON'T
YOU SUBSCRIBING. OUR SYSTEM NOT
. CALLER PLEASE. X. WILL BE ABLE
OF THREE TO SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH-
MY NAME IS LINDA CARL CONNOR I
HAVE A TWENTY NINE YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER SIOBHAN WHO HAS
MULTIPLE DISABILITIES AND IS NON
SPEAKING BUT IS A VERY ADOPT
USER OF AUGMENTATIVE
COMMUNICATION. SHE LEFT SCHOOL
WITH FUNCTIONAL COMMUNICATION
BUT SHE ENTERED AN ADULT
SERVICES WORLD WHICH WAS
COMPLETELY UNPREPARED TO PROVIDE
STAFF ABLE TO SUPPORT HER
COMMUNICATION AS WELL THOSE
OTHER COMPLEX NEEDS. I FOUND A
REAL LACK OF EXPECTATION OF
COMMUNICATION FOR THIS
POPULATION AND THE AGENCIES SAY
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER
CLIENTS BY COUPON IN ANY
PHYSICAL COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS
HAVE BEEN AROUND. FOR THIRTY
FIVE OR FORTY YEARS. WE ARE NOW
IN OUR FIFTH YEAR OF WAITING FOR
REGIONAL CENTER VANDER JARVIS'S
THAT WERE AUTHORIZED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. WE'VE HAD EIGHT
REFERRALS TO FLSA AGENCIES WHO
SAY THEY CANNOT FIND STAFF WITH
SKILLS TO SERVE HER AT EXISTING
PAY RATES. CHIU AGENCY SAID THEY
WOULD SUBMITHEALTH AND SAFETY
WAIVERS TO GET A HIGHER PAY RATE
AND THEN FAIL TO DO SO. OF THE
TIME WE REQUESTED SERVICES MY
HUSBAND HAS DIED I REMOVED FROM
MY EARLY SIXTIES TO MY LATE
SIXTIES. FROM SOMEBODY WHO WAS
IN GOOD HEALTH TO SOMEONE WHO'S
BEEN POOR HEALTH DUE TO THE-
UNCEASING ROUND THE CLOCK CARE I
HAVE TO PROVIDE BECAUSE I DON'T
HAVE ANY OTHER CHOICE ON TOP OF
MY FULL TIME JOB. I WANT TO BE
CLEAR WE HAVE NOT REJECTED ANY
SERVICES THE AGENCIES HAVE
REJECTED US. BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
HIRE SKILLED STAFF NEAR MINIMUM
WAGE. AND FURTHERMORE THERE THE
SOS AGENCIES WERE UNABLE OR
UNWILLING TO PROVIDE MANY OF THE
SERVICES LISTED IN THE AFTERLIFE
STATUTES AND REGULATIONS. THAT
REQUIRE A HIGHER SKILL LEVEL. OF
LAST YEAR THERE WERE TWO
LEGISLATIVE INITIATIVES PROPOSED
I BELIEVE BY DRC BUT THEY WERE
NOT DISCUSSED IN THE HEARING.
ONE WOULD HAVE ALLOWED REGIONAL
CENTERS TO ADJUST PAY RATES IN
SITUATIONS BY GUARDS WERE VENDOR
AGENCIES ARE UNWILLING TO DO THE
WORK TO SUBMIT A HEALTH AND
SAFETY WAIVER. THE OTHER
INVOLVES REMOVING ANY BARRIERS
FOR FLS SERVICES TO BE PROVIDED
TO ADULTS WHO LIVE WITH THEIR
FAMILIES THERE'S NO WAY WITH ALL
THE GAPS IN SERVICES THAT MY
DAUGHTER COULD LIVE ANYWHERE
ELSE. THANK YOU I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU HOLDING THESE
HEARINGS I'M ALWAYS REALLY
IMPRESSED BY THE CARING I HEAR.
WHICH MAKES WHAT WE EXPERIENCE
ON THE GROUND THAT MUCH MORE
SHOCKING. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS NUMBER. THREE
TWENTY NINE. HELLO NOT MUCH OF A
QUESTION THREE. THIS COULD
ALMOST HEAR THE NUMBER TWO
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT THAT MANDATE
THE CANNELLA MANNER. BECAUSE
WE'LL GET TO THE CENTER FOR
HUMAN THE LESS THAN A YEAR. IF
THE LEGISLATURE CAREFULLY IN THE
COMING PERILOUSLY ALREADY SEVEN
FIVE YOU'LL BE ABLE TO THAT
FILIPINO THE LOCAL COMPLETE COPY. OF THE LETTER FOR THE MUSEUM-
THE MOBILE I RECOGNIZE THAT THE
LONGER THE FEEL. IN ANOTHER BOTH
OF THE- NEW VEHICLE CLEAR.
ASSEMBLY WHO IT BECAUSE- ONE OF
THE OTHER OTHER. MAN **** THE
THREE SEVEN SEVEN. USUALLY
ALLOWED TO. IMPOSES WANNA BE IN
THE LOW THE FINAL POLITICAL ON.
YOU KNOW I COULD RESERVE THE
COMPANY THAT ON THE- A STORM
CALLING PARTY. REGULATORY CRISIS
NO. OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLAY.
IT WILL BE LINE THREE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL OUR
TIME WHEN NUMBERS ALWAYS. BY
MONITORING YOUR I'LL BE ABOUT
THE NEXT I. A MANDATE BY A BY
YEAH MIGHT BE IF THE GOVERNMENT
ARE QUITE A FILE JONES BUT
NOTHING ANY THIRD BODY OF ELEVEN
YEAR I DO MY YEAH YES OUR SYSTEM
. MEXICO PLEASE. TO BE NO. TWO
FIFTY THREE. HELLO MY NAME IS
MARGARET THE LOCAL LEVEL- I
THINK FROM OUR CLIENTS- OF THE
MRC. M. THE FINAL ONE. BAGHDAD
THANKS THE GUIDANCE BEFORE OF I
THINK MICRON ARE NOW IN THE
DETERMINE BOB. WE DON'T THANK
THEM SOME CHALLENGES. ARE
FINDING PEOPLE BY THEIR- ARE
WILLING TO WALK ON WALK ON THEIR
OF SELF DETERMINATION AND ALSO I
AM FINANCED ARE MAKING THINGS
COMPLICATED FOR FAMILY. BOB
DESPITE ALL THE FAILURE MY FONG
HOW ABOUT YOU NOW HAVE. MORE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE- THEN INCOME
WITH THE TRAVEL CHANNEL. I ALSO
A FOOTBALL ONE ARE USING MY AND
COVERED BY ON YOUR ABSENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
THANKS TO BE THREE THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU COULD CHEN C. HELLO
OKAY. I AM WILL BE FROM YOUR
SOME OF THE INCIDENTS IN
PARTICULAR PRODUCTS THE NUMBER
EIGHT WE GET THEM AND THEN
THAT'LL DO IT WHAT LOCAL NOTHING
YOUR DAILY HABITS GOAL WILL MAKE
A THIRD THE BENEFIT BUTTON OKAY
GOT IN FACT IN BUT HE DID HE END
UP DOING ABOUT THE MATTER AYE
DADDY WHY DO BAD IT GETS. THE
NOT JACK YEAH THOU LOOK AT TO BE
BUILT THE QUALITY. OUR FIND A
FAMILY OUR AGE THE BODY AT IN
EFFECT THANK GOD DATE DATE DATE
THE- FORMALLY THE- NOTHING
ALREADY HAVE IT I A MORE TROUBLE
LATINOS HE TOLD ME WHAT. I GUESS
. IT WILL BE FOR. HE AMONG
ALABAMA EIGHT THE AGONIZING IT
BUT I. AT AT IT. YOU GET ACT YES
FOR A THAT SENATE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY POINT THIRTY. BECAUSE WHEN I. HARPER NEXT
PLEASE. THANKS IS NUMBER TO
THIRTY SEVEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. MY NAME IS MARIA- I
HAVE A DOG SEVEN YEARS- I WOULD
HOWEVER. ALMOST THE DAY SHE WAS
BORN ENTER THE PLAN WHAT THE
SOCIAL WORKER. AT WORK BUT
HARPER REGIONAL. AND MY DAUGHTER
WAS BORN I HAVE NEVER DONE HELP.
I HAVE NEVER GOT ANYTHING FROM
THEM. AND UNTIL NOW THAT HE CAN
SEVENTEEN I MET- THE LADY FROM
ICC. AND THEN THEY STARTED
GIVING ME SOME HELP FROM
PARLIAMENT DID NOT ORIGINAL-
WHEN I ASK FOR HELP THEY WOULD
SEND ME TO- DIFFERENT PLACES AND
I WOULD GET VERY SCARED THEY'VE
BEEN TAUGHT ME THAT I HAD TO GET
RID OF MY DAUGHTER IN. ORDER TO
GET ALL THE BENEFITS AND I THINK
THAT- ASSEMBLY- SENATE I FEEL
LIKE THERE WERE- PRETTY ME OTHER
MINORITIES AND EVEN MY DAUGHTER
YOU KNOW WITH THE SPECIAL NEEDS
. AND I JUST WANT. TO SAY THAT-
UT MARTIN AND I LOOKED AT THE
COMMENTS ARE DOING A GREAT JOB
HELPING US. TO NAVIGATE AND-
TALK TO HER REGIONAL AND. I JUST
WANTED TO- HELP BUT- OUR LATINO
COMMUNITIES AND MINORITIES THAT
HARBOR REGIONAL MAKES A LOT OF.
A LOT OF VERY GOOD FOR US TO
NAVIGATE AND I EVEN TOLD THEM
YOU KNOW WHAT CAN I DO HOW CAN I
DO IT IN. MY WORKERS THAT WHILE
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW TO NAVIGATE
THE SYSTEM YOU NEED TO LEARN TO
DO IT LIKE HOW. WELL YOU KNOW.
MAYBE NEXT TIME I WILL TELL YOU
KNOW SOMEONE WITH YOU KNOW HE
WOULD NEVER HELP ME. AND
UNFORTUNATELY LOST MY JOB. AND
MY DAD HAD BEEN HAVE FOR TWO
YEARS- MEDICAL. AND I SAID HOW
CAN I GET- MEDICAL FOR HER. WELL
I AND I WENT UP BY A QUALIFIED.
WELL THERE'S NOTHING ELSE I CAN
I CAN DO FOR YOU. BUT THANK GOD
THAT I MET ELIZABETH COMMENTS
AND- THANK YOU SEE LADIES AND-
I'M GOING TO GIVE HIM A LITTLE
BETTER HELP. AND YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN FOUND THEM ABOUT THAT- THE
COMMON NINETEEN THEY SAID THAT
IS GONE I DON'T KNOW BUT TO US.
IT'S GETTING MORE. RIDICULOUS
THAT THE NUMBERS ARE GETTING
HIGHER AND MORE PEOPLE AROUND US
ARE GETTING- SIX BUT YESTERDAY'S
GONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR-
LISTENING TO OUR VOICES AND I
REALLY HOPE THAT YOU GUYS. HELP
BUT- WHO. DR HARBOR REGIONAL AND
THEY MAKE OUR JOB EASIER FOR
SELF DETERMINATION BUT YES WE
ARE MINORITIES BUT WE ARE
LEARNING ABOUT THE SYSTEM NOW
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS OF
NUMBER THREE FORTY THANK. SEEING
OF CULTURE C. OKAY YOU KNOW MAY
BE THIRTY UP AT SEATTLE ANGELS
GOING MODERATELY LONG COMMANDED
THE CENTER CAN NINETY ENGLAND.
ANY COPYING NAY THANK YOU TO
FIND YOUR THINKING UP THE SMOKE
. DON'T FORGET FOR THE GOVERNOR
OF KENTUCKY OF THE- DUTY MARKET
DAISY YOU- FOR A LAUGH AND I
LOOK AT THE OKAY THAT I LET THE
PHONE UP- NEED OF YOUR BOOK ON.
THE SEVENTH BY THE US GOVERNMENT
ECONOMIC PREVENTIVE TELESCOPE ON
ICCA THE COMPUTER LATINA
INTERCONNECTED FURNITURE CHEAP.
YOU FOR THAT SO YOU CAN EXPECT
EITHER GIVE. ME THE BALLOT YOU
KNOW. THAT'S THE OF SONORA.
OPERATOR NEXT FALL PLEASE. NEXT
IS NUMBER. THREE FIFTY. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES SIR. HI MY
NAME IS AMANDA PRESS APPLE I AM
THE FATHER OF THAT- JAPANESE
GENTLEMAN- THE YOUNG MY ACCOUNT
FROM THE TWENTY TWO THAT MY WIFE
JUST MENTION I'M CALLING FROM A
DIFFERENT LOCATION. SURE ENOUGH
I D AGREE WHOLEHEARTEDLY WITH
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM DREAM
MARK AND ELIZABETH BATTLEMENTS-
I ALSO WANTED TO- NOTIFY ALL OF
YOU THAT THAT INDEED. YOU MAY
HAVE HEARD SOME OF THOSE HORROR
STORIES OF. THE PEOPLE AREAS
THAT ARE NON WHITE IT'S HARD TO
SAY THAT ARE NOT RECEIVING THE
BENEFITS AND THE NUMBER OF
ABUSES. BY THE REGIONAL CENTERS
MA'AM I PAYING JUST ONE BUT
IT'S- NOT THE NUMBER. OF- LET'S
SEE POLICIES OR THE WAY THAT
EACH REGIONAL CENTER CONDUCTS
ITSELF. THEY ALL ALL TWENTY ONE
HAVE DIFFERENT RULES OF COURSE
THAT IS VERY- A BIASED TOWARDS.
A CERTAIN NUMBER OF PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
DISABLED- AND SO FOR THAT REASON
I ALSO WHAT WHAT SUPPORT THE
SPEEDY MESS UP THIS STUDY THAT
YOU ARE THAT YOU'RE CONDUCTING
AND MAKE SURE THAT THESE THINGS
ARE ACTUALLY DONE IN A PROPER
WAY BECAUSE- AS YOU HAVE HEARD-
THE- MINIMUM WAGE WENT UP IN
CALIFORNIA. AND YET THEY'RE
GOING WHERE THE BUDGET THAT WE
HAVE FROM YEARS AGO. AND SO.
EVERYBODY'S PRICE WENT UP AND
EVERY VENDOR IS PRICE BUT NOT
BUT THEY STILL WANT US TO
CONFORM WITH THE OLD CRISIS THAT
MOST VENDORS MODEL NUMBER EXCEPT
THAT'S WHY THE LACK OF PERSONNEL
OR THE LACK OF VENDORS THAT WILL
GIVE US THE SERVICES THAT WE
NEED. ANYWHERE IN EITHER CASE-
AGAIN I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT
JUDY MARC. AND BBQ AND A LITTLE
BIT. OF BONUS. FOR THAT REASON
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT AT NUMBER
THREE FIFTY SIX. THREE FIFTY
SIX. YOU. THIS IS WHEN I'M NOT.
THIS WHICH ALMOST. ARE THE
NUMBER OF MEDALLIONS YEAH BUT MY
MOTHER NAY THE ONLY DO THAT WHEN
YOU KNOW THEY THE FIFTIETH
ANNUAL OCCUPIED AT THE TIME OVER
HERE NOT. IN THE- I. HERE YET SO
YEAH HE I'M GLAD THOUGH BUT I
BUT I SAID LET'S NOT BE THERE
THERE IS A LOT. IT'S A LAPTOP IT
LOOKS NAME OF ELEPHANT ALL RIGHT
YOU'RE NOT. IF YOU HAVE BEEN
TECTONIC REAP I DON'T KNOW
GETTING. ON A GET AND THAT'LL OF
THE CORBYN'S NONE OF GET ENOUGH
PROVIDE A ON OF THE TICKET THE
FEDERAL HELLO IS THE AWESOME I
THOUGHT PROVIDE THAT HE YES I
AKIO TOYODA. UP YEAH AND THE
LAST YOUR AT EIGHTY SEVEN YEAH I
THOUGHT I AM BUT I. WOULD CHECK
HAS BEEN I REPEAT MANY VOTE.
THREE FIVE EIGHT WHAT MAKES.
THAT. GROSSEST NANA. NEXT READ
ONLINE ONE NINETY SEVEN. HELLO
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. HI REGINA
LOPEZ I AM CALLING TO ASK YOU TO
PLEASE SUPPORT THE ARCA AND
LATTER RAIN COALITION BUDGET
REQUESTS BURKE THE THING ABOUT
FUNDING INCLUDING CELEBRATED
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROVIDER RATE
INCREASES. AFFECTING THE CORE
STAFFING FORMULA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE'RE GONNA NUMBER THREE
SIXTY TWO. HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. I HELLO ME NUMBER OF
MULTILATERAL BOB LONG BALL- BUT
APPLE YEAH AND COMMENT THAT EVEN
IF WE HAD ANY COMMENT BERMAN IF
YOU'RE A GOOD MIGHT I MEAN I
FELT ON THE COMMODITY OWN A HOPE
AND A YOU'RE NOT JUST GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THE NECESSITY
FURNITURE OF THE CLARK- YEAH
LEARN ABOUT THEM BEING BUT A-
LEVEL OF THE STUDY THAT IS
CAPABLE OF THE- FROM A MODEL
HOLDEN THE REGION OKAY. BETTER
BILL LIKE THAT ISN'T I CAN'T
ANSWER HELP WITH THE PRINTER THE
VENDORS TO THANK BE THAT AS IT
WAS OUR TO YET AGAIN IN BECAUSE
THAT AND THE OTHER CUIDADO DE
CAMILLA YEAH I MORTARBOARD THOSE
ARE I DON'T THE VEHICLE NEEDS
CAN STILL CREATE ANOTHER
METHODICAL ATTEMPT TO KNOW THAT
THE L. ORD I AM BUT WITH THE BY
ISN'T MOVIES HE'S- I THINK WHAT
A NUMBER OF SAMPLES. ENOUGH AND
I'M YOU THAT THE FUNDS ON THE
PENINSULA OF US GREAT ON THE
PHONE THAT AND IT COULD COME
MORE NORMAL BUNDLED UNDER THAT
IS BACK I ABOUT THE BECAUSE THE
HOMES PANEL.
AND FOCUS. ON ON
YOUR DENTAL- APPLE YOU KNOW BUT
IT IS- YEAH. CAN I HAVE THE
STUDY THAT IS GOING TO
CONSTRUCTING AND NUMBER WILL BE
THERE- KILEY THAT. BUT AGAIN
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR THEM AND THEN
LOOK AT IT FROM THE- BODY MUCH
OF THE REST. GROSS SONORA. NEXT
CALL PLEASE. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHER CALLERS IN THE
QUEUE. OPERATOR DO YOU MIND-
REMINDING ABOUT THE INSTRUCTIONS
AND SEEING IF WE CAN ASK OF ANY
OTHER PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO QUEUE
WHEN. ABSOLUTELY MANY OTHERS
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND WE NEED TO HAVE SOME MORE IN
QUEUE TO BE JUST A MOMENT. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD- ELEVEN
O'CLOCK THIS. WELL I LOVE THE
HOME ITSELF. I'M NOT THE WHOLE.
MONTAUBAN. YEAH OKAY YEAH DO
HAVE A FOR MY IT HAPPEN TELL YOU
THE MINIMUM ON THE OF POLITICAL
PRISON YOUNG. I THINK YOU WILL
HAVE YOUR BILL FOR NORTH OF BE
ALL. OKAY AND THEN. WILL BE. ALL
NO BETTER VALUE SO THAT THE THAN
BONE NOT. HE HAS BEEN TAKING.
YEAH BUT I'M NOT THE VERY LONG
SEEING IT. LOOK FOR ABOUT IT BY
. THE BOOK IMAM HOME A LONG LONG
FOR THE WAY. BOTH THE IF YOU
FIND EVAN LOW. OKAY I HAVE A. AB
ONE MORE THE NEW YORK BUT I LOVE
MY GOING ALL OUT THAT THE OLD
WAITING AREA COME ON THE. YOU
KNOW HOME. HELLO. ALTHOUGH OF
COURSE FROM CAMANCHE CHANNEL
pCONTACT. THE WAS DEVASTATED-
LONG NO DON'T APOLOGIZE CONTACT
OKAY A LOT OF CONSEQUENCE YEAH.
HELLO OKAY BERMAN AND AMONG OF.
THE WE GOT BUT I DIDN'T BOUGHT
IT. ONE OF YOUR LAST. BELIEVE
THE ALL OF THE OTHER BUT OF
WORKING ON. OKAY IT'S GOING BUT
I THINK THAT IS HANDLED LAW.
BAKOOL I THOUGHT IT I LIKE THE
ALONE FULLER YEAH WELL. COOL
MODERN HOW WILL BE PUBLIC THE OF. THE PROPOSAL OF DON'T. WANT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS I
REALLY APPROVED AND THEN MY
MOTHER TO A SEVEN YEAR OLD BOY
WITH AUTISM AUTISM RUNS AND MY
HUGE FAMILY AND FAMILY ALL OF
THEM ONLY EVER RECEIVED HELP
FROM THE REGIONAL CENTER HAD AN
ADULT R TEENAGE YEAR- THIS IS
ONE OF THE DISPARITIES THAT BY
EVEN TO THIS DAY NO COORDINATOR
OF MINE EVER MENTIONS EVERYTHING
THAT MIGHT THAT WILL BENEFIT
FROM SUCH AS PERSONAL ASSISTANT
AND MORE GOING UP- MY BROTHER HE
IS TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD HE WAS
EVER OFFERED RESPITE PERSONAL
SINCE THEN AS WELL- ANY MENTION
OF A B. SERVICE FINANCIAL
KNOWLEDGE. IT'S BEEN VERY HARD
ON MY FAMILY- TRYING TO HELP ON-
AND THIS IS WHY I WANT TO
PERSONALLY THANK ELIZABETH IN
THE INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATING OPENING OUR EYES
IN BREAKING THAT CHANGE EVERY
DAY TAKING THEIR THERE WAS A
SERVICE THAT WE WERE ON THE
WORLD- AGREEMENT. SHIPPING KILL
. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXAVAR. THREE THIRTY SIX. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. ALL FIVE OF
MY NAME'S MARY ELLEN SPAR AND
THE TIME I'M AN OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST- I'M NOT GOING TO
PREPARE A VENDOR OR A DIVISION
OF AMERICA. FIRST OF ALL I
WANTED TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
THE ARCHIVE AND LAUNCH RAMPS AND
COALITION BUDGET REQUESTS FOR
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING- I HOPE-
GOODBYE I. OUR PROVIDERS ENTRY.
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY SERVICES
SO- I NOTICED- BEFORE THE
CLIENT- I WANT TO COMMEND
PROJECT FOR REGIONAL CENTER AT
ZERO TWO THREE YEARS OLD THEIR
ASSETS FOR OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
SERVICES. AND THEN AT AGE THREE
THERE AFFECT AGAIN FOR SCHOOL
BASED OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
SERVICES. BUT THEN WHEN THEY
COME BACK TO THE REGIONAL CENTER
AT AGE TWENTY ONE. AT AGE
EIGHTEEN FIVE MILLION SIX
HUNDRED ONE. THEY'RE NOT UPSET
AND SO I EIGHT. I WOULD LIKE TO
SUGGEST THAT THAT AT LEAST YOU
CAN HAVE A POSSIBILITY TO SPEAK
YOU KNOW BUT ARE NOT. DON'T YOU
SERVICES THAT THEY RECEIVE. THE
BENEFIT THEM BECAUSE LIFE
DOESN'T AND TWENTY ONE THAT
COULD BE CONSTRUCTING DEPENDENT
AND- ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT
THE GOLDBERG EDUCATIONAL THERAPY
IS FOR THE CLIENT COULD BE MORE
INDEPENDENT- THROUGHOUT THE
LIFESPAN- THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO
SAY THANK YOU. THANK. YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO BE ABLE
THREE SIXTY FOUR. YES HELLO-
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS ROSE
IDEAS AND I AM A TEACHER HERE IN
LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA MY SON IS
JOHN JOHNNY VALENZUELA AND HE'S
BEEN A CLIENT OF HARBOR REGIONAL
CENTER HERE IN IN TORRANCE SINCE
HE WAS TWO AND A HALF. AND LIKE
I HAVE PUBLICLY COMMENTED BEFORE
- THE YES THERE IS A LOT OF
SERVICES THERE ARE A LOT OF
SERVICES BEFORE THE CHILDREN ARE
THREE YEARS OLD AND THEN THEY
TRANSITION INTO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I REMEMBER HEARING
COMMENTS ABOUT CERTAIN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE BETTER THAN OTHERS
NOW MY SON IS TWENTY FOUR YEARS
OLD. THROUGHOUT THE TIME WITH
HARBOR REGIONAL THERE WERE NEVER
ANY SERVICES OFFERED OTHER THAN
REST TAKE CARE- MY SON IS ONE OF
THOSE- AGGRESSIVE TYPE OF
INDIVIDUALS- NONVERBAL. AND
THERE REALLY ISN'T VERY LITTLE
SUPPORT- THIS PAST YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY- I HAD MY RICH BROKEN BY
HIM AND MY FINGER- I DID CALL
HARPER REGIONAL I CALLED THE
PERSON AND THE SERVICE
COORDINATOR AT THE TIME. AND
REALLY NO HELP. THERE IS NO
SUPPORT OUT THERE I KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE THE NAME OF CRISIS
INTERVENTION TEAM. BUT NEVER
RESULTED IN ANY TYPE OF SUPPORT
WHATSOEVER. REQUESTED A NEW
SERVICE COORDINATOR COORDINATOR
HOPING THAT THAT WOULD RESOLVE
THE PROBLEM AND IT'S STILL
AWAITING GAME IT STILL MIGHT
SENATE SIXTY THREE. ANYWAY IT'S
NOW FOR SIXTY FOUR POUNDS USED
TO WAY TOO CLOSE TO FOUR NINETY
POUNDS- I'VE BEEN WORKING OUT
DILIGENTLY WITH HIM NOW THAT MY
HEALTH IS BETTER- HELPING HIM TO
LOSE THE WEIGHT AND TO LOWER HIS
A. ONE C. BECAUSE HE WAS
CONSIDERED A DIABETIC HE NO
LONGER IS. BECAUSE THEY GET THE
PRE DIABETIC BUT MY POINT HERE
IS THAT HARPER REGIONAL IS
SUPPOSED TO BE A CENTER THAT
PROVIDES SUPPORT TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE THAT PROVIDES MENTORING
FOR US SIMPLE WORKSHOPS
ANNOUNCED IN THE BOOKLET ARE NOT
ENOUGH- THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE BIT
THERE WERE NO PHONE CALLS. THE
PHONE CALLS THAT WERE MADE WERE
INITIATED BY ME LIKE MANY OF THE
OTHER PARENTS HERE. AN IT
WASN'T UNTIL I MET- MEMBERS OF.
THE LIVES OF IT GOMEZ AND THE
OTHER MEMBERS THAT I REALIZED.
THAT WE FINALLY HAD. SOMEONE WAS
A BASICALLY TO FAMILIES SUCH AS
MYSELF- VOICE. THE SOMEONE WAS
ACTUALLY OUT THERE ADVOCATING
FOR OUR FAMILIES. AND- WE NEED
TO DO MORE WE NEED TO DO RIGHT
BY OUR CHILDREN THEY NEED A
HIGH. QUALITY OF LIFE THEY
DESERVE A QUALITY OF LIFE JUST
LIKE ANYONE ELSE IT'S SO HARD TO
FIND GREAT GOOD DENTISTS THAT
WILL CARE FOR KIDS. PEOPLE THAT
WILL CUT THEIR HAIR PEOPLE THAT
ARE GENUINELY INTERESTED IN THE
WELFARE OF OUR CHILDREN WE NEED
TO ATTRACT PEOPLE THAT WERE
WILLING TO WORK WITH OUR
CHILDREN. AND NOT JUST PULL
ANYONE OFF THE STREET WE NEED TO
PROVIDE TRAINING TO EVERYONE IN
THE COMMUNITY AND SO PLEASE
LISTEN TO US PLEASE LISTEN TO US
I'M NOT ONLY A TEACHER BUT I'M
THE PARENT OF A TWENTY FOUR YEAR
OLD NONVERBAL OCCURRED THINKING
MAN. I'M ONLY FIVE FEET ONE AND
I DEFINITELY WAY WAY LESS THAN
TWO HUNDRED POUNDS AND SO I I'M
DEALING WITH IN THE STATE THE
PEOPLE LOOK AT ME AS A HOW DO
YOU DO IT. HOW DO I NOT DO IT
I'M A MOTHER HE IS MY CHILD. AND
I'M JUST APPALLED AT THE FACT
THAT THAT THE HARBOR OUR
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE NOT DOING
ENOUGH. IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A
LOT OF RED TAPE OUT THERE. WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO ALONG WITH
CARING FOR OUR CHILDREN. HAVE TO
ALSO BATTLE. BETWEEN AGENCIES
THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT. SO PLEASE LISTEN TO THE
PARENT SURVEY YES DO WHATEVER
YOU NEED TO DO TO FIND OUT THE
TRUTH OF WHAT'S GOING ON. MY SON
HAS BEEN A CLIENT FOR TO SINCE
HE WAS TWO AND A HALF AND I HAVE
NEVER EVER HEARD OF ANY OF THE
PROGRAMS. UNTIL THIS YEAR. AND
I'M AN EDUCATED PERSON I SPEAK
FLUENT ENGLISH AND I SPEAK
FLUENT SPANISH. THE ONLY
DIFFERENCE IS THAT MY LAST THING
IS AND MY HUSBAND MY SON
BLASTING IN VALENZUELA. SO WHAT
IS THAT WHAT IT WHAT'S GOING ON.
THAT'S WHERE THE QUESTION IS
WHAT WHAT IS GOING ON. LOOK AT
THE NUMBERS AND LOOK AT WHO IS
GETTING THE SERVICES THAT WHO IS
NOT GETTING THE SERVICES THEN
WHY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANKS TO NUMBER TWO FORTY SIX.
YES MY NAME IS DOROTHY CHARLES
AND I'M BROWN MOTHER TO A TWENTY
NINE YEAR OLD GRANDSON WITH AN
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY HE HAS
BEEN A CLIENT OF THE BALLOT NOT
REGIONAL CENTER FOR THE LAST
TWENTY SIX YEARS. IN LISTENING
TO THE LAST MONTH- SPEAK I
REALIZED THAT HER EXPERIENCE HAS
BEEN SIMILAR TO MINE ONE
DIFFERENCE MY GRANDSON HAD HAVE
HAD SEVERE BEHAVIORS FROM THE
TIME HE BECAME A REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENTS AT THREE YEARS OF AGE. I
RATE HIM. HE IS BY FAR. HE ENDED
UP WITH THREE DE CARE HOMES
QUIET BECAUSE I WAS NEVER TOLD
THAT HE COULD STAY HOME WITH ME
AND BASICALLY TAKING SURVEYS. I
WAS TOLD BY A SERVICE
COORDINATOR YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO GIVE HIM UP. WHY BECAUSE I
WAS A FULL FINE FINGAL GRANDMA.
THAT'S NOT RIGHT. YOU HAVE TO
GIVE UP TIME FOR GRABS TOOK CARE
HOMES. WHEN I MET BEYONC YOU
YOU'RE GOING TO FACE IN MY
GRANDSON WITH TWENTY THREE AND
HE WAS STILL IN A CARE HOME AND
HE WAS. PUT IN THE HOSPITAL
EVERY THREE MONTHS BECAUSE HE
WAS BEING OVER MEDICATED AND
HAVE FOLLOWING. WHAT WAS. HE
SAID HE WAS GETTING OPERATIONAL
VOLUME EVERY THREE MONTHS THAT'S
NOT RIGHT. AND I TRIED MY BEST
TO GO TO THE STATE TO THE STATE
LEVEL TO PAY THEY ARE OVER BUT
IT ACADIAN CHILDREN IN. CARE
HOME. AND YOU KNOW HOW I WAS
ABLE TO CHANGE THE MEDICATION.
BY GETTING CONSERVATORSHIP AND
MAKING THE DECISIONS FOR HIM.
THAT'S NOT WHAT IT. I MET BE
ARGUES THE ORGANIZATION AND THE
LIVES OF THE PHARMACEUTICAL
GROUP. WHEN MIKE BRANSON WITH
TWENTY THREE. THANK HELP FIFTY
THAT I COULD KEEP HIM AT HOME.
BUT I CAN'T HELP SERVICES. THEY
WERE A GODSEND TO. I CALL THEM
MY ANGELS I AM NOW AND I FEW
FIGURE PACK ABOUT ORDER AND
PRODUCT BECAUSE BALLOT HELPING
OTHERS WHO WANT TO KEEP THEIR
CHILDREN AT HOME. NOT TURN THEM
INTO CARE IN TOOK CARE OF ALL
THE BETTER NOT PROPERLY MONITOR.
NOT EVEN BY MONITORED BY THE
MEDICAL WITH PARTY OR WHATEVER-
MEMBER WHATEVER GROUP HAD
OVERSEE THE PART BECAUSE I
CONSIDER. THAT GO AROUND OVER.
MEDICATING CHILDREN CARE HOPE.
HOME MY BOY IS BREAKING THEY
LOOK THEIR HOME ARE IN THE-
PHOTO HAVE THAT BECAUSE HE- IT
HAVE A FAMILY LIKE. MIKE BENSON
TO GET. NOW LIVING WITH B. M. B.
C. FOR LIKE YOU SHOULD. I AM
REQUIRED GO WITH. I HAVE BEEN
WITH THE ICC NOW GOING ON THREE
YEARS. AND I DO HAVE TO SAY THAT
VALLEY MOUNTAIN REGIONAL CENTER
HAS. SOME POSITIVELY MADE
POSITIVE IN BOTH OF THE BACK OF
A LOT OF THE AREA. WE HAVE NOW
BEEN ACCEPTED OF THE
ORGANIZATION THAT IS GOING TO BE
ADVOCATING FOR ALL FAMILIES IN
THE CATCHMENT AREA. M. WE'VE
EXCEPT WE'VE BEEN ACCEPTED THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING AWAY AND THAT WE
ARE ADDRESSING THE REAL
DISPARITIES. AFTER A ROCKY START
IN WHICH WE WERE SEEN AS
AGGRESSIVE AND THREATENING. WE
HAVE BEEN SOMEWHAT AT THE STATE
HELP RATHER THAN A HINDRANCE TO
THE REGIONAL CENTER TO WRITE THE
DISPARITIES. IN PARTICULAR ARE
DIRECTOR TONY ANDERSON AND
GABRIELA LOPEZ CULTURAL
SPECIALIST HELP HELP TO BRIDGE
THE GAP BY NEEDING MONTHLY TO
HAVE A- REPRESENTS THE VOICE OF
THE COMMUNITY AND ADDRESS
SYSTEMIC ISSUES AND CHALLENGES.
WITH INDIVIDUAL FOR THE POSTAL
SERVICE COORDINATOR AND PROGRAM
MANAGER. WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY
BUT WE STILL HAVE A LONG WAY TO
GO IN OUR EFFORTS TO GAIN
TRANSPARENCY AND INCLUSION.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO ORGANIZE TO
PROPERTY THOUGHT WE CALL THEM
COLLABORATIVE COFFEE BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT
COLLABORATION IT WHAT'S THE
COMMUNITY IS ABLE TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS. AND ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT READ REGIONAL CENTER
POLICIES AND PRACTICES. IT IS
OUR HOPE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE BEEFED UP WITH PEOPLE THAT
ARE REGIONAL CENTER ON A MONTHLY
BASIS AND BUILD THAT TRUST
FEATHER FOUND LACKING IN OUR
LATINO COMMUNITY. IF WE ARE TO
MAKE TO MAKE CHANGES TO ADDRESS
DISPARITIES. THEN WE MUST
INVOLVE THE GRASS ROOTS
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. AND
I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY ALL TO SUPPORT
WHAT JUDY MARC STATED DURING HER
. TESTIMONIAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND THAT
COMES FROM LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TWO FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN I'M NOT. THERE WHICH IS
BETTER FOR THEM LOCAL CANNELLA
PRODUCT IF I'M NOT. CAREFUL OR
YOU'LL BE LOOKING INSIDE YOU THE
SEATTLE NOTHING OUT OF YOUR
REMARKS. THE NEW YORK YOU ARE.
THEY NORMALLY COVER THE MOMENT.
ACC LOWER BACK K. YEAH YEAH IN
THE LOCAL ONLY THAT I HAD BUT I
FOR YEAH AND THEN LET THE LOCAL
MOM ALSO TOOK. YOUR BUT MEDICAL
BUT NO NEED TO PRETEND SENT TO
OVER TO MONDAY O'CLOCK. HELLO
THE PLUG FROM. PROFOUND
CAMPOREALE BEEN LAST FEW YES THE
ROLE. ONE ON WHICH SOMEONE THAN
WITH THANK YOU. DOES NOT BAD DAY
. OKAY NOT COAST. YOU CAN ALSO A
PEOPLE YOUR MIND QUE YOU'RE NOT
BY THAT POINT DEVICE. I WOULD BE
IN CLOSE OUTLOOK ONE PICKED UP
NUMBERING COURT BEFORE FUNDING
FOR THAT. HE DON'T CARE PENALTY
WHICH A LOT TALKS AT THAT OKAY.
TO LOOK AT. UP ON PRODUCT. IF I
DON'T BEFORE ASK PEOPLE THAT
ANYTHING THAT I'VE GOT A LONG A
LITTLE BIT BUT I FOUND THIS. THE
ONE MEANT THAT FROM THEM GET
MORE WILL TO FEEL OKAY OFTEN
RIGHT FOR ONE CUP. THE DEFECT
YOUR- KNOW ONCE AGAIN THIS.
YOU'RE WELCOME ABOUT IT THE CITY
COUNCIL. YOU CAN LIGHT UP ON
SOME OTHER POPULAR COULD BE. I'M
GOOD FOR COULD LOOK BAD LOOK IN
THE MANUAL. I'M WATCHING TO
MARGARITA. YOUR EITHER THE A
STAMP. THANK YOU FUNDAMENTAL IT
SOME INPUT ON BILL BE. ASSEMBLY
CHU SEVEN FIELD BUT I KNOW MY
CORPORATE IT THINK. ONE WILL NOT
LISTEN PRINT LIFT EVEN ABLE
FRESNO COULD BE KIND OF QUALITY
EVEN CHILDREN HE- WHAT YOU GET
RESERVE ONE. OF FROM LOCAL OF A
SYSTEM. GOING TO. BE OKAY THE
WOMAN COMPUTER ON THE LOWER OKAY
IF WE CALL OUT SOME THE
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE BOTH THE KEEP
LEVEL. AND YOUR- IT. WILL NOT BE
PREGNANT OTHER THAN YOU'RE
GETTING YOUR PHONE FROM
HAPPENING TO THE CORRECT MEANT
THAT YOU BUT AND DEATH. I LOVE
HIM LED BEING THE- I MEAN YOU'LL
BE LOCAL. THE ONE OF MY THAT IT
I YEAH. GOVERNMENT THAT FAMILIES
THANK BAM LAWSON BE REDIRECT. A
NEEDS. WATER IF. A MODIFIED YOUR
YOUR PLACENTA CAN ONE OF THE
REPORTER FROM EITHER IF YOU WANT
IN YOUR HOME OCTOBER FIFTH IN
THE ONLY CONNECTED YEAH. YEAH
YEAH THREE THEY KEPT IN BLACK
AND IN THE TO GET MY HE IS GOING
WITH A ID. ONE IS.
CATION OF
PROVIDER RATE INCREASES AND FIX
THE CORE STAFFING FORMULA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THAT COMES FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY SEVEN ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS TODD THE
BEEN VERY TOUCHED BY ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SHARED
THEIR- PERSONAL STORIES TODAY
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO ASK TO
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE TELL
PLEASE SUPPORT THE ARC-
MENTIONED THAT COALITION BUDGET
REQUESTS FOR SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING. INCLUDING ACCELERATED
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROVIDER RATE
INCREASES AFFECTING THE CORE
STAFFING FORMULA- THANK YOU
AGAIN. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU AND THAT COMES
TO MIND TWO HUNDRED AND TWELVE
TO TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
YES I AM CAN YOU HEAR ME SUSAN
LAURA. OKAY MY NAME IS RAVI
SANTANA I'M HERE FOR A DOUBLE
BOMBING INCLUDING MARK. THANK
YOU MATE IF THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS GOING ON YOU KNOW
INTIMIDATION OR RETALIATION AND
ABUSE OF POER. IN MY OPINION I
HAVE THREE CHILDREN WHO ARE
CLIENTS FOLKS SOUTH CENTRAL
REGIONAL CENTER COOPER AN
ATTORNEY TO FIGHT AGAINST THEIR
OWN CLIENTS. THAT WHAT MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. BACKING DAY
I EVEN. FOCUSED ON YOU ARE
DESTROYED NOT AND THEN- FOR
HEARING. AT THE MALL THERE AND
ANYTHING ABOUT THE ORDER I HAVE
EXPERIENCE THAT A LOT OF
INTIMIDATION TO WORK. ESPECIALLY
IF SPEND COMMUNITY ORANGE COUNTY
REGIONAL CENTER INLAND EMPIRE
ECONOMY EVEN LATE. WE CAN FEEL
THE PRESSURE BY THE SPACING AND
IDEA. THANK I ALREADY MENTIONED
. WE ARE LOST THE CLIENT ONE IN
ORANGE COUNTY WAS MIKE. I
COULDN'T GO TO NOT BRING MAKING
JUST FEEL WAITING FOR A-
BIRTHDAY PRESENT. THEY SHOULDN'T
BE HAPPENING. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE MY COMMENTS
. NPD'S HERE FROM THE PATTERN
TOWARDS WILL BRING UP FROM THE
ACCIDENT SCENE. WHEN MY PERSONAL
OPINION ARE MAKING MONEY FROM
OUR HEAT. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU TO ONE OF YOU ARE ANGELES
WITH DOCTOR WIENER FROM NOT LOOK
THAT DILUTES WHICH OFTEN ARE.
ALWAYS THERE LEADING THE WAY FOR
A CHANGE OPENING THE DOOR FOR
THE COMMUNITY. SHE IS THE
EXAMPLE AND I THINK IF SHE WON'T
LEAVE DATE CHANGE FOR THE TWENTY
ONE WHICH UP BANNERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THUS THE SONORA. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THAT'S COMING
FROM LINE THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TO THREE THIRTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BINALONG THANK YOU
HELLO. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY THANK YOU MY
NAME SO AND I AM A THIRTY FIVE
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER WHO- IF THE
CLIENT HAS IN MIND REGIONAL
CENTER AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE- RATE INCREASES
ALSO- TWENTY FIFTY FIVE THE
HIRING OF MARS YES HE- CURRENTLY
IN MY I IT. ONE FOUR. YES ONE
CST EIGHTY CLIENTS THAT REALLY
RIDICULOUS AND- TRYING TO GET
SERVICES RIGHT NOW HAS BEEN
REALLY DIFFICULT BUT BOTH-
OFFENDERS AND THROUGH REGION
GOLF CENTER THE OTHER THING THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK IF. FIFTY-
PDF. CONSIDER I'M CONTINUING THE. ABOUT THE SERVICE THAT'S THE
ONLY WAY THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO- FIFTEEN OURSELVES THROUGH.
THE PANDEMIC AND- I'D LIKE TO
SEE THAT CONTINUE- AS OF RIGHT
NOW- IT'S GOING OF LATE I THINK
MARCH TWENTY SECOND AND SALAS HI
GARY- BECAUSE IN OTHER THE
VENDORS OUT THERE- THAT ARE
WILLING TO TAKE OUR CLIENTS WITH. BEHAVIORS SO. WE PLEASE
CONSIDER I'M CONTINUING WITH THE
PROJECTS AND DIRECTED SERVICEMEN
AND THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND I KANSEN LINE THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY EIGHT THREE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
THREE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YOUR PHONE ON MUTE. THANK
MY NAME IS TANYA AND I HAVE TWO
CHILDREN- WITH OPTIMISM ONE
SEVERE NONVERBAL MY SEVEN YEAR
OLD AND- MY FOUR YEAR OLD I
BELONG TO THE LARGE REGIONAL.
AND I TOTALLY AGREE WITH
ELIZABETH BY BILLS. I'M JUDY
MARC BLACK TO HAVE MET THE ICC
GROUP BECAUSE IF IT WASN'T FOR
THEM I WOULDN'T BEING GETTING
ANY TYPE OF SERVICE SINCE. I'VE
HAD MY SON AND REGIONAL SINCE HE
WAS TWO AND A HALF. AND I JUST I
STARTED EARLY INTERVENTION AND
THEN ONCE HE GOT TRANSFERRED I
NEVER GOT OFFERED ANY TYPE OF
SERVICE. AND NOW THAT I'M WITH
ICC WHILE THEY'VE BEEN HELPING
ME OUT NOW I DO GET SOME TYPE OF
SERVICES BUT I THOUGHT WE ARE
LIKE THE COORDINATORS. AND THEY
DON'T DO VERY WELL IN
COMMUNICATION. WHEN THE PANDEMIC
STARTED THEY NEVER TOLD ME LIKE
THAT THEIR WORK HOURS WHICH
QUITE FRANKLY KEEP. THIRD THERE
IS- HOURS FOR COLLATOR ONE THING
THAT THEY WILL BE ABLE TO HELP
ME. HELP ME OUT WITH- I AM I'M
NOW I'M HAPPY BECAUSE I GET SOME
TYPE OF SERVICES FOR MY SON AND
WE AS PARENTS HAVE TO HAVE MORE
KNOWLEDGE THAN WE DON'T GET FROM
. ALL THE INFORMATION FROM
REGIONAL WE HAVE TO LOOK OUT IN
THE COMMUNITY. AND HELP OTHER
PARENTS. IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
DON'T GET ANY TYPE OF SERVICES
BECAUSE IF IT IF THE TOP FOR THE
COMMUNITY WE DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
THAT'S GOING ON. AT THE REGIONAL
CENTERS. THAT'S IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND THAT COMES TO MIND THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE THREE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE FORTY THREE. AND
THREE FORTY THREE IS YOUR PHONE
ON MUTE. HELLO THERE WE GO SIR
THANK YOU. ALL WONDERFUL I WOULD
LIKE TO REITERATE A LOT OF- A
LOT OF THINGS THAT HAPPENED WITH
A LOT OF VENDORS WILL BE THERE
TO SUPPORT A LOT OF FAMILY
MEMBERS BUT ONCE AGAIN THE RATES
ARE NOT. APPROPRIATE FOR THE
COMMUNITY AT THE ENTRANCE TO OUR
MAJOR PROBLEM HERE TODAY THE
RATE. THESE RATES ARE STILL ALL
. AND YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
MORATORIUM ON THE RATE COMES TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. A LOT OF.
THE BARK LIKE BACK. IN WE SHOULD
NOT HAVE GOTTEN TO THE POINT
WHERE WE ACTUALLY HAD TO HAVE
THE- TYPE OF MEETING WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN KNOWN TO DO
BETTER. HI HERE GOOD PARENTS IN
A LOT OF THE PARENTS THAT
DEFINITELY CONCERNING BANGING ON
THE PARENTS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THEIR TEAM THING AND THEY'RE
LOOKING CONSERVATIVE AND
SERVICES YOU NEED TO BE RINKER
AND WE CAN'T EVEN PAINT THE
VENDOR I THINK YEARS AGO I WAS I
WAS IN UNION SHOPS TO THE LOCAL
TO COULD BE HEALTHCARE WORKERS
UNIONS. AND WHAT. SURELY WHERE
TOM. IN ONE OF OUR WAS THE LOCAL
TO FIFTY WORKERS IN WAS THAT WE
TAKE CARE OF THE WHO CARE OF THE
CONSOLE. AND WE NEED DO IN YOU
LEAVE PEOPLE OUT IN THE COLD
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE SO WHATEVER
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IS THAT-
AND THEN THE YEAH THIS PETITION
THAT WE HAVE OUT THERE GET THE
THANKS FONG. LET'S GET THE WORD
. AND LEGISLATORS YEAH I MEAN
YOU'VE GOT THE LAWMAKERS THERE
LET'S GET THE GOVERNMENT. IT
COULD NOT TALKING. YES THEY HEAR
THE PARENTS TALK IS OF GRIEVING
MY HEART AND I'M A VENDOR AND
I'M ALSO A FAMILY MEMBER. PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I'M
GRIEVING RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I
HEAR COMPLETELY WHICH. SO I
GUESS I MARKET OPENS UP TO YOU
GUYS. IT REALLY DOES. AND MAY
GOD BLESS YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
AND I COME TO MIND THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX THREE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIX THREE FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND THREE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN IS
YOUR PHONE ON MUTE. WHAT THE
RESPONSE WILL READ MOVED TO LIVE
THREE SIXTY IN LIGHT THREE FORTY
SIX IF YOU'D LIKE TO ASK YOU
ARE. STATE YOUR COMMENT PLEASE.
VQ UP. LINE THREE SIXTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO I'M A PARENT
OF A THIRTY YEAR OLD. CHILD MAN
OF AUTISM AND- I'M PLEASE TO
KNOW I'M NOT ALONE IN MY-
UNDERSTANDING AND EXPERIENCES-
MY CHILD ALSO ONLY GOT SOME
RESPITE CARE. UNTIL HE WAS- AND
TEENAGE YEARS I WOULD SAY
SEVENTEEN OR EIGHTEEN. AND BY
THEN IT WAS TOO LATE TO
COORDINATE- ACTIVITIES THAT
WOULD HAVE HELPED HIM SOCIALLY-
THE MAIN. THING I CAN TAKE AWAY
FROM THIS. TELL CON. IS THAT- NO
WAY. IS BEYOND THE- BEING BIASED
TO I HAVE A BEING ON A BLACKLIST
IN MY SCHOOL DISTRICT. I HAVE
EXPERIENCED- HAVING REGIONAL
CENTER- COORDINATORS TELL ME
THAT MY SON WAS ABSOLUTELY
NORMAL BUT THAT- HE COULDN'T
HAVE- SYRUPY SESSIONS ON
HORSEBACK WHICH HELLO I HAD TO
GO TO DUE PROCESS TO GET FOR
HIM- THEY THEY DIDN'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT HIPPO THERAPY.
AND WHAT I WILL SAY IS ON A
POSITIVE NOTE IT IS THAT ONE OF
THE- PARENTS TALKED ABOUT-
FINDING SUPPORT THROUGH
LEADERSHIP. THE IT- IN OUR IN
OUR LOCAL IN OUR GOVERNMENT OR
IN OUR REGIONAL CENTERS BUT I
THINK THE PARENTS ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO MAKE A COALITION AND
HAVE- I SHARING ONLINE AND
PERHAPS MONTHLY LOCAL MEETINGS
AND DO IT YOURSELF BECAUSE I
DIDN'T GET ANY SERVICES IN O. T.
SO I DID IT MYSELF I DIDN'T GET
ANY SERVICES AND EDUCATION THREE
OR FOUR YEARS OLD HE WAS TOO
SMART DID IT MYSELF. AND I HAD
TO GO THROUGH THE EXPERIENCE OF
WITNESSING MY SON FALL BEHIND-
FOUR YEARS IN SCHOOL AND BECOME
A WORSE BEHAVIOR PROBLEM. AFTER
WE SWITCHED TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND WENT FROM HAVING A
SUCCESSFUL. BEHAVIORAL SYSTEM-
THAT WE USED AT HOME AND AT
SCHOOL. AND THAN BEING
CATEGORIZED AS AN STD CLIENT AND
HE WASN'T. SO YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
WHO IS ABOVE AVERAGE IN I. Q.
VERBAL- NOT ALLOWED TO TAKE
THINGS IN HIGH SCHOOL LIKE CAR
MECHANICS NO INVENTORY OF SKILLS
. NO ADVOCACY FROM REGIONAL
CENTER COORDINATORS WHO SAT IN
ON MULTITUDINOUS I. E. P.
MEETING- THESE ARE ALL THINGS
THAT ARE DON'T TAKE ANYMORE REAL
. GREAT EFFORT BUT IT WHAT
OCCURS TO ME IS THAT SOMEONE-
NEEDS TO DESIGN A SYSTEM. WHERE
EVERYONE THE CHILDREN ARE
MOTIVATED TO BEHAVE IF THEY HAVE
A BEHAVIORAL SYSTEM OR THEY'RE
MOTIVATED TO LEARN YES THEY
HAVE- NEEDS AN EDUCATION. AND I
WOULD GO TO A NON PROFIT OR A
SCHOOL- THAT IS DOING IT OUTSIDE
THE BOX I WOULD NOT LOOK AT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IN PUBLIC SCHOOL.
BECAUSE IT'S JUST WAREHOUSING I
WENT TO AN ORGANIZATION CALLED
HANDLE H. A. N. D. ELLIE AND
SEATTLE. AND THEY GAVE ME SOME
THINGS TO WORK ON AT HOME AND
FIGURED OUT THAT MY SON'S EYES
DON'T WORK. LIKE EVERYBODY
ELSE'S AND- ALSO DIAGNOSED HIM
WITH OTHER THINGS THAT I HAD
TROUBLE GETTING- MY SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO. I UNDERSTAND- I
THINK THAT THERE SHOULD BE AT
FIRST OF ALL A NARROW PSYCH
ITSELF FOR THESE CHILDREN. AND
IT SHOULD BE DONE BY SOMEBODY IN
THE REGIONAL CENTER IT SHOULD
NOT BE DONE AT THE SCHOOLS
BECAUSE THE SCHOOLS. R. O. T.
AND THEIR THEIR PSYCHOLOGIST
THEY JUST THEY HAVE A VERY VERY
LIMITED TIME AND THEY DON'T
COORDINATE WITH THE TEACHERS AT
ALL. SO IF THIS GUY IS GOING TO
TAKE MORE MONEY. I SUPPORT THE
ARCA LAW WHICH I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF LISTENING TO ON
SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY NINE-
DEFINITELY DEFINITELY FOR
SOMEBODY WHO IS A AVERAGE TO
ABOVE AVERAGE IQ AND SOME OF
THESE KIDS WHO THEY SAY CAN'T
LEARN THEY CAN LEARN AND THERE
ARE THINGS YOU CAN DO WITH THEM
YOU JUST HAVE TO. ASK THE
PARENTS WHAT DO YOUR CHILDREN
LIKE TO DO I DEVISED A PROGRAM
OF SOCIAL PROGRAMS FOR THE-
PEDIATRIC THERAPY NETWORK AND
THEY THEY WOULD ALL WE DID WAS
DROP A HINT AS TO WHAT THE ALL
THE BOYS COULD DO AND THESE ARE
MOSTLY BOYS. THAT THEY HAVE ON
THESE THESE PROGRAMS ON A WHY IT
TOO IS THAT WHY THEY HAVE SO
MANY BOYS IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
HAS SOMETHING GENETIC ABOUT THAT
- ANYWAY IT'S JUST SAD SO I
WOULD JUST SAY YOU KNOW TO
PARENTS DO IT YOURSELF UNTIL THE
MONIES COME IN BUT THERE NEEDS
TO BE BETTER ORGANIZATION THERE
NEEDS TO BE LESS MEETINGS WHERE
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT WE HAVE TO
FILL OUT THIS THIS AND THIS AND
WE'RE GOING TO GET SO AND SO ON
BOARD AND IT'S ALL GOING TO BE
GREAT BUT THERE'S NO TALK ABOUT
WHAT IS ACTUALLY GOING TO HAPPEN
. THERE HAS TO BE HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO DO THIS. YOU KNOW AND
THE ACHIEVEMENT STANDARD
SHOULDN'T BE. JOHNNY WILL HOLD-
A RATE AND HE WILL LEARN HOW TO
WATER PLANTS OUTSIDE. YOU KNOW
THAT KIND OF THING THAT'S
RIDICULOUS. I WOULDN'T THINK
THAT ANYBODY ANY ADULT WOULD
WANT TO WASTE HOURS OF THEIR
TIME DURING THE WORKDAY WHICH MY
HUSBAND DID HOURS FOUR HOURS IT
EVERY MONTH FOR ALL OVER TWO
YEARS ALMOST WE WERE IN AN IEP
MEETING. AND- JUST YOU KNOW NO
NO NO THE ONLY THING WE WANT TO
DO IS TO COME INTO A- WAREHOUSE
. YOU KNOW NON PUBLIC SCHOOL AND
LET THEM DEAL WITH IT. AND WHAT
DO THOSE PEOPLE DO THEY TEACH
THEM A SKILL OKAY YOU
COORDINATORS SKILLED WITH-
LEARNING IN THE CLASSROOM. IT'S
LIKE HERE WE HAVE THESE CHILDREN
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE SO
DIFFERENT. WHAT ARE THEY HOW ARE
THEY LIKE THE REST OF THE
POPULATION THAT'S HOW THIS ARC A
PROGRAM IS GOING TO WORK IS BY
FINDING OUT YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
THEY CAN DO MY SONHAPPENS TO BE
REALLY REALLY GOOD AT COMPUTERS
AND RENAME DRAMMEN STIMPY WHEN
HE WAS FOUR YEARS OLD IF THAT
MEANS ANYTHING TO ANYBODY-
ANYWAY. I DON'T HAVE MUCH ELSE
TO SAY EXCEPT THAT I WANTED TO
GET ON THE CALL AND SUPPORT ARCA
AND- LANDRUM IN COALITION BUDGET
REQUESTS. AND YOU KNOW DON'T
DON'T- GET RID OF THINGS LIKE-
THE BUDDY SYSTEM OR THE
SUPPORTIVE SUPPORTIVE ASPECTS
FOR SOMEONE WHO IS WHO HAS NO
FRIENDS OKAY THE CHILD HAS NO
FRIEND HE'S NOT IN SPORTS SO
THEN. YOU KNOW DON'T MAKE DON'T
PULL THEM OUT AND MAKE THEM LOOK
. DEAR FRIEND IF THEY DON'T LOOK
DIFFERENT. HELP TO GET THE
MAINSTREAM YOU KNOW ALL OF THE
AUTHORITY SAID MY CHILD SHOULD
BE MAINSTREAMED AND- HE WITH HIS
HIS BEHAVIORS FOUR POINT 001%
POINT 002% AND THOSE DISTRICT WE
WERE IN STOCK IN BACK IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION BECAUSE HE HAD. DID
STRANGE THINGS ON THE PLATE- HE
DIDN'T DIDN'T PLAY WITH BALLS.
WE KNOW NOW WHY HE DIDN'T PLAY
WITH BALLS. HE COULDN'T PLAY
WITH BALL HE CAN'T HE CAN'T DO
IT NOW YOU THROW A BALL AT HIM
HIS EYES. LOOK AT IT LIKE IT'S A
MISSILE COMING AT HIM BUT HE CAN
THROW A BASEBALL SIDEWAYS WHICH
IS REALLY INTERESTING AND HIT A
TARGET BECAUSE HIS EYES SEE
OUTWARDLY. I MEAN THIS KIND OF
THING. SHOULDN'T BE ROCKET
SCIENCE SO- I DON'T KNOW IT
TAKES. THE FIRST START WITH THE
EVALUATION AND DON'T MAKE IT A
PUBLIC SCHOOL ONE THAT SAYS
THAT'S THE FIRST MISTAKE AND-
DON'T OVER MEDICATE YOUR
CHILDREN LIKE THOSE OTHER PEOPLE
WERE SAYING THAT'S ANOTHER
MISTAKE- YOU DON'T WANT TO WASTE
TIME TIME IS THE ENEMY OF THE
PARENT SAYS YOU CAN WATCH YOUR
CHILD JUST GO DOWN THE DRAIN.
AND THAT'S MY STORY MY SON IS
THIRTY YEARS OLD HE IS NOT IN A
GOOD STATE SITUATION RIGHT NOW-
HE'S BEING SUPPORTED FINALLY YOU
KNOW THE INCIDENT MAN HOUSING.
BUT- YOU KNOW. SOMEBODY WE
ACTUALLY HAD HOPES AND DREAMS
FOR. SO ANYWAY HAVE A GOOD
MEETING I WILL CLOCK OUT THAT'S
ALL I HAVE TO SAY THAT I WOULD
GO TO ONE OF THE WORST MORE
ACADEMY IN INDIANAPOLIS BRANDI
JACKSON WON THE JEFFERSON AWARD
AFTER WHAT TO DO. GO FIND PEOPLE
LIKE THAT GO FIND LEADERS LIKE
THAT WHO ACTUALLY KNOW HOW TO
PUT TOGETHER A PROGRAM FOR
DIFFERENT FLEAS FUND FUNCTIONING
DISABILITIES SCHOOLS GO ASK THEM. GO OUTSIDE THE PUBLIC VENUE.
OKAY THANK YOU MA'AM. BYE BYE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND NOW TO
LINE THREE SIXTY EIGHT THREE
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO. WE CONTINUE SIR. OKAY ARE
. OF A KILL THE CHILDREN. AND-
MY WIFE AND I HAVE GONE THROUGH
. SO MANY OBSTACLES AND BARRIERS
TRYING TO GET SERVICES FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTER. BECAUSE EVERY
TIME WE ASK FOR A SERVICE. THAT
FOR CHILDREN. ACTUALLY THIS
SERVICE AND A QUALIFY FOR IN
ORDER OPINION OF COURSE. FIVE
REGIONAL CENTERS FOR THE
REGIONAL CENTER- TURN IT DOWN
SAYING THAT YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
USE THE- GENETIC SERVICES BEFORE
THEY CAN PAY FOR ANYTHING. TEN
EVEN TRYING. TO OUR SCHEDULE
MEETINGS WITH HIM FOR IDPS AND
STYLES BUSINESS TRAVEL. FOR
EXAMPLE WE'VE WE HAVE ONE
PENDING AND WE HAVE HAD.
ACTUALLY WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
SAID THAT MEANING FOR THE LAST
TWO MONTHS. AARON WE CAN'T
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE. A
TRANSLATOR FOR MY WIFE SHE'S
PIXMA BETTER LITTLE ENGLISH AND
- SHE CANNOT COMMUNICATE UNLESS
. THAT IS THE- SPANISH
TRANSLATOR AND. THE ORIGINAL
CENTER KEEP SOME BLAMING. ON THE
TRANSLATOR NOT BEING ABLE TO. WE
HAVE RECEIVED A COUPLE OF- WELL
MORE THAN A COUPLE I THINK IT IS
LIKE TWENTY FOUR. EMAILS FROM
THE. TO PROVIDE SERVE MY- ORDER
SERVICE COORDINATOR SUPERVISOR.
AND ON A COUPLE THEM. HE HAD
SAID THAT. NAY MEETING IS SOME
OF WHAT WE ARE ACTUALLY ARE. SO
FAR BEHIND ON THESE MATTER THAT
. HE STARTED TRAINING US BY
TELLING IS THAT. IF WE DON'T
SAID MEETING SOMEONE. IN ORDER
SON IS GOING TO BEING. THIS
CONTINUED FROM I THINK GREAT
CHANNEL CENTER. CLIENT ARE NOT
UP TO LEGAL. FIND OUT. NOT HAS
HAPPENED A COUPLE OF TIMES
ALREADY- ONE TIME THE SERVICE
COORDINATOR CALL US. AND SAID
THAT HE WANTED TO HAVE A AN IPP
MEETING. OR MMHM AND WE TOLD
THEM NOT BECAUSE WE ARE IN THE
PANDEMIC AND WE ARE NOT
ACCEPTING ANY. VISITORS. AND
EVEN THOUGH WE TOLD THEM NOW THE
FOLLOWING DAY HE SHOWED UP WITH
A SET OF PAPERS THAT WE NEEDED
TO FIND. AARON HE SAID THAT IF
WE DIDN'T AGREE TO SIGN THEM
THEN. FOR SOME WAS GOING TO BE
DISCONTINUED ACCESS. REGIONAL
CENTER THE CLIENT AND IS A
DIFFERENT GET WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT NOW- EVERY TIME WE STEPPED
IN TO THEIR BRING YOUR
PROCEDURAL CENTERS OFFICE. IN
THE PAST. J. A. C. S. AND THEY-
THEY KNOW THAT WE POSED NO
THREAT TO THEM BECAUSE- MY
STRUCTURE IT'S ONLY LIKE. FIVE
FOUR. BLACK HAIR BROWN'S CAN. AS
YOU IN HERE I HAVE A- VERY
PRONOUNCED ACCENT. AND THEY KNOW
THAT. HE'S NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
DO ANYTHING. AND THEY JUST. TURN
DOWN BUT NOT ONLY ME- I HAVE
AREAS STORIES FROM HER PARENTS
IN ORDER- NEIGHBORHOOD. THERE IS
A REGIONAL CENTER IS THERE GREG
WHAT COAST REGIONAL CENTER. AND
THEY ARE. THEIR LIVING ROOM
BECAUSE- I CANNOT BELIEVE THAT.
WE CANNOT FATHOM THAT WE HAVE TO
BEG FOR SERVICES REGIONAL
CENTERS. OUR. ARE THERE TO
SUPPORT. AND. THEY ARE NOT-
CHERRY. OFFICES FOR WHATEVER
THAT IS- SO HOPEFULLY THERE ARE. SOON SO HOPEFULLY THIS TIME WE
CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE. WE ARE
SUPPORTING- SEVEN BONUS. BUT I
SIXTY AND MY NAME IS MARIA LAST
NAME BAKA- MY CHILDREN.
CHILDREN'S NAME. OR NAMES HELLO
IN CANADA BACA. HOPEFULLY- THIS
TIME AROUND. WE CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE HOPEFULLY WE CAN. BE
ABLE TO BE A LISTEN AND-
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN ADVOCATE FOR
US. YES WE NEED IT THAT WE'RE IN
A DIRE SITUATION. THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME. THANK YOU SIR.
OPERATOR NEXT COLOR. THANK YOU
THAT COMES NINE THREE SEVENTY
ONE THREE HUNDRED W. Y. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY WELL. I JUST WANT
TO THANK GOD BLESS YOU. WHERE
COOPER. MY IS MARIA. I'M SEVEN
FOUR YEARS OLD. FORTY YEARS AGO
I WAS OF THE GREW. ARE NEEDLES.
AND WHAT ARE YOU COULD NOT IS
THIS. THERE ARE. WENT THROUGH
FORTY YEAR AGO. AND LOOK AT HOW
IT IS IT DIDN'T TAKE HOLD JIM
BRING UP THE RATIO WAS. IN AND
IN EVERY OTHER OF THE SITE WHEN
WE WANT TO FOR OUR CHILDREN.
THAT'S WHAT ABBOTT IS WHY DO WE
HAVE FIGHT SO HARD. THE REGIONAL
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET AWAY WITH
THEIR ATTITUDINAL BIAS AGAINST
BROWN AND BLACK AND DETERMINE
WHO'S WARRANTY THAT NEEDS TO
STOP THAT'S THE LEGACY OF THE
STATE HOSPITAL. THAT EXISTED
BEFORE REGIONAL CENTERS WHERE
THEY USE THAT THEIR ALLIES FOR
THEIR ALLIES BROWN. WHAT DO YOU
CARE. TO CHILDREN. TO BE PART
THE PAST. IT'S STILL GOING. YES
THEY DESERVE A QUALITY OF LIFE
EVEN THOUGH IT'S A PANDEMIC.
REGIONAL CENTERS CAN DO YOU
DON'T REIMAGINE HOW WE CONSIDER
HOW WE CAN GIVE THEM QUALITY OF
LIFE YEAH THAT NONO THIS THEY
DON'T DESERVE IT. IF YOU ONLY
KNOW HOW BEAUTIFUL THE CULTURE.
AND THE- ARTS FOR CHILDREN THEN
THE VALUE IT'S NOT LIKE WESTERN
CIVILIZATION WE DON'T HAVE THAT
HISTORY WHERE WE PUT PEOPLE AWAY
AND WE THEIR ALLIES AND PUT
AMONG. THE BRANCHES OF SOCIETY.
IT'S CALLED HAS ANYTHING FOR US
IS THAT. IT'S BROUGHT TO LIFE
THE END JUSTICE ALL THE SYSTEMS
THAT EXISTS THERE. THAT ARE
BASED ON ATTITUDES OF
SUPERIORITY. AND HELD BY A LOT
OF PEOPLE THAT THEY DON'T KNOW
ABOUT LOOK AT LOOK AT HOW THE
ATTITUDES ARE TOWARDS SPANISH
SPEAKING PEOPLE LIKE WORK AREAS
THAT HE LEGAL. WE HAVE A TREATY
WITH THE US. IT'S ONLY BEEN A
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE YEARS SINCE
THE TREATY OF GUADALUPE THIS
WHAT PEOPLE WE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
ON THIS LAND WHICH SPEAK SPANISH
SOME OF THE THINKING GOES SOME
OF THAT. OUR OWN NATIVE
LANGUAGES BUT WE ARE WE ARE SO
AMERICANS AND WE WANT WE WANT
EDUCATION WE WANT OUR FUTURE FOR
OUR KIDS. MY DAUGHTER BEEN A
LONG FEW OF SPECIAL OLYMPICS.
WITH THE WOMAN- COMMITTEE AND
THEY WERE SAYING WHEN THEY FIRST
STARTED SPECIAL OLYMPICS THEY
DIDN'T KNOW HOW MUCH THE KIDS
COULD DO RUNNING AND SWIMMING
AND THEN THE SPORTS. AND NOW
THEY'RE IN. THE OLYMPIC SIZE-
COURSE THERE IS WHERE YOU TRY
FIELD. ONCE YOU LEFT THE. THANK
YOU DON'T BEING YOU CAN'T YOU
KNOW MY DAUGHTER WHEN SHE BORN
THREE TOLD ME CLEAR THAT IS JUST
WHAT. TO YOU WANT. SO I COME.
AND I'M THINKING HOW THEY HELP
THEY DON'T EXPECT DONATE WILL
DONATE THAT SHE SHE BEAUTIFUL
CHILD SHE TEACHERS. WHAT AND
EVEN IF THEY GOD WE GREAT PEOPLE. SHAREHOLDERS BUT SHE SHE TO BE-ON THE PATH BETTER PROGRAM
THAT'S NOT LIKE A WHERE IT'S
FUNNY BECAUSE IT'S A BORDERS
GIRLS SCOUT AND YOU KNOW WHAT.
THE PEOPLE THAT WERE NOT. THEY
YOU SO MUCH THE THAT RETRIEVER
MARC IT'S THEY READ THEIR THAT
AND BROWN WOMEN WITH KNOWLEDGE
CAN ALL NOTE THEY SHOULD HAVE
THEY CALL FOR THIS RECALL BY FOR
THAT TO BE TOLD READ SAID. NO
I'M WHAT HI OF PEOPLE ARE
RUNNING THAT THEY'RE BIAS. NEEDS
TO BE CHALLENGED. FORTY YEARS
YOU KNOW THAT. IT NOT THE
PROBLEM WITH THE FAMILY. NOT
WHAT THE KID. THE STATE
GOVERNMENT THIS YOU KNOW THAT
ONE MARK YOU KNOW THE POSITIVE
START- HELLO CAMBIO WE THOUGHT
THERE ARE MONSTERS AND I'M IN
THE BAY AREA AND THEY HAVE USED
BY ONE OF THEIR THINGS SAME
THING FOR OUR FAMILY. THAT OUR
FAMILY GREW IF CHANGES. AND SO
WE'RE MARGIN. WITH THEM WE HAVE
THE THREE ISSUE HERE IN THE
STATE. AND I HOPE THAT ALL THE
REGIONAL STANDARD GET MORE SAW
BECAUSE THIS. GOD BLESS YOU.
DAHLE IT'S NOT UP TO THAT ARE.
M. Y. AT ALL WE WANT IS JUST. SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AT NINE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD THREE SEVENTY
TWO. I AM THREE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IS YOUR PHONE ON
MUTE. THE RESPONSIBLE TO LINE
THREE SEVENTY SIX AND NINE THREE
SEVENTY TWO IF YOU'D LIKE THAT
BIG COMMENT PLEASE RE QUEUE UP.
THREE SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WHEN I DON'T YOU'LL PLEASE
ALLOW THE OF ADVOCATES FOR YOU
ON THAT AND- NO YOU SEVEN BERMAN
YEAH DO THEY MARK TWAIN. DOES
NOT TOUCH UPON THE DISCOVERY
COULD NOT ONE ON THE LINE. ET
THERE IS A INTELLECT THE SEVEN.
BOTH OF YOUR AT ALL OR YOU IF.
IF YOU CAN FORMA MESSAGES FROM
OFFENSIVE NOT DO WILL BE I DO
THEY MOCK. ON THE- THINK IT'S
GOING TO AFFECT UP BUT I PLAN
MIDDLE DAUGHTER. TOTAL DO YOU
COULD NOT WE CAN WITH ANY OF THE
- BEST- OKAY TO THE K. CARE LOS
ANGELES UNITED. EXAMPLE OF.
ABOUT BUT OUR YOU GOT. IT MONDAY
. IN MY HALEKULANI THE WOULD GO
I DO NOT AND BISCAYNE USE THAT
IN THE OF THE ENVELOPE FULL
STOLEN OF MARKETS I. LIVE IN
YOUR CALL MAY COME THE FACT
GOVERNMENT GIVE ME IT BACK IT'S
- AND THEN YOU WHERE. W. LIVE
TODAY IN. IN IS THE- TO ROLL. WE
GET OUR IT MOVED OUT OF IT. YEAR
BEFORE THE PEOPLE BEFORE THAT
WILL BE PEOPLE WITHOUT ME
BECAUSE OF ALL THE LITTLE BOOK.
BUT I SIMPLY. ARE YOU NOT. BE IN
A. HAVE THEM WHICH WOULD CANCEL
BUT I KNEW THAT IF THE MOMENT I
WALKED OUT TO YOU ABOUT FOR A
THE DONALD FILM. HE NOTED ON
MARCH I DO A- STILL K. ANSWER.
MUSTAPHA IS ONLY TO PUT AN OFFER
SAID. THAT INSTEAD OF IN THE
FIELD. IF PEOPLE FEEL THE COULD
AMONG OUR- KIND OF LIKE WHEN YOU
I YOU GOT I THINK. I THINK YOU
ARE BOOKED OUT FOR. NINE NINE
ANY. THE LINE NINETY THEM A
MINUTE SMITTY GOT I MOVED TO
SAID THE SUSPECT CARE ACT AND
NOT CANNOT PIANIST LUCKMAN EVEN
LOOKING BASIC DNA. BECAUSE THAT
I COULD ASK YOU DON'T BUY THAT A
LOOK. AT IT PM. THIS BOOK OKAY
PLAN ON FEB. AND OPINION THE
SENATE THAT WHEN ENABLED. YES
THE COMING UP THE NEW NUYS THE
NOT OUT OF BED. EVEN THANK THE
COMMUNITIES. NO OKAY. SO IT MORE
AND LOCAL THIS IN YEAR AND AS A
FIX THEN AND I GIVE. YOU MY FOR
HIM ALWAYS ABOUT UP BUT A BUT
OUT MONEY HOW TO GO YOU CAN
DISCOVER THAT IS. NOPE WITHIN
ENVELOPE WITH STAY THERE. ESTADO
AQUI HAVE PLACED A CAMERA AND I
UP THERE NOT BE ENOUGH OKAY WHAT
THE PHONE CONNECTED. IT AGAINST
. LOOK PERSONAL NOT LOOKED UP
ABOUT YOU THAT YOU ARE THE PART
OF THAT BECAUSE PEOPLE CAN'T
HAVE BEEN THE OF THE NINE
GENERAL UNITED BACK. I THANK.
GOOD MORNING. RESPOND WITH THE
PEOPLE ON OUR- PEOPLE CAN. NINE
PEOPLE CALL HOME A COOPERATIVE.
CRISFIELD I THOUGHT WHAT ARE THE
ISSUES YOU HAVE FOUND IN A-
MORNING LOOK YOU'LL DEDUCTIBLE
CAN LOOK IT. UP AND- I MY HE
BEGINS THAT IDENTIFICATION
ARRIVING VIRGINIA ABA IF IN MY
LAST OPINION THE TEMPERATURES A
SINGLE YOU'RE NOT MISSING KNOW
WHAT I. THE SOMETHING BLESSED
BASILE. THE NORTH COAST. YOUR
SIGNAL ARE IN NON ALONG WITH SET
TO BE DECIDED BY THE FEDERAL
JUDGE OF THE COURT BATTLE. IN
THE COMMUNITY THAT BUT HE SAID.
YEAH THE FACT THAT THAT THING
YOU. IF YOU DON'T KNOW CAL PUT
NEED MORE SPECIAL IN. THE
FINANCING. THE MEDICINE
DEPENDING YEAH ASSEMBLY HERE NOT
NINE WITH. IN THE THIRD STILL
MISSING ALL SOME MORE YOU.
MARGINALLY AT THAT THOUGHT. THE
MEASURE ANALYSIS ASSEMBLY
ETHICAL MORAL. EMBOLUS FROM.
THAT'S HOW YOU LOOK AT AMAZON
MARC RELAXING ON THE FIFTH OF
MARCH BUT THEN AGAIN I WANT.
NORTH OF THE MEXICAN. WHAT WE
NORMALLY READ ARE MOVING.
MEDIANS CAN ALSO BE. THING
WONDER WHY THE WON THE LOTTERY
IF YOU WANT I CAN THINK YOU SOME
OF THE METAL. PEOPLE. THINK
ABOUT THE BATTLE. WHAT LOOKS TO
BE QUARTER UDGET. BY KNOW THAT
THE DALLAS. PLEASE HOLD. ON THE
FEELING FULL OF PEOPLE YEAH THAT
I HAVE DONE NOTHING MORE NOT A
OF I'M HE WILL MAKE A HAVE GONE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THE HOBBIT ALL
THE PEOPLE THEY OF THE BATTLE.
FIVE ONE THOUSAND FIVE HOME
WITHOUT OF THE COMPANY HOURS ARE
SUPPORTED YOUR GOING TO START
WITH WILL. WE DO NOT GET A JOB.
ANY OTHER BUT I'M SICK BOB DOLE
SOLA YES WE OPENED UP WITHIN THE
THIRD THROUGH SCHOOLS NORMALLY
ARTICLE ABOUT ABOUT A PREVENTIVE
PRODUCTS. ON THE ALLOW FIFTY NOT
GIVE US THE ONE MILLION
LIABILITY SYSTEM WILL BE BUILT
ON THE PHOTOCATALYTIC HE DECIDED
THE BUCKET IN SECTOR-LIMÓN. THE
NEW YORKER. WHEN WE HAD THE BALL
IF A PERSONAL TO BE SINCE. TO
HAVE FUN THERE ARE GOING. YES
GOOD NOT BE A KEY I THINK THAT'S
THE ONE RESPECT THE FINAL FOR
BUT ON THE FLIP SIDE. IT OF THE
BALLOT. THE NEW YORK. HE SAID
THANK YOU SEE AND WHAT HE SAID I. WELL THAT THEY'VE BEEN YEAH I
MEAN THE WHOLE HE- OF THE BOOK
BUT THAT IN. BEING NOT.
ACCORDING I'M NOT THAT FAMILIAR
THE MESSAGE BUT I COULD TELL YOU
WHAT WILL MAKE MY MOTHER PUT
FIFTY YOU DON'T KNOW A GOOD
THING. YEAH BUT IT'S- NOT YOU.
KNOW I DO NOT THAT UNTIL. I LIKE
THE- MORE. ON SB SEVEN FORM A
LOT. OF BY UNANIMOUS. THEM EQUAL
. I THINK IT. GET OUT WALK UP
THERE SOME OF THEM YOU KNOW. BUT
AGAIN I DO WANT TO BOOK IT UNITS
THAT COME TO MIND. YOU DON'T.
GET A YUBA COMMUNITY. ABOUT HERE
YOU GO I. IN ORDER TO UP AN
EXAMPLE BUTTON STILL NOT FOR ME
OKAY. IF THEN THERE ARE THIS.
OUR TO GIVE UP THE FINAL. OKAY
NORTH. YOUR WHEN ALL YOU.
KENNELS I DO THEY IT'S GOOD TO.
YOUR FOR YOUR LEAST FAVORITE ON
TO THE POLICY OF THIS BEEN
ACCOUNT. YEAH I GOT I BEEN GIVEN
BUT IT THE OF FUSS TOTAL THE YOU
. BUT A GOOD THING NINE ONE OF
THE BEST YOU CAN. BUT I NEED
BYPASS HOLD IN THE MIDDLE OF
ELEVEN. IN MY MOST AFFECTED. BUT
MENTAL. THANK A LOT ABOUT IT
MATTER OF FACT. WHEN IS THE YOU
FOR THE THIRD DAY OF THE PHONES. OUR WATER. CAN YOU. DID YOU
KNOW YOU DON'T WANT GETTING UP
AT LEAST ONE OKAY. ARE YOU ABOUT
YOU FOR NEW BY. MEDIA LOOKING TO
MOVE FROM NEEDLES AFTER THEY HE
YOU ARE YOU FROM SOME SEVEN WILL
NOT OF. ARE YOU THAT A YOUR- WE
COMING FOR HIM AND WHAT FOR YOU. IN A COUPLE YOUNG NO WAY STE.
NOT THAT THE FAMILY WITHOUT OF
THE SADDAM OF ITS MARCH BUT A
POLITICAL OF STATE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF. YEAH YEAH HE WAS
MICHAEL BEEN ASKED IF BRIAN
MILLER SIX OTHER FIGURE FOR THE
A COMBAT VEHICLE YOUR YOU GOT TO
PUSH WHICH UP. COULD I PUT IT ON
CHECK OUR SYSTEM THAT GO. TO
OPERATOR NEXT PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL
GO LINE THREE EIGHTY THREE AHEAD. THREE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY WE'LL TRY
THREE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YES SIR GOOD EVENING NOT
BACKED ARAMBULA IN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS FERNANDO
GOMEZ AND I AM- FIRSTLY A FATHER
OF A YOUNG MAN THE FIFTEEN YEAR
OLD WITH DOWN SYNDROME WHO IS
SERVED BY THE REGIONALS OF
SERVICE. I'M SO THE REGIONAL
SYSTEM. I'M ALSO THE CO FOUNDER
OF BOTH DISABILITY VOICES UNITED
AND- THE INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE. I JUST WANT TO
TAKE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR OUR FAMILIES
HERE FROM THE HEART. SHARE THEIR
STORIES AND BE ABLE TO. HAVE AN
EMPOWERMENT COMMUNICATING WHAT
DIRECTLY FROM WHAT THEY'RE
FEELING AND WHAT THE
EXPERIENCING. WE KNOW BUT THERE
ARE A LOT OF CHALLENGES AND WE
KNOW THAT THE REGIONALS. THE
CENTER SYSTEM NEEDS TO HAVE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF CHANGES
ESPECIALLY WITHIN THE CULTURE-
WHAT WAS PASSED TODAY BY BACK TO
THE MARKET AND OTHER TWENTY BE
YOU FROM THE LIST OF THE- WITH
THE ICC. TALKS DIRECTLY FROM OUR
NEEDS IN OUR HEARTS AND WHAT I
WANTED TO SHARE WAS. THE EX
WE'RE LOOKING TO CHANGE THE
SYSTEM TO BE PART OF THAT CHANGE
TRANSPARENCY ADVOCATES. ASKING
THAT. WE LOOK AT AS WE LOOK AT
THE SYSTEM THERE ARE AREAS THAT
NEED TO BE FIXED BEFORE.
ADDITIONAL ELEMENTS CAN BE
THROWN AT THEM AND- WHAT YOU
HEARD AS FAR AS RECOMMENDATIONS
WITH THE SPECIFICS. AND I KNOW
THAT A LOT OF OUR PARENTS ARE
SHARING THE HARD TO DISMISS.
THEIR STORIES AND- YOU KNOW I'M
JUST REALLY OVERWHELMED. ABOUT
HOW PROUD I AM FOR THEM TO BE
BRAVE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK FROM
THEIR HEARTS AND SHARE WITH YOU
SOMETHING THAT JUST. NOT TOO
LONG AGO THAT WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO. WE THOUGH THERE
WERE A STRONG NEED TO DO SO. I
ALSO WANT TO SHARE THAT WE HAVE
MADE INROADS WE SEE. CHANGE WE
SEE THE ABILITY TO ALWAYS BALLOT
GET BEING EMPOWERED TO BE ABLE
TO COMMUNICATE THAT BUT WE SEE
THAT THERE IS CHANGE COMING.
SPECIALLY THANKING DIRECTOR
BARTMAN AND HER STAFF FOR ITS
COULD GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HELP THE SYSTEM HELP US IN
ONE CASE IN PARTICULAR THAT I
WANTED TO POINT OUT IS THAT
NORTH LOS ANGELES COUNTY
REGIONAL CENTER. BUT DIRECTOR
RICK JANGA AND HER SENIOR STAFF
THAT LED BY DR JESSE WELLER.
OPEN THEIR DOORS TO US DATE SAT
DOWN WITH THE- BIG LISTENED THEY
HEARD TO WHAT WE DO WE HAVE TO
SAY SB PUT A PLAN IN PLACE IN
COLLABORATION WITH US TO GO OUT
INTO THE COMMUNITY. ENGAGE THE
COMMUNITY WE'VE CREATED SOME
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS LIKE THE
MEN'S GROUP EIGHT CAPITAL SHE
DOES TRAININGS ARE A CALLED UP
AND THEN DOWN TO NOTE THAT
OTHERS. THAT ENGAGES THE
COMMUNITY SO YOU CAN SEE WHAT'S
NEW THE TONIGHT THOSE THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE ABILITY. TO
COME AND SHARE WITH YOU THEIR
FEELINGS SO I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK. YOU AT THE BAG. I HOPE. I
SEE A RAY OF LIGHT. I SEE.
COMING BUT I KNOW THAT IT'S ONLY
GOING TO HAPPEN IF WE STAY IN
PROP WE'RE STILL THAT WERE PART
OF THAT SOLUTION PART OF THE
QUESTION. AND HELP IN THE SYSTEM
HELP US THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
STAYING THIS LATE INTERNET STOP.
PREACHING YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
SIR. OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER ONE IS NOT JUST A PHOTO.
THE NUMBER IS NOT YET IN OFFICE
JUST BILLIONS OF FINANCING OF
AUTOMATIC YOU FEED THEM AGAINST
LIKE MINDED PEOPLE CONTENT THAT
ISN'T EXACTLY HE SAID UP WITH
MUSTANG ISLAND COMMENT THAT
ELICITS GO INTO. A DIFFERENT OF
ACCESSIBLE OF THE CENTER LEFT IN
THAT BOOK BUT I'M GETTING ALL OF
THAT WITH THE SUPPORT FROM THAT
IF COULD CHANNEL. BUT THE BOTTOM
COLLECTED THE SAMPLES OF
BREAKING PUT THEM THANK GOD THAT
I RECORDED BOTH OF CORTES ON
SEEING THEM BATTLE WITH THEM
OKAY GET THEM BEING OUT OF ADDED
COUNTY WITH THE MOST
RECOGNIZABLE MOTIVE BUT WE HAD A
FEW THAT COULD HAVE BEEN A FROM
THE VANDERBILT FEDERAL. THE NEW
MOTORCADE TO COMPETE THE
CHOLESTEROL COMMENTED ABOUT IT
ON OUR OWN ON OUR OWN COOKING
ONE. OF NOT ENOUGH IN A COMPANY
THAT BOUGHT A PRODUCT FROM
NEEDED ASPEN FROM TRADITIONAL
NODDED OF THE FIFTY. THREE SEVEN
PM OVER TELEVISION THAT
IDENTIFIED ON THE SENATE JACKSON
ADDED I THANK YOUNG TECH
PLUMMETED AFTER K. M. KATE
COMMITTEE ON THE COMMERCIAL
TELEPHONE FROM HIS FELLOW NFL
SEVENTEEN THAT'LL FROM THE
SENATE REPUBLICAN JOHN OUT. OPEN
THE LAST MODIFIED REMOVED
EFFECTIVE FEDERAL POLICE
ABOLITION OF BOTH THE- ASSEMBLY
WILL PREVENT DECADES BANK OF
KENTUCKY CANNOT MEDICINE YOU
KNOW ABOUT THE JUNGLE OF THE
IDEON COMPOUND ON EACH YEAR.
HELLO BUT ONE HUNDRED NOT THE
KNOWLEDGE INFORMATION NOT. A
PROPOSED AT THE TIME WE GET THE
KIND OF DISSIPATING PROFOUNDLY
AFFECTED BY THAN A FOCUS UNIONS
THAT ARE MUCH OF THE TO BE
WRAPPED IN A MEDICAL WHICH IS OF
THE PROJECT ABOUT THE BELGIAN
THOUGH EVEN WITH OTHER PARTS OF
THE BODY THAT WAS FOUND IN THE
MINING OF THE THOUGHT OF.
LOS
ANGELES UNITED. IT OF ALL THAT I
LOVE MY THAT IS NOT A PROBLEM
THAT HE COULDN'T GIVE A WHAT THE
PAYMENT AMOUNTS MUSTACHE BONTA
POLITICALLY COMPLAINING IT'LL
CALL THE WHOLE IS AN OPTION ON
THE WOMAN'S. BEEN ABLE TO
CONVINCE MY SPECIALNESS COVERAGE
OF BIG EIGHT FIFTEEN AM OWN IN
ORDER CORTES SONG AND THE FINAL
VOTE YES DEFINITELY BECAUSE OF
THE IBM APPLE JUNGLE INFANTILISM
ALEX HIM BUT IT WAS MAYBE
FEASIBLE CONTRACT PERSONA AND
ACCOMPLISHMENT THAT IS GOIG ON
THE VEHICLE IS GOING TO KEEP OF
THIS INTERVENTION THAT. COULD
NOT DELAYED RESPONSE AND- SPEED
UP WITH MATHEMATIC ELEVENTH OF
CLASS SYSTEM AND- TRAVIS. TO BE
GIVEN TO SET ASIDE OUR DEBT BUT
FINAL IS THE PHONE CALL ANYTIME
YOU'RE MUCH OF THE REST OF THE
PUBLIC TICKET THAT- WHEN I
NOTICED. THAT OUR SYSTEM IN
ORDER. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHT EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT I WOULD
IMAGINE THOSE MONIES OKAY. HI
MOM ONLY NEW YORK ON SUMMIT IN A
BUT IT. LET ME A LITTLE BIT IS
IMPORTANT ON. THE VIOLENCE. IF
DELIVER WHAT THE OTHER. BUT IT
COULD TRAVELS. ACCORDING CAN PAY
THIRTIES HAS MAN LOOKED WAS PUT
IN SOMEONE IN MINUTE. AT THE BUT
THAT IS THINGS HIM NOT BOTH. WHO
ARE LOOKING TO POLICE YOU DON'T
. HE THE POLITICAL FOR ME UNDER
NORMAL CLEARLY. I DON'T THINK
ANYTHING OKAY DEAL OKAY HAVE
BEEN. YOU HAVE YOUR PERSONAL
ECONOMY COULD. FATAL CAME INTO
LAGOS TWO COMO. WE LOOK AT US
CONTINUE SOMEBODY BUT A BE
BECAUSE THING I LOOK AT THE AT
MINNEAPOLIS. WHAT I MEAN LOOK AT
ME LOOKING WILL NOT BE. HELLO AT
MEDICAL. IT'S BEEN A KNOW.
SANTEE RESIDENT. IT OPERATES
COMMITTEE. IF YOU IS NOT ENOUGH
GOOD MOOD IN ORDER BUT I'M
LOOKING. BUT A PART OF IT IN
TERMS OF HOW ANY. IT TOOK A THEM
FOR COMBINE YEAH. IMPOSES ON ONE
OF PROTECTED THE. THE ONLY THING
IF YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MILLION
MILLION A MILLION BUCKS. THERE
WHAT HAPPENED WHICH PROPOSAL I
MEAN I DON'T THANK IF THEY WHAT
. CALL IT GUESTS YOU KNOW THE
FUTURE AMANDA IAN PAUL IT'S I
MEAN I WAS IDEA. OKAY WE DON'T
MY MAN I ONE OF THE MANY TO
YOUNG IT MONDAY A THAT HIM NOT
OF THE GOING. TO APPLE YEAH I
DON'T MIND ME ASKING WHAT CAN I
TO SEE THAT. BUT A LIVING AT THE
TIME. AND THE COMING OUT OF. I
DON'T KNOW WHICH OF THEM. THE
NEW YORK CAN'T OKAY. IN LOCAL
MORE. IT'S A GOING EASY ON. IT'S
WE BILLION MARKET YOU DON'T KNOW
WHERE SOMEONE'S TO TELL YOU
BATTLE ON P. I. N. GOING ALSO
THE TWENTY IS NOT A WEAPON THAT
KILLS POUNDS USING YORK. IT NOT
GOING TO SEE A- NOT COMMANDED.
IN WHICH A BUT THE YOUNG CHIU-
ARE WE JUST NOT BUT HE TELL ME
YOU'LL BE ABLE WITH ON NO I
DON'T BY TO GET A THE OPEN YEAH
BUT I'M CALL. HE GAVE ME A CALL
LEAST. BUT CAN YOU CALL FOR YOUR
WAY THE WAY NOW MULTIPLE BY THE. MY MOM. BUILDING A ENOUGH OKAY
OKAY. HELLO YEAH MY NORMAN TIMES
. THE NEW. NEW YORK BUT I THINK
REMAIN HOPELESS. WITH IN THE
PORT WITH A SINGLE MOTTO OUR
FAILED BATTLE WITH YOU KNOW WITH
THE I CAN EVEN IF WE WILL BE
SENT BACK. IF YOU WANT TO
AMENITIES COULD BEEN SEEN YOU
SPENT ON THE PHONE GOOD ACTORS.
IF THERE IS AN ARCADE. BUT A
GOOD THING ON A POINT OF IF THEY
DON'T CALIFORNIA MANY ONTO THE
STATE OKAY. OKAY WELL THE
LEADING. FIVE IS THERE. ANY
POINT PUT THEM IN KEEP CAME. IT
WILL BE ONE COULD LOCATE YOUR
CHILD OKAY READY FOR ALL. YOUR
FOR YOUR- COMMENT ON OF THE LAST
THING YOU WANT TO LEAVE THEM IN
BY OFF EACH OF THE- PRODUCT CARE
THANK FOR MORE THE- TO ONE ALL.
UP AND GET THIS INTO THE YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO COME IN THE CALL IF
THEY DON'T GOING TO SEE INTO ON
REPEAT COME IN OF COSTA.
FINANCES AND IF YOU'LL KEEP AND
WHAT MONEY AND THE MEDICAL HOME
TALK. CAN YOU CALL. OKAY TO BE
TO. CAME TO SEE. A LOT OF PEOPLE
MORE WHICH IS WHAT A LOT OF YOU
KNOW FOR THE APPOINTMENT OF A-
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG. YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE MENTION. MORE PEOPLE
OKAY LET WAY LAW HOSPITAL IS
GOING BONTA. IT WAS OF THAT LOVE
MATHIS THAT ANYTHING NOT. THANK
YOUNG BLACK. HE OF THE COACHING
ONE OF A COUPLE. PRESS OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO OF THREE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO. HELLO WE CAN HELLO WE
CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY HI MY NAME IS
ZACH WE WERE ON BACK ON AGAIN.
WE HAVE A LOT OF COMPLAINTS AND-
THANK GOD I DO SPEAK SPANISH SO.
I UNDERSTAND. WHAT THE PARENTS
WERE SAYING BUT I DO THIS SOUNDS
LIKE WE HAVE LIKE USED TO BIGGER
THAN THE REGIONAL CENTER THING
LIKE WE NEED TO DO SOME CHANGES
AT THE TOP. AND THE TOP THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES IN WE DEAL WITH THE
SERVICES SEEMS LIKE WE CAN DO
SOMETHING WITH THE REGIONAL
FINANCING. GAVE THE ACTIVE. THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE REGION ALSO- I
THINK IT KIND OF WEIRD EVERY
TIME WE GET A NEW DIRECTOR OF D.
S. R. O. THE EMPLOYEES OF THE
ACT THEY ALL COME FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM ARE HAVE
SOME BACKGROUND IN REGIONAL
CENTER- WAIT THE WHOLE SYSTEM
NEEDS TO CHANGE FROM THE VERY
TOP OF THE TOP OF THE REGIONAL
CENTER AND THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE RETAIL SECTOR
BUT WE NEED TO CHANGE THE TOPIC
DDS- WELL. I MEAN NOT THE VENDOR
I YOU KNOW I'M LOOKING INTO A
LOT OF THESE CALLS ARE COMING.
BACK IMPORTANT I'M LISTENING TO
THE COMPLAINTS THAT ACTUALLY
COMING AND GOING THE
APPRECIATION OF. THE FUNDING BUT
HERE WE ARE ONCE AGAIN DELIVERED
FUNDING ISSUE AND THE FUNDING
ISSUE. HAVE BEEN GOING ON FOR
YEARS FOR A LOT OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND- VENDORS OF COLOR.
GOOD FOR MANY YEARS WE WERE NOT
GIVEN A FAIR SHAKE UP THE DEAL
SUCH AS MYSELF. AND BECAUSE I
TALKED OPENS VOEPEL. I WOULD
BLACKSPOT AGAIN. AND WE WILL
ALSO DEALT WITH I. HOW CUTE
ARCTIC ONE THAT MAKING WAGE HOW
CAN YOU SOME. WHEN YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO SUPPLY SERVICES
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY IN YOUR
ONLY BEGINNING CONTRIBUTION
BACKED UP FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
A MONTH IN THE PERSON. IF WE'RE
GOING TO CLEAN UP THE
STRAIGHTENING UP IN WHAT I WRITE
IF NOT. THROW MONEY TO DDS TO
GIVE TO US TO BILLION FUNDING
THROUGH THE REGIONAL CENTER WE
NEED TO CLEAN IT UP. SO THE
ARGUMENTS. IS BROKEN. THANK YOU
ARE NOT THE FOCAL BODY IN THE
BODY IF YOUR HOURS DON'T MATCH
YOUR CONTRIBUTION SO THAT THE
TIME THAT I'M NOT IN YOUR BACK.
THANK YOU SIR. OPERATOR OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YOUR NEXT
QUESTION COMES FROM LINE THREE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
MICHAEL DANIEL AND OUR PROVIDED
BY- THAT GREW WHEELER. AND I
DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT THE
REGIONAL STANDARDS AND WHAT THEY
HAVE TO OFFER BUT I NEED- ALL
THAT I CAN GET THEM ALL THAT I
CAN GET. FOR MY BROTHER- WHO
HAVE THE BIRD DISABILITY. SO I
NEED TO SEE IF YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION- CAN
OBTAIN THAT DON'T FALL THE
BENEFIT. SIR I BELIEVE HELLO
AGAIN YES I BELIEVE YOU CAN GO
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WEBSITE
AND FIND YOUR LOCUSTS LOCAL.
REGIONAL CENTER WHICH- HOPEFULLY
WILL THEN BE ABLE TO EXTEND THE
SERVICES YOU'RE LOOKING FOR.
HERE I'LL BILL WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTER HEREABOUT THAT OF. THEM
ARE REALLY DON'T- I WENT TO MY
BROTHER HE WORKS IN THE FIRST
SO- WORK PROGRAM. AND THEN- WHEN
RECORD COMMINGLED GOVERNOR HE
CUT OFF A LOT OF THAT GOAL IN
MIND THAT MESSED UP SO NOW HE'S
NOT ACTIVELY WORKING IN THE
RETURN OF BANNER- OUR YOU GONNA
READ LOCAL BUT I'M STILL GETTING
A LETTER FROM A REASONABLE
STANDARD. AND WHEN I CALL A
RIGHT BACK I DON'T GET NO
RESPONSE. SO I DON'T YOU KNOW
IT'S LIKE I'M LEFT IN LIMBO. YOU
KNOW WHAT KIND OF BENEFITS I
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET FROM MY
BROTHER UP ECONOMY TO GO OUTSIDE
AT THE REGIONAL CENTER HERE IN
LOS ANGELES. THANK YOU SIR.
OPERATOR CAN GO TO THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YOUR NEXT CALL
QUESTION COMES FROM LINE THREE
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND I'M
SORRY THERE ARE NO FURTHER.
QUESTIONS IN KILL. THANK YOU
OPERATOR I WILL TAKE THAT AS THE
CONCLUSION OF PUBLIC COMMENT AND
AS- WE ARE ABOUT TO END OF THIS
SEVEN HOUR MEETING I WANTED TO
TAKE A MOMENT AND THANK ALL THE
STAFF WHO HELPED TO PROTECT THE
MATERIALS HERE TODAY THE GENERAL
SERVICES WHO HOPES TO CLEAN THIS
ROOM THE SERGEANTS WHO KEPT US
SAFE THE TECHNOLOGY TEAM WHO
HELPED TO. BROADCAST THIS ACROSS
THE STATE AS WELL AS THE ENTIRE
ADMINISTRATION BUT SPECIFICALLY
WANTED TO CALL OUT TO DIRECTOR
PARCHMENT APPRECIATE THE TIME
AND EFFORT THAT SHE BROUGHT BUT
BEFORE WE CLOSE I FEEL IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE PUBLIC WHO PARTICIPATED AND
WAS HEARD HERE AND TODAY'S
COMMITTEE AND I AM VERY THANKFUL
THAT THEY WILL CONTINUE TO COME
TO OUR COMMITTEE AND TO FEEL
THAT THEIR VOICES MATTER.
BECAUSE THEY MATTER TO US HERE
IN THIS HOUSE THE PUBLIC HOUSE
AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE TO
THANK THE PUBLIC FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S HEARING
AS WELL. WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED HAVE A GOOD NIGHT.